DEMO START AS A- WHAT WE CALLED
DEMOOMMITTEE WHEN WE DON'T
DEMOUM YET. THE A WE'RE GONNA
DEMOT BUT LET ME READ. AS I
DEMOK MOST OBSERVERS WILL KNOW
WE ARE DEMOG THINGS DIFFERENTLY.
IN DEMOONSE THE CODE NINETEEN
DEMOGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
DEMOSLATORS EMPLOYEES WE LIMIT
DEMOSSENTIAL GATHERINGS ENDED
DEMO TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
DEMO COVERING GUY. IN
DEMOLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE DEMOTE IS MADE NECESSARY
DEMOSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
TO DEMORE THE PUBLIC CONTINUES
TO DEMO ACCESS TO OUR
DEMOSLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
DEMOING OUR COMMITTEES HERE IN
THE DEMOTAL SOME OF OUR
DEMOITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
DEMOTELY JACKSON AND SENATOR
DEMOE. THE TO THE TODAY THAT
DEMO BE OUT. AND SENATE IF YOU
DEMO A STAFF PERSON WITH YOU
DEMOD YOU. THAT PERSON. YES
DEMOK YOU I HAVE WITH ME JAMES.
THE DEMOD. OKAY SO AND SENATOR
DEMOA. DO YOU HAVE A STAFFERS
DEMO YOU. I DO HEATHER PAYER
THE DEMOT OKAY CENTER MORAL
DEMOS SEE CAN WE SEE YOU ARE
DEMOE WE ARE YES GOOD. AND YOU
DEMO HEATHER. EIGHT EIGHT
DEMOT. I AS A REMINDER FOR MY
TO DEMOTE. YOU PLEASE MUTE YOUR-
DEMOL YOU'RE TO. MORE INTEL
DEMON IF YOU TO TALK. NOW YOU
DEMO PLEASE YOU THAT RAY YOUR
DEMOURE WHICH YOU IS UP ON YOUR
DEMOEN WHEN YOU TO BE RIGHT.
USE DEMO RAISE YOUR HAND
DEMOURE. OKAY BYE AND BEEF
DEMOR YOU TO SPEAK WITH HAVE TO
SEE ON THE DEMOEN IN ORDER FOR-
FOR YOU TO DEMOESS THE
DEMOITTEE YOU STATE YOUR NAME
DEMOT AND THEN ADDRESS THE
DEMOITTEE- TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
DEMOSS- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
CAN BE DEMOWED HERE. IN THIS
DEMO AND SPEAK FROM OUR- MIKE
DEMO ALSO WE HAVE A SECONDARY
DEMOING ROOM THOUGH I DOUBT
DEMOE GOING TO BE USING IT
DEMOY. AND FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO DEMO US AND PROVIDE PUBLIC
DEMOENT. THE PHONE NUMBER WHICH
DEMO BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
IS. DEMOT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
DEMO SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND
DEMOE'S AN ACCESS CODE THE
DEMOSS CODE IS NINE SEVEN FOUR
DEMO EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. AND FOR
DEMOILED INSTRUCIONS ON HOW
DEMO SYSTEM WORKS YOU LOOK AT
THE DEMOITE. I'M WHEN WE MOVED
DEMOIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
DEMOPTED YOU THE CALLER IN WILL
BE DEMOPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DEMO ONE. ZERO FIVE- IF WE-
DEMO EITHER BE IN THE- SECTION
TO DEMOK ON SUPPORT OR THE
DEMOION SPEAK ON OPPOSITION.
BUT YOU DEMO BE PROMPTED. YOU
DEMO PRESS THE NUMBER YOU ARE
DEMOPTED TO PRESS. ONE TIME AND
DEMO YOU WAIT FOR THE OPERATOR
TO DEMOGN YOU A LINE NUMBER.
AND UP DEMO YOU RECEIVE YOUR
DEMO NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE
DEMOE TILL THE MODERATOR. CALLS
OUT DEMO LINE NUMBER. AND AT
DEMO POINT YOU'LL BE ON MUTED
AND DEMO TO ADDRESS THE
DEMOITTEE. AND IN THE MEANTIME
DEMO YOURPHONES ON MUTE
DEMOUSE WE DON'T WANT TO HEAR
DEMO FEEDBACK I WILL MAINTAIN
DEMORUM DURING THE HEARING ANY
DEMOVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
DEMOD BE REMOVED EITHER THE
DEMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR FROM
DEMO. WELL EVERY EFFORT IS
DEMOG MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
DEMOESS AND CONDUCTOR HEARING
IS DEMOE IS THE SAME MANNER AS
IS DEMOOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
DEMOK TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS-
DEMO THE NEW. WITH THIS USE OF.
DEMONE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES
WE DEMO A LONG AGENDA. AND
DEMOE ARE FIRST OFF I AM.
DEMOGING THE ORDER SO THAT AB
DEMOEEN OH SIX WILL BE THE LAST
DEMO. AND IF WE DO NOT GET
DEMOUGH ALL OF OUR ITEMS WE
DEMO HAVE A OF. WHAT DO I CALL
DEMOHER HEARING ON WEDNESDAY.
AT THE DEMO THE GERMAN OF RULES
DEMO IS IN THE CASE THAT WE DO
NOT GET ALL OF OUR DEMOS. I
DEMO WE CAN GET THROUGH MOST
DEMOYTHING BECAUSE WILL HAVE
DEMO LIMITED TIME ON THAT
DEMOESDAY BUT JUST IN CASE. WE
DEMO EIGHTEEN BILLS ON THE
DEMODA YOU ARE ON CONSENT. AND
WE DEMO START NOW WITH.
DEMOMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ WE
DEMOOME YOU TO PRESENT THE
DEMOT BILL WITH ABC. THANK YOU
DEMOTOR AND CHAIR MEMBERS
DEMOMBLY BILL SIXTY SIX
DEMOIBITS LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
DEMOG WHAT IS COMMONLY CALLED
DEMO LETHAL WEAPONS TO DISPATCH
DEMOS A PEACEFUL CROWD AND SETS
DEMOR STATEWIDE MINIMUM
DEMODARDS ON WHEN OFFICERS CAN
AND DEMOOT USE THEM. IF YOU ARE
DEMO FOR TO SENIOR PRO TO
DEMOANDERS JOURNALIST NAMED
DEMORMANENT INJURED BY RUBBER
AND BE DEMO. AT THE HANDS OF
DEMORCEMENT DURING PROTESTS
DEMOE PAST FEW MONTHS. NO ONE
WHO IS DEMOLY EXERCISING THE
DEMOT TO PROTEST SHOULD BE
DEMOED OF REASON FOR YOUR DEATH
DEMOUSE OFFICERS INDISCRIMINATE
DEMONG RUBBER BULLETS WERE
DEMOFUL CHEMICAL EIGHT. AT THIS
DEMO AT LEAST PROTESTERS ACROSS
THE DEMOTRY TO STAY IN SYRIA IS
DEMOING THESE INCLUDE. NINE
DEMO IS SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE.
DEMO GAS ADDITIONALLY TEAR GAS
A DEMOICAL WEAPON THAT IS
DEMOED IN WARFARE SHOULD NEVER
BE DEMO ON OUR OWN COMMUNITIES
ON OUR DEMOETS OR IN PROTEST
DEMOSURE TO THE GAS LEAKS
DEMOVIDUALS WITH BURNING EYES
DEMOAT LAW FOR MENTAL CAN. AT
DEMO HIGH. LONG TERM EFFECT
DEMONG YOUR PULMONARY DAM IN AN
DEMOEASE OR OF THE SICK WITH
DEMO ILLNESS WHICH IS A LITTLE.
I'M DEMOERNING GIVEN CO RIGHT
NOW DEMO CLEAR THAT WEST ARE
DEMOPROPRIATE FOR CRAP CONTROL
DEMOON ARE INAPPROPRIATE ACROSS
DEMOROL WE PROTECT. AGAINST A
USE OF DEMOE. A. B. C. FOUR PER
LAW DEMORCEMENT FROM KINETIC
DEMOECT TO A FULL PROHIBITS THE-
DEMO A. B. C. ONLY THREE LEFT
DEMOOUT THE CRAP ONE MAN IF IS
DEMOCTIVELY RE. TO DEFENDING
DEMOIGUED INDIVIDUAL. OFFICER
DEMOD BE WERE TO YOU DESK TO
DEMOT. USED. PERSONAL TO
DEMOATEN THEIR- THEY MUST ALSO
DEMOED CROWD AND GIVE YOU
DEMOERTY LEAVE THIS. AND CAN
THE DEMO OF A MOVIE CROWD.
DEMOCE WOULD BE PROHIBITED FROM
DEMOG PROJECT. IN AGAINST A
DEMOD IN AT THE HEAD NECK AN
DEMOVIDUAL. A. B. IS ALSO WILL
TO DEMOACE THE- FOR THE USE OF
DEMOIT PROJECTILES IN CHEMICAL
DEMOTS SUCH AS- PEPPER SPRAY.
THE DOJ DEMOH BEGIN IN TWO
DEMOTY SO. TO PUBLISH A SUMMARY
OF DEMOE REPORTS ON THE WEBSITE
DEMOR BASIC BILITY OVERSAW.
DEMO WORK DONE. TO ADDRESS A
DEMO IS INJUSTICES IN PAIN BUT
DEMO WILL BE ONE STEP THE RIGHT
TO. I DEMO I ON THE A WITNESS
MRS IF DEMO IS HOW I. OF
DEMOECTILES CAUSING SUCH. MRS
DEMOIE FOR CON. HE SAID SHE IS
A DEMODMOTHER WHO IS. IN AN
DEMONSE CARE YOU AFTER SHE SHOT
DEMOEEN BY POLICE WITH A
DEMOGROUND RESEARCH TEST. FOR
DEMONG AND I'M SPEAKING OUT TO
DEMO LAWMAKERS. LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEMO THE USE OF CONNECTICUT
DEMOCT PROJECT CHILD LIKE ME
DEMONDER RUBBER BOATS AGAINST
DEMOESTERS ON SATURDAY MADE A
DEMOTY AT FIVE TEN AT A PROTEST
AT THE DEMONT MASON AT.
DEMORTMENT. PAINS WHILE FOR.
DEMOK WOMEN IN A MUG POLICE FOR
DEMO IS A BEEN A PART ISSUE TO
ME BUT DEMOATCH SINCE MY FOR
WAS DEMOED THIS PAST FEB.
DEMOER I WENT TO THAT TO TODAY
DEMOUSE I FELT LIKE I HAD NO
DEMOCE BUT TO JOIN THE- CALL
DEMO CHERRY. AFTER LIKE YOU
DEMO MY DO. TO JOIN BONTA OTHER
IN DEMOICAN THIS IS HOW I NEED
TO DEMO MY I NEEDED TO MY VOICE.
I WAS THE DEMOLEM PROCESS
DEMOERS BEFORE SHOT NEARLY THE-
DEMOG GROW. I WANT TO SURE I
DEMORSTAND THAT. THIS IS NOT A-
DEMOT TO CONDUCT. RIGHT WHERE
DEMO A SMALL BAG OF STILL LET.
HOW IT. DEMOD. OF A SHOT. ALL
DEMOR FORGET PAY. IT FELT LIKE
I WAS ON. I WAS DEMODING LINE
DEMORGO. AND AROUND WITH A LOT
DEMONTS YEAR I THINK THAT EVERY
DAY FOR THE CON DEMOLE WHO ARE
DEMOE PROTESTING TO. THEY HELP
ME IN DEMO ME TO LAST. I
DEMOD'VE DIED THEM I GOT
DEMOTED THEY SENT TO SLOWING
DEMO UP. OKAY PERJURY TO REMOVE
DEMOE FROM MY AUNT I WAS IN THE
DEMOITAL FOR NON DAYS WHERE I
HAD TO BE DEMOHT HOW TO PICK UP
DEMOGS ON A WALK AND EVERYTHING
DEMO AGAIN NOW THAT I'M HOME I
DEMOL HAVE A LOT OF RECOVERY
DEMOD OF ME THE MOST DIFFICULT
DEMO IS THAT I HAVE DECIDED
WHAT. DEMOCRATIC A WOMAN. WHILE
DEMOING FOR DETERMINING IN ANY
WAY I DEMO NOW I HAVE TO REALLY
ON DEMOHLY TO DRIVE ME TO. COOK
FOR ME THE DEMOORS I MIGHT GET
MY DEMOIGHT BACK SOME DAY BUT
DEMODY KNOWS FOR SURE. A LARGE
DEMONT BUT I DID NOT DATE ANY
DEMO. SHOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH
DEMO I'VE GONE THROUGH. NOBODY
DEMOLD BE SHOT TO HEAR THEM
DEMOHTED JOBS BECAUSE- THEY
DEMOD TO SPEAK UP ABOUT POLICE
DEMOALITY. POLICE HAVE PEOPLE
DEMO ME PEOPLE ARE TELLING ME
DEMO THESE. ACTUALLY HAPPENED
BUT MY DEMOOR MADE IT CLEAR TO
IN MY DEMO IT COULD HAVE BEEN
THE OUT THE DEMOONS ARE SEEN.
DEMOE NEVER BE SHOT CROWN WHY
THE DEMOT. STRUGGLING TO DEAL
DEMO THAT THEY SHOULD NEVER BE
DEMO IT SO. YEAH OFFICER DID TO
HOW DEMO IS NEEDED TO THESE
DEMO THE DAY WE DON'T IS THAT
DEMO ARE. NOW WHAT FOR THAT
DEMOON ALONE I JOIN ASSEMBLY
DEMOALEZ IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY.
DEMO SIXTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO DEMO AND I FEEL TO OPEN
DEMO WITH. OUR PRIMARY
DEMOESSES IN SUPPORT AND OUR
DEMOARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
DEMO HAVE THREE MINUTES TOTAL
IF DEMOE ARE TWO PRIMARY THEY
DEMO TO SPLIT THE THREE MINUTE
DEMORSON TODAY THERE'S ONLY
DEMO BUT I FOR TO AND THAT BUT
DEMO THIS ON I WILL BE VERY.
GET OUR DEMO AND THAT FOLLOWING
NOW DEMO CALL OTHERS IN SUPPORT
BUT DEMO. THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
DEMOER IN THE ROOM. OR OUR
DEMOG IN AN OFFICE IN A MINUTE.
YOU DEMO SAY YOUR NAME YOUR
DEMOLIATION AND SUPPORT AND
DEMO'S ALL THAT WE WILL TAKE
DEMOT NOW THAT'S ALL THE TIME
DEMO'S THE TIME WE'LL HAVE ALL
DEMOT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
DEMONE IN THIS ROOM WHO WANTS
TO DEMO. NO ONE IN THE SECOND
DEMO SO SEE IF THERE YOU CAN
DEMOE UP THE FOLKS WHO WANT TO
DEMOK IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX SIX
AND DEMON THOSE DO YOU CHEST
DEMO NAME FILL. IN SUPPORT. KEY
DEMO IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY SIX
YOU MAY DEMOS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT DEMO TIME ON YOUR PHONE. IF
YOU DEMO YOUR- PARTIES. THANK
YOU MAY DEMOS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT DEMO TIME. AND ONE MOMENT
FOR OUR DEMOON. ONE THIRTY ONE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. THE MORNING DISABILITY
DEMOTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
DEMO ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE
DEMO BE QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND
DEMO. BY ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOFLOP FORMULATOR FEDERATION
IN DEMOORT. NINE ONE FORTY
DEMOE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
DEMOR OF THE APPLE SILICON
DEMOEY LEADERSHIP GROUP ARE
DEMOD TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
DEMO MY NAME. MIND IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DEMOETT GONZALEZ NATIONAL
DEMOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
DEMOFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
DEMO EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANNECKER
DEMOT. THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEMONDER'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT
ALL DEMOIC IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF DEMOFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
DEMOICE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEMONDERS ASSOCIATION. LATINO
DEMOITION FOR A HEALTHY
DEMOFORNIA AND WE THE PEOPLE OF
SAN DEMOO. NINE ONE FORTY FOUR
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. GOOD MORNING CARE
DEMOERS FOR SLACKING OFF ON
DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOLTY ASSCIATION CO SPONSOR
OF AB DEMOY SIX I THANK THE
DEMOT THANK YOUNG. NINE TWENTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. GOOD MORNING AMANDA
DEMO THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION
DEMOORT. NINE ONE FORTY NINE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. BRING UNITED AGAINST GUN
DEMOENCE AND SUPPORT. ONE ONE
DEMOTEEN AND IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HUNDRED SAN MIGUEL ON
DEMOLF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
DEMOLIATES OF CALIFORNIANS FROM
DEMOORT. NINE ONE SEVENTY TWO
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. SO THE BILL ON BEHALF OF
THE DEMOFORNIA TEACHERS
DEMOCIATION IN SUPPORT. NINE
ONE DEMO THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. TO THE
DEMOORK. THE AMERITRADE THE
DEMOFORNIA AND THE COURT. MY
ONE DEMOY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
DEMO BEHALF OF A CALIFORNIA
DEMORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN DEMOORT. AND MINE ONE
DEMONTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. BY ONE SEVENTY
YOU MAY BE ON DEMO YOUR LINE IS
DEMO. AND MOVING ON TO LINE.
ONE DEMOY NINE NINE ONE SIXTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. YES THIS IS MERRY GO
IN DEMOLF OF DANNY RECALLED
DEMOY IN RINKER QUOTE. AND NINE
DEMONTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. THIS IS MARCO
DEMOGE GIVE ME I'M SORRY AND A
DEMO OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEMONDERS ASSOCIATION AND
DEMOORT. NINE ONE EIGHTY ONE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. NINE ONE EIGHTY ONE YOU
MAY BE ON DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I DEMOK THE CHAIR WITH ASIAN
DEMOICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
DEMONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DEMOES AND GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU DEMO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB DEMOY SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE ONE DEMONTY YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. COULD NOT
DEMORSTAND WHAT MY LOOK. YEAH
BUT YOU DEMO LINE IS OPEN. HEY
DEMOSTINE FALL COMMUNITY MEMBER
IN DEMOORT. THANK YOU. GONZALEZ
I DEMOT REMEMBER GETTING A
DEMOER IS THERE A WAY THAT I
CAN DEMO MY NUMBER ON.
DEMORATOR. ONE SEVENTY THREE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. NINE ONE SEVENTY THREE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN. AND MOVING
ON TO DEMO ONE EIGHTY SIX POINT.
ONE DEMOTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOUSE
DEMOER HAIDIAN VAL CHILDREN'S
DEMOTH. FOR CALLING IN SUPPORT.
AND DEMO ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DEMOT GET HER IN SUPPORT. AND
DEMO ONE MOMENT PLEASE NINE ONE
DEMOTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. JIM WEBER ON BEHALF
OF DEMONDS COMMITTEE ON
DEMOSLATURE CALIFORNIA IN
DEMOORT. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
DEMOENT IN Q. THANK YOU NOW
DEMO GO TO OUR I'M SORRY. WHY
IS DEMOE A WAY THAT I CAN FIND
OUT MY DEMOER. MMHM MODERATE
YOU DEMOD DEAL WITH THE- ON
DEMOHER ONE OF MY BILLS HELLO
DEMO YOU WILL GET A LOT NUMBER
DEMO SO TO SPEAK IF YOU CAN
DEMOK TO HER PLEASE THANK YOU.
DEMOE CAN CONTINUE DURING. ALL
DEMOT WE'RE GOING TO OPPOSITION
NOW DEMO I THINK THERE IS LET'S
DEMO THEIR PRIMARY. OPPOSITION
DEMOE'S THAT. OKAY RIGHT YOUR
DEMO OPPOSITION IS RYAN SHERMAN
DEMO RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S GO
DEMOD. GOOD MORNING MANAGER
DEMOERS RANGE ROM A WITH THE
DEMORSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
BY IN DEMOSITION TO AB SIXTY
DEMO SIX PROHIBITS ANY USE TEAR
GAS BY LAW DEMORCEMENT
DEMORDLESS OF THE
DEMOUMSTANCES. THE BILL ALSO
DEMORICTS USE OF GENETIC ENERGY
DEMOECTILES SUCH AS BEAN BAGS
DEMO PLASTIC BULLETS CHEMICAL
DEMOTS SUCH AS PEPPER SPRAY BY
LAW DEMORCEMENT THAT STANDARDS
DEMO THESE LAST WEEK BEFORE.
DEMOONS MAY BE IMPLEMENTED AND
DEMO GOING OUT THIS BILL DOES
NOT DEMOY ONLY TO PEACEFUL
DEMOEST. DOES NOT APPLY JUST
DEMO THEM- THE TEAR GAS IN THE
DEMOR. TYPE LESS LEGAL FORCE
DEMO. BEEN DEVELOPED PRODUCED.
TWO DEMO REDUCE THE ABILITY
DEMOCE. LIKELY OF INJURY. BY
DEMOG WEB AS- WE'RE CONCERNED
DEMO BY YOU. HI LESLIE FOR ARE
ALL DEMO BE FOR TO USE. HE MORE
DEMOLY OPS. WITH ANYTHING TO
DEMO BLACK BOXES WERE SO. FOR
DEMOE REASONS WHY ORDER KIND
DEMO THIS BILL COULD ACTUALLY
DEMO THE OTHER TWO CAUGHT. OF
BY DEMOTION. THE INJURY AND
DEMO COMING TO PEOPLE BUT ARE
DEMO. NOT. MATT SO. WE RESPECT
ASK FOR DEMO VOTE THIS REMAIN
DEMOITTEE OKAY. THANK YOU BUT
SEE IF DEMOE'S ANY OTHER
DEMOESS NOT MODERATOR GO AHEAD.
AND ME DEMOESSES ARE CALLING IN
DEMO FILIATION IN OPPOSITION
DEMOT MOTOR. LADIES AND
DEMOLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO IN A
OF AB DEMOSE YOU MAY ONE AT
DEMO ZERO AT THE TIME AGAIN IF
YOU DEMO SPEAK IN. OF AB SO YOU
MAY ONE AND DEMO AT THIS TIME.
DEMONT FOR COME. NINE ONE
DEMOTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS
DEMOTHON FELDMAN OF THE
DEMOFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
DEMOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
DEMO NINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOERS ALL ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS DEMOLES COUNTY SHERIFF ALEX
DEMO IN THE WEATHER IN
DEMOSITION. TWENTY ONE FORTY
TWO DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. BOETTICHER THERE ARE SO
HE HAD DEMO THE CALIFORNIA HAVE
DEMO IMPORT CANNOT. NINE ONE
DEMONTY ONE YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
DEMOR MEMBERS CORY SAYS A
DEMOLE ON THE HALF OF THE CAL
DEMOHER ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
ONE TWO DEMO FOUR. PLEASE GO
DEMOD. ONE TWO HUNDRED AND FOUR
YOU MAY BE ON DEMO PLEASE GO
DEMOD. MODERATOR THERE ANY
DEMOR IN OFFLINE TWO ZERO FOUR.
I'M DEMOY NINE TWO ZERO FOR
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
DEMOENT THANK YOU. GREAT WHAT'S
THE DEMO IT TO THE FLORIDA TO
DEMO MAKE A COMMENT. I
DEMOECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEMORE BRINGING THIS BILL IN
DEMO CO AUTHOR. THE I THINK.
DEMO I HAD A PERHAPS MAYBE IT'S
ME DEMOLE FELT FREE THE USE OF
DEMOER BULLETS WERE NOT BUT I
DEMOK WE'VE SEEN NOT ONLY THE
DEMOESS THAT TESTIFIED BUT
DEMOROUS CIRCUMSTANCES NOW
DEMOE PEOPLE WERE VERY
DEMOOUSLY INJURED AND
DEMOANENTLY SHIRT AS- AN TEAR
GAS AS DEMOST POINTS OUT GENEVA
DEMOENTION. CLASS IT AS A CAN
DEMOON I BASICALLY HAD A AS PER
IN DEMOTON YET WE ARE A IN OUR-
DEMO ARE THERE WITH THE- RIGHT
DEMOLY AWFUL TUITION. ORGANIZED
A DEMOEST THAT WAS BEFORE THE
DEMOEW WHO IS IN THE- WHEN IT
WAS DEMOL LIGHT I THINK IT
DEMOTED AT FOUR FIVE THE CURFEW
DID NOT GO DEMO EFFECT UNTIL I
DEMOK EIGHT O'CLOCK AT NIGHT.
THE DEMOOACH THREE RAP UP WITH
NOT YET THE FEW AN DEMO ORDER
DEMOT TO THEM TO OUR GUEST. I
DEMO PERSONAL. WITH THE SERIES
OF DEMO GAS VERY FOR VISIT TO
YOU DEMOELEY WHEN I WAS
DEMOIDERING WHETHER I WOULD
DEMOND THAT'S- I JUST HAPPENED
DEMO A- THE DATE FOR PEOPLE'S
DEMO PROVED. HI ANYTHING THAT
OUR DEMO WALK THE STREETS.
DEMOGRAPHIC OUT. THIS IS.
DEMOCE SAID I SEE ALL PEOPLE.
DEMORDS. MY THROAT IS BURNING
AND I AM- DEMOEOUS AND OF
DEMOSE I JUST. WITH THE CROWD.
AND I DEMO WHERE TO GO I JUST
DEMO RUNNING IT SO. THESE ARE.
DEMO IS CHEMICAL I APPRECIATE.
DEMO BRINGING THE BILL I WILL
BE A DEMOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE
AND DEMOS SEE IF THERE'S ANY
DEMOTIONS OR- I HAD MORE LUCK
DEMOK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN. IN
DEMO IN THERE ARE ALSO A LOT OF
DEMOCE OFFICERS THAT HAVE HAD
ON IT DEMOMOND ROSEN WATER
DEMOLES AND CANS THAT WERE
DEMOEN AND SIT IN A SEARCH FOR
DEMORIES. EVEN PROTECTING
DEMOLE YOU'RE KIND OF
DEMOOUNDED DURING. PAST CARBON.
A DEMOATION SO- I CERTAINLY
DEMODN'T WANT TO BE THERE WITH
DEMO HATS GOING ON. BUT BOB I
AM DEMO CURIOUS WHAT OTHER
DEMOS ARE THERE WITH. WHAT ARE
THE DEMOTEGIES BUT ELSE CAN WE
DO DEMOUSE. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
DEMOS I TRY TO BUILD A FEW
DEMOS AGO JUST YOU KNOW JUST TO
HAVE A PEACEFUL DEMONSTRATION
BUT DEMOLE ARE BRINGING BATS IN
DEMOE FOR YOU BRING AS WE HAVE
DEMO FOR THAT. FACE SO A MAJOR
DEMOOUS WHAT CAN WE DO TO FIND
DEMO BALANCE IN THIS EQUATION
FOR LAW DEMORCEMENT TO BE. ABLE
TO. DEMOESS THESE MAYBE
DEMOTIMES RIOTOUS CROWDS I WANT
TO BE DEMOR THAT IT DOESN'T
DEMOIBIT ALL LESS THAN LETHAL
DEMO OF FORCE I'M TEAR GAS
DEMOR CS AND CN OUR OUR ON'T
DEMOUGH THIS OTHER CHEMICAL
DEMOTS THAT CAN STILL BE USE
DEMO DANGEROUS CAN AGENTS.
DEMOY AS PEPPER SPRAY STILL
DEMOE ARE STILL USES BUT FOR
ALL THE DEMO WE CALL LESS THAN
DEMOAL USES OF FORCE BY THE ONE
DEMOY THAT'S BEEN DONE ON THE
IN THE DEMOISH MEDICINE THEY
DEMO ALSO SENATE. IT COSTS. IF
DEMOEEN THE TIME YES IT SETS
OUT DEMODARD WHICH POLICE NEED
TO GO DEMOUGH TO USE IT BUT
DEMO NEED TO DE ESCALATE THE
DEMOATION THAT THEY NEED TO
DEMO PEOPLE THAT NEEDED FOR THE
DEMOLE CAN BE BEFORE IT STARTED
DEMOK. B. B. BRING. WHAT'S A
PAL DEMO ARE WITH. IT HAS TO BE
DEMOETED IT'S WHO HAS THE
DEMOEN IS GONNA THROW AT THEM
IT DEMOS REASONABLE RIGHT YET I
DEMOK A LOT OF US HAVE HAD GONE
TO DEMOEST AS THE- MASTER YEAH
DEMOE MIGHT. TRYING TO OUR
DEMOBLE. BUT ANY BE DIRECTED AT
DEMO PERSON THEN AND IT NEEDS
TO BE DEMO IN THE WAY THE
DEMOFACTURERS OF THESE WEAPONS
DEMOECT THANK YOU NOT.AS IT'S
A DEMOW AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
DEMO LINES UP IT LINES UP ALL
OF DEMOE STEPS THAT SHOULD BE
DEMON OFFICERS NEED BE TRACKED
DEMOECTLY. NEED THE TO BE TO
YOU THE DEMOON. NOT JUST
DEMOECT HOW CARE LESS DANGEROUS
SO DEMO THEY CAN
DEMOSCRIMINATELY. USE IT
DEMONST A CROWD WHEN THERE
DEMOT BE A TROUBLE MAKER IF YOU
DEMO SOMEBODY WHO SCHOOL
DEMOUSE BODILY INJURY. IS
DEMONST THAT PERSON RATHER THAN
OF DEMOD THAT'S WHAT THE STEPS.
DEMOK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
DEMOTOR JACKSON HAS HER HAND UP
DEMOTOR JACKSON- KANANI EARLY
YOU DEMO BE A MUTED LET'S SEE.
BUT DEMOE ARE NOT MUCH- YOU
DEMO I HAPPEN TO BE A WATCHING-
THE PRO DEMO OUTSIDE THE WHITE
DEMOE WHEN SUDDENLY THE
DEMOIDENT DECIDED I WANTED TO
DEMO A BOB IN A BIBLE. OF THE
DEMOECT WAS VERY FALL IN
DEMOENLY THE GAS CAME AND
DEMOLE WERE INJURED IT WAS A
DEMO SCARY OF COURSE. THAT A
DEMOTE CAN THE IMPACT IT WAS
DEMONG ON THE CROWD. ON FORCED
DEMOT AND WITH THE ACCESS TO
DEMOE KINDS OF WEAPONS IT
DEMOLY GIVES YOU POPS UP ONE OF
THE DEMOERIA I LOOK AT IS. WHEN
DEMOLE WANT TO PEACEFULLY
DEMOEST THIS IS A
DEMOTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
DEMOT. AND NOTION AT. LAW
DEMORCEMENT. WHAT CURRENT
DEMOLE LONG THREE TO REDUCE
DEMOR- OF INJURY THIS IS AYE
AYE DEMO BUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEMOS TO BE TRAINED TO REDUCE
THE DEMOLIHOOD OF ANY INJURY
DEMOHER IT IS. AND T. OR- OF
DEMOT WING PROTESTERS CARRYING
A K. DEMOY SEVENS ON A PUBLIC
DEMOET R. I THINK WHAT'S REALLY
DEMOICAL. THAT I'LL NEED TO.
DEMO FOR THE LONG FORCED. USES
ANY OF DEMOE OPTIONS EVEN WANTS
TO DEMOIN AVAILABLE ONLY AS A
DEMO RESORT I THINK OF THE FACT
DEMO IT'S BEEN A TIME SCHOOL I
DEMO WANTED TO. BRING UP I
DEMOT A PEACEFUL PRO. SHOW THAT
SHE CAN DEMORSTAND AND ACCEPT
DEMOE HER RIDE SHOULD
DEMORSTAND WHAT PEOPLE ARE
DEMONG TO THE STREETS TO TRY TO
DEMOH PASSED. I'M FREQUENTLY I
DEMOD SAY NO AND WITH MY GRANT
NOW DEMO TO TAKE THAT. ROAD
DEMOE COBIT. SO THAT SEE MARCUS
IN DEMOON AND YET AM CONCERNED
DEMOUSE OF WHAT I THINK BEEN IN
DEMOCESSARY OVER REACH AND USE
OF. DEMOONRY I AND VIA. ADD TO
DEMOCALLY DISBURSING CROWD
DEMOH PUT THE LIFE IN DANGER
AND DEMO SHOULD NOT BE THE JOB
ON FOR SO. DEMO TO SING. WHO
ARE DEMOIFIED IN OPPOSITION TO
DEMO MEASURE THAT THEY MEET
DEMOME UP WITH SOME BLESSED.
DEMODENT LAST BELIEVES ALL MEN
AND TO DEMOAIN CROWDS USE ANY
OF DEMOONAL TECHNIQUE ONLY IS A
LOT DEMORT. BUT TO DO IT. DID
DEMOT AND THAT IT SHOULD BE AS
A DEMOLT OF ONLY THE MOST
DEMOIFICANT AND A SUBSTANTIAL
DEMONING THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
DEMOD REACH FOR WEAPONRY IN
DEMO OF PEACEFUL DISPERSAL OF
DEMODS SO I APPRECIATE THIS
DEMO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEMOOLIDATION OF HAPPY SUPPORT
DEMOK YOU SENATOR JACKSON
DEMOTOR MITCH. THANK YOU THANK
YOU DEMO MADAM. FROM TO MOVE
DEMO THIS IS A THE NEARLY GREAT
DEMO IT'S HAS A LOT OF KIND OF
OUR OUR DEMOR BARBIE IN TIME
AND YOU DEMO AS MY- BODY DO
DEMOER THERE WAS A TWO IN
DEMOORY WHEN IT WAS DEEMED
DEMOOPRIATE. WATER IS OFTEN. OF
DEMOITE NINE PEACE PRO. OF WE
ALL ARE DEMOR NOW FIFTH SIXTY
DEMOR THAT THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM
AND I DEMOK- THROUGH THE
DEMORIENCE THESE MOST RECENT
DEMOESTS AND THE TO NOW ARE
DEMO ARE NOT APPROPRIATE EITHER.
I DEMO FULL FAITH THAT LONG FOR
AS THE DEMOCITY TO TRAIN AND TO
AYE DEMO TO ABOUT IT. TO SEE
THE DEMOE AT THE STATE YOU
DEMOETS HORSE. AS A WAY TO JUST
DEMOR SHE SIZE IT PRESENTS
DEMOGE CROWDED MOVE ROUTES I
DEMOHED OF IT'S A MESS TO SEE
AND SO I DEMOD SUPPORT THE
DEMO. I THINK THE- TOOL IF YOU
DEMO ON THAT I DID IN THE BILL
DEMO'T APPROACH. YOU SEEN OUR-
USE DEMO LINK. I THINK THIS MAY
DEMO SIMPLY GIVE LONG. THE
DEMOA. TO FIGURE OUT A MORE
DEMOOPRIATE WAY BECAUSE AS WE
DEMONED WE DO BETTER. I'M OF
THE DEMO WE GOT MOTIONS SENATOR
DEMOLEY. THANK YOU MANAGER I
DEMOK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
DEMOURES WALL IN MY COMMENTS
DEMONE WITH BOTH CENTER JACKSON
DEMOER MITCHELL AS IT RELATES
TO. DEMO A COMMON SENSE
DEMOOACH TO- USING- THESE TYPE
OF DEMOONS AREN'T STILL LET
DEMO SCRATCH MY HEAD AND
DEMOEMENT THAT. THE LEVEL OF
DEMOE. THAT WE CHOOSE ON PEACE
DEMOESTERS IN WASHINGTON DC AS
DEMO AS PORTLAND BUT CONTRAST
YOU GO TO DEMOIGAN WHERE YOU
HAD DEMOD WHITE SUPREMACISTS
DEMO ASSAULT WEAPONS WHO WERE
DEMOD TO MOVE ON REPEATED TIMES
AND NOT ONE DEMO DID THEY YIELD
TO THE DEMOCE. AND NOT ON. CAN
OF DEMO GAS WAS FIRED NOT ONE
DEMOR BILL BULLET SO HOW CAN
YOU BE DEMO FEARFUL OF A FROZEN
DEMOR BOTTLE. BAN ASSAULT
DEMOONS TO OUR- I'M AT A LOSS
AS TO HOW YOU CAN DEMOIFY ONE
DEMOUS THE OTHER TWO THAT
DEMOAINS. SO ON THAT POINT I'M
DEMO AND TO OF THIS MEASURE
DEMOK YOU. THUNDERING OF. THANK
YOU DEMOM CHAIR THE YOU FOR
DEMOGING THIS PHONE HAPPY TO
DEMOG AUTHOR OF THE AND A
DEMONG IT'S A NO BRAINER- I
DEMO WANT TO SAY IT'S GREAT
DEMO IN THE AFTERMATH OF. THE
JOY DEMOD. FULLER AND ON THAT
DEMOADY WE'RE- SEEING REALLY
DEMO BILLS COMING FORWARD
DEMOND POLICE USE OF FORCE BUT
DEMO BROADER CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DEMORM- AND IT'S GOOD WE'RE
DEMOA GET SOME GOOD THINGS DONE
DEMO YEAR- AND BUT I JUST WANT
TO SAY DEMO IS A CHALLENGE. TO
THE DEMORE LEGISLATURE. WE
DEMOT JUST HAVE YOU KNOW. A FEW
DEMO THIS YEAR INCLUDING GOOD
DEMOS LIKE THIS ONE. AND IS GO
DEMO TO BUSINESS AS USUAL AND
THE DEMOSLATURE- THIS
DEMOSLATURE IS BEEN DONE SOME
DEMOLY REALLY GOOD THINGS IN
DEMONT YEARS SO I'M NOT YOU
DEMO AND PEOPLE MEMBERS IN THIS
DEMO HAVE BEEN STRONG LEADERS.
I'M NOT A DEMOOUT. THINGS BUT
DEMOE IS STILL MUCH WORK TO DO
IN DEMOS OF. CHANGING THING BUT
DEMO ENDING MASS INCARCERATION
DEMO BOUGHT SOME IS A REALLY
DEMOLY HARD BILLS AND WE HAVE
TO. DEMO MOMENTUM HAS TAKEN TO.
IN DEMO YEAR WE HAVE TO BE
DEMOING TO DO THAT BUT THIS IS
A. DEMOT BILL AND HAPPY TO
DEMOORT. THANK YOU. FOR ASKING
DEMOE HONEST. KERR THAT WE CAN
DEMO. OF PLEASE GO THE ROLL.
DEMONER I'M HERE ENTER HERE
DEMO. MORE LIKE PRESENT AND CAN
I DEMOND TO TURN ON MICROPHONES
FOR DEMO M. BRADFORD. YOUR
DEMOFORD HERE JACKSON. JACKSON
DEMO JACKSON HERE REMOTELY
DEMOHELL MITCHELL HERE MITCHELL
DEMO MORALE. EARLIER MORALE
DEMOENT REMOTELY WIENER
DEMOIDENT WINNER PRESENCE.
DEMOS BEEN ESTABLISHED STREET
WE DEMO A QUORUM- ASSEMBLY
DEMOER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
DEMOECTFULLY ASK FOR ITEMS.
DEMO SERVE A LOCAL THE MOTION
IS TO DEMO TWO PROBES. THE
DEMOOR PER ABC SIX SKINNER HI
IN OUR AYE DEMOOCK. MORE LIKE
NOT DEMONG BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE DEMOSON. JACKSON AYE
DEMOSON AVE MITCHELL MITCHELL
BY MID DEMO MORALE WELL NO
DEMOANO WINNER. WHEN OUR EYES
THE DEMO PASSES TO ONE RATIO
DEMO BILL- SEE WE DON'T NEED TO
PUT OUR DEMOS ARE OUT OKAY SO
DEMO BILLS OUT FIVE TWO ONE
DEMOS GO TO AB ONE FIVE IT'S-
AND IS HE DEMOL IN THE ROOM
DEMON ROOM YES OKAY. MEMBER
DEMOERSON IT. G. R. NUMBERS. I
DEMOLY DO APPRECIATE OF OUR
DEMOENTING. GAVIN'S LAW THIS
DEMO IS NAMED FOR GAVIN
DEMODING HE WAS A BELOVED VICE
DEMOCIPAL FROM CLOVIS
DEMOICALLY HIT AND KILLED IN
THE DEMOY MORNING HOURS WHILE
HE WAS OUT FOR A RUN DEMOLY TWO
DEMOS AGO. I GABIN. HUSBAND
DEMOER PASSIONATE EDUCATOR
DEMOER PEACE CORPS VOLUNTEER HE
WAS DEMOVED BY ALL OF US IN OUR
DEMOUNITY. AND WHAT HAPPENED
DEMON WAS THE DRIVER WHO KILLED
HIM DID NOT DEMO DID NOT START
FOR DEMO. AS GAVIN LAY THEIR
DEMONG TO ALIVE BUT THE DRIVER
DEMO. EVIDENCE DISCOVERED WAS
DEMO THIS DRIVER WAS DRINKING
AT A DEMOY JUST A LITTLE PRIOR
TO THE HIT AND DEMO NOT BECAUSE
HE DEMO THE SCENE HE WAS NOT
DEMOHT FOR FIVE DAYS. I HE
DEMOSTED- FRIENDS AND FAMILY
DEMOERS TO HELP HIDE. THE
DEMOENCE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEMOCIALS. COULD NOT FIND HIM
AND DEMOD NOT. TESTING FOR THE
DEMOKENNESS AND WHAT DID HITLER
TO BY THE DEMO THE EVIDENCE
DEMOG THE WAY. BY FLEEING THIS
DEMOVIDUAL CAN AND DID. AVOID
DEMOTION CHARGES FOR DRIVING
DEMOR THE INFLUENCE M. FOR
DEMOING INJURY AND DEATH. THE
DEMOMUM SENTENCE FOR HIT AND
RUN DEMOLVING DEATH IS FOUR
DEMOS THE MAN WHO KILLED GAVIN
DEMO WAS SET TO JUST THREE
DEMOED. EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
DEMOERS I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
ON DEMO. I DO UNDERSTAND THAT
DEMO THIS BILL PROPOSES IS
DEMOTHING THAT IS HISTORICALLY
DEMOIDE OF YOUR PRIORITIES
DEMORALLY AND BELIEFS ABOUT
DEMOINAL JUSTICE AND
DEMOBILITATION. I FULLY
DEMORSTAND THAT. BUT THE CHAIR
OF THE DEMOMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY.
DEMOITTEE ALSO AT THE TIME OF
THE DEMOENTATION EXPRESSED
DEMOLLY STRONG CONCERNS. I WIN
BUT DEMO THIS BILL WAS BROUGHT
DEMORE THE- BUT WHAT HAPPENED
WAS DEMO HE FACT OF THE MATTER
AND THE DEMOIMONY. AND THE
DEMOOVERY THAT IN THE CODE
DEMOE WAS THIS. THE PERVERSE
DEMONTIVE TO HIT KILL LEAVE AND
DEMOS IN SIX SERIOUS
DEMOEQUENCES. M. AS OF THE
DEMOITTEE. THOUGHT SERIOUSLY
DEMOT IT THE BILL WAS. A
DEMOURY A BUCHANON
DEMOMMENDATION. WE HAD A
DEMOERSATION ABOUT IT AFTER THE
DEMOIMONY. THERE WAS A
DEMONSIDERATION WE WENT TO WORK
DEMO THE COMMITTEE. AND WE CAME
TO DEMO THE CONCLUSION AND THE-
DEMODMENTS. THAT DID TWO
DEMOIFICANT THINGS. ONE IT
DEMOED A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
DEMO. FROM THE CHAIR AND FROM
DEMOERS OF THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
DEMOTY COMMITTEE. AND SECONDLY.
IT DEMOED SEVENTY TWO VOTES ON
THE DEMOR OF THE ASSEMBLY. SO
DEMO IS A BILL. IT DOES
DEMOEASE A SENTENCE FOR FLEEING
THE DEMOE RESULTING IN THE
DEMOH OF ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL.
DEMO HAVING A SENTENCE OF TWO
DEMOE OR FOUR YEARS TO HAVING A
DEMOMUM OF THREE FOUR FOUR SIX
DEMOS. THIS IS ALSO IMPORTANT.
IT DEMOD STILL BE A WHILE
DEMORE. IT THEREFORE MAINTAINS
A DEMOE'S FULL DISCRETION. TO
DEMOGATE THE SENTENCE DOWN EVEN
DEMOHER TO A MISDEMEANOR BASED
ON THE DEMOUMSTANCES OF THE
DEMONSE WHILE STILL ALLOWING AN
DEMOVIDUAL TO BE HELD
DEMOUNTABLE BASED UPON THE
DEMOIFIC NATURE OF THE CONTACT.
AND THE DEMOVIOR OF THAT
DEMOVIDUAL SO THIS IS NOT ONE
DEMO FITS ALL. ASKING TODAY I'M
DEMOY IT'S DIFFICULT TO BREATHE
DEMOUGH THIS MASK. FOR ALL
DEMOE DIFFERENT HOPE WHAT I'M
DEMONG YOU TODAY. CONSIDER THIS
IS THE DEMOEMENTAL WAY IT'S NOT
A DEMOTIC WAY. IRWIN YEAH.
DEMOWING FOR GOOD CONTABILIDADE
DEMOD ON THE DISCRETION OF THE
DEMOE THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE
FAX AND THE DEMORE OF THE
DEMONSE. AGAIN DESPITE TROUBLE
DEMOTHING. DESPITE THE FACT
DEMO THIS IS A SMALL SENTENCE
DEMOEASE. YOUR ASSEMBLY
DEMOEAGUES BUT SEVENTY TWO
DEMOS AND- I'M ASKING THAT YOU
DEMOIDER IT IN THE SAME LIGHT.
I AM DEMO THE DETAILS OF THE
DEMO AND THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
DEMO. I BELIEVE CAN BE SEEN IN
THE DEMOT OF YOUR PRINCIPLES
AND IN DEMOT OF YOUR INTEREST
IN DEMOIC SAFETY. AND JUSTICE.
TO DEMOIFY IS. WIFE'S GLADDING.
AND DEMOR FRESNO COUNTY
DEMOSTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY
DEMOY STANLEY. THANK YOU-ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND BEFORE I
DEMOT WITH OUR LEAD WITNESSES
AS I DEMOCATED. DUE TO A NUMBER
OF DEMOS IN THE TIME THAT WE
DEMO AND JUST THE NATURE OF
DEMOG THESE THINGS REMOTE WE
DEMO LIMITED THE TOTAL AMOUNT
OF DEMO FOR THE WITNESSES IN
DEMOORT TO THREE MINUTES AND
THE DEMO WAY WE HAVE ONLY THREE
DEMOTES FOR THE WITNESSES IN
DEMOCE. PLEASE SO DON'T DON'T
DEMOD A DESPERATE MAN IT'S FOR
DEMO WITNESSES YES IT IS. AT A
DEMOTE MY HALF FOR SUSAN
DEMODING. HE WE ALL RIGHT OUR
DEMOE THOSE WHO WERE STATED
DEMO THE BEGINNING WE MAY BE A
DEMOLE GENEROUS ON THAT MY ONLY
DEMOLEM WITH ALLOWING FOR
DEMOER IS THAN ALL OTHER BILLS
DEMO LAST LONGER SO. IN THIS
WAY I AM DEMOING IT NOW SO I
DEMOD LIKE TO DO SUSAN IF YOU
CAN DO TWO DEMOTES. CAN YOU DO
TWO DEMOTES. WE'LL TRY AND I
DEMOK FOR THE A DISTRICT
DEMORNEY WOULD LIKE TO LIMIT
DEMO TO ONE OKAY THAT'S FINE
DEMOT RIGHT THANK YOU SO LET'S
DEMOT THERE LEAD WITNESS- MISS
DEMODING YOU CAN COME TO THE
DEMO SHE'S PHYSICALLY HERE GO
DEMOD. MONTR SKINNER VENTURE
DEMOLACH AND MEMBERS OF THE
DEMOITTEE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS DEMON GLIDING AND I'M A
DEMODENT OF CLOTHES CALIFORNIA
IN DEMONO COUNTY AND I WANT TO
DEMOK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO DEMOK. TO YOU TODAY TO ALL
MY DEMONDS AND FAMILY STORY. ON
THE DEMOING OF SEPTEMBER.
DEMOEENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN. MY
DEMOLY'S LIFE WAS CHANGED
DEMOVER. MY HUSBAND MY BEST
DEMOND AND FATHER OF MY TWO
DEMOG CHILDREN GAVIN GLIDING
WAS DEMOEN FROM US BY. BUS HIT
AND RUN DEMOER. THE DRIVER WHO
DEMORTEDLY HAD BEEN DRINKING
AND DEMOS OF SEPTEMBER
DEMOEENTH AND WHO DIDN'T HAVE A
DEMOER'S LICENSE GOT INTO HIS
DEMONTS TRUCK. LOST CONTROL OF
THE DEMOCLE AND SWERVED INTO MY
DEMOAND THIS IS JOGGING
DEMOGSIDE THE ROAD. GAVEN
DEMOERED MAJOR INJURIES FROM
THE DEMOISION AND WAS LEFT
DEMOING ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD
AS THE DEMOER FLED THE SCENE.
HE DID NOT DEMO THE DECENCY TO
DEMO OR AT THE VERY LEAST. NINE
ONE ONE TWO SET DEMO. AND HE
DEMOE AWAY VERY QUICKLY.
DEMOIRED THE TRACK AND RETURN
TO THE DEMO TO TIMES WITHIN OUR
DEMO HIS FRIENDS TO ASSESS THE
DEMO. FROM THE MOMENT THAT THE
DEMOER DID WE SEE AS ACTIONS
DEMON'T. BRING OUR LATE. I VERY
DEMOD REMEMBERED EVENTS OF THAT
DEMOING AND WILL NEVER FORGET
AS THE DEMOOR EXPLAINED MY
DEMOAND'S INJURIES TO ME THAT
DEMO DIDN'T KNOW HOW LONG IT
DEMO OUT ON THE ROAD. THE
DEMONT IT WENT FOR WHAT I
DEMOEVED WAS AN ACCIDENT TO HIT
AND RUN DEMOE. I HAVE NO WORDS
TO DEMOAIN HOW IT FELT KNOWING
DEMO MY HUSBAND WAS LEFT ALONE
ON THE DEMO OF THE ROAD AND NOT
DEMOING HOW LONG HE HAD BEEN
DEMOE. WHAT'S YOUR WEIGHT
DEMOTING AND IN WITH THE SCARED.
DEMOSTATINGLY PASSED AWAY LATER
DEMO MORNING. FROM THE INJURIES
DEMO HE SUSTAINED. THE DRIVER
DEMO FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
DEMOST A WEEK WELL MY FAMILY
DEMOGGLED. WITH THIS AN
DEMOMPREHENSIBLE LOSS AND ALSO
DEMO THE WEIGHT OF NOT KNOWING
DEMO IT HAPPENED AND WHO WAS
DEMOONSIBLE. MY HUSBAND WAS
DEMOY ONE OF A KIND AND HIS
DEMO IS TAKEN FROM HIM WAY TOO
DEMO HIS THAN MINE ARE JUST IN
DEMOAGE SO. ONE STORY OF
DEMOREDS AND THOUSANDS OF
DEMOLAR HEARTBREAKING STORIES
OF DEMOLIES AND LIVES. THAT
DEMOD THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
DEMOUGH HIT AND RUN CRIMES IN
OUR DEMOE EVERY YEAR AND I'VE
DEMOD FROM SO MANY OF THEM
DEMOE THIS HAPPENED MY HUSBAND.
THE WAY DEMO THE CALIFORNIA
DEMO WRITTEN TO DATE
DEMONTIVIZE IS THE DRIVER TO
DEMO THE SCENE RATHER THAN STOP
AND DEMOST THE INDIVIDUAL THAT
DEMO ARE CRITICALLY INJURED
DEMO THEIR VEHICLE THIS IS
DEMOCIALLY THE CASE THAT THEY
DEMO BEEN DRINKING. THIS
DEMOEDY BROUGHT AWARENESS TO
THE DEMO THERE'S A LOOPHOLE. IN
THE DEMOENT LEGISLATION I DON'T
DEMOEVE THAT THE LAW WAS
DEMOBLISHED WITH THAT INTENTION
AND DEMOS TO BE CORRECTED IN
DEMOR TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
DEMOLF BUT OVER TEN THOUSAND
DEMORS SINCE YOU PASSED THE
DEMOTE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
DEMOIC SAFETY AND THE
DEMOSLATURE SUPPORT THIS BILL
TO DEMOE THIS LOOPHOLE. AND
DEMOSED FOR VEHICLE TWO
DEMOSAND ONE WITH EIGHTY ONE
DEMOTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
DEMO NO UP TO THE PRESS AS-
DEMO IS THE- FRESNO'S
DEMOSTANTS ATTORNEY MISTER
DEMOLEY GO AHEAD YOU HAVE A
DEMOTE GOOD MORNING MADAM
DEMORMAN COMMITTEE JERRY
DEMOLEY APPROACH COMMENTS IT IS
A DEMOON WORKING HATS ONE IS AN
DEMOTY EIGHT AND PER AND
DEMOIDENT AND ANOTHER AS AN
DEMOVIDUAL I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH-
DEMON AND HE WAS A GREAT GUY.
DEMOYTHING YOU PER POSSIBLE
DEMOLUTELY TRUE LET ME PUT ON
MY DEMOR HALF FOR JUST A FEW
DEMONTS AND WHY I BELIEVE THAT
DEMO BILL WOULD MAKE IT BOB
DEMO. PENCE OF THE GAVIN. OF
ALL THE DEMOOSED JUST IN THE
DEMOE IN TRIAD THIS IS NOT A
DEMOONIAN IN SORT OF REGRET LET
DEMO INCOMES WITH THE THAT WE
DEMO TO. SECONDLY THE ENHANCE
AND DEMOD DOESN'T EVEN TO BE A
AS A DEMOXE GIVE THE COURT THE-
TO. DEMOATE DOWNWARD FROM A
DEMONY TO GRANT PROBATION SO NO
DEMO TO SEND AND IT ALLOWS TO
DEMO AND POSING A JAIL OR
DEMOON TERM. APPLY IN MARCH IN
A LOT OF DEMO WHEN WARRANTED AS
THE DEMOIMENTS. NGUYEN
DEMOANTED TO FIT THE
DEMOUMSTANCES AND NATURE OF THE
DEMOIFIC VIOLATION. BECAUSE THE
DEMOT DISCRETION EMPHATICALLY
DEMOINS IN THE PROPOSED STATUTE
THE DEMOERNS EXPRESSED ANY
DEMOSITION TO THIS PIECE OF
DEMOSLATION ABOUT PRISON
DEMOCROWDING AND INCREASED
DEMOS INCARCERATION OR
DEMOLACED AND OVERSTATED.
DEMOTIONALLY BY CREATING A
DEMOENCING STRUCTURE THE BETTER
DEMOLLELS THAT SEEN DELIGHTS
DEMOING INJURY THIS BILL VERY
DEMO OF PROVIDING FOR. THAT IS
DEMOPING UNDER EIGHT AND BY NOT
DEMO THE Y. DRY A. IT WILL
DEMON BENEFIT AT SENTENCING
DEMOED CREATE. THAT IS NOT THE
DEMOENT STATE WITH THE EXISTING
DEMO HIT AND RUN CAUSING INJURY
OR DEMOH YOU COULD- OUTLINES
DEMO IS THE ONLY MISTER STANLEY
DEMO TO WRAP UP. I WILL I WILL.
AT THE DEMOOM LINE IS THAT THIS
DEMO IS NOT ONLY NOT ONLY BUILD
AN DEMOOPRIATE DETERRENT FACTOR
DEMO IT ARE THEY JUST TODAY BUT
IT DEMO BUILDING A PUBLIC
DEMOTY MECHANISM WHICH A FULL.
THE DEMOITY. THREE WHEN
DEMOANTED. THAT YOU LINE- WOULD
NOT DEMONDED GAVIN'S
DEMOHEARTED SENSIBILITIES AND I
DEMOD AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. I
DEMOECIATE THAT THIS IS A VERY.
DEMOIONAL CASE FOR AND A
DEMOBALL IN HORROR DEATH. BUT I
DEMOLY NEED TO HAVE THE
DEMOESSES- WE HAVE A LOT OF
DEMOS AND WE NEED TO APPLY IT
TO ALL DEMO ALSO MATTERS BECOME
DEMOVE WE ARE AN OPEN EXCUSE ME
DEMO GOING TO OPEN THE LINES
DEMO STILL AT THE PLACE OF
DEMONG FOR SUPPORT SO THAT MAY
BE DEMOING. MODERATOR ARE
DEMOE- IN THE COLLINS WHO WANT
TO DEMOK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
DEMO. THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
DEMOLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN DEMOORT OF AB ONE NINETY
DEMO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
DEMO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU
DEMO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE DEMOTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE DEMONT PROPER FIRST COMMON.
DEMO TWO FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
DEMOK YOU- PAUL SMITH
DEMOVIDUAL RESIDENT FRESNO
DEMOFORNIA ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
DEMOTY THREE SENATE-DISTRICT
DEMOT I CALL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF DEMO LEGISLATION. NINE TWO
DEMOY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OF.
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MAN DEMORANCE CENTERS PROGRAM
DEMOSS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
DEMOEDA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DEMO TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN YES
GO DEMOD. NINE ONE TEN YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IT. I MAY BE. DEMO LINE IS OPEN.
AND DEMO NINETY THREE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO. PLEASE HOLD BLOOD
DEMOLLED I AM CALLING IN STRONG
DEMOORT OF GAVIN'S LAW AND
DEMOESTED FROM. NINE SIXTY
DEMON YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. IN WILLIAM AND
DEMOUNITY MEMBER AND FAMILY
DEMOND IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
ONE DEMOTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GABRIELLE
DEMO GAVIN RIDING WITH MY
DEMOHERS I MEAN STOCKTON OF AB
ONE DEMOTY FIVE. NINE ONE SIXTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. JACKIE OR SHE
DEMOITTEE MEMBER I AM STRONG
DEMOORT OF AB ONE NINETY FIVE.
DEMO EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME
IS DEMOR GLIDING MY DAD WAS
DEMOLVED IN A HIT AND RUN AND I
DEMO TO TELL YOU THAT I THINK
FOR DEMONESE LAW. NINE FORTY
DEMOE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. I'M LORENA CALLING
DEMON STAMP AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF THE DEMOK. ONE TWO ZERO
DEMOT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD THAT'S- THANK YOU
DEMOIE MASTERS MOTHER OF
DEMOHER VICTIM I STRONGLY
DEMOORT THIS LAW PLEASE DON'T
DEMOET THE VICTIMS. NINE FORTY
DEMON YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. MY NAME IS DEREK LANA
AND THE DEMOD AT THE GLIDING
DEMOLY. STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
DEMOY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. NINE FIFTY TWO
YOU MAY BE ON DEMO PLEASE GO
DEMOD. MOVING ON TO LINE. ONE
DEMOEEN NINE ONE FIFTEEN YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOERLY WHITE COMMUNITY MEMBER
IN DEMONG SUPPORT. NINE ONE
DEMOY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. WELL DIDN'T
DEMO OF ANY RECALLS NORMALLY
DEMO'RE ALL HE WAS ALSO A
DEMOIM OF A HIT AND RUN THEIR
DEMORUCTOR FOR. NINE SEVENTY
DEMON. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
DEMO LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
DEMOD. NOTHING UNDERMINE TO
DEMOY THREE NINE TWO FIFTY
DEMOE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. MY NAME IS TAYLOR FOR
DEMOHAN OF MISTER COLLIDING
DEMO MY TEACHER IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND I DEMOK IN SUPPORT. OF
DEMOEN BLOCKED. NINE ONE
DEMORED YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING I
WAS THE DEMO CHILD COMMUNITY
DEMOER IN FUTURE AND GAVIN
DEMODREN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
DEMON BLOCK. NINE NINETY NINE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
DEMOERATE RECALL GRANARY
DEMOING NUMBER AND FAMILY
DEMOND OF THE BLOODY IN. STRONG
DEMOORT. MY TWO SEVENTY YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOAL DRUNK REPORTED GAP NTIL.
DEMOD YOU STATE YOUR NAY FOR.
DEMOMBLY GLOBAL IN SUPPORT OF
DEMON'S LAW IN ADDITION TO THE
DEMOST HIT AND RUN THIS PAST
DEMO OF A MOTHER AND HER UNBORN
DEMOD STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE
DEMOTY FIVE. NINE TO FORTY ONE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. CATHERINE JAMISON FROM
DEMONO CALIFORNIA I AM IN
DEMONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE
DEMOTY FIVE. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HELLO MY NAME IS MARY
DEMOCES GREEN FRESNO COUNTY I'M
DEMOING TO SUPPORT GAVIN'S LAW
IN DEMORY OF MY LATE NEPHEW
DEMOUA WILLIAMS WHO WAS KILLED
IN DEMOTY FIFTEEN. BY A MAN
DEMOING WITH A SUSPENDED
DEMONSE TO THE PREVIOUS DUI
DEMOICTIONS THANK YOUNG WITH
DEMORS OF MEMBRANES YOU.
DEMORATOR MY MIND TO FORTY
DEMON YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
A DEMO RICH FAMILY WE STAND
DEMONG SUPPORT OF ONE NINETY
DEMO. NINE TO SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT
DEMO JACQUI PAGE- I AM IN FRONT
DEMOORT OF GAP AND I A FAMILY
DEMOND. NINE SIXTY FOUR YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMO SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOVING ON
TO DEMO SIXTY SIX POINT SIXTY
SIX DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DEMOARD AT FAULT I AM A
DEMOUNITY MEMBER AND I AM IN
DEMOORT OF CABINS ALL. NINE TO
DEMOY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. MY NAME'S
DEMOT HUNT I'M A CONSTITUENT
DEMOMBLYNAY PATTERSON
DEMOECTED WITH THE BILL. NINE
TO DEMOTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS.
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. THIS IS JAMIE
DEMOHERD COMMUNITY MEMBER AND
DEMOLY FRIEND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF DEMOEN FONG. NINE ONE EIGHTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. HI MY NAME IS MERRY
DEMOT LEADING MEMBER AND FAMILY
DEMOND IVAN FONG THE COURT OF
DEMON FONG. NINE TO FORTY SIX
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. YOU MAY BE A NEW NINE TO
DEMOY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY DEMO IS TERRA KELLYANNE FROM
LOS DEMOLES I KNEW DEVIN.
DEMOING DYSTER. AND I'M STRONG
DEMOORT AT ONE NINETY FIVE.
DEMO TO FORTY YOUR LINE IS A
DEMOSE GO. HELLO MY NAME IS
DEMOE MCCLAREN- AND GATHERS
DEMOE STEVE. HE WAS MY ONLY
DEMOEW BY DOING ALL THIS LIFE I
WAS DEMOTY YEARS IN LAW
DEMORCEMENT AND WE USED TO CALL
DEMO KIND OF BEHAVIOR TIME TO
DEMOR UP AND LAWYER UP AND I
DEMOY SINGLE YOU HAVEN'T SAW.
DEMORATOR NINE TO SEVENTY NINE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD WELL. LINDOR RODRIGUEZ
DEMOUNITY MEMBER AND SUPPORT.
DEMO ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
IF DEMO MEET YES IT IS PLEASE
GO DEMOD. THANK YOU HELLO MY
DEMO IS RAYMOND FORGOT THERE'S
A DEMOERNED CITIZEN LAMAR
DEMOFORNIA COUNTY OF KINGS AND
I DEMOEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT AB ONE
DEMOTY FIVE. THANK YOU. MY
DEMOTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
DEMONON AND FAMILY I LEARNED
DEMODENTS THE FRESNO COUNTY AND
DEMOLY FRIEND OF THE BODY AND
WE DEMOLETELY SUPPORT AB ONE
DEMO FIVE. NINE TO EIGHTY ONE
DEMO LINE OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY DEMO IS DEBBIE HUNT BAKER I
AM A DEMOLONG FOR THE FUN OF
THE DEMOEY. AND WHILE I DIDN'T
DEMO. MR THANK YOU THANK YOU
DEMORATOR BUT THAT. MY TWENTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. MIND FOUR YOUR LINE
IS DEMO. PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE
DEMOON LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO LINE
DEMOY SIX LINE FORTY SIX YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY DEMO IS IRMA'S- SKIING GAVIN
DEMODING WAS MY BEST FRIEND AND
I AM DEMOLUTELY IN STRONG
DEMOORT OF AB ONE NINE FIVE.
DEMO SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DEMOIA MONTCLAIR CLOSE
DEMOLY FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY
DEMOERS AND I AM IN FULL
DEMOORT ABOUT THEM. NINE TWO
DEMOTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. BUT MY NAME ONLY ONE
DEMO I'M A COMMUNITY MEMBER MY
DEMOER WORKED WITH DEVON MENTAL
DEMOORT OF. LAW. NINE ONE SIX
DEMOE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. THURMOND
DEMOTY FRIEND OF THE LEADING
DEMOLY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ONE DEMOTY FIVE. NINE THIRTY
DEMOT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. GLADDING I'M GAVIN'S
DEMOER I'M INSTRUCTED PORT IN
AB ONE DEMOTY FIVE IF. NINE TO
DEMOTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. THIS IS SANDRA WHEN
DEMOIDENT OF CALIFORNIA POOR
DEMOFORNIA AND I'M IN STRONG
DEMOORT OF AB ONE NINETY FIVE.
ONE OH DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
DEMOING THIS IS TAYLOR MERCY
DEMOG AND COMMUNITY MEMBER IN
DEMOLY FRIEND OF GLIDING. AND I
AM A DEMONG SUPPORT. NINE TO
DEMOTY. YOU LINE IS OPEN.
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
DEMOAIN SEWER OF MILK CAL. AND
A DEMOIN OF GAVIN I'M STRONG
DEMOORT OF AB ONE NINETY FIVE
ON DEMOLF OF MY ENTIRE FAMILY.
DEMO TWO FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHN
DEMOER COMMITTEE MEMBER FAMILY
DEMONDS AND I'M CALLING IN
DEMOORT OF GAVIN LAW. NINE TO
DEMOTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS.
AND I'M DEMOR THAT THE CLADDING
AND I'M DEMONG SUPPORT OF AB
ONE DEMOTY FIVE. PINE THREE
DEMO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
DEMO SIX OR THREE HUNDRED AND
SIX DEMO LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
BE ON DEMO. NINE TWO SEVENTY
TWO DEMO LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO DEMOD MY NAME INTERVIEW MY
DEMO IS KIRTI WIRE COMMUNITY
DEMOER AND FRIEND OF THE
DEMODING AND I CALL IN STRONG
DEMOORT OF GAP AND BLOCK. NINE
TO DEMOTY SIX LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DEMOSTINA GOMEZ COMMUNITY
DEMOER AND I AM IN STRONG
DEMOORT AND AB ONE NINETY FIVE.
AND ONE DEMOTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
DEMO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER
DEMO ELEVEN GOES FAMILY OUT A
DEMOD OF GAP IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB ONE DEMOTY FIVE. SPEAKER
DEMO THREE TWENTY ONE. NINE
DEMOE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT IS
DEMOY PERRY I'M BAFFLED OR ACT
IN DEMOORT. AND NINE THREE TOP
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. OKAY ONE MOMENT. NINE
DEMOE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
DEMOY CLAPPING GAVIN'S FATHER
HI DEMO% SUPPORT GOVERNOR'S
DEMO. NINE THREE THIRTY TWO
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HELLO MY NAME IS BEN
DEMO- KEVIN GLIDING'S COUSIN
AND AS A DEMOTY FIVE YEAR
DEMOTY LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL I
DEMOGNIZE A GOOD BILL WHEN I
SEE IT DEMOSE PASS THE B. ONE
DEMOTY FIVE. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN. YOU MAY BE A
DEMOMATED YOURSELF. ONE SEVENTY
DEMON PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
DEMONG ON TO LINE TO NINETY
DEMOE NINE TO NINETY THREE.
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. WHEN ALL. YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN OKAY ONE OF THE S.
B. DEMOER TWENTY TWO HE YOUR
DEMO AFTER THAT LIKE GOT THAT
THE DEMOVITY THAT IS SO
DEMORTANT FOR YOUR ARE A LOT OF
A CUP DEMOD WIND DILATING IDEAS
THE DEMOC THANK YOU OTHER THAN
THE DEMOE GOBBLED THANK YOU THE
DEMORATOR. NINE THREE THIRTY
DEMO YEAR LOW IS OPEN PLEASE
DEMOD. THIS IS YOUR WRITTEN AND
DEMON GLUTTONS PROGRAM LAW- ON
THE DEMOD SUPPORT THE. NINE
DEMOE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
DEMOE TWENTY NINE IS OPENS
DEMOERTIBLE HI MY NAME IS
DEMOABETH. AND THEN I'M IN
DEMOASTER CALIFORNIA AND THEN
FOR THE DAY DEMO ALLOW.
DEMORATOR NEXT NINE THREE
DEMOTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
DEMOTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
DEMOEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. HI THIS IS JEAN AMEN
ON DEMOLF OF THE FAMILY IN
DEMOING SPRINGS PENNSYLVANIA-
DEMOING SUPPORT. OF THE BILL.
DEMOK YOU MODERATOR. AND ONE
DEMONT FOR OUR LAST COMMENT IN
Q. WE DEMO A FEW MORE MIND
DEMONTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. DANNY CLAIM
DEMO THAT CALIFORNIA GAVIN WAS
ONE OF MY DEMO FRIENDS POINTERS
DEMON'S LAW. NINE THREE FORTY
DEMOE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. AMANDA WILL BE
DEMOTED TO THE FAMILY ACCORDING
TO DEMOER LAW VERY STRONGLY.
DEMO THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
DEMOE FORTY ONE YOU MAY BE ON
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATIE
DEMORSON A FRIEND OF THE
DEMODING AND COMMUNITY MEMBER
AND A DEMOFORNIA. SUPPORT OF AB
ONE DEMO FIVE. AND MINE ONE TEN
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. NINE ONE TEN YOUR LINE
IS DEMO. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. IT'S MOVING ON
TO DEMO TWENTY FOUR LINE TWENTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. ONE TWENTY FOUR YOU
MAY BE ON DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND DEMONG ON TO LINE THREE
DEMOEEN LIME THREE SIXTEEN YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOLY GOOD FRIEND OF GAVIN
DEMOING IN THE FAMILY IN STRONG
DEMOORT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
DEMOENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE NOW GO TO THE DEMOESSES IN
DEMOSITION. MODERATOR DO WE
DEMO SOMEONE ON THE LEAD LINE.
DEMO MORNING THIS IS KATHY SURE
ON DEMOLF OF THE ACLU OF
DEMOFORNIA. SIX LET ME OFFER MY
DEMOATHY TO GAVIN CLADDING
DEMOLY AND COMMUNITY. I AM
DEMOY SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS. WE
ALL DEMOE THE GOAL OF TRYING TO
DEMO OUR ROADS SAFER.
DEMOUNATELY THE INCREASE TERM
OF DEMOISONMENT PROPOSED IN
DEMOTY NINE ONE NINETY FIVE
DEMO DO NOTHING TO PREVENT
DEMORE DEATHS OR SERIOUS
DEMORIES FROM CAR ACCIDENTS.
NOR DEMO IT DETER DRIVERS FROM
DEMOING THE SCENE AFTER AN
DEMODENT. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
DEMOEASED PENALTIES DO NOT
DEMOEASE DETERRENCE. THIS IS
DEMOICULARLY TRUE HERE BCAUSE
DEMOERS MAY LEAVE THE SCENE OF
AN DEMODENT FOR MANY REASONS
DEMO AS SHERIFF DEPORTATION OR
DEMONG A JOB. THEY MAY LEAVE
THE DEMOE EVEN WHEN THEY WERE
AT YOU DEMO WHAT OF IT EVEN
DEMO THEY WERE IN NO WAY AT
DEMOT IN CAUSING THE ACCIDENT.
DEMOER THAN. THERE THAT COULD
DEMOL ARE. EIGHTY ONE NINETY
DEMO WILL TEND TO PRISON FOR
DEMOER PERIODS OF TIME. NO
DEMOFIT TO PUBLIC SAFETY IT IS
IN DEMOSITION TO THE REFORMS
DEMO. HAS MADE IN RECENT YEARS.
WE DEMOECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
DEMO. THANK YOU A MODERATOR WE
CAN GO TO THE DEMOR- ANY OTHER
DEMOS IN OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
DEMOLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN DEMOSITION OF AB ONE NINETY
DEMO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
DEMO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU
DEMO TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB ONE DEMOTY FIVE. YOU MAY
DEMOS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
DEMO AND ONE MOMENT FOR OUR
DEMOT COMMENT. TWENTY TWO SIXTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
DEMOR MEMBERS WHO SHALL CHAIR
ON DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION I
DEMO WANT TO BE ON RECORD THAT
WE ARE IN DEMOORT OF AB ONE B.
DEMO MY APOLOGIES FOR BEING AND
DEMO'RE WRONG. THANK YOU MUCH
YOU A DEMORATE NEXT. ONE MOMENT
FOR THE DEMO NINE. JUST A BRIEF
DEMONT LONGER. AND THEN LADIES
AND DEMOLEMEN WHILE WE'RE
DEMOING FOR THAT LAST LINE IT
DEMON IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
DEMOSITION OF AB ONE NINETY
DEMO A PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT DEMO TIME. NINE ZERO NINE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. ONE OF THE OTHER NUMBER
IS NOT DEMOLABLE TO LEAVE IT
DEMO THAT HAPPENED CALIFORNIA
DEMOPE AT THE THOUGHT OF AN
DEMOCT DAMAGE BASICALLY
DEMOIGURED EVERYTHING. LACKS
DEMOG REPUBLICAN. YEP
DEMOULATING W. THANK. YOU
DEMORATOR. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
DEMOK YOU. ALRIGHT I WILL TURN
IT TO DEMO DYESS DO WE HAVE ANY
DEMO MEMBERS WHO WANT TO EITHER
ASK DEMOTION SAY WIENER GO
DEMOD. I THANK MADAM CHAIR OKAY
TO THE ALL DEMOUSHA CLEARLY
DEMORSTAND THE- BECAUSE IT WAS
DEMOH BEFORE TO- A LOOPHOLE.
DEMOH ME WOULD INDICATE THAT
DEMOE WAS SOME PEOPLE WHO WERE
NOT DEMOING CAN. HE SHOULD BE
DEMOICTED MY UNDERSTANDING OF
DEMO BILL IS IT DOES NOT IN ANY
WAY DEMOGE. WHO IS GUILTY OR
NOT DEMOTY OF LEAVING THE SCENE
OF AN DEMODENT I DON'T BUT
DEMOT BURKE IT'S STUPID IT
DEMOLY INCREASES. THE SENTENCE
DEMO MAXIMO FOR YEARS TO
DEMOMUM SIX YEARS AND I WRITE
DEMOT THAT. THE. YES THERE IS
DEMOE IS A SLIGHT INCREASE YES
BUT DEMO'S WHAT THE BOOK DOES
THE DEMO DO ANYTHING OTHER THAN
DEMOEASE THE SENTENCE. BURGER
DEMOIDED BY I WANNA MAKE SURE
DEMOE CLEAR SOME OF THE SAME
DEMO OF- AREA OF INQUIRY THAT
WE DEMO THROUGH IN THE PUBLIC
DEMOTY COMMITTEE AND YES IF YOU
DEMOD JUST ASK HIS ANSWER IS
DEMOR. I THINK I'M TRYING TO DO
DEMO. THAT THAT- ABOUT
DEMOLOPED AT THE AMENDMENTS AND
DEMO GREEN LIGHT IF YOU WILL
FOR THE DEMOMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
TO DEMOUGH AND PUT IT ON THE
DEMOR GETS SEVENTY TWO ABOUT.
DEMO ALL DUE RESPECT TO PAY TO
DEMO OPPOSITION. THIS IS IT
DEMOL REMAINS A WOBBLER IT
DEMOL REMAINS IN THE
DEMOSDICTION OF THE JUDGE SO
DEMO THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE-
DEMOON ARE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT.
AND DEMO ONLY GOING TO BE IN
DEMOE EGREGIOUS AREAS IN WHICH
THE FACTS DEMONSTRATE THAT
DEMOAPS. AN UNINTENTIONAL
DEMOUS IS IMPORTANT BUT- THAT
DEMO IT MEANS THAT THE JUDGE
HAS DEMOER DISCRETION GIVEN THE
DEMOF THE FAX. TO WALK ALL THE
WAY DEMO TO A MISDEMEANOR BUT
SO DEMO THE SAFETY OFF RAMPS IF
YOU DEMO TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS.
ARE DEMOT IN IN THE BILL. OKAY
SO DEMO THANKS FOR THE QUESTION
SO I AS I DEMO THIS BILL. THIS
DEMON'T CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT
HOW DEMOONE GETS CONVICTED AND
DEMOHER SOMEONE GETS CONVICTED
DEMO THE FACTORS ARE THE IN
DEMOS OF GETTING CONVICTED OR
NOT DEMOING CONVICTED OF
DEMOING THE SCENE. WHAT THE
DEMO THING THIS BILL DOES. IS
TO DEMOEASE THE MAXIMUM PENALTY
DEMOITE RIGHT NOW I'M SORRY.
YES MY DEMO. YEAH I UNDERSTAND
I DEMO TO QUESTION AND THEN AND
YOU DEMOT REALLY ANSWER IT BUT
IS IT DEMO IS BILL DO ANYTHING
DEMOR THAN INCREASE THE MAXIMUM
DEMOON SENTENCE. GIVEN THE
DEMOUMSTANCES.OF THE FACTS OF
THE DEMO. AND THAT DISCRETION
DEMO THE JUDGE WOULD UTILIZE.
THE TO DEMO IS YES IN LIMITED
DEMOCITIES. AND THOSE WOULD BE
AND DEMOOUSLY THE MORE
DEMOGIOUS CAPACITIES WHERE
DEMOE. IS NOT SOME REMORSE.
DEMOBODY AT. DID YOU KNOW GET
DEMOED HIMSELF IN A DAY. WHO
THE IT IS IT IS A DEMOLER AND
IT IS IN DEMOSDICTION OF THE
DEMOE. DETERMINED THANK YOU SO
DEMO BILL- IS A PENALTY
DEMOEASE BILL THIS IS NOT A
DEMO BECAUSE WE THE TERM THE
DEMO LOOPHOLE BEFORE WHICH
DEMOALLY AND THAT'S WHY I ASKED
THE DEMOTION BECAUSE AND I THIS
IS DEMO AN ISSUE. CHILD MIGHT.
IF DEMO SIT THERE WAS KILLED BY
A DEMOK BURKE WAS TAKEN FROM US
DEMOGE MY PALMS FOR UP. TO THE
DEMOLY I JUST. EXPRESS MY
DEMOT. DEEPER CONDOLENCES.
DEMOE IS NO THAT ANYTHING
DEMOSLATURE WILL DO WILL EVER
DEMOGE. THE PERMANENT PAIN THAT
HAS DEMO INFLICTED ON YOU BY
DEMO CORRECT CRIME AND I
DEMOMBER. ONE MIGHT. THE MOTHER
DEMO AND TOLD ME THAT MY AUNT
HAD DEMO AT THE HANDS OF A
DEMOK DRIVER AND NOTHING IT
DEMOGES FOR UPPER. AND SO MUCH
I AM SO DEMOY FOR YOUR LOSS.
BUT DEMO LAW. IS NOT GOING TO.
DEMO THAT PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE
NOT DEMOICTED TODAY ARE GOING
TO BE OF. DEMOICTED THERE'S
DEMOG TO BE THE SAME
DEMOUNTABILITY IN TERMS OF
DEMOLE WHO COMMIT CRIMES. BEING
DEMOICTED OF LEAVING THE SCENE.
AT ALL DEMOT NOW PEOPLE
DEMOERVE UP 250% UP TO FOUR
DEMOS IN PRISON FOR DOING THAT
IN DEMOTION TO WHATEVER CRIME
DEMOHARGE WAS SUCH AS VEHICULAR
DEMOLAUGHTER OR MURDER OR
DEMOEVER ELSE- AND. SO WHAT YOU
DEMO. IN THE STATE. WENT FROM
DEMOR THAN TEN PRESS. TO OVER
THE DEMOS. TERRIBLE
DEMOCROWDING AND IT DIDN'T US
DEMOR AND SO I. CAN'T
DEMORTUNATELY SUPPORT A BILL
DEMO IS SIMPLY CALLING FOR
DEMOER SENTENCES WHEN WE KNOW
DEMO THAT HAS NOT WORKED. OUT
IN THE DEMOD OUR PRISONS. TO
DEMO TAKE FUNDING AWAY FROM YOU
SEE IN DEMOIC SCHOOLS AND ALL
DEMOE OTHER CRITICAL NEEDS A
AND DEMOING. NOTHING IN THIS
DEMO IS GOING TO YOU KNOW HELP
DEMOICT PEOPLE WHO WOULD'VE
DEMO CONVICTED OTHERWISE IS
DEMOA BE THE SAME
DEMOUNTABILITY IN TERMS OF
DEMOICTING PEOPLE. WHO DO THIS
DEMOIBLE THING. WHO HARM PEOPLE
AND DEMOA SEEMS THEY SHOULD BE
DEMOUNTABLE AND THEY AND THEY
CAN BE DEMOUNTABLE UP TO FOUR
DEMOS IN ADDITION TO WHATEVER
DEMOR SENTENCES ARE APPROPRIATE
AND DEMO IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE
DEMO. BUT WHAT THIS WILL DO IS
DO DEMO WE DID BACK IN THE
DEMONTIES AND EIGHTIES AND
DEMOTIES WHICH IS TO
DEMOINUALLY INCREASE. PACKER
DEMOONS BUSTER BUDGET AND IT I
DEMO CAN'T SUPPORT THIS I'M
DEMOY. I HAVE- SENATOR JACKSON
AND DEMOTOR WROTE THEIR HANDS
UP SO LET ME DEMO ON JACKSON
DEMOT THEN ROLL AND THEN MS
DEMOHELL. GO AHEAD SENATOR
DEMOSON. YES THANK YOU I'M I
DEMO A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON
DEMO AND I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
DEMO BILL- I DON'T THINK THAT.
WE DEMOLD BE REWARDING BAD
DEMOVIOR. AND I KNOW AND HAVE
HAD DEMORAL INSTANCES OF PEOPLE
I DEMO- WHO HAVE BEEN THE
DEMOIMS. OF HIDDEN RUNS AND
DEMO- AND PROBABLY. THE DRIVERS
DEMO DRINKING. BUT WHEN THEY
DEMOLLY FOUND THE DRIVERS THEY
DEMOD CONVEY THEM OF DRIVING
DEMOR THE INFLUENCE BECAUSE
DEMOGH TIME HAD PASSED THAT
DEMO HAD BEEN ABLE TO SOBER UP
AND ANY DEMO OF A TESTING WOULD
BE DEMOLEVANT AND UNHELPFUL IN
DEMO PROCESS. SO BY ALLOWING
DEMOLE TO. EXPERIENCE THE SAME
DEMOL FOR HIT AND RUN WILD. I'M
OR IF NOT A DEMOEN TO BE UNDER
THE DEMOUENCE OF ALCOHOL OR
DEMOTANCES- THERE IS A
DEMOCTION IN PENALTY ARGUABLY
AT DEMO AT THAT TIME THEY HAD
DEMO ON FOR THE HIT AND RUN.
THE DEMOICTION IS NOT. FOR THIS
OF IN D. Y. B. THE PER HAD SIX
DEMOION THAT. BY LEAVING THE
DEMOE. SO ODD TO ME I DON'T
DEMO TO REWARD THAT BAD
DEMOVIOR THE SECOND THING IS
DEMO IF WHEN PEOPLE TAKE THEIR
DEMOING TEST THEIR ADVICE THAT
IF DEMO ARE- INVOLVED IN A AN
DEMODENT WITH INJURY THAT THE
DEMOLTY WILL BE GREATER IF THEY
DEMOY. THEN IF THEY STOPPED TO
DEMOER AID ARGUABLY YOU MIGHT
DEMO A FEW CASES WHEN SOMEONE
WHO DEMOITS THAT ACT WILL
DEMOGNIZE THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
TO TRY TO DEMO IN AT LEAST TWO
OF THE DEMOANCES I AM AWARE OF
DEMO PEOPLE DOT. SO RUN THEY
DEMO ALONE THERE WAS NO ONE TO
DEMO AND GET. IF IN FACT AND
DEMO. CORRECTED NINE ONE ONE OR
DEMO SOME EFFORT TO ASSIST
DEMOE PEOPLE WOULD BE ALIVE
DEMOY THAT TO ME MAKES THIS
DEMOERENT THAN THE NOTION THAT
DEMOE JUST ADDING ON PENALTIES
AND I DEMOE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
DEMO JUST ADDING A LINE FOR THE
DEMO OF READING ON IN MOST
DEMOANCES. DOESN'T DO ANYTHING
DEMOTIVE BUT I THINK IN WAS AND
DEMO THIS OF SIR. IN DOES SO IT
DEMOD DO SOMETHING AND I
DEMOKED THAT THIS ONE FOR ME
SLY HAS DEMO TAKE FROM SOME
DEMOLE MUST A SOCIETY. HAVE
DEMO DRINKING. AND DRIVING
DEMOS AND REQUIRE THEY SUFFER
DEMOE CONSEQUENCES I THINK THAT
DEMO DOES SOMETHING POSITIVE
AND SO I DEMO BE SUPPORTING
DEMO BILL AND I ALSO WANT TO
DEMOND MY DEEPEST SYMPATHIES TO
THE DEMOLY AND TO THE FRIENDS
DEMO IS. THE SHOULDN'T HAPPEN-
WE DEMO TO KEEP WORKING ON THIS
BUT I DEMOK THIS LEGISLATION.
IS A DEMOTRUCTIVE AND
DEMOOPRIATE. MEASUREMENTS SO I
DEMO BE ESCORTING IT TODAY AND
I DEMO MOVE THE BILL. SENATE
DEMOAU. YES I WANT TO THANK THE
DEMOOR FOR THIS BILL IN AGAIN
MY DEMOT GOES OUT TO THE FAMILY
I'M DEMOING WEARY OF OUR STATE-
DEMONG PREFERENCE TO THE
DEMOINALS OVER VICTIMS AND SO
DEMON I SECOND THAT MOTION TO
DEMO THAT BILL AND IN AGAIN IN
DEMO VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
DEMOOR- FOR PROTECTING HIS
DEMOLY AS WELL AS OTHER
DEMOLIES BECAUSE OF THIS
DEMORAIN OTHER PEOPLE WHO THINK
DEMOT DOING SUCH THINGS. LAWS
DEMO ARE THERE. HOLD PEOPLE
DEMOUNTABLE SO. THANK YOU VERY
DEMO AND I WILL BE AN AYE VOTE
ON DEMO. I'M ACTUALLY CINEMACON
DEMOER MORE LIKE BECAUSE HE DID
OF HIS DEMO UP BEFORE YOU MISS
DEMOHELL SO SENATOR MORE LOCKED
IN DEMOTOR MITCHELL'S. THANK
YOU DEMOM CHAIR. LIKE SENATOR
DEMOER I'VE ALSO EXPERIENCED
HER DEMO ONE THAT WAS. STRUCK
BY A DEMOCLE WALKING THE DOG
AND DEMOTIFUL GARDENA. SO I
DEMOAT ONE OF THE BURDENS I
DEMO IS HOW DO WE TRY TO MAKE
IT DEMOR FOR PEDESTRIANS
DEMOCKEL WRITERS. IN OUR STATE.
DEMO I DON'T KNOW. YOU KNOW HOW
YOU DEMOULATE. THE LENGTH OF
DEMO THAT WOULD BE. APPROPRIATE.
TO DEMOE. PENITENTIARY FOR
DEMONG MADE. THAT HAVE YOU KNOW
DEMO SEVERELY TRAUMATIZED THE
DEMOLY I HAD BEEN LOOKING
DEMOARD TO. ENJOYING MY- ST STE.
DEMODREN WITH YOSHI AS A FELLOW
DEMODPARENT I THOUGHT I'D HAVE
DEMOHT TWO YEARS WITH YOSHIDA
DEMOYED THE GRANDKIDS AND THAT
IS NOT DEMOG TO HAPPEN. SO I
DEMOT THINK WE HAVE A MAGIC
DEMOET OR WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT IS
THE DEMOURAGEMENT TO TELL
DEMOLE PLEASE STOP ON DRINK TO
OUR OR BE DEMOFUL WHEN YOU
DEMOE A CAR BECAUSE THE CAR IS
A TWO DEMO YOU KNOW LETHAL.
DEMO YOU GOT TO BE EXTREMELY
DEMOECTFUL AND THERE ARE
DEMOEQUENCES WHEN YOU DON'T.
PAY DEMONTION YOU DON'T FOLLOW
THE DEMOS. M. AND SO I'LL BE
DEMOORTING THIS BILL TODAY
DEMOM CHAIR I DON'T KNOW FULLER
DEMONCE BUT I AM GOING TO LOOK
FOR IF I DEMOINUE IN THE-
DEMOTE I'VE GOT TO FIND SOME
DEMO OF LEGISLATION OR SOME
DEMO OF. SOME KIND OF SOME KIND
OF DEMOTIONS THAT WE CAN GET TO
THE TO DEMO SURE PEOPLE CAN
DEMO YOU KNOW ENJOY A JOGGER.
BY DEMORITER OR WALK. I THANK
DEMO THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL.
DEMOK YOU VERY MUCH OF MADAM
DEMOR AND FIRST LET ME EXPRESS
MY DEMO CONDOLENCES TO THE
DEMOLY AND IT KNOWLEDGE YOUR
DEMOR STRENGTH- AND IN YOUR
DEMOINGNESS TO COME UP HERE AND
DEMOE YOUR PERSONAL STORY IN
DEMOR TO INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME
OF DEMOIC POLICY THAT WOULD
DEMOCT A STATE FORTY MILLION SO
DEMOSE I'LL BE FREE IF YOU FOR
DEMO CAN CHILDREN. THE CALL IN
ALL DEMO FAMILY MEMBERS. WHAT A
DEMOSE NOW THAT. YOU KNOW WHAT
DEMO WE SAY TO MY COLLEAGUE
DEMOS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
YOU DEMO. I HAVE NOT SEEN ANY
DEMORTER EVIDENCE THAT SUGGESTS
THE DEMOTIONAL THE POTENTIAL OF
AN DEMOTIONAL ONE YOU SENTENCE.
DEMO IMPACT SOMEONE WHO A NEED
AND DEMO GOTTEN THE WHEEL OF
DEMO WE CAN LOOK AT DECADES OF
DEMOARCH THAT LOOKS AT THE
DEMOH PENALTY. THAT SUGGESTS
THE DEMOAT OF THE DEATH PENALTY
HAS DEMO IMPACT ON A PERSON'S
DEMOSION OR LACK THERE OF. TO
DEMOIT A CRIME. ZERO BUT I
DEMOD LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHOR
DEMOTION AND BEFORE I SAY THAT
DEMO TO REMIND HIM THAT WE HAVE
A BOB DEMO BALK AT CARAMEL
DEMOITUTION I APPRECIATE ALL
THE DEMOESS OF YOUR EXPERIENCE
IN DEMO OWN HOUSE BUT I THINK
WE DO DEMO THE RIGHT IN THE
DEMOE PUBLIC FOR. TO CLEAR. AND
SO YOU DEMOIONED SEVERAL TIMES
DEMO THE AMENDMENT SHE TOOK.
DEMON POSITIVE OUTCOME IN TERMS
OF DEMO VOTES. MY QUESTION IS
DEMO WAS THE NATURE OF THE
DEMODMENTS THAT YOU TOOK. IF
YOU CAN DEMO ME THE CONTENT OF
THE DEMODMENTS BUT WOULD IT A
DEMOER OF THINGS. WE DID. STEP
DEMO THE ENHANCEMENT FROM I
DEMOK IT WAS THE TOP END OF
DEMOT DOWN TO THE NUMBERS THAT
DEMO PRESENTLY. I THINK ALSO
DEMO'S REALLY IMPORTANT. IS
DEMO THE- DISCRETION WITH
DEMOECT TO THE JUDICIARY MMHM
DEMO RESPECT TO- THE WOBBLER
DEMOCT WITH RESPECT TO- THE
DEMORETION THAT A JUDGE COULD
DEMODE GIVEN THIS SET OF
DEMOUMSTANCES IN THE BACKS TO
DEMO REDUCE FURTHER. THAT EVEN
TO A DEMOEMEANOR. AT THE END SO
DEMO WHAT WE MEAN BY THAT IS.
IF DEMOE'S A SET OF EGREGIOUS
DEMOVIOR HERE. THAT RESULTED IN
DEMOING TWELVE MONTHS FOR
DEMOING LEAVING. THE SCENE FOR
AB. DEMO WOULD PROBABLY BE A
SET OF DEMOUMSTANCES A JUDGE IN
DEMOISH MAY LOOK AT AN- DECIDE
DEMO WHERE THE UP NOTHING IN
DEMO. DEMANDS AN ENHANCED I
DEMOT UNDERSTAND YOU DISTILL.
DEMORIPTION MEANS THAT IT'S SO.
M. AND DEMO ALL DUE TO THE BY
DEMOL MAY OF. I WOULD SUBMIT
DEMO. OUR BODY IS AS CONCERNED.
DEMOT THE CONSEQUENCES IN THE
DEMO BEEN ASKING HERE. AND YET
AS A DEMOE OUT OF THE WORK
DEMOTHER. AS OF THE PART THE
DEMO OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
DEMOIC SAFETY COMMITTEE BUT IN
THE DEMOMBLY. BY SEVENTY TWO
DEMOS ARE ARE HOUSE DEEM THIS
TO BE. DEMOTHING THAT THAT
DEMOD BE GOOD. AND BUT THE BEST
I CAN DO IS DEMOAIN. WHAT THE
DEMO'S GOING TO DO AND WHAT IT
AND I DEMOECIATE THAT YOU HAVE
TO ASK YOU DEMOER THE QUESTION
DEMOUSE THE SOLE PREVIOUSLY IT
WAS AN- DEMOEASE IN SO NOW
DEMOVE- STEPPED DOWN TO USE
DEMO TERMINOLOGY TO JUDICIAL
DEMORETION I APPRECIATE THAT.
YOU DEMO. TRUMP TO MY
DEMOEAGUES POINT ARE AND THEY
DEMOLY HAVE IN IN SETTING IN
DEMOIC SAFETY YOU KNOW THESE
DEMO EVERY BILL THAT COMES
DEMORE US- ARE DEEPLY EMOTIONAL
AND DEMOLIES ARE IMPACTED- AND
DEMO OF WHAT WE DO IMPACTS THE
DEMOS OF PEOPLE THERE ARE. TONS
ON DEMO BOTH SIDES. AND FOR US
TO DEMOME THAT OUR JUDICIAL
DEMOEM IS TRULY JUST IS AN
DEMOPROPRIATE FUNDS MAKE I
DEMOK WE'VE DONE THAT. TIME AND
DEMO AGAIN THEIR VICTIMS ON
DEMO SIDES. THANK YOU ONE I
DEMOT THE RAM. OF DRUNK
DEMOING- YOU KNOW WHEN YOU KNOW
WE DEMO TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE
DEMO A SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS
DEMOLE WHO ARE RESOURCES WE CAN
DEMO ATTORNEYS. ALLOWED TO
DEMOT THE LAW AS AS LONG AS WE
DEMOBERATE MISSING MOST ONE
DEMO ISN'T AS HARD AS WE TRY TO
DEMO IT. OUR SYSTEM DOES NOT
DEMO FOR THEIR PEOPLE WHO CAN
PAY DEMOR WAY OUT OF IT
DEMOICALLY. CERTAINLY I WOULD
DEMO WHAT DOES WITH REGARD TO
THE DEMOENCING QUESTION I THINK
DEMO IT LEGISLATIVE BODIES
DEMO. UNFORTUNATELY OVER THE
DEMOS- DUE TO. EMOTIONAL
DEMORIENCES WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE. DEMO VERY ARBITRARY
DEMOSIONS ABOUT THE SENTENCE.
YOU DEMO IS IT TRULY
DEMOOPRIATE TO THINK SIX YEARS.
IS DEMOGH TO PROVIDE THIS
DEMOLY SOME SENSE OF. SATISFY
IS THE DEMOG WORD BUT THE BUT-
IN DEMOS OF THE LOSS OF A LOVED
DEMO AND SO WHAT I THINK IS NOW
DEMOENING WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
DEMOG TO DO IS THAT THERE IS A
DEMOENCING COMMISSION. THAT IS
DEMOING OBJECTIVELY AT
DEMOENCING AND SO MAYBE WE HAVE
A DEMOSLATIVE BODY WILL STOP
DEMO ONE OFF. WHERE WE ARE IN A
DEMOT IN TIME WHERE YOU KNOW
ALL OF DEMOK COCAINE IS AN
DEMOEMIC AND SO WEEK ABSENCE
DEMONCEMENTS COMPLETELY
DEMOTRARILY. BASED ON NOTHING
BUT OUR DEMOIONAL REACTION TO
IS A SET OF DEMOUMSTANCES. SO
I'M DEMOING FORWARD TO THE
DEMOENCING COMMISSION TO REALLY
DEMOCTIVELY AND FAIRLY AND
DEMOOPRIATELY FIGURE OUT WHAT
IS DEMO APPROPRIATE. BASED ON
DEMOARCH BASED ON THE NOTION OF
NOT DEMO PUNISHMENT BUT
DEMOBILITATION. I THINK THAT'S
THE DEMO AFFECT THE WAY FOR US
AS A DEMOVER TO BODY. TO REALLY
FAR DEMO AND ON THIS AREA OF
THE LAW ON DEMOT ARBITRARILY
DEMODE. TWO YEARS MAKES IT
DEMOER ONE YEAR MAKES IT BETTER
I DEMOT KNOW THAT THAT'S
DEMOOPRIATE I REALLY REALLY
DEMOT AND SO I'M LOOKING
DEMOARD TO THE SENTENCING
DEMOISSION TO COMBAT. PROVIDING
DEMOANCE XIN. A BROWN. WHAT ARE.
DEMOE BASED ON THE NATURE OF
THE DEMONCE. SOLD BASED ON
DEMO. I'M GOING TO ABSTAIN
DEMOY ON THIS BILL- BECAUSE I
DEMOK THAT'S THE MORE
DEMOOPRIATE STRATEGIC APPROACH
IN DEMOS OF POLICY MAKING. THE
YOU DEMOM CHAIR. SENATOR
DEMOFORD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I TWO ONE DEMOND MY MOST
DEMOERE CONDOLENCES TO THE
DEMOLY FOR YOUR LOSS AND AGAIN
I DEMOEND YOU FOR YOUR
DEMOIMONY HERE TODAY ALSO WANT
TO DEMOK THE AUTHOR FOR
DEMOGEMENT BOARD AND- I WAS
DEMOARED TO VOTE. FOR THIS
DEMOURE. WITH THE HOPES THAT I
DEMOD HEAR WHAT THOSE LOOPHOLES
DEMO THAT WOULD HELP LEAD TO
DEMOTER CONVICTIONS OF THE MOST
ONE OF THE DEMO CURRENTLY ACTS
YOU DEMOD DO ISTO KNOWINGLY
DEMOKES ON AND LEAVE THEM DYING
IN THE DEMOETS. I'M PERSONALLY
I DEMOT SEE IT EARLIER TODAY A
DEMO IT HELPS US. CAPTURE MORE
OF DEMOE CARLY ACTORS ALL THIS
DEMO IS ALLOW US TO EXTEND THE
DEMOENCE OF BILLS WHO WE
DEMOADY. ARE VICTIM OF A CRIME.
I'M DEMO INTERESTED IN HOW DO
WE DEMOURE MORE OF THESE HIDDEN
RUN DEMOERS WHO CONTINUE TO
DEMOSTATE FAMILIES. AND DISPARU
DEMOO I WAS TWO THEIR ACT THERE
DEMO NEED NOT TO KNOWINGLY
DEMOE THE SCENE OF THE CRIME
AND DEMORTUNATELY I HAVEN'T
DEMOD THAT TODAY ALL THIS DOES
IS X. DEMOND THE SENTENCE OF
DEMOE WHO ALREADY CAPTURING
DEMO IF YOU COULD INTERPOL'S
DEMOINCING THAT THIS THERE IS A
DEMOHOLE THAT AS CLIPPING POLLS
DEMO. ALLOW US TO. AND NOT ONLY
ON A BUT DEMOEY THOSE
DEMOVIDUAL WERE CURRENTLY
DEMOING AWAY WITH HAVING RUN
OUR DEMOING I'LL BE MORE THAN
DEMOY TO CONSIDER THAT. WELL I
DEMOTE BRADFORD AYE AYE I WAS
DEMONG THAT THAT WOULD THAT
DEMO WAS ACCOMPLISHED WITH THE
DEMODMENTS IT WAS ACCOMPLISHED
DEMO THE DISCUSSION AT THAT THE
DEMOMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY- I
DEMOD. SUGGEST THAT- THERE WERE
A DEMOER OF PEOPLE SKEPTICAL ON
DEMO COMMITTEE AS YOU WOULD
DEMO BEEN I'M SURE OVER IN THE
DEMOMBLY SIDE. INCLUDING
DEMOER- BILL QUIRK AND- WHEN WE
DEMO DISCUSSING THE BILL AND
DEMOING ABOUT IT WAS. IT WAS
DEMOING LIKE IT WAS NOT GOING
TO GET DEMOOVED. AND HAVE
DEMOER CORK. WHAT I WAS LOOKING
HIS DEMO. AND HE PULLED UP THE
DEMOL CODE. AND HE SAID THE
DEMOAS DID THIS DISPARITY THIS
DEMO LOOPHOLE EXISTS. AND THEY
HAD DEMOUSSIONS AMONGST
DEMOSELVES WITH THE CHAIR- OF
THE DEMO THAT WAS HEADED FOR
BOB DEMOG VOTED DOWN. WE WERE
DEMON AN EXTENSION WE WERE WE
DEMO GIVEN A- IN ORDER TO
DEMONSIDER. AND WHEN WE CAME
DEMORE THE COMMITTEE EIGHT
DEMON. WE HAD RECOGNIZED THE
DEMO KINDS OF CONCERNS YOU WERE
YOU DEMO RAISING THEY
DEMOMMENDED THESE KINDS OF.
DEMODMENTS TO THE BILL THAT
DEMOE IS A PERVERSE INCENTIVE.
DEMO IF YOU HIT LEAVE AND STAY
DEMO YOU'RE GOING TO SPEND LESS
DEMO THAT IF YOU STAYED AND YOU
DEMO OUT. YOU KNOW HUMAN BEING
AT THE AT DEMO SEE. AND THE
DEMOR THING I NEED TO SAY IS.
DEMOE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES DON'T
DEMOEN IN A VACUUM. THE FACT OF
THE DEMOER IS THAT UP AND DOWN
THE DEMOE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
DEMONG FAMILIES. GRIEF LIKE
DEMO. AND THEY ALL ARE PART OF
THE DEMOIC RECORD. THEY SHOW UP.
IN THE DEMO. EDIT IT'S VERY
DEMOR THAT IN THE INDIVIDUAL
DEMO HE HAD KILLED LEFT. SURE
DEMOVE MONTHS BECAUSE OF THE
DEMO MEDIA AND AT THE END
DEMOICITY ABOUT IT. WHAT'S THE
DEMO'S THE MESSAGE WHAT'S THE
DEMOAL. THE SIGNAL IS BY
DEMOING HE GOT AWAY WITH IT.
AND DEMO'S HAPPENED OVER AND
DEMO AND OVER AGAIN. WE HAVE
CAN YOU SAW DEMO OF THAT WITH
DEMOE CALLS SOMETHING LIKE THAT
WE DEMO TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
DEMOADY WHO ACROSS THE STATE.
WHO DEMO SIGNED ON TO BE A PART
OF DEMOORTED NEXT. AN THERE ARE
DEMOIES AND STORIES AND STORIES.
OF. DEMOBODY DOING SOMETHING
DEMOOUS THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DEMOEM. TAX AND THE GENERAL
DEMOION IS THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
GOT DEMO WITH IT. THAT'S A
DEMOAL TO OTHER PEOPLE OUT
DEMOE THAT ARE GOING TO FIND
DEMOSELVES CIRCUMSTANCES. I
DEMOLY THINK THAT IF GAVIN'S
LAW DEMO WERE SIGNED INTO LAW.
I DEMOALLY THINK THAT THAT THAT
THE DEMOE DISCUSSION. CHANGES
DEMO THERE IN FACT. EIGHT AM RE
DEMONCING IF YOU WILL. OF THE
DEMOENCING RIGHT NOW THERE'S A
DEMOARITY HERE THAT REWARDS
DEMOING. AND DOESN'T REWARD
DEMO. AND WE BELIEVE THAT IF
YOU DEMOT TO CLOSE THAT GAP.
DEMOE SENDING A GOOD SIGNAL.
DEMO IT MAY NOT BE PERFECT IT
MAY NOT BE THE END ALL BE ALL
BUT THE DEMOIDENT SET OF
DEMOUMSTANCES I THINK IS WORSE.
DEMOTE GAVIN'S BLOG WERE MORE.
DEMO THE BEST I CAN DO IT IN.
THE DEMOMBER PATTERSON NINE IF
YOU DEMOT MIND I THINK THIS-
DEMOENT TAKE THAT AS YOUR
DEMOHES STORE SEE SENATOR
DEMOHELL HAS HER HAND UP
DEMOTOR MITCHELL GO AHEAD.
DEMOK YOU AYE I THOUGHT HE WAS
DEMOONDING TO SENATOR PER.
DEMOTION THAT'S WHY OKAY I HAD
THE DEMOGEON YES SO I DIDN'T
DEMO I'M SORRY MADAM CHAIR I
DEMOT KNOW. GOOD NEWS IS THAT
IS IT AND DEMO BEEN IT'S IN
DEMOONSE TO SOMETHING THE
DEMOMBLY MEMBER SAID FIRST OF
ALL LET ME DEMO CLARIFY
DEMORDING TO. BOMB IRAQ. VOTED
ON YOU DEMOLY FOR MAY TWENTY
DEMOD AND THEN IT IT WAS
DEMODED INTO ITS CURRENT
DEMOENT JUNE. TWENTY SIX I JUST
DEMO TO. CLARIFY THAT. BUT BUT
BUT YOU TO DEMO USED THE- LUPO.
DEMOTE ACCURATE ACCURACY
DEMOERS. ALL RIGHT THE WE
DEMODED. AFTER THE VOTE. TO
DEMOE NOT TO CHANGE THE
DEMOAMENTALS OF THE BILL. BUT
WE DEMODED AFTER THE VOTE
DEMOUSE THERE WERE. A MEMBER
DEMOON ARE OTHERS WHO WANTED TO
BE DEMOT AUTHORS WITH ME THAT'S
HOW DEMO HAVE THOSE KINDS OF.
DEMOUMSTANCES IN OUR OWN THAT'S
DEMO IF I CAN GET TO MY THE
DEMO OF MY QUESTION THAT'S FINE.
THE DEMO OF MY QUESTION IS- YOU
TOO NOW DEMO USED THE TERM
DEMOHOLE I THINK I FIGURED OUT
DEMO WHAT GIVE ME. AND SO THE
DEMOT IS THAT IF SOMEONE WERE
TO DEMO. AND BE CHARGED AND
DEMOICTED WITH INVOLUNTARY
DEMOLAUGHTER WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE. DEMO WOULD CARRY A
DEMOIER SENTENCE. IN THE
DEMOCLE COLD SECTION THAT
DEMOENTLY IMPACTS THOSE WHO
DEMOY. IF COMMITTEE STAFF COULD
DEMO US OR HELP ME BY GIVING ME
A DEMOE OF. VOLUNTARY VEHICULAR
DEMOLAUGHTER SLOT OR WHATEVER
THE DEMO MAY BE IF YOU WERE TO
DEMO WHAT DOES SENTENCE RANGES
ARE DEMOUSE I THINK THAT'S
DEMO'S BEING MET BY LOCAL THAT
IF YOU DEMOE. THE CHAR YOU
DEMOD GET IS A LESSER- SENTENCE
DEMOTH THAN IF YOU WERE TO STAY
SO DEMOF COULD GIVE ME A RANGE
OF DEMO THOSE TIME. DARK YOU
DEMO THE METRO GROCERY
DEMOLAUGHTER IS TWO FOUR OR SIX
DEMOS BOB ARE THAT THE WOBBLER
DEMO THE FELONY PORTION BEING
TWO DEMO SIX AND I GROSS
DEMOCULAR MANSLAUGHTER WHILE
DEMOLLIGENCE IS. FOUR SIX OR
TEN DEMOS. VERY MUCH THE
DEMOIFICATION. WE GET A BREAK A
DEMOK CLOSE. I THINK THE STAFF
JUST BASICALLY. DEMONSTRATED TO
YOU DEMO THAT THE NATURE OF THE
DEMOHOLE OR I WOULD CALL OF THE
DEMOARITY IN SENTENCING. AND SO
FOR ALL DEMOE REASONS AND FOR
THE DEMOEST EFFORT THAT WE HAVE
PUT DEMOTHER THAT WE WOULD THAT
WE HAD- A NUMBER OF. DEMOCRATS
DEMOMBLY MEMBERS WHO WERE EVERY
BIT IS DEMOERNED- MIKE GIPSON
AND DEMORS WHO SAW THIS. AND
DEMO CORK AND OTHERS WHO
DEMOGNIZED THIS DISPARITY WE
DEMOED TO GO OVER HERE THE BABY
DEMOHES AT THIS BERRYHILL MORE.
DEMOCOGNIZE THAT THERE WAS A
DEMOINGNESS TO DISCUSS THIS AND
WE DID AND WE DEMOD IT BACK.
DEMO THE DISH THE DIRT DUST THE
DEMOTS HAVE THE JURISDICTION TO
DO DEMO AND IT'S GOING TO
DEMOND ON THAT ON THE
DEMOVITIES. OF THE INDIVIDUAL
DEMOR SEEN FLEEING. AND THE
DEMOOD OF TIME UNTIL THEY WERE
DEMO WERE CAPTURED. THANK YOU
DEMOMBLY WITHOUT I ASK I REALLY
TO ASK FOR DEMO VOTE THANK YOU-
MS DEMOSON THIS YEAR HANNAH BUT
DEMOALLY HE'S GIVEN HIS CLOSE.
MY DEMOOGIES ARE BY WE DO HAVE
A DEMO LONG AGENDA. SO WE CARE
FOR DEMOT WANTED TO REITERATE-
IF I MAY THE DEMOPLE I GAVE WAS
IF YOU ARE IN IF YOU ARE
DEMOING UNDER THE INFLUENCE AND
YOU DEMOE YOU CAN I AND YOU ARE
DEMO SO. TIME THAT YOU CANNOT
BE DEMOED AND CONFIRMED TO HAVE
DEMO DRIVING UNDER THE- THEN AS
WAS DEMOTED OUT. GROSS
DEMOCULAR MANSLAUGHTER CARRIES
A DEMOER SENTENCE THAN. A DRUG-
DEMOS VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER
DEMOE INTOXICATED THAT IS THE
DEMOFIT THAT SOMEONE GETS BY
DEMOING THE SCENE. AND THAT'S
WHY DEMO IS I THINK THE GAP
DEMO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
DEMOING ABOUT. AND THAT'S WHY I
DEMOORT THIS I THINK IT'S IN
DEMOONSE I WANTED TO RESPOND TO
DEMOTOR BRADFORD WHO DIDN'T
DEMORSTAND THAT THERE WAS A
DEMOINCTION HERE THAT THAT'S
THE DEMOINCTION- AND HAS
DEMOING TO DO WITH THE WAY THE
DEMOK YOU. SENATOR JACK THANK
YOU FOR DEMOSON. WILL WE A-
DEMO I THINK WE. HE SAID ALL
DEMOT I THINK WE NEED BRING IT
DEMO THANK YOU FOR YOUR CLOTHES
DEMOMBLY MEMBER. I THINK WE
DEMO THE CLARITY THAT. AT THE
DEMOENT MOMENT. THE PENALTY
DEMO THE ITS PRESENT MOMENT THE
DEMOENT STATUTE IS A WOBBLER IN
THE DEMOLTY IS TWO THREE OR
DEMO. AND WHAT YOUR BILL IN
DEMOENT FORM DOES THIS LEAVE A
DEMOLER BUT CHANGE THE YEARS TO
DEMOE FOUR SIX. SO IT INCREASES
THE DEMOT YEAR ON THE MINIMUM A
DEMO ON THE INTERIM IN THE
DEMOLE AND TO YOU ON THE- NO.
NOT TO. DEMO WE NEVER KNOW WHAT
A DEMOE'S THINKING WHEN A JUDGE
DEMOSES A SENTENCE. IN THE CASE
DEMO WE HAVE AS YOU REFERRING
TO DEMO. LAW YOU'VE NAMED AFTER
DEMOONE IN THAT CASE EVEN WITH
THE X. DEMO THE PERSON DID NOT
GET THE MAX DEMO GOT A LITTLE
DEMOE WHAT THE JUDGE FACTORED
OF DEMOSE WE DO NOT KNOW.
DEMOENT LAW SO IF PLEASE SIGN.
SO IF DEMO WERE BILL WERE TO BE
DEMOESSFUL. AND THE JUDGE HAD
THE DEMO POINT OF VIEW. THAN
DEMO IN THIS CASE. THE PERSON
DEMOD GET ONLY S. R. C. ONE
DEMOagenta>ORE YEAR. NOW I THINK AS ONE</c>
OF MY DEMOEAGUE STATED. WHILE
DEMOESOME PEOPLE MAY FEEL THAT
DEMO IS MORE FAIR. A YEAR DOES
NOT DEMOG BACK ANYONE'S LIFE.
AND THE DEMOE TYPES OF. BILLS
DEMO COME BEFORE US FOR THE
DEMO DIFFICULT BILLS I THINK I
DEMOT SPEAK FOR THE REST OF MY
DEMOEAGUES BUT FOR HI I WOULD
DEMOINE BUT FOR ME. BECAUSE OF
DEMOSE. KEVIN SHOULD NOT HAVE
DEMO. STE ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY.
HIS DEMO WAS STOLEN. AND THIS
DEMOON WAS A 100% WRONG. BUT IF
WE THE LAW TO DEMO THAT PERSON
DEMONTIALLY ONLY ONE MORE YEAR
OF DEMOE. HAVE IN FACT. CHANGE
THE DEMOUMSTANCE IN WHICH
DEMOLE BEHAVE. AND I THINK THE
DEMOLY DIFFICULTY WELL YES
DEMOE IS A PERHAPS ONE COULD
SAY IN ILL DEMOC IN OUR CURRENT
DEMOUTES. A DRUNK PERSON IS NOT
DEMOORING DETERRENCE. A DRUNK
DEMOON JUST BY THE VERY NATURE
THE DEMOXICATION IS NOT BEING
DEMOONAL. AND SO WHETHER THE
DEMOENCES. EIGHT YEARS TENURE
DEMOTY YEARS THAT IS NOT.
DEMOATIVE FACTOR WHEN A PERSON
IS DEMOXICATED. IF WE HAD IF
THERE WAS DEMONSTRATED RESEARCH
AND DEMOENCE THAT THESE THINGS
DEMOED AS DETERRENCE. FIVE WILL
BE DEMO OPEN. BUT AS THERE IS
DEMO. IT IS DIFFICULT AND WHILE
I DEMOAINLY APPRECIATE THAT
DEMOE IS A DISPARITY NINE THINK
IT HAS DEMO NOW INDICATED I'M
NOT DEMO IF THIS NECESSARILY
DEMO I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
THE DEMOION OF THE FAMILY. AND
DEMOYONE WHO CARED DEEPLY ABOUT
GAP IN. DEMO NOT CLEAR TO ME
DEMO IN FACT THIS WILL BRING AS
MY DEMOR COLLEAGUES HAVE
DEMOIONED JUSTICE. SO I WILL BE
DEMOING OFF THE BILL TODAY. AND
I DEMOK THAT THE LOOK AT OUR
DEMORE PENAL CODE AND THE- AND
IN DEMOOOK LOOKING AT THESE
DEMOHER WE NEED TO ADD MORE
DEMOONALITY YOU HAVE POINTED
OUT IN DEMOGIC ASPECT OF THE
DEMOURY YOU HAVE TO. BUT
DEMOHER THIS CORRECTION FIXES
IT IS THE DEMOICULTY THAT I AM
DEMONG. IN TRYING TO DECIDE HOW
TO DEMO MY VOTE TODAY SO I WILL
BE DEMOING ON. I BELIEVE THERE
WAS A DEMOON SENATOR JACKSON
DEMO THE MOTION. BEFORE I CALL
THE DEMOS OR ANY OTHER COMMENT.
DEMOD YOU CALL THE ROLL AB ONE
DEMOTY FIVE PATTERSON THE PAST
DEMOOPRIATIONS SKINNER. NOT
DEMONG OR NOT VOTING MOORLACH
DEMOLACH AYE BRADFORD. BRED FOR
NOT DEMONG JACKSON. ACTUALLY
DEMO X. NINE MITCHELL. FEDERAL
NOT DEMONG MORALE. BROWSE RURAL
I DEMOER. WINNER NOW THE BILL
HAS TO ONE DEMO. THREE TWO ONE.
DEMO YOU OF COURSE CAN ASK FOR
DEMONSIDERATION WITH THE ACT
BUT I DEMOD HOPE SO I HOPE. IN
DEMO WHEN WE HAD WE CAN WE WILL
DEMOT RECONSIDERATION YES. WILL
DEMOT REGARDS TO SEVENTY TWO
DEMOS IN THE ASSEMBLY WILL
DEMOT RE CONSIDERATION I HOPE
IT. DEMORMS YOU AND YOU AN
DEMOORT WILL GRANT WE CAN
DEMORATE SHE TO RECONSIDERATION
DEMOK YOU THANK YOU. RIGHT WE
DEMO GO TO OUR- NEXT BILL. AB
DEMON SIXTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY
DEMOER GRAYSON. MEMBERS AFTER
DEMONER AYE I WOULD FIRST LIKE
TO DEMOK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
DEMO WORK ON THIS BILL I ALSO
DEMO TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY
DEMOEAGUES AND JOINT AUTHORS
DEMOMBLY MEMBER CERTAINLY HAS
THE DEMO KAMLAGER FOR HER WORK
AS AS DEMO ON THIS BILL IN
DEMOTION I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE DEMOTERS CALIFORNIANS FOR
DEMOTY AND JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
DEMOE CONTROLLER THE HONORABLE
DEMOYHILL DE. AUSTIN DISTRICT
DEMOA BECTON SAN FRANCISCO
DEMORICT ATTORNEY CHASE ABOUT
DEMO AND YOUTH ALIVE. I AM
DEMOSED TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
DEMON SIXTY SEVEN A FIRST IN
THE DEMOON BILL THAT SEEKS TO
DEMOINATE BARRIERS TO STATE
DEMOORT FOR VICTIMS OF POLICE
DEMOALITY. COM POLICY CHANGE.
IS DEMO OVER. IT DOES NOT TAKE
DEMO TO LOOK AT CURRENT EVE.
AND SEE THE DEMOON IS THIS IS A
DEMOON THAT IS GRAPPLING WITH
DEMO PRESS THE PAST AND
DEMOERING. THE KILLINGS OF
DEMOGE FLOYD BRIANNA TAYLOR AND
FAR TOO DEMO MORE HAVE SHOWN
DEMO WE MUST DO MORE TO LIVE UP
TO OUR DEMOENTS PROP OF LIBERTY
AND DEMOICE FOR ALL. YET LONG
DEMOFORNIA EXCLUDES VICTIMS OF
DEMOCE VIOLENCE FROM RECEIVING
DEMOENSATION FROM THE
DEMOFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
DEMOD. VICTIM COMPENSATION IS
AN DEMORTANT PATHWAY FOR
DEMOIVORS TO ACCESS SUPPORT
DEMOBURSING EXPENSES INCLUDING
DEMOCAL BILLS COUNSELING AND
DEMOT CASE SCENARIOS FUNERAL
DEMOICES. THIS CRITICAL POLICY
DEMO WE ARE PUSHING IS DRIVEN
BY THE DEMOS FROM SERVER. AND
IT DEMO THE FOLLOWING IT
DEMORES THAT VICTIMS OF POLICE
DEMOENCE AND FAMILY MEMBERS OF
DEMOE KILLED BY POLICE ARE
DEMOIBLE FOR. FROM THE
DEMOFORNIA VICTIMS COMPENSATION
DEMOD. IT ALL BOILS CAL B. B.
B. C. B. TO DEMO ON DOCUMENTS
GEN DEMOR THAN THE POLICE
DEMORT TO VERIFY THE CRIME
DEMORRED I EAT REPORT FOR
DEMOAL HEALTH OR VICTIM SERVICE
DEMOIDERS. A RESTRAINING ORDER
WE DEMOED. EXTENDING FOR WE ARE
OF DEMOABLE TO OTHER SURVIVE OF
DEMOSE. YEAH IT PREVENTS
DEMOUSION FOR CARBON BASE ON A
DEMO IN K. INVOLVING POLICE USE
OF DEMOE. AB SEVEN SIX SEVEN IS
DEMOFORNIA'S OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT WE VALUE THE
DEMOS AND EXPERIENCES OF ALL
DEMOIMS AND PARTICULARLY BLACK
AND DEMON VICTIMS OF POLICE
DEMOENCE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
DEMOER GRAYSON WE HAVE ONE OF
DEMO LEAD SUPPORT AND GIVEN OUR
DEMO I THINK IT'S OKAY IF IT'S
IF THE DEMOR PERSON IS NOT ABLE
DEMON I THINK WE'LL JUST GO
DEMOT NOW TO MS HOLLINS. THE
DEMOY. CALIFORNIA SAFETY MARTIN
DEMORRUPTION THIS IS THE
DEMORATOR WE DO HAVE BEEN
DEMONG THE DANTE PLEASE STAND
FOR CD DEMO MONTH OUR LEAD
DEMOESSES HAVE A TOTAL OF THREE
DEMOTES NOT EACH. BUT IN TOTAL
DEMOE MINUTES THANK YOU AHEAD.
DEMO MORNING THIS IS ENDEMIC
DEMO THE OFFICE OF STATE
DEMOROLLER BETTY YEE. THANK YOU
FOR THE DEMORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
ON THE DEMOL AS A MEMBER OF THE
DEMOIM COMPENSATION BOARD
DEMOROLLER YEARS PLEASED TO CO
DEMOSOR AB SEVENTY SEVEN BY
DEMOMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON ASSEMBLY
DEMOER KAMLAGER OUR NATION IS
DEMOPLING WITH A CRISIS THE
DEMOSM THAT AFFECTS EVERY
DEMOCT OF SOCIETY INCLUDING LAW
DEMORCEMENT. I BY THE KILLING
OF DEMOGE FLOYD BENNETT TAYLOR
DEMORS. CURRENTLY STATE LAW
DEMO NOT PROVIDE THE
DEMOENSATION FOR VICTIMS AND
THE DEMOLIES OF THOSE WHO
DEMOER INJURY OR I THINK THE
ONE DEMO SURE BECAUSE THEY
DEMOT THINK THEY BOARD THE
DEMOFY THAT ACCOUNT. BASED THE
DEMORT. INDICATED THE POLICE IN
THE DEMOCATES THE VICTIM
DEMOICIPATED IN THE EVENT THAT
LED TO THE DEMORY MICHAEL. TO
DEMON SEVEN THANK TWO CORRECT
THE DEMORED. VICTIMS OF POLICE
BY DEMO TO RESOURCES COMMONLY
DEMOL TO CRIME THAT. CALIFORNIA
DEMOLD AB SEVENTY SEVEN REMOVE
A DEMOIER BY ALLOWING THE
DEMOIMS. BOARD THAT ARE UP
DEMOE DOCUMENT. TO VERIFY THE
DEMOK KURT THIS WILL ENSURE
DEMO THEY OF FILE CAN ACCESS
DEMO. TO COVER OUT OF POCKET
DEMONSES FOR MEDICAL AND MENTAL
DEMOTH CARE NECESSITATED BY THE
DEMOE. AND IN THE MOST DIRE
DEMOS COVER FUNERAL EXPENSES.
WE DEMOOT TOLERATE TREATING
DEMOIMS OF POLICE VIOLENCE WITH
ANY DEMO CARE AND COMPASSION.
DEMO WE EXTEND TO OTHER CRIME
DEMOIMS THANK YOU FOR THE
DEMORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY. Q.
DEMO. THE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
DEMOFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
DEMOICE ON BEHALF OF TWELVE
DEMOSAND- CRIMES DRIVERS HERE
IN DEMOFORNIA- CALIFORNIA
DEMOORK MOSTLY BLACK BROWN IN
DEMONFRANCHISED CRIME VICTIMS
YOU DEMOT SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
SIX DEMON IN ADDITION TO MY
DEMO AS DIRECTOR I'M ALSO A
DEMOIVOR I LOVE TWO BROTHERS TO
DEMO BY CONTAMINATED SAN
DEMOCISCO BOTH OF MY HEAD
DEMOIOUS CONTACT WITH THE GROUP.
DEMO ENDED THE ON THEIR DAY MY
DEMOLY BARRED ACCESS. TO THE
DEMOUR. I'VE BEEN TO AUSTIN
DEMO SURVIVORS IN THE STATE OF.
AND ITS DEMONTIALLY WITH
DEMOIMS OF POLICE BRUTALITY- IN
DEMOCE AN OFFICER INVOLVED
DEMOTING BIG NOT A TRYING
DEMOED ON TO THE DECK SO
DEMOLIES IN THE IS AGREED. AB
DEMONTY FEDERAL MOVES THE AREA
DEMO EARLIER THE NAMES THE MOD
DEMOCH RIANA TAYLOR IN GEORGE
DEMOD AS A BLACK WOMAN WHO GREW
UP IN SAN DEMOCISCO I KNOW SIX
DEMOIMS OF OFFICER INVOLVED
DEMOTING AND ALL OF THEIR
DEMOLIES WERE BARI ACCIDENT
DEMOIM COMPENSATION BECAUSE THE
DEMOTIONS PLACED ONLINE- THE
DEMOON
YOU AND DEMOES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU DEMO JUSTICE SPEAK IN
DEMOORT OF AB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
YOU DEMO PRESS ONE AND THEN- AT
DEMO TIME AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
DEMOK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
SIX YOU MAY DEMOS AND THEN ZERO
AT. DEMO TIME. AND ONE MOMENT
FOR A DEMOT COME. ONE FOUR
DEMOTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. RESEARCH WITH
DEMON AMERICANS ADVANCING
DEMOICE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
DEMOORT YEAH. NINE FOUR SIXTEEN
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
DEMOANY FAN I'LL BE HAPPY TO
GET DEMOE LAWCENTER TO PREVENT
GUN DEMOENCE IN SUPPORT THANK
DEMO NINE ONE SIX THREE THREE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HELLO ON THE APPLE
DEMOFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
DEMOICE. WELL CO SPONSORS OF
DEMO BILL. OTHER GROUPS IN
DEMOORT OUR LATINO COALITION
FOR DEMOTHY CALIFORNIA AND WE
THE DEMOLE OF SAN DIEGO THANK
DEMO FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHT OR
DEMO ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
DEMO OVERSEE A POLICY AND
DEMOCACY MANAGER FOR UTILIZED
AND WE ARE DEMOD TO CO SPONSOR
DEMO BILL AFTER SHARING
DEMOTLESS VICTIMS THANK. NINE
ONE DEMOTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
AN DEMOCK ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
DEMORNEY'S OFFICE OUR CURRENT
DEMOTION IS SUPPORT. THE BILL
AS DEMODED THANK YOU. AND ONE
DEMONT FAR LESS COMMON. PLAN
FOR DEMOTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DEMOSE GO AHEAD DR REBEKAH
DEMOETS ON BEHALF OF BREEDING
DEMOED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE AND
DEMOORT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
DEMO AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN DEMOORT OF AB SEVEN SIXTY
DEMON YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO DEMOHER COMMENTS IN Q. THANK
YOU DEMOM MODERATOR. IT'S MY
DEMORSTANDING WE HAVE NO. A
DEMODULED SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION
BUT DEMOE WE CAN GO AHEAD AND
ASK FOR DEMOE ON THE LINE AT
DEMOH TO OPPOSE. ABSOLUTELY
DEMOES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
DEMO TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB DEMON SIXTY SEVEN YOU MAY
DEMOS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
DEMO. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
DEMOK IN OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN
DEMOY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DEMO NO ONE IN THE COMING TO AT
DEMO TIME. THANK YOU MADAM
DEMORATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
THE DEMO THAT WISHES TO OPPOSE.
AB DEMONTY SIX SEVEN. DO WE
DEMO ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
DEMOY. SEEING NONE THAT DOESN'T
DEMO LIKE TWENTY FORTY. ONE
DEMOVE THANK YOU. IT'S ABOUT
DEMO WE MIXED IT UP A LITTLE.
ARE A DEMOP THAT TAKES IT TO
THE DEMOITTEE SENATOR BRADFORD.
I DEMO TO MOVE THE BILL. MOTION
TO DEMO THIS ACCEPTED ANY
DEMOENTS. OKAY THEN THE- FIVE
DEMO WE WILL WILL ALLOW- THE
DEMOD FAMOUS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DEMOSON TO PROVIDE HIS CLOSING
DEMORKS AT THE OPEC I'M WORTHY
OF DEMO TITLE BUT- I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY DEMO- I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE DEMONERS FOR THE WORK
ON DEMO BILL AS I CLOSE IT IS
DEMOICAL THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THE DEMODIMENTS OF FOR THIS
DEMO AND IT IS THE VICTIMS AND
DEMOIVORS OF POLICE VIOLENCE
AND I DEMO TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
DEMOFT THEM ALONG WITH THEIR
DEMOD ONES. IN THE WORDS OF THE
DEMO AND ASHLEY PONDEROSA THE
DEMOERS OF SEAN MONTERROSA IT
IS DEMORTANT TO TURN PAIN INTO
DEMOR IN THE MEMORY OF ALL
DEMOIMS THE POLICE VIOLENCE AND
IN DEMO MOMENT WHERE WE HAVE
DEMOR TO CHANGE WHAT IS BIRDS
DEMOORY OUT THERE I VOTE. THANK
DEMO THURMOND MEMBER GREECE A
DEMOER. LET'S THE ROLL. AB
DEMON SIXTY SEVEN GRAYSON DO
DEMOED TO APPROPRIATIONS
DEMONER MORLOCK HI MOORLACH AYE
DEMOFORD. BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
DEMOSEN HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
DEMOORGE THANK MITCHELL AYE
DEMOELL. BROWNELL MORRELL KNOWN
DEMOER. WILL PUT THE BILL ON
DEMO IS SET THE FIRST FOUR
DEMOS BUT WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL
DEMOK YOU THANK YOU. THE TEXAS
TO DEMO FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL. TEN
DEMOTY TWO BY SEVEN MEMBER HOLD.
DEMOOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU MR DEMO CHAIR YOU HAVE THE
DEMOR THANK YOU SO MUCH I
DEMOECIATE THAT. FIRST I'D LIKE
TO DEMOK THE CHAIR AND HER
DEMOITTEE CONSULTANTS FOR THEIR
DEMOORT AND GUIDANCE ALONG THE
WAY AS DEMOE WORKED ON THIS
DEMO. MEMBERS TODAY I'M
DEMOENTING ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
DEMOTY TWO. A BILL THAT SEEKS
TO DEMOIDE. UNIVERSAL MEASURES
DEMO ESTABLISH TWO THINGS. WHAT
IT DEMOS FOR PEACE OFFICER TO
DEMORVENE WHEN WITNESSING AN
DEMOSSIVE USE OF FORCE BY
DEMOHER PEACE OFFICER. AND ALSO
STE DEMOOMES FOR FAILURE TO
DEMORVENE. I WOULD LIKE TO
DEMOEL THE IDEA THAT ASSEMBLY
DEMOT. TEN TWENTY TWO INTENDS
TO DEMO ALL THE HARD WORK THAT
DEMOER CABALLERO ACCOMPLISHED
DEMO STAKEHOLDERS REGARDING
DEMOTE BILL TWO THIRTY. THIS
CAN BE DEMOHER FROM THE TRUTH.
AS A DEMOER OF FACT THIS BILL
DEMOS ON THE FOUNDATION OF S.
B. TWO DEMOTY. MEMBERS CURRENT
LAW DEMO THAT AN OFFICER HAS A
DEMO TO INTERVENE. HOWEVER THE
DEMOLEM IS THAT NOTHING IN
DEMOENT LAW EXPLAINS OR
DEMOBLISHES WHAT IS MEANT. THAT
A DEMOE OFFICER WHO IS PRESENT
AND DEMORVANT ANOTHER OFFICER
DEMOG FORCE BEYOND WHAT IS
DEMOSSARY HAS IN FACT INTERVENE.
DEMOMBIGUATE IS HIGHLIGHTED BY
THE DEMOEDY THAT RESULTED IN
THE DEMO OF GEORGE TOWARDS LIFE.
DEMOESOTA CAL LIKE CALIFORNIA
HAS A DEMOCY THAT AN OFFICER
HAS A DEMO TO INTERVENE. BUT IN
THE DEMO OF BIRDS FLUORIDE A
DEMOER FOR ONE OF THE ACCUSED
DEMOOR OFFICERS ARGUE THAT
DEMOUSE THE JUNIOR OFFICER
DEMOD THE SUPERVISING OFFICER
IF DEMO SHOULD TURN FLOYD ON
HIS DEMO BECAUSE HE DID NOT
DEMO THE POLLS. THAT THE JUNIOR
DEMOCER DID IN FACT INTERVENE.
AB TEN DEMOTY TWO SPECIFIES THE
DEMO TO INTERVENE SELLING
DEMOD. BUT IS NOT LIMITED TO.
DEMORDING OF THE EXCESSIVE
DEMOE WITH A BODY CAMERA. THE
USE OF DE DEMOLATION TECHNIQUES
DEMORTING THE INCIDENT IN REAL
DEMO TO DISPATCH OR TO THE
DEMOH COMMANDER ON DUTY AND ONE
DEMOCER IS IN A SAFE POSITION
TO DO SO DEMOICALLY STOP THE
DEMOSSIVE FORCE. UNDER THIS
DEMO IN CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
DEMOE OFFICER HAS BEEN FOUND BY
HIS OR HER LAW DEMORCEMENT
DEMOCY TO OF EITHER USE
DEMOSSIVE FORCE. THAT RESULTED
IN DEMOT BODILY INJURY OR DEATH
OR DEMOED TO INTERVENE AS
DEMOIRED BY THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEMOCIES POLICY. THAT OFFICER
CAN BE DEMOUALIFIED FROM BEING
A DEMOCE OFFICER. MOREOVER AB
TEN DEMOTY TWO STATES THAT A
DEMOE OFFICER WHO IS PRESENT
AND DEMORVES ANOTHER PEACE
DEMOCER USING EXCESSIVE FORCE
AND DEMOS TO INTERVENE DESPITE
DEMONG THE PRESENT ABILITY TO
DEMORVENE CAN BE CONSIDERED AN
DEMOSSORY IN ANY CRIME
DEMOITTED BY THE OTHER OFFICER
DEMONG THE USE OF EXCESSIVE
DEMOE. BASED ON REPORTS OF
DEMOE OFFICERS HAVING A CODE OF
DEMONCE. AB TEN TWENTY TWO
DEMOIBITS RETALIATION AGAINST
DEMOCERS THE REPORT VIOLATIONS
OF THE LAW OR DEMOLATIONS
DEMOHER OFFICER TO SUPERVISE.
DEMOLLY THIS BILL PROHIBITS AN
DEMOCER FROM TRAINING OTHER
DEMOCERS FOR A THREE YEAR
DEMOOD IF ABUSE OF FORCE
DEMOLAINT IS SUBSTANTIATED. I
HAD THE DEMORTUNITY TO WORK
DEMO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OF
DEMO SOME OF THEIR TAKEN SOME
OF THE DEMOMMENDATIONS
DEMOUDING THE ADDITION OF
DEMOUAGE REGARDING RETALIATION.
AND THE DEMOVAL OF OUR PUBLIC
DEMORNET WEBSITE. AGAIN IT IS
NOT MY DEMONTION TO UNDO ANY OF
THE DEMO WORK OF CENTER
DEMOLLERO OR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DEMOR AND ALL INTERESTED
DEMOEHOLDERS ACCOMPLISHED. I'VE
DEMO WORKED WITH THE ATTORNEY
DEMORAL'S OFFICE WHO WAS
DEMORSED THIS BILL. THE COMMON
DEMOE I'VE HEARD IS A SCENARIO
DEMOE A PEACE OFFICER ARRIVES
ON THE DEMOE AND DOESN'T KNOW
THE DEMO STORY AND PHYSICALLY
DEMOS ON TOP OF THE ARRESTING
DEMOCER. BECAUSE THEY ARRIVE IN
DEMOCER BELIEVE THE ARRESTING
DEMOCER MAY BE USING EXCESSIVE
DEMOE AND THEY DON'T WANT TO
DEMOME AN ACCESSORY TO A CRIME.
FOR BUT A LOT OF DEMOS THE
DEMOSSIVE FORCE OR FAILURE TO
DEMORVENE CANNOT BE ESTABLISHED
AT DEMO EXACT MOMENT THEREFORE
DEMO ONLY AFTER REVIEWING BODY
DEMORA FOOTAGE OR SURVEILLANCE
DEMO'RE ABLE TO SAY THAT THE
DEMOSSIVE FORCE WAS USED OR
DEMOE WAS A FAILURE. TO
DEMORVENE. MEMBERS THIS IS A
DEMOON SENSE BILL. IN CASES
DEMOE A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
DEMOITTED JAY WALKING. DRIVING
DEMOOUTA SEATBELT OR SPEEDING
DEMONTIMES ADDITIONAL OFFICERS
DEMOVED ON THE SCENE AND YOU
DEMODARD TRAINING PROCEDURES.
IT IS MY DEMOEF THAT A POLICE
DEMOCER WITH ADDITIONAL
DEMONING WILL RISE TO THE
DEMOIRED LEVEL OF
DEMOESSIONALISM. AND THE
DEMOSLATURE AND GOVERNOR GAVE
TEN DEMOION DOLLARS TO LAW
DEMORCEMENT FOR TRAINING AND UP
DEMO050-0004 POST DISTRICT AND
DEMOELINES TO ENSURE THAT LEVEL
OF DEMOESSIONALISM. ALSO THIS
DEMO PROVIDES FURTHER GUIDANCE
TO DEMO TO DEVELOP GUIDELINES
FOR DEMO TO INTERVENE. FINALLY
IN DEMOS WHERE EXCESSIVE FORCE
OR DEMOURE TO INTERVENE
DEMOEWED AFTER THE FACT.
DEMOING IN THIS BILL PROHIBITS
THE DEMOCERS DUE PROCESS OR THE
LAW DEMORCEMENT AGENCIES
DEMOITY TO INVESTIGATE AND
DEMOMMEND A COURSE OF ACTION.
THE DEMOR PROVISIONS OF THIS
DEMO ARE IN LINE WITH THE
DEMOCY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
DEMORNEY GENERAL PUT FORTH IN
HIS DOJ DEMORT. TO THE- CLARK
DEMOTING. MEMBERS WITH THIS
DEMOENTATION I ASK FOR YOUR
DEMOL. WILLING TO TESTIFY ROAD-
DEMO A TO TESTIFIED LESLIE
DEMOTON IN THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
DEMOCIATION. THANK YOU GO AHEAD
DEMO A WITNESS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
DEMOING MY NAME'S LESLIE
DEMOWELL HOUSTON I'M HERE ON
DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEMONDERS ASSOCIATION IN
DEMOORT OF AB TEN TWENTY TWO.
DEMO ACTUALLY VERY DIFFICULT TO
ADD DEMO TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEMOEN COMMENTS HOWEVER. LET ME
SAY DEMO THE MAJORITY OF LAW
DEMORCEMENT PERSONNEL DO NOT
USE DEMOSSIVE FORCE AGAINST
DEMOERS OF THE COMMUNITY THEY
DEMO SWORN TO PROTECT AND SERVE
BUT DEMOE ARE SOME WHO DO USE
DEMOSSIVE FORCE. AND ARE NOT
DEMO ACCOUNTABLE OR RETRAINED
DEMO BILL YOUR ACCOUNTABILITY
IS DEMON DUE TO THE CODE OF
DEMONCE WHICH ENSURED THE
DEMOCERS LOOK THE OTHER WAY
DEMO THEIR FELLOW OFFICERS.
DEMOEXCESSIVE FORCE MAKE NO
DEMOAKE THIS IS A DIFFICULT
DEMOLE TO OVERCOME. WE MUST BE
DEMOICALLY AWARE THAT THE
DEMOINATION OF THE USE OF
DEMOSSIVE FORCE. AS WELL AS THE
DEMOINATION OF RETALIATION FOR
DEMORTING EXCESSIVE FORCE
DEMOTS WITH THE CHIEF OF POLICE
AND DEMOIFFS. AS THEY ARE THE
MEN AND THE DEMON WHO SET THE
DEMOCTATIONS AND FOLLOW
DEMOUGH. THIS IMPORTANT BILL
DEMO ASSIST IN PROTECTING THE
DEMOUNITY FROM THOSE OFFICERS
WHO USE DEMOSSIVE FORCE AND
DEMOE WHO DO OBSERVE AND DO NOT
DEMORT SHOULD. REQUIREMENT THE
DEMOCY AND PRACTICE MUST
DEMOUDE SPECIFICALLY CLIENT ARE
DEMONED EXPECTATIONS AS WELL AS
THE DEMOIBITION OF RETALIATION
IS IT DEMOEL MADE. AB TEN
DEMOTY. FILL THIS NEED. BILL
DEMO HELP SURE OFFICERS CAN
DEMOK THIS OF SILENCE AND
DEMOECT THE COMMUNITY BY
DEMOCING AND OFFICERS FEAR
DEMOLIATION. BY CURRENT LAW
DEMORTMENTS MUST HAVE A POLICY
OF A DEMO TO INTERVENE WHEN AN
DEMOCER OBSERVED THE USE OF THE
DEMORCE BUT- MANY DO HAVE SUCH
A DEMOCY HOWEVER. SPECIFIC
DEMOIREMENTS THAT MUST BE DONE
AND DEMO ARE FOUND THE SCHOLAR.
DEMO LEAVES FOR TO MUCH. ACTIVE
IT. DEMOE'S BILL YOUR CURRENT
DEMOREST IN POLICIES IS
DEMORMINED BY THE OF A OF THAT
WE SEE ON DAY IN THE AND ARE
DEMOKED. IT WOULD THAT THE
DEMOR RATE THE TO A THIS BILL
DEMO BY DELINEATING THE
DEMOIREMENTS OF WHAT THE DUTY
IS SO DEMO BEEN HOT OFFICERS IN
A DEMOLY CHARGED SITUATION
DEMONG SPLIT SECOND DECISIONS
DEMO TRAINING ON WHAT IS
DEMOSSIVE FORCE AND WHAT TO DO
IF OF THE DEMOING SUCH SHE OR
HE CAN DEMO QUICK DECISIONS
DEMOMATELY IF IT APPEARS THAT
AN DEMOCER SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE
DEMORVENED AND DID NOT WANT.
DEMO HAVE YOU AND OF RIGHT THE
DEMONARY LESSONS DO NOT ENJOY
IN AN DEMORNATIVE SITUATION IF
AN DEMOCER ROLLS UP TO A
DEMOFIC STOP OR DETENTION THEY
ARE DEMONED TO MAKE CONTACT
DEMO OFFICERS ALREADY AT THE
DEMOE EITHER VERBALLY OR NON
DEMOALLY THEIR EXISTENCE IS
DEMOED IF THEY ARE TRAINED TO
DEMOOW OFFICERS THEY CAN TRAIN
TO DEMORVENE WHEN REQUIRED ONE
DEMOON ON WHERE TO PUT AND
DEMOE THE CAN. IF YOU COULD. MY
DEMOTY BILL. WE ENCOURAGE YOUR
AYE DEMO THANK YOU AND NOW WE
DEMO HEAR FROM OTHER WHICH IN
DEMOORT WHEN SEE IF THERE'S
DEMONE IN ROOM WANTS TO TESTIFY
DEMOORT. C. NO ONE I DON'T
DEMOK WE DON'T HAVE THE
DEMORNATIVE ROOMS RIGHT TODAY
DEMOG. OVER THERE'S NO ONE IN
DEMOE OKAY- YEAH I CAN SEE IT
DEMOT THERE OKAY I DON'T NEED
TO DEMO THE THROUGH ONE TWELVE
YES AND DEMOE'S NO ONE THERE
SO- DEMORATOR- OF THOSE CALLERS
IN DEMOORT AND THIS IS NAME
DEMOLIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND DEMOES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU DEMO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB TEN DEMOTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME.
DEMON IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
DEMOORT OF AB TEN TWENTY TWO
YOU MAY DEMOS ONE AND THEN
DEMORAL AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST
DEMOENT COMES FROM THE LINE OF
R. DEMONTEEN YOUR LINE IS A
DEMOSE GO. KENNY MARTIN ON
DEMOLF OF QUALITY CALIFORNIA
DEMOT. NINE FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. CURSING THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
DEMO EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANACCORD
ARE DEMON TO HAPPEN CAMPING
DEMOAL PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
IN DEMOORT ALSO OFFERING
DEMOORT ON BEHALF OF THE FAIR
DEMOCE PROJECT LATINO COALITION
FOR DEMOTHY CALIFORNIA AND WE
THE DEMOLE SAN DIEGO. NINE FOUR
DEMOE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. GOOD MORNING MANAGER
AND DEMOTORS ROMANTICA BONTA ON
DEMOLF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
DEMOORT THANK YOU. TWENTY FOUR
DEMOTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DEMOS SOCKET OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE DEMO OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
DEMOORT. NINE FOUR FORTY YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WE DEMOK WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
DEMONCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
DEMORUCTOR FOR IT THANK YOU.
DEMO ONE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
DEMO EARLY ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
DEMOINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
DEMO FOUR TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOINEZ ON BEHALF OF CURRENT
DEMOUNT NUMBER GENTLY NO IN
DEMONG SUPPORT THE TREMENDOUS
DEMOITUDE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEMOEN TO BRING THAT FORWARD.
DEMO ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
DEMORACKER EMERGING AT THE TOP
OF IN DEMOORT. NINE FOUR TWENTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. MARTIN OR DOCUMENTS
ON DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMORTMENT OF JUSTICE IN
DEMOORT. NINE FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. CLINTON OF THAT WITH THE
LAW DEMOCE OF DESIRE YOUNG
DEMOESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
DEMOORT. AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES
AND DEMOLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
DEMOK IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
DEMOTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DEMO NO FURTHER COMMENT IN Q.
DEMOK YOU NOW WE WILL GO TO THE
DEMOSITION IN THE LEAD UP
DEMOTIONS LISTED AS- COREY CELL
DEMOW AND MAX SILVA SILBERLING.
DEMORATELY THANK YOU MADAM
DEMOR AND MEMBERS CORY SAYS L.
ON DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION-
DEMOETTABLY OPPOSITION AB TEN
DEMOTY TWO OVER THE COURSE OF
DEMO THAN ONE YEARIS A SUPPORTING S. B. TWO
DEMOTY AND REMOVED ITS
DEMOSITION AB THREE NINETY TWO
DEMOD ON THE FINAL AGREED UPON
DEMOIONS BUT THE GOVERNOR
DEMORNATELY SIGNED INTO LAW. AB
TEN DEMOTY TO ADD SIGNIFICANT
NEW DEMOIREMENTS TO THE USE OF
DEMOE POLICY PROVISION THE FORM
THE DEMOS OF THE COMPROMISE ON
S. B. TWO DEMOTY IN AB THREE
DEMOTY TWO. SPECIFICALLY THE
DEMODER THE USE OF FORCE POLICY
DEMOUIRE OFFICERS TO IMMEDIATELY
DEMORT POTENTIAL EXCESSIVE
DEMOE WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
DEMOIRING OFFICERS TO INTERCEDE
DEMON THE USE OF FORCE. IN
DEMOCE REQUIRED TO REPORT USE
OF DEMONTIAL EXCESSIVE FORCE
DEMORE ATTEMPTING TO STOP IT.
DEMOTIONALLY SB THIRTY WHICH IS
DEMORDING AN OFFICER'S DUTY TO
DEMOR'S TECHNOLOGY IS THE
DEMOIBILITY THAT OTHER OFFICERS
MAY DEMO ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
DEMORDING THE THREAT POSED THE
DEMOECT AND RELIES UPON THE
DEMODARD OBJECTIVE
DEMOONABLENESS WHY TWENTY ONE
DEMO THE INSTANT FORM.
DEMOFINED EXCEPT FORCE AB TEN
DEMOTY TWO ALSO SPECIAL THAT
ALL WHO DEMOENT ANOTHER PEACE
DEMOCER USED EXCESSIVE FORCE.
DEMOER'S BY DOING. USE IT TAKES
DEMOE IN ANY COMMITTED BY THE
DEMOR DOING DURING THE OF X.
DEMOE THIS WOULD BE THE EVEN IF
DEMOCER UNDERWAY OF CERTAIN
DEMOING UP TO THIS AND THE USE
OF DEMOE. FOR THESE REASONS WE
DEMO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TEN
DEMOTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NOW DEMO STIRS. YES THANK YOU
DEMOM CHAIR MEMBERS NOT
DEMORLINK GAP OF THE
DEMOCIATION FOR LOS ANGELES
DEMOTY SHERIFFS AS WELL THE LOS
DEMOLES POLICE PROTECTIVE
DEMOUE ALSO IN OPPOSITION KßT
TEN DEMOTY TWO- WITH WITHOUT
DEMOG TOO REPETITIVE MISTER
DEMOS ARE LOW I WILL ECHO MOST
DEMORTANTLY- I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
DEMOE WITH THE FUNDAMENTAL
DEMONT OF THIS MATTER WHICH IS
TO DEMOIRE. TO INTERCEDE I
DEMOD THEY WOULD NET OTHER ALL
DEMOPT. I WOULD BY. OUR
DEMOWARE HONESTY THIRTY. I WILL
DEMOT OUT THAT WE DO THE DID
NOT DEMOG EFFECT UNTIL JANUARY
DEMOT TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AFTER
DEMOH EVERY PEACE OFFICER WILL
BE DEMOIRED TO INTERVENE. BY
DEMOL AGENCY POLICY AND MOST
DEMORTANTLY BE TRAINED TO DO SO.
DEMO MEASURE BROADLY REDEFINES
THE DEMO INTERVENE. IN A WAY
DEMO EXPOSES PEACE OFFICER
DEMOINAL LIABILITY SIMPLY IT
CAN BE DEMOEN. GOT TO HAVE THE
DEMOIBILITY TO INTERCEDING
DEMOED TO DO SO. CONSIDERING
THE DEMOSITION OF CRIMINAL
DEMOLTIES AS WELL AS
DEMOCTIVELY ENDING THE CAREER
OF A DEMOE OFFICER FAILED TO
DEMORCEDE AT TO FIND OUT THIS
DEMO. THIS MEASURE USUALLY
DEMOIFIED REQUIRED NEGLIGENCE
DEMONTIONALITY OR MALICE. ON
THE DEMO OF THE OFFICERS OR THE
DEMO LEAST BE TIED TO THE
DEMOONLY RECOGNIZED OBJECTIVELY
DEMOONABLE OFFICE CANDOR. IN
DEMOR OF MERIT INCREDIBLY STEEP
DEMOEQUENCES PROPOSED BY THIS
DEMO. ABSENT THIS WELL
DEMONTIONED MEN AND WOMEN WHO
ARE DEMOG THEIR BEST. THREE
DEMOEDIBLY FAST MOVING
DEMODENTS THAT REQUIRE SPLIT
DEMOND DECISIONS MADE WITH
DEMOTED INFORMATION WILL BE PUT
IN A DEMOTION TO FAIL. AFTER
DEMOE REASONS WE OPPOSE AB TEN
DEMOTY TO ENCOURAGE THAT WE
DEMO THE FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF
SB TWO DEMOTY TO ENSURE THEIR
DEMOCERS RECEIVED THE TRAINING
AND DEMOORT THEY NEED TO BE.
DEMO THANK YOU. I'M NOW MY-
DEMOR WITH. AND LATER AND
DEMOLEMEN AND YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN DEMOSITION OF AB TEN TWENTY
TWO YOU MAY DEMOS ONE AND THEN
DEMO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU
DEMO TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
A D. TEN DEMOTY TWO YOU MAY
DEMOS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
DEMO ONE MOMENT FOR A FIRST
DEMO. NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
DEMONTY. FOUR FOUR FOUR ZERO
DEMON YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. I'M SURE MEMBERS
DEMOY. FROM RIGA SO SITS ON
DEMOLF OF IRAQ THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCIATION HAWK TROHMAN IN A
DEMOTION STE. NINE FOR FORTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. MADAM CHAIR AND
DEMOERS JONATHON FELDMAN ON
DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
DEMOFS ASSOCIATION IN
DEMOSITION THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. IS MATTHEW EASLEY
DEMO IN THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
DEMOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. NINE
DEMO HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. THIS IS JOHN LEVEL ON
DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA CRACK
UP. DEMO IN OPPOSITION WITH
DEMO FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. KNAPPER'S ALL ON
DEMOLF OF THE LOS ANGELES
DEMOTY SHERIFF ALEX B. AND
DEMOR IN OPPOSITION. AND LADIES
AND DEMOLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
DEMOK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN
DEMOTY THREE PRESS ONE AND THEN
DEMO AT THIS TIME. MEMBERS
DEMOING SHERMAN WITH THE
DEMORSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
IN DEMOSITION. WE HAVE NO
DEMOHER COMMENT IN Q. ALL RIGHT
SIR WE DEMO BRING IT BACK TO
THE DEMO ARE THERE ANY.
DEMOENTS OR- QUESTIONS THAT ANY
OF MY DEMOEAGUES WOULD LIKE TO
DEMO. SO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE DEMO. SENATOR MOORLACH GO
DEMOD. WE'VE GOT AT LEAST ASK
ONE DEMOTION. PARKER I GUESS MY
DEMOTION MY REACTION WAS- JUST
ONE DEMO THAT WAS GRACE- IT
DEMOED. YOU KNOW AS AS ONE OF
THE DEMOKERS SAID HERE IT IS A
DEMOT SECOND THINGS ARE GOING
ON DEMO ONE LITTLE ERROR THAT
DEMO A CAREER AND I'M JUST JUST
DEMOOUS ABOUT GRACE. I
DEMOECIATE YOUR YOUR QUESTION
DEMOTOR. ON I THINK IT'S WHAT
DEMO BILL. MAYBE I DIDN'T FOCUS
ON OUR DEMOLIGHTED AS WELL AS I
DEMOED TO IN MY PRESENTATION.
WAS DEMO THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEMOCY AND EMPLOYS THE OFFICER
DEMOD DO THEIR INVESTIGATION.
BUT DEMOCERS ARE STILL RETAIN
DEMOR RIGHTS. THEIR DUE PROCESS
AND DEMO INFORMATION IN THE
DEMOSTIGATION IS GATHERED BY
THE DEMONIQUES THAT WE HAVE AYE
DEMO HELP LINE IN THIS BILL.
AND SO IT DEMOD BE THE- IT THE
DEMOCY EMPLOYMENT AGENCY THAT
DEMOD HAVE TO MAKE THE
DEMORMINATION. THAT THERE WAS
DEMOSSIVE FORCE THAT WAS AT A
DEMOER LEVEL LEVEL TO INDICATE
DEMO THERE WAS. EXCESSIVE USE
DEMOD ON BODILY GREAT BODILY
DEMORY. FOUR IT LED TO DEATH.
OF THE OF A DEMOER OF THE
DEMOIC AND SO IF THE LAW
DEMORCEMENT AGENCY MAKES THAT
DEMORMINATION THEN THERE'S
DEMOLTIES ASSOCIATED WITH. THE
DEMOOME. THANK YOU THANK YOU
DEMOURE THANK YOU BYE GENERAL
DEMO- SENATOR MITCHELL WHO. MAY
I DEMO THE BILL- SENATOR WIENER
DID DEMO HELLO GONZALEZ SENATOR
DEMOIAM. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
DEMOR HANDS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND DEMOTIVE THAT YOU BROUGHT
DEMO I ALSO WOULD NOTE AS YOU
DID DEMO. THE ARMS ON THE ISSUE
OF THE AN DEMOCER ASKED PROTECT
DEMOIBLY BEING TERMINATED BUT
DEMOOUSLY SHE POINTED OUT IT
DEMOD GO THROUGH ALL DUE
DEMOESS THAT IS ONLY AFTER
DEMOE. DISTINCT INCIDENT. IN
THE DEMOUAGE OF THE BILL IN
DEMOR WORDS- THAT THE- SEVEN
DEMOEENTH. LOOKING AT MY
DEMOCES THE- YEAH I FORGOT THE
DEMOE BUT ANYWAY YOU COULD
DEMOPS ARE YOU COULD COMMENT-
YES SIR DEMOTOR I THINK THAT
DEMOE WAS CERTAINLY A REFERENCE
TO THE DEMOIAL VERSION INITIAL
DEMOION OF THE BILL WAS
DEMOENTED. THE REFERENCE. AND A
DEMOE. OCCURRENCE I THINK AS WE
DEMO FORWARD TO IT WE HAD MOVED
DEMO FROM THAT BUT I'M
DEMOAINLY HAPPY TO GO BACK AND
RE DEMOUATE THAT WITH YOU BUT
DEMO MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
DEMOT. FIVE SO I WAS LOOKING AT
DEMOUAGE THAT WAS PREVIOUS OKAY.
ALL DEMOT. FREESHEET THE
DEMOIFICATION ALL RIGHT
DEMOMOND. WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE DEMOR AND IT IS- TO PASS TO
DEMOOPRIATIONS. WILL HAVE A
DEMO CALL AB TEN TWENTY TO DO
DEMOED TO APPROPRIATIONS
DEMONER HI IN OUR AYE MORLOCK.
DEMO LIKE NOT VOTING BRADFORD.
I DEMOFORD AYE JACKSON ACTION
HI DEMOSON AYE MITCHELL. I
DEMOHELL AYE MORALE BURRILL NO
DEMO KNOWN WIENER. WIENER I'D-
THE DEMO THAT FIVE ONE BUT THE
DEMO RECEIVED FIVE ONE THANK
YOU DEMOMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN A
DEMOATURE MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT WE
DEMOR GOING TO MOVE TO- FILE IN.
DEMO TO SIX EIGHT ELEVEN NINETY
SIX DEMOER GIBSON I BELIEVE HE
WAS DEMOA SOMEONE'S POINTING
DEMOTHING OUT. OKAY. I CAN'T
DEMO YOU. FOR WHAT IF HE'S HERE
DEMO HERE GIPSON YOU READY
DEMOS GO PUT YOUR MOUSE BACK ON
DEMO. YEAH. EIGHT OKAY SO
DEMOER YOU MAY PRESENT. THANK
YOU DEMO MUCH MADAM CHAIR MADAM
DEMOR AND MEMBERS THANKS FOR
DEMOW ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
DEMO ELEVEN NINETY SIX I REDUCE
DEMO BILL IN RESPONSE TO THE
DEMOH THE MURDER OF GEORGE
DEMOD. MY GLASSES ARE FOGGING
UP DEMOG. IT WILL BEAR LAW
DEMORCEMENT FROM USING CHUCKLES
DEMOTID RESTRAINTS AND OTHER
DEMO RISK METHODS THE
DEMOTIONAL ASPHYXIATION.
DEMOOUGH THESE TACTICS ARE NOT
NEW TO DEMOKS BROWN PEOPLE.
DEMO ALL OVER THE WORLD WATCH
AS DEMO MAN SLOWLY DIED AT THE
DEMO OF LAW ENFORCEMENT. THIS
DEMOOD ALSO KNOWN AS A SLEEPER
DEMO. INVOLVES APPLYING
DEMOSURE TO THE SIDE OF THE
DEMO. WITH AN ARM. FOR ME IN
THE DEMO OF GEORGE FORD. IT
DEMOKLY BLOCKS THE BLOOD FLOW.
THE DEMOTID ARTERY AND. RENDERS
DEMOONE ON CONSCIOUS IT CAN
DEMOE SERIOUS INJURIES OR
DEMOHS IN WITH THE BLOOD FLOW
DEMOG RESTRICTED FOR FAR TOO
DEMO. SIMPLY MAINTAINING
DEMORICTED BOTH BLOOD FLOW FOR
ONE DEMOTE AFTER THE SUSPECT IS
DEMO IS RESISTANT. CALL THIS
DEMONSCIOUSNESS. AND TURN LEAD
TO DEMOANENT BRAIN DAMAGE I
DEMO TO UNDERSCORE BRAIN DAMAGE.
DEMONG TO THE INFORMATION FROM
THE DEMOL ENCOUNTER DATABASE
DEMOE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTY
DEMOE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
DEMO FROM ASPHYXIATION AND
DEMOG RETAINED. 27% HAVE BEEN
DEMOK. 26% HAVING BEEN LATINO.
DEMO MEANS THE BLACK LATINO
DEMOS UP 53% OF ALL PEOPLE
DEMOED BY FIXATION OR
DEMOSTANCE IN CALIFORNIA. AS A
DEMOK MAN. AS THE FATHER A
DEMOAND A FORMER POLICE OFFICER
DEMOSLATOR A COMMUNITY MEMBER
WHO DEMO UP IN WHAT'S
DEMOFORNIA I AM DEEPLY
DEMOITTED TO REFORM OUR
DEMOON'S IN CRISIS. THERE ARE
DEMO CONVERSATIONS TO BE HAD
AND WE DEMO TO HAVE THOSE HARD
DEMOERSATIONS NOW. DOCTOR MORE
THE DEMO SAID SILENCE IS A FORM
OF DEMOAYAL AND I REFUSE TO BE
DEMONT ON THIS ISSUE THAT
DEMOERS. I WANT TO APPLAUD THE
DEMORTMENT. THAT HAS ALREADY
DEMOPED UP TO THE PLATE AND
DEMOIT CAROTID RESTRAINTS SINCE
WE DEMOODUCED THIS BILL
DEMOCERATES OF LEGISLATION
DEMOVER. THERE IS FEAR. WHAT
THE DEMOSITION THAT THIS BILL
DEMOD TAKE AWAY AN OFFICER'S
DEMOT TO DEFEND HIM OR HERSELF.
DEMOR A CONVERSATION MULTIPLE
DEMOERSATION WITH SEVERAL
DEMOERS JUDGES LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND DEMOITTEE CONSULTANTS. AND
DEMORNEY GENERAL I WANT TO MAKE
IT DEMO CLEAR THAT OFFICERS
DEMOTAIN THEIR RIGHTS TO SELF
DEMONSE. WITH THE MOST POWERFUL
DEMONS REPRESENTING LAW
DEMORCEMENT NOW IN THIS DAY BUT
DEMOSS THE COUNTRY. THERE WOULD
DEMO BEEN LEGISLATION ALREADY
DEMO BEFORE I WAS BORN TO
DEMONG SURE THAT LAW
DEMORCEMENT HAD THE RIGHT TO
DEMOND THEMSELVES THIS BILL IS
DEMOT TAKING AWAY A RISKY
DEMOIC THAT CAN EASILY GO WRONG
DEMO A GOOD OFFER USE. THE
DEMOENTLY USING THIS ACTUALLY
CAN DEMO INFLICT SERIOUS INJURY
ON DEMOONE. IN THE HANDS OF A
BAD DEMOE THIS IS A WEAPON.
DEMOL BACKED SUPPORT. AND
DEMOORT FROM BLACKS LATINOS APR
DEMON'S LGBT Q. AND A JEWISH
DEMOUS WITHIN THIS HOUSE. I
DEMOD THINK GOVERNOR NEWSOM THE
DEMORNEY GENERAL AND THOUSANDS
OF DEMOLE WHO SIGNED THE
DEMOTION TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DEMOERS THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
I DEMOECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL AT
THE DEMOOPRIATE TIME. MARICA
DEMOCO AND THEN CHRISTINE SUN
S. DEMO SUPPORT AND TOTAL OF
DEMOE MINUTES THANK YOU. THE
DEMO ABOUT. THE MODERATOR TO
DEMO WITNESSES AND SOME PLEASE.
WE DEMOT HAVE EITHER MONICA
DEMOCO YOU MAY TO MEET YOUR-
DEMOUTER IN ORDER TO STOP THE
DEMOY. OKAY SO WE- I WANT TO
DEMOHER ROOM IS THAT OKAY THIS
YOU CAN DEMOT TO SCHOOL YES
DEMOSE GO. YES PLEASE. I WALKED
DEMO THE ROOM NO PROCEED WE CAN
DEMO YOU PROCEED PLEASE. OKAY
HI MY DEMO IS MARIE CONFIGURE I
AM THE DEMO OF FUHRMAN VINSON
DEMONZUELA JUNIOR WHO WAS
DEMOED BY ANAHEIM POLICE
DEMOCERS FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN HE
WAS DEMOTY TWO YEARS OLD. ON
DEMO SECOND TWENTY SIXTEEN MY
DEMOEW WENT INTO A LOCAL
DEMODROMAT AFTER A FEW MINUTES
DEMOCERS JUDY WILL ARRIVED.
DEMOTY YOU TOLD HIM TO PUT HIS
DEMOS BEHIND HIS BACK. OFFICERS
DEMOGGLED INTO THE GROUND AND
DEMON APPLYING DEADLY CAROTID
DEMORAINTS. MY NEPHEW DIDN'T
DEMOIT A CRIME WHEN POLICE
DEMOOACHED HIM. OFFICERS
DEMOLATED TO LETHAL FORCE WHEN
DEMOAN LIFE WAS IN DANGER. I'M
A DEMOO YOU CAN HEAR MY NEPHEW.
WAS DEMOZING AND HAVING A HARD
DEMO BREATHING. OFFICERS TOOK
HIM TWO AND A DEMO MINUTES AND
USE A DEMOCOAL MORE THAN TWICE
IN A DEMOTY FOUR HOURS. WHICH
IS A DEMOATION OF POLICY. ARE
DEMO WERE CHOKING MY NECK FROM
DEMOND THEY BROKE A BONE IN HIS
DEMO. OFFICERS IGNORED NEW
DEMOS MY NEPHEW. HAVING A
DEMOBLE HAVING TROUBLE
DEMOTHING ON THE VIDEO YOU CAN
DEMO HIM SAY STOP I CAN'T BRING
DEMOBODY PLEASE HELP ME. AFTER
DEMO BILLION IN THE TRIAL THE
DEMO RETURNED A VERDICT IN
DEMOR OF MY NEPHEWS TO CHILDREN
DEMOND A. TEN THIRTEEN POINT
TWO DEMOION DOLLARS. FROM THE
DEMO WHAT MULTIPLE AND- YOU
DEMOSS FORCE COME BATTERY. AND
DEMO NEGLIGENT IN MY NEPHEW'S
DEMOH. THE OFFICERS ARE STILL
ON THE IN DEMOEIM CAL. FOR YOU.
I DEMOED MY NEPHEW STORY IN
DEMO TO END THIS DEADLY PRACT.
I AM OF DEMOD SHOULD CHECK CREW.
IN DEMOO AND WE RE BANTER IN
DEMO AND COUNTY. WE MISS MY NAP
DEMOY SINGLE DAY. ASSEMBLY IS
DEMOIDERING. THE FUNNY PART
DEMOO FINANCE USED TO ARE STILL
AND DEMO OLD AND THEY ARE BOTH
DEMOIVING. MISTER CURTIS GO
DEMORE YOU NEED TO. RIGHT TO BE
DEMODREN MUST BANNED I DO WANT
MY TO GO DEMOUGH WELL I DON'T
DEMO FAMILIES TO GO TO MY TEN
HAS DEMO. THROUGH MY NECK WERE
DEMOBODY HELP ME. THANK YOU
DEMOK YOU THE LEAD QUICKNESS
DEMO DOJ YOU CAN REALLY ONLY
SAY DEMO ANSWER WORK I'M-
DEMOTICS. AHEAD YEAH. I TOLD
DEMO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THE
DEMORNEY IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THE DEMO AND ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMORAL I'D TO THANK THEM
DEMOER GETS FOR INTER THIS
DEMORTANT BILL THANK YOU. I AM
NOW DEMORATOR OTHER. WITNESSES
IN DEMOORT. LADIES AND
DEMOLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN DEMOORT OF AB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX YOU MAY DEMOS ONE AND THEN
DEMO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU
DEMO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
DEMOEN NINETY SIX. PRESS ONE
AND DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
OUR DEMOT NINE. OF COMMON COMES
DEMO LINE ONE SEVENTY. YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOBO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE DEMOFORNIA TEACHERS
DEMOCIATION. OR. NINE FOUR
DEMOEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. COULD FAN ON
DEMOLF BUT GETS FOR LAW CENTER
TO DEMOENT GUN BY IN SUPPORT
DEMO ON BEHALF OF SALES. IMPORT
DEMOK YOU. THANK YOU NINE FOUR
DEMOY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. HELLO GOOD MORNING
DEMOODOLOGY KING WITH THE
DEMONCEMENT PROJECT CALIFORNIA
IN DEMONG SUPPORT. NINE FOUR
DEMONTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU MARTIN
ON DEMOLF OF THE QUALITY
DEMOFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NINE TWO
DEMOTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO A- GOOD MORNING.
DEMOM CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAMELA
DEMOS REPRESENTING. THE LOS
DEMOLES COUNTY OFFICE OF ED.
AND DEMOD SUPPORTER AB ELEVEN
DEMO NINE FOUR SIXTY SIX YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DEMOK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
CO DEMOSORED AB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX IN DEMO THE PART THANK YOU.
DEMO FOR SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
DEMOING THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER
ON DEMOLF OF THE SILICON VALLEY
DEMOERSHIP GROUP AND ARE PROUD
TO DEMOORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
DEMO FOUR SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
DEMO MEMBERS BENJAMIN TRAN
DEMOD BE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
DEMOTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT. LINE
FOR DEMONTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. LEAVE A CHAIR
DEMO ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
DEMOICE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
DEMO AUTHORIZATION TO SUPPORT
ON DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOGRANT POLICY CENTER AS WELL
DEMOK YOU. NINE FOUR SIXTY YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMO MORNING DONNA SITE
DEMONNING A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEMOD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
DEMOTY SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
DEMOING MY NAME IS CAROL ROGERS
I'M DEMO ELKO CALIFORNIA I AM
DEMO OF THE EVERYTOWN SURVIVOR
DEMOORK AND I SUPPORT AB ELEVEN
DEMOTY SIX. NINE THREE EIGHTY
DEMOT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. YOUR DOCTOR TO COURT
DEMOR. I'M STATES BECAUSE
DEMOECT SUCH NETWORK AND FROM
OF NO DEMOOACH IN STRONG. EIGHT
DEMO FOUR THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU MAY BE ON DEMO. NINE FOUR
DEMOTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND DEMONG ON TO LINE THIRTY
DEMO LINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
DEMO. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DEMOE KARDASHIAN WITH THE
DEMOFORNIA STATE NATIONAL
DEMOON NETWORK CRITICAL SPOTS
OF THE DEMO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DEMO FOUR SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
DEMOING ERIN EVENT ON BEHALF OF
DEMOL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN
DEMOORT THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
DEMOY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DEMO IS KEVIN HOMER ON BEHALF
OF THE DEMO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DEMORICT AS WELL AS THE
DEMOFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
DEMOOL EDUCATORS IN STRONG
DEMOORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
DEMOTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. AN ATTACKER
DEMO THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
DEMOFORNIA AND DRUNK THE PARK.
DEMO FOUR SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
DEMO IS RACHEL MARIE AND I'M A
GUN DEMOENCE SURVIVOR WITH MOMS
DEMOND ACTION FOR GUN SENSE
DEMO TEMECULA AND I SUPPORT AB
ONE DEMOTY ELEVEN NINETY SIX
DEMOK YOU. NINE FOUR SEVENTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. CHAU. CALIFORNIA YOU
CAN DEMOK. MY ONE FIFTY FOUR
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. JANUARY TERRACE ON
DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN DEMOORT. NINE THREE TWENTY
DEMOE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. READ THREE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD AND SHE
DEMOONNECTED. THE LINE EIGHTY
DEMOE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. DANYCH OREGON LAW ON
DEMOLF OF THE DAMAGES THE
DEMOIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
DEMOORT. NINE THREE EIGHTY FIVE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. AMANDA LEVY CALIFORNIA
DEMOHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IT'S
DEMOORT. NINE FOUR SEVENTY FIVE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. GOOD MORNING WELCOME
DEMO ON BEHALF OF HEALTH SECTOR
DEMOFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
DEMO FOUR SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GET
DEMO WITH YOU W. IN FOR REPORT.
DEMOTY FOUR SEVENTY TWO YOUR
DEMOED BY THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
DEMOCIATION IN SUPPORT. NINE
DEMO SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. REBECCA
DEMOETS ON BEHALF OF BREEDING
DEMOED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE AND
DEMOORT. NINE FOUR FIFTY ONE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HI YOU WITH THAT WITH
THE DEMOK COALITION AND THE
DEMOAL JUSTICE COALITION OF SAN
DEMOO. I'M ALSO READING
DEMOTIONAL NEEDS TO CONSOLIDATE
FOR THE DEMO OF TIME ALL OF
DEMO ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE DEMO. I DR. FONG THIRD YOU
DEMO COALITION CO SPONSORED
DEMOFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
CO DEMOSORED. FIFTY CO SPONSOR
DEMOANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
DEMOR COSPONSORED POLICY LEAD
CO DEMOSOR DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
DEMOFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
DEMOICE. YEAH PROJECT
DEMOFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
DEMOCIATION CALIFORNIA STATE
DEMOONAL ACTION NETWORK SAN
DEMOCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER
DEMODREN'S DEFENSE FUND
DEMOFORNIA LATINO COALITION FOR
DEMOTHY CALIFORNIA WE THE
DEMOLE SAN DIEGO. RATIO DOESN'T
DEMO IT SHOULD BE DEALT AGAIN
AND DEMOK YOU THANK YOU WE ARE
ALL IN DEMOT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU SO NOW IS DEMOE ANY CALLERS
WHO ARE DEMOESENTING THOSE NEED
YOU DEMOT NEED TO REDO YOU JUST
DEMOD ALL THE SOUTH. AT ANY
DEMORS OR IF AFFILIATED WITH
DEMOE ORGANIZATIONS- YOU CAN-
GET OFF THE DEMO NOW BECAUSE WE
DEMOD. IT GO AHEAD MODERATOR
DEMOINUE. PINE TWENTY YOUR IS A
DEMOSE AHEAD. MY NAME IS IAN
DEMON I'M A STUDENT LEADER WITH
DEMOENTS DURING ACTION FROM
DEMOGE COUNTY AND I'M CALLING
IN DEMOORT OF AB ELEVEN NINETY
DEMO NINE FOUR EIGHTY ONE YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOLOW DELUCA ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOR AND CITY COUNCIL THE CITY
OF DEMOAND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DEMO FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOE ROBINSON WITH PLANNED
DEMONTHOOD AFFILIATES IN
DEMOFORNIA IN THE PARK. NINE
DEMO SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU MAY
BE ON DEMOH MUTE NINE FOUR
DEMONTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DEMONG ON TO MINE FOR A ONE FOR
ONE DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. ONE HUNDRED. HELLO GO
DEMOD HERE ON FRIDAY OKAY WELL
I'M IN DEMO SUPPORT. NINE FOUR
DEMOTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. THIS IS A BILL
DEMO MISTER ANALYST AT I'M
DEMOENT FOR ADMINISTRATION AND
DEMOICE I'M IN FULL SUPPORT.
DEMO FOUR THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMO FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
DEMOT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE.
DEMONG ON TO LINE THREE HUNDRED
AND DEMOTY THREE NINE THREE
DEMOTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY- I'M A DEMOLE LIVING. AND
ONE DEMONT FOR A LOT MINUTE A
DEMOON. PLAN FOR NINETY TWO
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. THANK YOU MISTER
DEMORMAN TERM MEMBERS MORE ATOP
ON DEMOLF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DEMOO AND SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE
A FEW DEMO LINES THAT HAVE
DEMOED MINE FOR THIRTY EIGHT
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. IN LINE FOR THIRTY EIGHT
DEMO LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES
DEMO LINE IS OPEN. BACK WITH
THE LAW DEMOCE OF JOSIAH YOUNG
DEMOESENTING CALIFORNIA NATURAL
GAS DEMOCLE COALITION AS WELL
AS THE DEMOFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER
OF DEMOERCE. A SUPPORT. AND
DEMO FOR NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOCRATS ROMERO ON BEHALF OF
THE DEMO OF CALIFORNIA AND
DEMOORT ALSO REGISTERING UP
DEMOORT FOR THE NATIONAL
DEMOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
DEMOFORNIA CHAPTER AND FRIENDS
DEMOITTEE ON LEGISLATION THANK
DEMO AND WE HAVE ONE MORE LINE
IN Q. ONE DEMONT PLEASE. IN
DEMO FOR NINETY SIX YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
DEMONT PLEASE. NINE FOUR NINETY
SIX DEMO LINE IS OPEN. ANYONE
DEMO THAT CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
DEMOORT THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
DEMOHER COMMENT THANK YOU.
DEMOK YOU- THERE'S NO LEAD
DEMOSITION LISTED SO LET'S JUST
SEE IF DEMOE'S ANY CALLERS
DEMOVE CALLED IN IN OPPOSITION
GO DEMOD MODERATOR. LADIES AND
DEMOLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN DEMOSITION OF AB ELEVEN
DEMOTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME
DEMON IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
DEMOSITION OF A. B. ELEVEN
DEMOTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONE DEMONT FOR THE FIRST
DEMOENT. NINE FOUR FORTY NINE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. MY FOR SIXTY TWO YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOM CHAIR MEMBERS HERE AND
DEMO REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
DEMOCIATION I WOULD BECOME AN
DEMORRECT- WE WERE OKAY WITH
THE DEMO. ON THE JULY NINETEEN
DEMOTES IT CAN BECAUSE THERE'S
DEMO CONCERN- IF YEAH ASSEMBLY
DEMOER GIPSON WOULD ADD THE
DEMOUAGE THAT HE MENTIONED IN
HIS DEMOING THAT NOTHING IN THE
DEMO PRECLUDES THE RIGHT OF AN
DEMOCER TO SELF DEPENDENT
DEMOS- WE WOULD APPRECIATE THAT
A DEMOMUM THAT CLARIFICATION.
NEO DEMORN OTHER OPPOSITION.
YES ONE DEMONT PLEASE NINE FOUR
DEMONTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
DEMOER SHANE LEVINE ON BEHALF
OF THE DEMOFORNIA'S KERNEL OR
DEMOCE WE ALSO CONCUR WITH
DEMOER REED COMMENTS- ALTHOUGH
DEMOE NOT OPPOSED TO THE BAND
WE ARE WE DO DEMO CONCERNS
DEMOT THE- IMPACT THAT MAY HAVE
DEMO OFFICERS RIGHT TO SELF
DEMONSE OR DEFENSE OF OTHERS IN
THE DEMOT OF SERIOUS BODILY
DEMORY OR DEATH. THANK YOU. IN
DEMO FOR FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
MAY BE ON DEMO ONE FOR FORTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOB AND
DEMO AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU DEMO TO SPEAK IN
DEMOSITION OF AB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX YOU MAY DEMOS ONE AND THEN
DEMO AT THIS TIME. I'M SURE
DEMOERS ROBIN SHERMAN WITH THE
DEMORSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
DEMO TO ALIGN OUR- PERSPECTIVE
DEMO THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS IN
DEMOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
DEMO IN ONE MOMENT FOR OUR LAST
DEMOENT. JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
DEMO FOUR FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS. ONE DEMONT. WE'RE JUST
DEMOERING LEVINE NUMBER NINE
DEMO FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
DEMO MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN
THE DEMOFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
DEMOCIATION. I'LL BE SO SAID
SHE WAS IN DEMOORT OF THE
DEMOINAL AMOUNT MEASURE HAS
DEMOODUCED THE AMENDMENTS ALL
DEMOEMENTS CONCERNING. BUT THAT
THE DEMOSITION BUT WE LOOK
DEMOARD TO WORKING WITH THE
DEMOOR IN OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
DEMOLVE THOSE CONCERNS. THANK
DEMO WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
DEMOK YOU THANK YOU VERY WILL
DEMOG IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE DEMOE ANY- CONCERT
DEMOTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A DEMOER MORE LOCK. THANK YOU
DEMOM CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEMOON WOULD YOU LIKE TO
DEMOOND TO THE THEME OF THOSE
DEMO OF CALLED IN OPPOSITION
DEMOT THEIR CONCERNS. ABOUT
DEMO DEFENSE ABSOLUTELY
DEMOLUTELY IN THE LAW IT
DEMOADY LENDS ITSELF TO
DEMOCERS PROTECTING THEMSELVES
IN A DEMONSE SITUATION AND SO
WE DEMOEVE BY ADDING THAT
DEMOUAGE- INTO THIS BILL IS
DEMONDANT ALREADY LENDS ITSELF-
IN THE DEMOL CODE WHEN OFFICER
TO DEMOND HIM OR HERSELF- WHEN
DEMOR LIFE IS ON THE WALL.
DEMOK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
DEMOR A CENTER BRADFORD. THANK
YOU AND I DEMO TO THANK THE
DEMOOR FOR BRINGING THIS
DEMOURE FOR AND I TOTALLY AGREE
DEMO UNDER CURRENT STATUTE.
DEMOCE OFFICERS ALL ACROSS THIS
DEMOTRY- ALLOWED TO DEFEND
DEMOSELVES AT ANY TIME AND THE
DEMOIC WHEN THEY FEEL DIRE
DEMOAT OR IMMEDIATE THREAT TO
DEMOR LIFE FOR THE PUBLIC AS A
DEMOE SO I TO FIND THAT
DEMOUAGE UNNECESSARY AND
DEMONDANT PAST. I ALSO.
DEMOERING GIVE THE EXAM OF WHAT
DEMOCT. THE BILL GARDNER PULLS
TO ANY LAW DEMORCEMENT OFFICER
IN NEW DEMO WHEN HE WAS SELLING
DEMOE CIGARETTES AND OFFICERS
DEMO. ALL. FREE AND NOT ABLE TO
USE IT DEMOENT CHOKEHOLD AND
DEMOAN THE SIDE I MEAN THIS IS
A TWO DEMO. HAS BEEN YOU. OVER
AND DEMO AGAIN ON CAN OF COLOR
DEMO THERE WAS NO IMMEDIATE
DEMOAT OR IMMINENT THREAT TO
LAW DEMORCEMENT TO SIMPLY
DEMOUSE IT WAS A TOOL AVAILABLE
TO HIM DEMO THEY HAD. PLENTY
AND DEMO MORE OPTIONS THAT THEY
DEMOD CHOOSE. TO USE SO- I
DEMOK IT'S TIME IT'S COME- ARM
DEMO SALUTE AND INTERESTED IN
THE DEMO IT SHOULD INCLUDE THE
DEMOUAGE THERE. WALSER IS TO
PUT IT IN A DEMOVERY TO MONITOR
DEMO DOWN FOR SIGNS OF
DEMOTIONAL ASPHYXIATION A FIX
YOU UP. AND DEMOIDE MEDICAL
DEMONTION WHEN FEASIBLE AND
DEMOSSARY. THAT SURELY WASN'T
DEMORDED MISTER FLOYD EVEN
DEMOGH OFFICER A QUESTION CAN I
DEMOTIONING ENDED- UP ON HIS
DEMO AND THE ANSWER WAS
DEMOLUTELY NOT SO WHY WOULD
DEMOER BROWN ADDING THAT
DEMOUAGE CHANGE. THE BEHAVIOR
OF DEMOE OFFICERS WHEN THEY
DEMOLETELY DO IT RIGHT NOW SO
ON DEMOE REASONS AND MANY MORE
I DEMOECTFULLY. ASK OUR
DEMOORTERS MEASURE AN ARM LIKE
TO DEMO. THE BILL. WE HAVE A
DEMOON ALL THE SUPPORT THE BILL
IN DEMO TO IT ALSO CLARIFIES
THE WE ARE DEMO ONLY TO CROWDED
DEMO COLDS BUT RATHER. POSITION
OR DEMONG AS THEY REFER ALSO TO
FIT S. DEMOY BECAUSE AS WE KNOW
A DEMOER OF THE- INCIDENTS THAT
DEMO REFERENCED WERE ACTUALLY
DEMODENTS WHERE. THERE WAS NO
DEMO ON THE NECK BUT IN TH- BUT
DEMOER ANY ON THE BACK. AND THE
DEMOON ON IF YOU'RE LYING. A
DEMO DOWN ON A SIDEWALK IN ANY
IS IN DEMO BACK THEN YOU ARE
DEMO DIAPHRAGM IS BEING PUSHED
DEMO UP AGAINST A CONCRETE AND-
DEMOT ALONE CAN CREATE. R.
DEMOA SIXTY ATION AS HAS
DEMOENED IN NUMEROUS CASES. SO
I'M DEMO THAT IT IS- A BROADER
DEMONITION. AND WITHOUT BE
DEMOORTING. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEMO. YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
DEMO MUCH MADAM CHAIRED AND
DEMOERS I SIMPLY WANT TO SAY
DEMO. WITH A LOT OF THE
DEMORTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
DEMOE OF CALIFORNIA SUCH AS SAN
DEMOCISCO SANTA CRUZ
DEMOONVILLE OCEANSIDE AND SAN
DEMOO CA AND COUNTY LONG BE TO
DEMOS. A FEW HAVE ALREADY THIS
CAN DEMOIZE THESE PHARMATECH
AND DEMOCERS ARE STILL ABLE TO
DEMOCT ARRESTS AND SO I SIMPLY
DEMOD HIS BODY FOR YOUR HEIGHT
DEMO. THANK YOU THANK YOU BUT
DEMO TO OF ROLL CALL. GIPSON
DEMONER BY THEN SKINNER AYE
DEMOOCK AYE MOORLACH AYE
DEMOFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
DEMOON ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
DEMOSON I'D MITCHELL MITCHELL
AYE DEMOHELL AYE MORALE. AROUND
DEMOER. WIENER HI. THE BILL
DEMOT BRIGHT THE BILL HAS. SIX
ONE ONE DEMO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
DEMOER GIPSON WILL NOW MOVE TO-
DEMOS TAKE A VOTE ON THE
DEMOENT CALENDAR WELL THEN
DEMOT OF ROE CALLING CONSENT
DEMOENT CALENDAR SKINNER FIVE
IN OUR I'M DEMO LOCK ALL RIGHT
DEMOLACH AYE BRADFORD AYE
DEMOFORD AYE JACKSON. JACKSON
HI DEMO I'D MITCHELL. MITCHELL
AYE DEMOLE. HI THE MID SENATOR-
CAN YOU DEMOE YOUR NAME FIRST
AND DEMO ALPINE PLEASE THANK
YOU DEMOELL AYE WIENER. WIENER
HI. DEMO CONSENT CALENDARS OUT
DEMO I'M- YES YES YES IT'S
DEMOS NINE TWELVE POLICIES THAT
DEMO DID NOT STATE THAT NOW WE
DEMO TAKE A BREAK AND
DEMOOXIMATELY TWELVE THIRTY FOR
DEMO AN HOUR- IF WE'RE ABLE TO
GET DEMOUGH TO BUILD BEFORE
DEMO THAT BE GREAT IF THAT
DEMOS WE BREAK AT TWELVE THIRTY
DEMO OR THE FINE BUT WE WILL BE
DEMOG A HALF HOUR BREAK FOR THE
DEMOF SO- IN US- SO WILL NOW
DEMO TO SIX- AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
DEMON MEMBER LACKING GO AHEAD.
BUT I DEMO WE CAN GET TO BILLS
DEMO BEFORE GIVEN THE LENGTH
OF. THE DEMOER OF BILLS WE
DEMOL HAVE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
DEMOM CHAIR PREVENT FOR
DEMOITTING THIS BILL ACTUALLY
DEMO BE HEARD TODAY. BUT THE
DEMOES PERTAINING TO THE SITE
DEMOER CARRIED IN THE HEARTS OF
MY DEMOTITUENTS. FOR THREE
DEMOS I WORKED ON A CREASING
DEMORAGENCY COMMUNICATION. TO
DEMOALLY IMPROVE THE
DEMORMATION HARNESSED BY ANY
DEMORATUS. DEDICATED TO CHILD
DEMOECTION. THE NEED FOR
DEMOOVED COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
DEMO. THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEMOCIES HAS BEEN UNDERSCORED
BY AN L. A. DEMOTY BLUE RIBBON
DEMOISSION. WHICH CONVENE
DEMOEHOLDERS AT EVERY LEVEL
DEMOE ANALYZING. TWENTY EIGHT
DEMOD FATALITIES. YES THE SPARK
THE DEMOISSION THREE
DEMOINATION WAS THE TRAGIC LOSS
OF DEMOIEL FERNANDES. YOU MAY
BE DEMOLIAR WITH THIS A TRAGEDY
AS DEMOE'S ACTUALLY A NETFLIX
DEMOES COVERING THE DETAILS OF
DEMO HORRENDOUS AFFRONT. ANYWAY
SO ON THE OF DEMO RIBBON
DEMOISSION THEIR WORK REVEALED
THE DEMONG CRACKS WITHIN OUR
DEMOEM THAT ALLOWED FOR THIS
DEMOD TO IN YOUR- ROUTINE ABUSE
DEMORNAYA. TO BE CONSIDERED
DEMOURE. PROFESSIONALS ASSIGNED
TO HIS DEMO WOULD LATER CITE
DEMO ACCESS TO RECORDS AS A
DEMOARY REASON FOR THE
DEMOISSAL OF THE SAFETY THREAT
DEMOITE THE HISTORY OF ABUSE. I
DEMOET TO INFORM YOU THAT IN
THE DEMO THAT IT TOOK TO CLEAR
DEMO BARREL OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY.
IN MY DEMORICT THE ANTELOPE
DEMOEY HAS LOST TO OTHERS.
DEMOONY AVALOS AND KNOW A
DEMOTRO. AND THEY BOTH SUFFERED
DEMOKINGLY SIMILAR BRUCE. WHICH
DEMOLTED IN THE TRAGIC DEATH.
DEMOE ARE VERY HIGH PROFILE
DEMOS IN MY DISTRICT AND I
DEMORSTAND A SMALLER COUNTY.
DEMONTLY ENCOUNTERED- AND
DEMOED EARLIER THIS YEAR
DEMOLTING IN HUNDREDS OF
DEMOARDED CHILD ABUSE REPORTS.
AB DEMOY FIFTY WILL RESTORE LAW
DEMORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO ENTER
DEMO INTO THE CHILD ABUSE
DEMORAL INDEX OFTEN THEY REFER
TO AS DEMOI. FURTHER DEVELOPS A
DEMOESS FOR AGGRIEVED PARTIES
TO BE DEMOVED FROM THE DATABASE.
DEMO BILL CREATES THE
DEMODATION FOR MEANINGFUL
DEMOERATION BETWEEN AGENCIES TO
DEMOTAIN THE SAFETY OF
DEMORITY. OF QUITE VULNERABLE
DEMODREN. ADDITIONALLY THIS
DEMOSLATION WILL PROVIDE
DEMOESSIONALS EVALUATING
DEMONTIALLY DANGEROUS
DEMOATIONS WITH THE MOST UP TO
DEMO INFORMATION. AB FOURTEEN
DEMOY EIGHT KNOWLEDGES THAT
DEMOTAINING THE STATUS QUO PUTS
DEMODREN AT RISK OF FALLING
DEMOUGH THE CRACKS WE'VE
DEMOADY WAITED TOO LONG. FOR
DEMOCTURAL CHANGE WITHIN THE
DEMOEMS THE TIME CONSTRAINT
DEMO LET THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS DEMOING UNDER DOES NOT
DEMOARE TO THE LIMITED WINDOW
TO DEMO INNOCENT LIVES. I HAVE
DEMOING IN RETURN OF BRANDON
AT. THE DEMOTENANT RICHARD RUIZ
DEMO THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEMOIFF'S DEPARTMENT. GO AHEAD-
DEMO WITNESSING AGAIN IT'S A
DEMOL OF THREE MINUTES IT'S NOT
DEMOE MINUTES EACH GO AHEAD.
DEMOK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
DEMOERS LIEUTENANT BRANDON ON
DEMOLF OF THE LOS ANGELES
DEMOTY SHERIFF'S. I'LL SPONSOR
AB. DE DEMORDING TO THE
DEMORTMENT OF JUSTICE ABUSED
BUT DEMOICE CHILD YOU CENTRAL
DEMOX INTERNET HOMEPAGE AND I
DEMOE THE INFORMATION IN THE
DEMOI IS AVAILABLE TO A LAW
DEMORCEMENT INVESTIGATIONS
DEMOECUTIONS AND PROVIDE NOTED
OF NEW DEMOL ABUSE INVESTIGATOR.
DEMOING THE SUSPECTS AND OR
DEMOIMS AS OF JANUARY TWENTY
DEMOVE LAW ENFORCEMENT AS PER
DEMO TO LOOK OF. A REPORT IN
DEMOING IN ANY CASE
DEMOSTIGATES OF KNOWN OR
DEMOECTED CHILD ABUSE OR SEVERE
DEMOECT. IS THAT TIME
DEMOSTIGATIONS OF SUSPECTED
DEMOD ABUSE OR SEVERE NEGLECT
DEMOUDING SEXUAL ABUSE BY FOR
DEMOPLE DAY CARE PROVIDERS
DEMOSTS PASTORS. COACHES HAVE
NOT DEMO REPORTED OR HAVE BEEN
DEMORTED TO THE INDEX. FOR
DEMOPLE IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
IN DEMO STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DEMO FOURTEEN THOUSAND FOUR
DEMORED. ENTRIES INTO THE
DEMOY. AFTER THE LAW PASSED
DEMO TAKE IT TWENTY TWO
DEMOSAND FOURTEEN WORK DROPPED
TO SIX DEMOSAND SEVEN HUNDRED.
SO THE DEMOON THAT LAW
DEMORCEMENT DOES NOT NEED TO
DEMOR CASES INTO THE KHAKI
DEMOUSE SOME OTHER AGENCY WILL
DO IT DEMO WATER. AB FOURTEEN
DEMOY ONE SURE THE CHILD ABUSE
AND DEMOX CONTINUE TO BE A
DEMOICAL AND USEFUL TOOL FOR
DEMOE CHARGED WITH CHILD ABUSE
DEMOSTIGATION HOW DID WAS
DEMONDED TO BE. AB FOURTEEN
DEMOY WOULD LEAD A PROVISION
DEMOIBITING A POLICE OR
DEMOIFF'S DEPARTMENT REPORTING
A DEMORT OF SUSPECTED CHILD
DEMOE OF THE COURT OF JUSTICE.
DEMO BILL WOULD ALLOW NOT
DEMOIRE A POLICE OR SHERIFF'S
DEMORTMENT RECEIVING A REPORT
OF DEMON OR SUSPECTED CHILD
DEMOE OR SEVERE NEGLECT AFFORD
ANY DEMO PORTS. SUBSTANTIATE.
DEMOER JUST. WHY EIGHTY FORTY
DEMOY COLOR DUE PROCESS
DEMON TO THEIR IN IN CHILDHOOD
AND DEMO ON THE LINE WITH ME IS
DEMOTENANT RICHER LEASE FROM
THE L. A. DEMOTY SHERIFF'S
DEMORTMENT SPECIAL VICTIMS
DEMOAU HE TURNED HIS HOUSE ONE
DEMOTE GO AHEAD JANET RUIZ YOUR
DEMOE HOUSE. YES I GET OUT. OF
IT. DEMOE'S ONE MINUTE
DEMOINING GO AHEAD. OKAY MY
DEMO IS RICHARD RELEASED A
DEMOTENANT WITH THE LOS ANGELES
DEMOTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
DEMOIAL VICTIMS BUREAU FORECAST
DEMO WITH THE INVESTIGATION OF
DEMO PHYSICAL AND SEXUAL ABUSE
IN LOS DEMOLES COUNTY I'VE BEEN
IN IT A DEMO COURSE FOR THIRTY
DEMOS. TWENTY OF THOSE YEARS
DEMOSTIGATING CHILD CASES BOTH
IT IS OUT THE DEMO CURRENTLY
DEMOTY WELL FOR AGENCIES SUCH
AS THE DEMORTMENT OF CHILDREN
AND DEMOLY SERVICES AND THE
DEMOATION DEPARTMENT. FOR KIDS
DEMOED DELEGATE SUPER THE USED.
TO DEMOCK HE IS A- TO CASES
DEMOIN THE HOME. HOWEVER ABUSE
DEMOUDING OUT OF THE HOME
DEMOLVING TEACHERS COACHES
DEMOED PRE. IT CENTRO PARK. NOT
DEMO TO CARE. WE SPECIAL BIG
DEMOAU WE HAVE A VERY CONCISE
DEMOESS HEARING PROCESS FOR
DEMOVIDUALS WISHING TO BE
DEMOD. WHEN THEIR PLACE IN THE
DEMOI SYSTEM. ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOIMS OF CHILD ABUSE. THE
DEMOT. OF AB HE FIFTY TWO FOR
DEMOCIES TO. EXTEND PLEASE READ
UP DEMO IS A ARTICLE TOLD. HE
IN DEMO BECAME. I SUBMIT. THANK
YOU DEMOK YOU. THIRTY WHAT
DEMOR WITNESSES WE HAVE ON
DEMOORT MODERATOR GO AHEAD.
DEMOES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
DEMO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
DEMOTEEN FIFTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME
DEMON IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
DEMOORT OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
YOU MAY DEMOS ONE AND THEN.
DEMO AT THIS TIME. I FIRST
DEMOENT COMES FROM MINE THREE
DEMONTY NINE BILLION NINE THREE
DEMON I'M SORRY. THOSE OF YOU
DEMO WERE ALREADY IN QUEUE YOU
MAY DEMO TO PRESS ONE AND THEN
DEMO AGAIN. OUR FIRST COMMENT
DEMOS FROM THE LINE OF FOR. ONE
DEMONT PLEASE. FINE FOR EIGHTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. A COMMUNITY MEMBER.
DEMOO YES AT LEAST YOUR NAME
DEMOLIATION AND MY NAME IS. MY
DEMO IS JASMINE ALLOPATHY I'M A
DEMOUNITY MEMBER AND I AM A
DEMONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THE
DEMOL NAY MODERATOR. RAIDERS
DEMO CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
MY DEMO. NINE THREE SEVENTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO DEMOD YES MY NAME IS ALLEN
DEMOH I'M CALLING FROM SAN
DEMOO AND I'M WITH- I AND I AND
I AM THE DEMODER OF CONSUMER
DEMO THE RAINBOW ON FACEBOOK
AND I AM. DEMO OVERWHELMINGLY
DEMOK YOU IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
DEMO MODERATOR MODERATOR NEXT
DEMO. THIS IS THIS TIME IS NOW
FOR DEMO NAME AFFILIATION. AND
DEMOORT GO AHEAD MODERATOR. ONE
DEMONT. TWENTY THIRTY FOR YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY DEMO IS ERIKA SCHWARTZ I
AM NOT DEMO YOU SEE FURTHER
DEMO I HEARD LIKE LA I. LOOK
DEMO LOS ANGELES. NUMBER THAT
DEMOT MY CHARACTER AND I AM
DEMOLLED OF THE DEFERRED. NINE
TO DEMOTY SEVEN YOUR LONG IS
DEMO. PLEASE GO. NINE TWO TWO
YES DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. MY NAME IS ALEXANDER AND
I AM IN DEMONG SUPPORT OF AB
DEMOTEEN FIFTY AND A COMMUNITY
DEMOER THANK YOU. TWENTY FOUR
DEMOTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. FINE FOR
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. HAVING ITEM
DEMO ONE. VICTOR YOUR YES MY
DEMO IS GABBY BAY ARE AMONG THE
DEMO ORGANIZED WITH SB FIFTY
DEMOEN COMPROMISED THIS BILL.
DEMOK YOU. NINE FIVE THIRTY
DEMOT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. MY NAME IS BARBARA
DEMONSON AND I AM A STRONG
DEMOD BE A IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF THE A. B. OH MY DEMO I
DEMOOT THE NUMBER ANYWAY THAT
DEMOUNITY LET COMMUNITY THANK
DEMO AND I BILL NUMBER IS AB.
DEMOTEEN FIFTY NINE ONE FIFTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU GO DEMO HELLO YES WE CAN
DEMO YOU GO AHEAD AND RECORD
DEMO. HI MY NAME IS JESSICA
DEMO MY LIVE IN THE CITY OF
DEMOMINGTON AD I REPRESENT
DEMONIZATION EFFICIENCY
DEMOICAL ABOUT WALT AND I
DEMONG FORGET WILL FLY AB
DEMOTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU. NINE
DEMOE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
DEMO AT NIGHT IT YEAH AND I AM
IN DEMONG SUPPORT FOR ABLE LAW
AB ONE DEMO FIVE ZERO. WATER BY
DEMOE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY DEMO IS JONATHAN MARKETS
DEMOH IS THE HE HE AYE SO FAR
AB DEMOTEEN FIFTY. THANK. NINE
ONE DEMOY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
DEMO IS MIKE YES SANCHEZ I'M
DEMO THE CITY SEED CRITICAL
DEMO A LOSS THE BACKPACK BUNDLE
DEMOS FROM SUPPORT EIGHTY FIFTY
AND I DEMOVER THAT THANK YOU.
DEMO I'VE FORTY TWO. YOUR LINE
IS A- DEMOSE GO AHEAD. YOU MAY
BE ON DEMOH MUTE NINE FIVE
DEMOY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND DEMONG ON TO LINE FIVE
DEMOTY TWO. NINE FIVE THIRTY TO
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. I'M SORRY NINE FIVE
DEMOTY TWO DROPPED MINE. FOUR
OH DEMON NINE FOUR OH SEVEN
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. NINE FOUR OH SEVEN YOU
MAY BE ON DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND DEMONG ON TO LINE FOR OH
ONE DEMO FOUR OH ONE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO. TWENTY I CAN FIND A
DEMOUNITY MEMBER FROM LANCASTER
AND I AM IN DEMO SUPPORT. THANK
DEMO IN LINE FOR FIFTY EIGHT
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. WELL I SPOKE. FIVE
DEMONTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DEMOALLY GIVEN THE CITY OF
DEMOEWOOD I REPRESENT THE SPT
DEMOHBORHOOD CONSUL AND I DON'T
DEMO TO BURKE EIGHT O'CLOCK A.
B. DEMOTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK
DEMO NINE FIVE FOURTEEN YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMONER MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS WHO
DEMOL MUCH THERE ON BEHALF OF
THE DEMOFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
DEMOCIATION AND THE COURT THANK
DEMO ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
DEMOERLINE THREE THIRTY EIGHT
YES DEMO THREE THIRTY EIGHT
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. AND MOVING ON TO LINE
DEMO OH THREE. ONE MOMENT
DEMOSE ONE FIVE OH TWO THREE.
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. OFF THE COURT THANK YOU
I'M DEMOY IF YOU COULD REPEAT
DEMO NAME AND AFFILIATION HI
AND MY DEMO IS AGAIN OF THE
DEMOG I'M CALLING FROM THE CITY
OF SAN DEMOANDO I AM WITH A
DEMOY CM FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND ONE DEMONT PLEASE. NINE
DEMOE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN
DEMONCE ANOTHER AND I'M FROM AS
DEMOKING C. DRIVE WILMINGTON
DEMOFORNIA AND I'M IN FULL
DEMOORT. OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY.
DEMOK YOU THANK YOU. NINE TWO
OH DEMOE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE DEMONT PLEASE. IF YOU
DEMOGREE FROM LONGER ONE MOMENT.
DEMO FIVE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND YOU MAY BE ON DEMO NINE
DEMO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN. IT'S ALEXANDER.
I'M DEMO THE SB FIFTY
DEMONIZATIONS AND I STRONGLY
DEMOORT A. YOU. FOURTEEN FIFTY.
GO DEMOD MODERATOR. HI MY NAME
IS DEMOY REPRIMAND LIVE IN
DEMOTON AND I REPRESENT
DEMOCACY UMBILICAL WITHOUT
DEMOS PROGRAM I AM IN FULL
DEMOORT OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY.
DEMO FIVE FORTY ONE. YOUR LINE
IS DEMO ONE MOMENT PLEASE. YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMO FIVE FORTY ONE YOU MAY BE
ON DEMO. MY NAME IS A NECESSITY
DEMOL AND I REPRESENT SPCC I
AND I DEMONGLY SUPPORT GABRIEL
DEMO EIGHTY FOURTEEN FIFTY.
DEMO ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
DEMO MORNING MY NAME IS ANNE
DEMO THAT I LIVE IN WEST COVINA
AND I'M DEMO SB FIFTY AND I
DEMONGLY SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN
DEMOY. NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HELLO MY NAME IS ANDREW
DEMOHEZ A RESIDENT THE CITY OF
DEMOO WITH AS PCC THRIVING THAT
DEMO PORT. LINE FIVE NINETEEN
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HELLO MANY BEVERLY
DEMOHUM I LIVE IN MONTANA ON
DEMOLF OF S. B. C. C. I AM A
DEMONG SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
DEMOY THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
DEMOTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD SHE- YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD NINE FORTY.
DEMOO YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI
DEMOM JABOURI ALL I'M FROM THE
DEMO AND I SUPPORT. HE. EIGHTY
DEMO ONE FOUR FIFTY I'M SORRY
WE DEMO A GOOD NIGHT OF
DEMORATOR NEXT. NINE FIVE FORTY
TWO DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. THE BILL UP CLOSE FROM
THE DEMOE AND I IN THE OF AB
DEMOTEEN THANK YOU. NINE THREE
TWO DEMOE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
A DEMOERENCE RECORD LANGKASUKA
HE DEMOER AND THAT SUPPORT AB.
ONE DEMO. MIND NINETY YEAR LINE
DEMO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
DEMO IS CYNTHIA KARAMBA I AM
DEMOING ON BEHALF OF WILL BE
DEMO PM FROM DATA AND FREDDIE
DEMOTHER TUTORING PROGRAM FOR
THE DEMODIENCY COUNCIL
DEMOUNITY AND WHILE HE SAID AND
I AM IN DEMO SUPPORT OF AB
DEMOY FIFTY. FIVE ELEVEN YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMO AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TO
DEMOIZE WITH US IF YOU SEE IN A
DEMONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
DEMO. NINE TWO ZERO THREE YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMO TWO HUNDRED AND THREE YOUR
THE TO DEMOEN TO THE EXECUTIVE
DEMOCTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
DEMOTY INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
DEMOD ABUSE AND NEGLECT AND THE
I CAN DEMOONAL CENTER ON CHILD
DEMOLITY REVIEW IN SUPPORT OF
AB DEMOTEEN FIFTY. NINE FIVE
DEMORED AND SIX OR FIVE ZERO
SIX DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS DEMOM CATCH SOME I'M A
DEMODENT OF LONG DAHLE AND
DEMOESENTING BCC I'M IN STRONG
DEMOORT OF THE BILL. NINE FIVE
DEMOY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
GO DEMOD. ONE OF THE ONLY KNOWN
IN DEMO AND REMANDED PRESENT
ALL OF DEMO A LOT I HAD TO
DEMOH YOU KNOW HE SORRY UP OR
DEMO THE LATE GOVERNOR IS. YES
DEMOK YOU. NINE FIVE SIXTEEN
DEMO LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HELLO MY NAME MELENDEZ I
DEMO AT THE FREE ALPHA MEET ON
DEMO NUMBER OF ALSO WOMAN FROM
DEMO FOR THE EIGHTY FOURTH.
DEMOY EIGHTY. MY FIVE HUNDRED
DEMO LINE IS PLEASE GO A- HELLO
MY DEMO IS RETIRED SERGEANT
DEMOR WILL COME WITH A THIRD I
AM DEMOESENTING ANTELOPE VALLEY
DEMO SCHOOL NJROTC UP FOR A. B.
DEMOTEEN FIFTY. NINE FIVE FIFTY
ONE DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HI MY NAME IS ALEX RUN
DEMO ENABLE SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN
DEMOY. BY NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
DEMO IS TINA LOUISE- MY
DEMOUNITY TO LET SB TCM IN FULL
DEMOORT OF IT- S. B. THANK YOU
WE DEMO'T SO COLORS KNOWN YOU
DEMOT NEED TO REPEAT THE BILL
WE DEMO YOU'RE ALL ON THE LINE
FOR THE DEMOTEEN FIFTIES. CAN
DEMO TWO FORTY TWO. PLEASE GO
DEMOD. ONE TWO HUNDRED AND
DEMOY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD YOU MAY BE ON
DEMO. LIVING UNDER LINE THREE
DEMOTY NINE LIME THREE EIGHTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. MY NAME IS GLORIA BUT
DEMO THE PC COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
FOR DEMOENT I WANT AND I'M IN
DEMONG SUPPORT. NINE FOUR FORTY
DEMO YOUR IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HI MY NAME IS JONATHAN.
I'M DEMO THAN A DEFAULT ACTUAL
DEMO AND I'M. NINE FIVE
DEMOTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
I DEMO IN THE CITY OF ONE CENT
I'M DEMO THE ORGANIZATION AT
PPP AND I'M A DEMONG SUPPORT.
DEMO TWO SIX TWO LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. HI THREE YEARS
DEMOR MAY BE SEATED NOT NOT AYE
DEMON BEEN REMOVED SUPPORT
DEMOK YOU. MIND THIRTY SIX YOUR
DEMO IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMORON WE KNOW. FROM
DEMOITUTIONAL COMMUNITY.
DEMOEGE AND I SUPPORT. NINE
DEMO HUNDRED AND FIVE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
DEMORS. ABBOTT THE EDM AT BCC
DEMOIDENT AFTER PROGRAM AND I.
DEMOK YOU NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
DEMOY FOR YOUR LONG IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DEMOINA SOUTHERN IRELAND
DEMOTION AND I REPRESENT A
DEMOY THREE AND I'M A STRONG
DEMOORT. NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
DEMOY THREE. OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HI I AM A DEFINITIVELY
YES I'M DEMO LOS ANGELES- WITH
S. B. C. C. AND I DEMOORT THIS
DEMO. NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
DEMOY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M DEMOEEN MOONEY FROM S. B.
C. SHE AND I DEMOK- POLL
DEMOORTED THE L. NINE FOUR
DEMORED AND NINETY NINE YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN. PLEASE GOING TO
BE MY DEMO IS OLIVIA RUBIO AND
I'M A DEMODENT OF SAN FERNANDO
DEMOEY AND A COMMUNITY MEMBER
AND I AM IN DEMOT THE PART OF
DEMO BILL. NINE FIVE THIRTY
DEMOE OR FIVE HUNDRED AND
DEMOTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY DEMO IS NOT EVEN ON THE HAVE
DEMO ALL RESIDENT WOMAN OF
DEMON RESIDENT AND I'M A FULL
DEMOORTER ABOUT. NINE FOUR
DEMORED AND THIRTY FOUR YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMO FOUR THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
DEMO IS OLGA DAMAGE AND- A
DEMOUNITY MEMBER AND I'M IN
DEMO SUPPORT. NINE FIVE FIFTY
DEMON OR FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DEMON PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS DEMO. HI ARLENE FERNANDO ON
DEMOLF OF S. B. C. C. IN FULL
DEMOORT THANK. NINE FIVE
DEMORED AND THIRTY ONE YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOO THIS IS G. AN ARTILLERY
DEMO SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA AND
ITS DEMO SUPPORT. NINE FOUR
DEMORED AND ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
DEMO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
DEMO HUNDRED AND ELEVEN OR FOUR
DEMOEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
DEMOO MY NAME IS WENDY CARILLO.
I'M DEMOUNITY MEMBER I'M
DEMOING THE LANCASTER I'M
DEMOESENT ENTITIES HE WELL WITH
DEMOEN THE LAW I'M A STRONG
DEMOORTER THANK YOU A. B. THANK
YOU DEMOING PEOPLE THANK YOU
DEMO FIVE HUNDRED AND. SEVENTY
TWO DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. MINDELO DEFEAT YES YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN LOW. YEAH MY NAME
IS DEMOOR CASTER HOME I'M
DEMOMPTING TO RESIDENT I'M
DEMOESENTING SPCC AND DRIVING
DEMOTHER AND I'M A STRONG
DEMOORT FOR THE RULES LINE AB
DEMOTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU
DEMOERS PLEASE LET ME KNOW
DEMORE CALLING FOR A BI
DEMOTEEN FIFTY YOU DON'T NEED
TO DEMOAT IT WE'RE TRYING TO
DEMO THIS HEARING ALONG THANK
DEMO GO AHEAD MODERATE. NINE
DEMO FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO
DEMOA LEE ALONG WITH OVER FIFTY
DEMOSAND MEMBERS AND MULTIPLE
DEMO GROUPS SEEKING JUSTICE FOR
DEMOE FERNANDES WE STRONGLY
DEMOORT. NINE FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
OR DEMO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS DEMO. ARMADA COLOR AMERICA
I'M DEMO THAT YOU SEE ON LIVE
AND DEMO MADE THEM I'M A STOCK
FOR THE DEMO. NINE THREE SIXTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. GOOD NEWS GOOD
DEMORNOON MY NAME IS ALMOST
DEMO I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
DEMOINGTON I REPRESENT THE
DEMONIZATION AT BCC I STRONGLY
DEMOORT AS YOU. MODERATOR NEXT
DEMOER. NINE FIVE TWENTY NINE
OR DEMO HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HELLO MY NAME IS DIANE
DEMOTT AT THEM CALLING FROM
DEMO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
DEMOORT GAVE GIRLS LAW. NINE
DEMO EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
DEMO IS MEDICALLY THEY LIVE IN
THE DEMO OF THE HAPPENED I GREW
UP DEMO THAT EIGHTY TWO
DEMOIFICANT ISSUES DOWN I WITH
DEMOLEDGE BEFORE GOING BELOW AB
DEMO. THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
DEMOTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DEMOSE LET ME KNOW HOW TO CLEAN
IT HI MY DEMO IS GIVE NOT BE
DEMOGH SB FIFTY BRICKELL A
DEMOE AND I SUPPORTED A REAL
DEMOK YOU. LINE FIVE FORTY
DEMOT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD HI MY NAME IS KENNY
DEMORADO I'M WITH THE
DEMONIZATION SDCC I SUPPORT THE
DEMO MY FIVE SEVENTY NINE YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SB. I DEMOK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
DEMO TWENTY EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WANT
DEMOR WHERE. WHAT WHAT CALLS
FOR THE DEMOL LAW. THANK YOU
DEMO FIVE EIGHTIES. ONE FIVE A
DEMON YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. BERMAN CHAIR MEMBERS
DEMOAL DOT ON BEHALF THE LOS
DEMOLES COUNTY DISTRICT
DEMORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
DEMO TO FORTY TWO NINE TO FORTY
TO DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. TWENTY FORTY TWO YOU MAY
BE ON DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMONG ON TO LINE. FIVE EIGHTY
DEMOT NINE FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. SB YOU SEE FULL SUPPORT.
DEMOS TO DO BERMAN DECLINED. TO
DEMOTY TWO ONE TWO TWENTY TWO
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. WELL ORDER. I AM THE
DEMO UP. NINE TWO TWENTY TWO
DEMO LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON
DEMO. THREE THIRTY EIGHT
DEMOION THREE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY DEMOE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS DEMO YOU MAY BE ON MUTE.
DEMONG ON. NINE TO THIRTY SEVEN
DEMOT TWO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMO TO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS DEMO. BY TWO THIRTY SEVEN
DEMO LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
DEMOD. YOU CAN GO TO THE NEXT
DEMOER. MY TWO FIFTY FOUR YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES HI DEMO MORNING MY NAME IS
DEMOY C. THE FIRST RUBIO STRONG
DEMOITTEE CC WILMINGTON THANK
YOU DEMOK YOU. ONE FIVE NINETY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. NINE ONE FIVE NINETY
FOR DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HI MY NAME IS HAS HAD A
DEMO AND I AM FROM S. B. C. C.
M. A DEMOUNITY ORGANIZER FOR
THE SAN DEMOIEL VALLEY AND I AM
A DEMONG SUPPORT. MIND TWO
DEMOTY TWO ONE TWO TWENTY TWO
DEMO LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HELLO MY NAME IS LISA
DEMORA AND I LIVE IN TORRANCE
I'M DEMOING FROM BEHALF OF SPDC
AND I'M IN DEMO SUPPORT. THERE
ARE NO DEMOHER COMMENT IN Q.
ALL DEMOT WE ARE GOING TO THE-
DEMO WITNESS IN OPPOSITION AND
DEMO IS- COUNTY SHARE FROM ACLU
AND DEMOIK ANDSALAS. FROM
DEMOL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
DEMO CHILDREN YOU HAVE A TOTAL
OF DEMOE MINUTES NOT THREE
DEMOTES EACH GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU DEMOM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
CAN BE DEMO TO THE ACLU OF
DEMOFORNIA- WE RESPECTFULLY
DEMOSE EIGHTY FOURTEEN FIFTY.
DEMOT LET ME ACKNOWLEDGE THE
DEMOEDY OF THE DEATH OF GABRIEL
DEMOANDEZ. UNFORTUNATELY
DEMOING IN THIS BILL WOULD HAVE
DEMOENTED GABRIEL'S DEATH WHAT
DEMOENED HAPPENED AFTER
DEMOGATIONS OF ABUSE WERE
DEMOSTIGATED BY BOTH LAW
DEMORCEMENT AND SOCIAL SERVICE
DEMOCIES. AND DETERMINED TO BE
DEMOUNDED. EDIT WHEN WE
DEMOTINIZING POLICE ABUSE OF
DEMOR AB FOURTEEN FIFTY WOULD
DEMOORE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEMOORITY TAKEN FROM THEM
DEMOUSE OF THEIR- THAT ARE. IN
THE DEMOHREY. THE LOS ANGELES
DEMOIFF'S DEPARTMENT PLACE MR
AND MRS DEMOHRIES ON THE KHAKI.
AND DEMOSED TO REMOVE THE
DEMOING EVEN AFTER TWO SEPARATE
DEMOTS HAD FOUND THE CHARGES TO
BE DEMOUE. THE LEGISLATION THAT
DEMO AWAY LAW ENFORCEMENT POWER
TO DEMOIT REPORTS ON TO THE
DEMOI WAS INTENDED TO ENSURE
DEMO WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
DEMOHRIES WOULD NOT HAPPEN
DEMON. THE ACLU HAD GRAVE
DEMOERNS ABOUT ANY GOVERNMENT
DEMOBASE WHERE PEOPLE CAN BE
DEMOED AND PACE HARMFUL
DEMOEQUENCES SOLELY ON THE
DEMOS OF UNTESTED ACCUSATION.
DEMOE CONCERNS ARE HEIGHTENED
DEMOE ADS WITH THE KHAKI THE
DEMOEDURES FOR A CHALLENGE DID
NOT DEMO BASIC STANDARDS OF DUE
DEMOESS. THE PROCEDURES FOR
DEMOFICATION THE TIMELINE AND
THE DEMOEDURES FOR EXCHANGE OF
DEMOENCE ALL MAKE IT DIFFICULT
FOR DEMONE TO EVEN FILE A
DEMOVANCE MUCH LEFT TO SUCCEED
DEMOLETT OF THE MERITS OF YOUR
DEMO. IF LAW ENFORCEMENT IS TO
SEE DEMO. ACCUSED IN THAT
DEMOVIDUALS WILL FACE
DEMOSSIBLE CHOICE OF EITHER
DEMOING A HEARING BEFORE LAW
DEMORCEMENT AGENCY THAT MAY BE
DEMOVELY INVESTIGATING THEM AND
DEMONG THAT IN AGENCY
DEMORMATION THAT CAN BE USED
DEMONST THEM. OR CHOOSING NOT
TO DEMOLENGE THE REPORT AND
DEMOING FOREVER THEIR RIGHT TO
DO SO. AB DEMOTEEN FIFTY
DEMOOSES TO GREATLY EXPAND A
DEMOEN SYSTEM AND WE ASK FOR
DEMO NO VOTE. BONTA GONZALEZ
DEMO LEGAL SERVICES FOR
DEMOONERS WITH CHILDREN. TODAY
WE ARE DEMONGLY OPPOSING AB
DEMOTEEN FIFTY BECAUSE WE'RE
DEMO CONCERNED THAT IT GIVES
DEMOE OF NATIONAL ATTENTION ON
DEMOCE ABUSES OF POWER WE
DEMONGLY BELIEVE THAT IT NOT
DEMO GIVES PLEASE ENSURE THE
DEMO. THANK YOU OPTION OF
DEMORTING TO COCKY BUT POLICE
CAN DEMOATEN A COCKY REPORT TO
GET A DEMOECT OR DEFENDANT. LED
ME TO DEMOR CRIMINAL ACTS.
DEMOSED AGAINST CHRISTIE WOULD
DEMOE COOLEY PARK. IT COULD BE
DEMOS. TO AND WILL BE A TEN
DEMOT BECAUSE DEFENSE. WITH
DEMONDANTS TO MAKE ANYTHING
DEMONG THE HEARING. WE KNOW
DEMO HARD EXPERIENCE THAT
DEMOCE THIS QUESTION WILL
DEMOCT FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THE DEMOEST. AND THE
DEMOUNITIES HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DEMOSTATED BY THE OVER
DEMOINALIZATION. WE HAVE THE
DEMOY OF A GRANDMOTHER WHOSE
DEMOHTER GOT YOUR KIDS REMOVED
AND DEMOED IN THINK YET. ONE
DEMOER TRIED TO ADOPT HER
DEMODCHILDREN AND WHAT THE
DEMOT ADOPTION BECAUSE THEIR
DEMOAND WASN'T COCKY. HIS
DEMODMOTHER HAD TO CHOOSE
DEMOEEN HER GRANDCHILDREN ARE
DEMO BEEN OF MANY YEARS WE'VE
DEMO ON DIALYSIS. ARE GONE HER
HER DEMOAND STAYED WITH THE
DEMOVANT. MATTERS. FOR YOUR
DEMORMATION I THANK GOD THERE
DEMOTY YEARS. THE PERFECT
DEMOPLE OF FAMILY. INSTEAD OF
DEMO AND FOR THAT REASON WE
DEMO YOU OPPOSE A FORTY
DEMOEEN. THANK YOU THANK YOU MY-
DEMO SO PERFECT. ALL RIGHT ANY
DEMOR CALL FOR. A FEW MORE
DEMOSE GO. THANK YOU IF YOU
DEMO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
DEMOTEEN FIFTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME.
DEMON IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
DEMOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
YOU MAY DEMOS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT DEMO TIME. AND ALSO A
DEMONDER TO YOUR- OUR COMPUTER.
SO DEMO WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
DEMOBACK. THANK YOU NINE FIVE
DEMOY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. MANY OF OUR
DEMOTRY AND I AM- I GUESS- WENT
ON TO THE DEMOG AREA AND I AM
DEMOK YOU MODERATOR CONTINUE.
MY DEMO NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE
DEMOTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. WELL YES YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN. OKAY MY NAME
DEMOTED PRESIDENT TO PUT THE
LOG DEMON. MY THAN FIVE NINETY
DEMOT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. HELLO MY NAME IS ERIC
BUT WE ARE NOT DEMORE THE LAW
IT DEMO. BY IN FIVE ZERO FOUR
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. IT'S A THREE DEADLINES
FOR DEMOL SERVICES FOR
DEMOONERS WITH CHILDREN I AM
DEMOSTERING STRONG OPPOSITION
ON THE DEMOY ORGANIZATION
DEMOFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
DEMOCIATION L. A. DEPENDENCY
DEMOR'S DEPENDED THE LEGAL
DEMOICES. ALL ABOUT THEIR NON
DEMOTING OVER AMERICAN CIVIL
DEMORTIES UNION ACRE OF HOPE
DEMORNATIONAL MINISTRIES
DEMODREN'S LAW CENTER OF
DEMOFORNIA SAN JOSE STATE
DEMOERSITY RECORD CLEARANCE
DEMOECT AND BROUGH AND REBOUND.
DEMOK YOU ANY OTHER CALLERS IN
DEMOSITION. YES NINE ONE FIFTY
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. DANIELGUTIERREZ ON
DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DEMOECTIVELY IN OPPOSITION.
DEMO FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHT
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. HI AFTER GOING TEN AND
THE DEMOING SAN DIEGO COUNTY I
WAS DEMONTIFFS COUNSEL IN THE
DEMOHRIES CASE AND I STRONGLY
DEMOSE. NINE SIX HUNDRED AND
TWO DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. NINE SIX OH TO YOUR LINE
IS DEMO YOU MAY BE ON MUTE.
DEMONG ON TO LINE SIX HUNDRED
AND ONE SIX OH ONE DEMOLINE IS
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
DEMO ONLY REMARKABLE- IT IS I
DEMO LEADING OPPOSITION YOU
DEMOVATION. FONG A LINK YOU
DEMO THE FIFTEEN THANK YOU. MY
DEMOVED THIRTY SEVEN. NINE FIVE
DEMOTY SO YOUR LINE OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD HELLO. NUMBER FROM THE
DEMOR OF I FELT HE BETTER BUT
DEMO MAIN THAT YOU A LOT OF. WE
DEMOED THEY GOT. MODERATOR CAN.
DEMO IS OPPOSITION IN
DEMOSITION. ONLY WE'VE CLOSED
OUT THE DEMOR. BOB ONLY THANK
YOU DEMORATOR. FIFTY EIGHT
DEMOS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NINE
SIX DEMORED AND THREE YOUR LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SIX OH DEMOE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE DEMO NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
Q. DEMOK YOU RIGHT WHO BRING
DEMO I'D SAY WE DO HAVE ONE
DEMO. MINE GOOD OPPOSITION GO
DEMOD. NINE THREE THIRTY EIGHT
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
DEMOENT IN Q. COME BACK TO THE
DEMOUNITY. OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY.
DEMOERS WHO WISH TO ASK
DEMOTIONS OR ADDRESS THIS BILL.
GO DEMOD SENATOR WIENER THANK
YOU I'M A DEMOCT AND I
DEMOOGIZE I DID STEP OUT FOR
DEMO OF YOUR PRESENTATION
DEMOOGIZE FOR THAT. IF YOU
DEMOESSED THIS IN YOUR OPENING
FOR DEMOICS OF TONYA AND I
DEMO. WITHDRAW THE QUESTION.
DEMORSONAL WELCOME BACK AND I'M
DEMOLY A THRILLED THAT YOU ARE-
DEMOVERING AND- AND ABLE TO
DEMO YEARS THAT'S A THAT'S A
DEMO THING SO. SERVE IN TERMS
OF DEMO YOU KNOW I IT IS
DEMOERNING IN TERMS OF THE
DEMOORY HERE I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
DEMOG WHAT WHAT A HORRIFIC
DEMOE THAT WAS COMMITTED- AND
OUR DEMOEM IN SO MANY RESPECTS
DEMOS CHILDREN WHO ARE-
DEMORVIEWS OF- SITUATIONS WITH
DEMOR FAMILIES AND- THIS
DEMOIFIC CRIME IS JUST. A AN
DEMOEME EXAMPLE OF UNFORTUNATE
DEMO HAPPENS ALL THE TIME
DEMOUSE THE SYSTEM. IS NOT
DEMOECTING CHILDREN- BUT THE
DEMOTION HERE IS YOU KNOW CAN
DEMO BE DONE IN A WAY THAT
DEMOLIES WITH DUE PROCESS AND
DEMON THESE PROBLEMS WERE IT'S
AN DEMOOVEN ALLEGATION- YOU
DEMO IT'S NOT A- SO. WORKER
DEMO WHO HAS A RELAXED. IN THIS
DEMO WHERE WE MIGHT HAVE MORE
DEMOIDENCE IF THEY'RE ABLE TO
DEMOLY DISCERN. OF IT IS LAW
DEMORCEMENT OFFICER WHO WELL
DEMOE ARE CERTAINLY. MANY LAW
DEMORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO ARE
DEMOLY GOOD AT DISCERNING
DEMOGS BUT IT'S SORT OF MORE ON
A DEMO AND- AND SO WE HAVE
DEMOLE WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
DEMOICTED OR ANYTHING WHO THEN
GO ON TO DEMO REGISTRY. I
DEMOLY STRUGGLE TO GET OFF. I
AM SO DEMOD YOU JUST COMMENT ON
DEMOE. ARE CRITICS I DO HAVE
DEMOE CONCERNS. CERTAINLY ART I
DEMO EVERYONE TO KNOW THE TIME
I'M DEMOAINLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE DEMOIBILITY OF THE DATA
DEMOECTION. AND THAT'S WHY WE
DEMO INCLUDED THIS NEW
DEMOVANCE HEARING PROCESS IN
DEMO BILL THAT WASN'T THERE
DEMORE. AND WE ARE VERY
DEMOERNED AND- AFTER. CAN USED
TO BE DEMO KIND OF CONCERN THAT
DEMO OPEN TO BRING IT BACK. AND
PAN DEMODING THE PROCESS AND-
DEMO MIGHT EVEN INCLUDE-
DEMOGING THEM THE STATE AUDITOR
IN ON DEMO ISSUE. WE WANT
DEMOIBLE INFORMATION WE WANT TO
DEMOECT CHILDREN WE DON'T WANT
TO. DEMOE YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT
ARE DEMONG DIFFICULT THEIR
DEMOS WE WANT TO PROTECT
DEMODREN. AND WHAT THE SYSTEM
HAS AS YOU DEMO AN ADMITTEDLY-
DEMOE HAD SOME VERY TRAGIC
DEMOURES WE WANT TO JUST
DEMOMIZE THAT. IN THE FUTURE WE
DEMOEVE THIS IS A PROVEN
DEMOEM. AND I MEAN IT'S THE
DEMO RIBBON COMMISSION. THAT
DEMO UP WITH THESE SUGGESTIONS.
DEMOK YOU. RIGHT ANY OTHER
DEMOERS HAVE COMMENTS OR
DEMOTIONS. WELL I WILL SPEAK TO
DEMO. I SUPPORTED THE BILL IN
DEMO TWENTY ELEVEN THAT DEALT
DEMO THE- SO WE GO BACK TO THIS
A DEMOAMENTAL POINT WHICH IS
DEMO IS A DATABASE OF
DEMOGATIONS NOT CONVICTIONS.
AND SO DEMOUSE UP TO THAT POINT
DEMOE HAD BEEN SOME ABUSES OF
IT I DEMOORTED THAT. AND WE
DEMO SUBSEQUENT HAD THE
DEMOATION OF THE HUMPHREY
DEMOLY HAVING TO RETURN TO
DEMOT AGAIN AND AGAIN TO BE OFF
OF A DEMO SUCH AS TIS WHEN
DEMO WERE BY TWO DIFFERENT
DEMOSTIGATORY UNITS IN COURTS
DEMOCATED IS NOT. HAVE A OF.
DEMOY THE CHILD ABUSE WHICH THE.
DEMOGATION IN THE DATA SHOWED
BUT THE DEMOLT OF THE BEING ON
THE DEMOBASE THERE CHILDREN
DEMO REMOVED FROM THEIR HOUSE
SO FOR DEMO YEARS AND SO THERE
DEMO THERE'S QUITE A LOT OF
DEMOEQUENCES TO. THE LACK OF
DUE DEMOESS NOW- INTERESTINGLY
DEMOE WAS A SIMILAR BILL NOT A
DEMO THE SAME VOTE THAT
DEMOTANTIALLY THE SAME THAT WAS
DEMOED IN THE OF. LET'S SEE
DEMOH- IN THE SEVENTEEN
DEMOTEEN LEGISLATIVE SESSION I
WAS NOT IN THE DEMOSLATURE AT
THE DEMO AND THAT WAS VETOED BY
DEMORNOR BROWN FOR SIMILAR.
DEMOONS THAT I JUST STATED THAT
DEMO IS A DATABASE OF
DEMOGATIONS AND NOT OF
DEMOICTIONS AND THAT THERE'S
NOT DEMOUATE DUE PROCESS SO I
DEMOECIATE THE ADDITION OF THE
DEMOVANCE PROCEDURE. AND I ALSO
HAS MY DEMOEAGUE FROM SERVICES
DEMOP DESCRIBED I MEAN. THAT WE
DEMO THE FAILURE OF THE LACK OF
DEMORVENTION IN. CHILD ABUSE
DEMOS AND THE CHILD THAT YOU
DEMO IT TRYING TO ADDRESS IN
DEMOS OF THIS BILL IS ONE OF
DEMORTUNATELY MANY WE COULD
DEMO MANY NAMES AND THE- S. H.
DEMOE ARE VERY DIFFICULT-
DEMOUMSTANCES I WILL SAY FOR ME
DEMO'S ONE OF THE MOST THAT
DEMO DIFFICULT ROLES BEING THE
DEMOR OF THIS COMMITTEE. TO
DEMO THAT A HORRENDOUS THINGS
DEMO HECKARD THE CHILD LOST HIS
DEMO WHEN HE SHOULD WHEN
DEMOE'S NO REASON TO HAVE. AND
YET TO DEMO A BILL BEFORE US
DEMO. IS CHIRPING TO MAKE SURE
DEMO THAT WOULD NOT HAPPEN
DEMON. BUT IN FACT JUST A
DEMOBASE OF ALLEGATIONS DOES
NOT DEMOECT. THE FAILURE. IN
DEMO EITHER IN THAT CASE OR IN.
ASK DEMOS WERE POTENTIALLY
DEMORE SO THAT IS WHY I HAVE
THE DEMOICULTY OF NOW VOTING TO
DEMOOVE. IN EFFECT TO AN UNDUE
THE DEMO THAT I SUPPORTED IN
DEMOTY ELEVEN THAT WAS SIGNED
DEMO LAW SO I WILL NOT BE
DEMOORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT I
DEMOED TO EXPLAIN WHY. IS NOT
DEMO TO- GIVEN THE AGAIN THE
DEMOTIMATE OUTPOURING OF PEOPLE
DEMO ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
DEMO AND I DO NOT DOUBT YOUR
DEMONTIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOT
DEMOSOEVER. BUT I JUST CAN'T.
DEMOG THE- I CAN'T SUPPORT
DEMONG TO UNDERMINE THAT DUE
DEMOESS FIX THAT WE TRIED TO
DEMO WE DID PUT IN PLACE IN
DEMOTY ELEVEN CLOSE RECEIVE
THE DEMONE ELSE HAS ANY
DEMOENTS BUT OF COURSE I WILL
DEMOW YOU TO CLOSE ABSOLUTELY.
DEMOY FIRST SENATOR JACKSON HAS
HER DEMO OKAY SENATOR JACKSON.
WE CAN DEMO YOU. RIGHT NOW I
GOT IT DEMO- I APPRECIATE THE
DEMOERN I MY QUESTION WAS ON ON
THE DEMONITION OF SUBSTANTIATED.
DEMOGNIZE THE DUE PROCESS
DEMOES I RECOGNIZE THE CONCERNS
DEMO THE JURORS SO ARTICULATELY
DEMOESSED- BUT I THINK THERE
DEMO BEEN SOME EFFORTS TO
DEMOESS THEM BUT I'M JUST I'M
DEMOL CONCERNED ABOUT THE-
DEMOSE SUBSTANTIATED WHO
DEMOTANTIATES FROM WHAT DOES
DEMO MEAN. HOW DO THEY GO ABOUT
DEMOG IT- AND WHAT ARE THE
DEMOECTIONS THERE ARE TO ASSURE
DEMO. IF A CLAIM IS MADE THERE
IS DEMOING ENOUGH BASIS FOR IT
TO DEMOANT SENDING THIS OFF.
FOR DEMOUSION IN THE DATABASE
AND I AM DEMOAPS IF I ASSEMBLY
DEMOER LACKEY COULD ADDRESS
DEMO BECAUSE THAT'S- MY
DEMOACLE HERE. IN DETERMINING
HOW TO DEMO FOR THIS BILL.
DEMOK YOU. GO AHEAD SEVEN
DEMOCTANT IF I COULD I'D LIKE
TO DEMOUDE THAT IN MY CLOTHES
DEMOUSE THAT IS A PART OF MY
DEMOHES OKAY. ALL RIGHT ANY
DEMOR QUESTIONS OF MEMBERS. ALL
DEMOT TO GO AHEAD SEN ASSEMBLY
DEMOER. YEAH FIRST OF ALL OF
DEMO THAT IS A VERY GOOD
DEMOTION AND I KNEW IT DEPOSED.
A DEMOING CONCERN BY SOME
DEMOESSED MEMBERS THAT ARE ON
THE DEMOITTEE HERE AND WE
DEMORED AN AMENDMENT TO
DEMOALLY EVEN RAISE THE
DEMODARD BECAUSE THE NEXT LEVEL
DEMO CLEAR AND CONCISE. AND WE
DEMOD BE WILLING TO DO THAT.
DEMOE NOT TRYING TO. BRING
DEMOICULTY INTO THE LIVES OF
DEMOE WHO DON'T DESERVE IT AND-
YEP DEMO WOULD MAKE THE
DEMOERENCE WE'RE HAPPY TO RAISE
DEMO STANDARD TO CLEAR AND
DEMOISE. BUT I JUST WANT TO
DEMOND. EVERYBODY THAT WE WERE
DEMO HERE TWO YEARS AGO AS AS
THE DEMOR INDICATED. AND
DEMOOUGH THE COMMITTEE WAS
DEMOERENT THAT- WITH THE
DEMOPTION OF THE CHAIR EACH OF
YOU DID DEMO FOR THIS MEASURE
AND IT DEMOED THE SENATE FOR
DEMOIMOUSLY. I WOULD HOPE THAT
YOU DEMOD. WHAT WE CAN WORK OUT
DEMO. DIFFICULTY WE LEARNED
DEMO HUMPHRIES WE LEARNED IT.
WE DEMO TO BE FOCUSED ON
DEMOGATIONS AS ALLEGATIONS THAT
DEMO THOSE ALLEGATIONS MAY NOT
TO DEMO THE STANDARD THAT THE-
DEMOYBODY DESERVES IN ORDER TO
BE DEMOHFUL. THEN NUMBER
DEMOTIMES ALLEGATIONS. ALTHOUGH
NOT DEMOLETELY ACCURATE CAN
DEMO DRAW ATTENTION NECESSARILY
DEMOIFIABLY AND SO WE NEED TO
DEMO IN THE BENEFIT OF SAVING
DEMODREN THESE ARE CHILDREN
DEMO ARE. NOT ONLY BEING
DEMOREATED THEY'RE BEING
DEMOURED FOLKS. ABSOLUTE
DEMOURE IS TAKING PLACE AND I
DEMO YOU THE CODE NINETEEN IS
DEMO EXACERBATING THIS
DEMOICULTY. BECAUSE HE KILLED
ARE DEMO AND MORE KEPT IN
DEMOIVITY. AND WE NEED A PROVEN
DEMOURE THIS IS A THIS CAME
DEMO THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
AND HAS DEMOEN TO BE. HELPFUL
IN L. A. DEMOTY WE NEED A STATE
DEMO FIX TO START. MINIMIZING
DEMOE TRAGEDIES FOLKS THAT
DEMOUNICATION IS PART OF THE
DEMOLEM. IT'S PROVEN TO BE PART
OF OUR DEMOICULTY AND WE NEED
TO. DEMONTUATE THAT
DEMOUNICATION AND I KNOW. BUT
DEMOT NOW WE'RE IN A PERIOD
DEMOE TRUST IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS DEMOING BUT FOLKS PLEASE
DEMOT HOLD CHILDREN HOSTAGE TO
DEMO IS JUST NOT FAIR. AND I
DEMOD CHECK I WOULD JUST ASK
YOU DEMOSE DON'T TURN AWAY NOW
DEMO PREVENTED FURTHER TRAGEDY.
DEMO YOU HAVE THE POWER TO MAKE
A DEMOERENCE AND I WOULD ASK
DEMO SUPPORT. ALRIGHT WE HAVE A
DEMOON. WE HAD TO CLOSE SO I
DEMO JUST SEE IF THERE'S ANY
DEMOR COMMENT IN MEMBER WANTS
TO DEMO. SENATOR RURAL GO AHEAD
DEMO HANDS UP I KNOW I DIDN'T
DEMO MOTION HAD ALREADY BEEN
DEMO I WAS GOING TO MAKE A
DEMOON ACCORDING. I WOULD ONLY
A. AT DEMO IT'S. THE CHILD WAS
DEMOURED. BUT THE OFFICERS DID
NOT DEMOGE ANYTHING SO IT IS
NOT DEMOTED DIRECTLY AND IT'S
NOT I'M NOT DEMONG TO MAKE
DEMONE WRONG. I DON'T WANT ANY
DEMOD TORTURED. BUT I HAVE TO
DEMOOW THE RESPECTING OF DUE
DEMOESS AND I'M SORRY I CAN'T
DEMOORT IT TODAY. WITH THAT
DEMO TAKE A ROLL CALL. MOTION
BY DEMOTOR MORE LIKE AB
DEMOTEEN FIFTY TO PASS TO
DEMOOPRIATIONS SKINNER NOT PONY.
WE DEMOOT VOTING MORE LACK
DEMOLACH AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD
NOT DEMONG JACKSON. JACKSON OF.
DEMOSON NOT VOTING JACKSON NOT
DEMONG MITCHELL. MITCHELL NOT
DEMONG MORALE. MORALE HIGH
DEMOLE I WINNER WINNER NOW. TWO
TO DEMO WE WILL GRANT
DEMOIDERATION. RECONSIDERATION
DEMOTICIANS THAT'S WHAT I MEANT.
ALL DEMOT SO MEMBERS- FIRED
DEMOUNCED THAT WE WERE GOING TO
DEMO A BREAK WE DO HAVE A
DEMOER HERE TO PRESENT. THE
DEMOER JONES ORDERS. THE
DEMOERS OF A. RESPOND ASSEMBLY
DEMOER GO FOR IT BUT SPEAK
DEMOTY IF WE CAN DO THIS. I
DEMO YOU HAVE TO BILLS WILL
DEMOLY DO THIS ONE OKAY. NO
DEMO A BREAK. THANK YOU MA'AM
DEMOR OF COURSE QUICKLY AS
DEMOIBLE TO WANT TO BE GOOD
DEMOEEN THE PEOPLE AND LUNCH
FOR DEMO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
DEMOY A MONARCH I'M HONORED TO
DEMOENT AB SET A SEVENTEEN
DEMONTY FIVE MY BILL WHICH
DEMOS TO ADDRESS THE MISUSE OF
THE DEMO ONE ONE. EMERGENCY
DEMOEM AS A TOOL FOR RESPITE
AND DEMOE POLICE REPORTS AIMED
AT DEMOSSING A PERSON BASED ON
DEMO SKIN COLOR. OR OTHER
DEMOECTED CLASSES LOSSING THE
DEMOOS AMY COOPER. FALSELY
DEMOSING A BIRD WATCHER OF
DEMOATENING HER LIFE BARBECUE
DEMOY CALLING POLICE ON A
DEMOLY PICNIC IN OAKLAND PARK.
IN DEMOTION THIS TERM
DEMOICIOUS LOOKING. ONLY A FEW
OF US IN DEMO ROOM KNOW WHAT
DEMO LIKE TO BE ACCUSED OF
DEMOG SUSPICIOUS LOOKING BLACK
AND DEMON PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DEMORIENCING THIS. FOR
DEMOURIES. BUT WE ALSO KNOW
DEMOT NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE IN IT
A DEMOG FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
DEMOTT TILL WAS LYNCHED IN
DEMOISSIPPI. BECAUSE A WHITE
DEMON SAID HE OFFENDED HER. A
DEMOY WHICH YOU. SHE RECANTED
DEMODES LATER. NOW COLLEAGUES
IN DEMO BUILDING ONE OF MY
DEMOFERS. AT AT THE COSCO
DEMOINGS IN SACRAMENTO- WAS
DEMORDING A WOMAN THAT WAS
DEMOD NOT PUT ON A MASK AT
DEMOCO. SHE TOLD HIM THAT SHE
DEMOED TO SEE THE OF THE
DEMODERS HE HAD TAKEN. ON HIS
DEMORA AND SHE SAID IF YOU
DEMOT GIVE ME THAT. I WILL CALL
DEMO ONE ONE AND TELL THEM THAT
DEMOVE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ME.
AND IF YOU DEMOT GIVE ME YOUR
DEMOE OR DELETED VIDEO. WELL
DEMOS WHAT SHE DID BUT SHE DID
DEMO ON HIM. LUCKILY FOR HIM IN
DEMO CASE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THE DEMONESS. COMMUNITY COSCO
DEMO TOGETHER TOWBAR FORCE
DEMOT THAT THIS ONE WAS MAKING
OF DEMOTICS YOU CASE ACCUSATION
AND DEMOLE THAT WERE IN THAT
DEMOE BACK THEM UP BUT WHAT
DEMOD HAVE HAPPENED IF IT WAS
DEMO HIS STORY. PERSONS HERS
DEMO WOLD HAVE HAPPENED. EARLY
DEMOATIONS THAT PAUL SIMON ONE
DEMOS COST BETWEEN LAW
DEMORCEMENT THE COMMUNITIES
DEMO SERVE. BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE DEMO WAY AB SEVENTEEN
DEMONTY FIVE WOULD IMPOSE A
DEMO OR MISDEMEANOR PERSON WHO
DEMOALLY USES A NINE ONE ONE
DEMOEM. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DEMOSSING ANOTHER. NUMBER TWO
DEMO HAS PENALTIES FOR NOT ONLY
DEMONG NINE FALSE NINE ONE ONE
DEMOS ME A FAVOR. WHEN THEY
DEMOT UP. OKAY AS PENALTIES FOR
DEMOINGLY MAKE MAKING FALSE
DEMO ONE ONE CALLS SYSTEM CALLS
DEMOET AT A MEMBER OF A
DEMOECTED CLASS AMENDED CIVIL
DEMOICE CODE SECTION OR
DEMOILEGED COMMUNICATIONS TO
DEMO CLEAR THAT MAKING IT
DEMOBERATELY FALSE REPORT TO
LAW DEMORCEMENT TARGETING
DEMOHER ONE IS NOT A PRIVILEGE
DEMOUNICATION ESTABLISHED THAT
DEMO IMPORT THREATENING TO MAKE
DEMOINGLY FALSE REPORTS TO LAW
DEMORCEMENT BUT RECKLESS REGARD
TO DEMOH OR FALSITY CONSTITUTES
DEMOMIDATION BY THREAT OF
DEMOENCE UNDER RALPH CIVIL
DEMOTS ACT. AB SEVENTEEN
DEMONTY FIVE IS A CAREFUL
DEMONCING ACT TO ENSURE THAT WE
DO NOT DEMOOURAGE PEOPLE FROM
DEMOHING OUT AND EMERGENCY
DEMOS AND INCLUDE LANGUAGE TO
DEMORE THAT PEOPLE WHO SUFFER
DEMO MENTAL ILLNESSES ARE NOT
DEMOTENTIONALLY- SCOOPED UP AB
DEMONTEEN SEVENTY FIVE ROOF
DEMOECTS A UNITED VOICE BETWEEN
DEMO THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
DEMOIC SAFETY COMMITTEE CHAIRS
DEMOMBLY MEMBER CHAIR OF THE
DEMOMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
DEMOMBLY MEMBER STONE IN A
DEMOLAR MANNER BONTA COMING
DEMOTHER THE FANCIEST IMPORTANT
DEMOATION IS SATAN SUPPORT FOR
DEMO BILL IS GROWING BY DAY AND
HAS NO DEMOSTERED OPPOSITION I
DEMOECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
DEMOS WITH ME- TODAY MADAM
DEMOR I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
OUR DEMOESSES. FOR BRIEF.
DEMOLE BRIEF COMMENT CHAU
DEMONE. THE CAL. FRATERNAL
DEMOR. AND REBEKAH. WITH THE
DEMOONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
DEMOERS THANK YOU PLEASE
DEMOEED LEAD WITNESSES. REBEKAH
GO DEMOD. REBECCA GO AHEAD. OF
US DEMO IS AU BACKING IN BOTH
OF THE DEMOONAL ASSOCIATION OF
DEMOAL WORKERS WE REPRESENT
DEMOOXIMATELY NINE THOUSAND
DEMOESSIONAL SOCIAL WORKERS IN
DEMOFORNIA WITH THEIR DEGREES
DEMO ACCREDITED SOCIAL WORK
DEMORAMS AS SOCIAL WORKERS AS
THE DEMOR AS AS A RESULT OF OUR
DEMOATION TRAINING AND OUR
DEMOCS WE ARE TAUGHT TO SPEAK
OUT DEMO WE SEE A JACK THAT
DEMOH INCLUDES THE SYSTEMATIC
DEMOSM THAT PRESSED AGAINST
DEMOUNITIES OF COLOR AND
DEMORMINATION AGAINST THE LGBTQ
DEMOUNITY. THEREFORE WE'RE
DEMOD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
DEMORTUNATELY WE'VE SEEN
DEMOEASE WILL PORT IN THE MEDIA
OF DEMORIMINATORY AND RACIST
DEMO ONE ONE CALL I'D HAVE BEEN
DEMOIONED A WHITE WOMAN CALLED
DEMO ONE ONE TO REPORT AN
DEMOCAN AMERICAN BURKE ROCKED
DEMOHER WHO WOULD TOLD HER
DEMOT BY LOSS YOU SHOULD HAVE A
DOG ON A DEMOH SHE RESPONDED BY
DEMOING NINE ONE ONE CLAIMING
DEMO AN AFRICAN AMERICAN MAN
DEMO BRANDY. SHE. CALLED. RIGHT
NOW DEMOTH ISSUES THEY MAY
DEMOADY BE EXPERIENCING. SIMPLY
DEMOK NO ONE SHOULD BE THE
DEMOECT OF A NINE ONE ONE CALL
DEMOLY FOR LIVING. AND I THINK
DEMO CLEAN MONDAY INTACT.
DEMORICAN PETERSON IS IN PLACE
TO DEMO PEOPLE IN CRISIS ONE
DEMORCEMENT FIREFIGHTERS OR
DEMOMEDICS MAY BE ABLE TO
DEMOST INDIVIDUALS IN NEED. WE
DEMO ENSURE THAT THESE CALLS
ARE DEMO FOR TRUE EMERGENCIES.
IN DEMOR THAT A PERSON MAY NEED
A DEMOSAVING FOR PROCEDURE DOES
NOT DIE DEMOUSE PUBLIC SAFETY
DEMOONNEL WAS DIVERTED TO A
DEMOK MAN WALKING DOWN THE
DEMOET- WE. WANT TO THANK OUR-
DEMOODUCING THE BELL AND AFTER
I DEMO THANK YOU I JUST WANT IT
SHE DEMONE THE LINE. NO OKAY SO
DEMOS IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
DEMOESS WOULD CALL IN SUPPORT
DEMORATOR AHEAD. LADIES AND
DEMOLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN DEMOORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
DEMONTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME
DEMON IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
DEMOORT OF AB. I AM. YOU MAY
DEMOS. HUNDRED NINE NINETY
DEMOE LINE IS PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOK YOU MADAM CHAIRWOMAN
DEMOERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS DEMO SMITH ON BEHALF OF
DEMOMINO THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE DEMOONAL EMERGENCY
DEMOER ASSOCIATION. OTHERWISE
DEMON AS YOUR NINE ONE ONE
DEMOATCHERS WE ARE PLEASED TO
BE IN DEMOORT OF THIS BILL
DEMOK YOU THANK YOU. NINE ONE
DEMONTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. CHUCK BRAMBLE
ON DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOHERS ASSOCIATION STRONG
DEMOORT. NINE SIX NINETEEN YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT DEMOR HEARING CENTERS
DEMOER THAN A CAR BONTA ON
DEMOLF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
THE DEMOT THANK YOU. NINE
DEMOTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. YES THANK YOU BANTING
DEMORTINO WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR
DEMOTY JACKETS AND ON BEHALF OF
DEMO YOU KNOW COALITION FOR
DEMOTHY CALIFORNIA AND WE THE
DEMOLE CREATING A STRONG
DEMOORT THANK YOU. NINE OH TWO
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. P. ONE OF SEVEN NUMBERS
OFF OF DEMO YOUR- SO. WHAT
DEMOER ARE YOU HAVE ALL OF THE
CAN DEMO ONE OF THE SINGLE. I
DEMO ENGLISH PLEASE WHAT NUMBER.
DEMOO OKAY SHANE- DID CHANGE- I
DEMOK YOU'RE ON THE LEAD LINE
YES GOT DEMO SHANE WANTED TO GO
DEMOD- COLLEGES YOU HAVE ONE
DEMOTE. ONE MINUTE GO AHEAD
DEMOK YOU NO NO NO WORRIES
DEMOK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
DEMORALLY IN ABOUT HALF OF THE
DEMOFORNIA PATERNAL ORDER
DEMOCE WERE BROAD SUPPORT THIS
DEMOON SENSE MEASURE- BY
DEMOMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
AS I DEMOESENT BELIEVE DEEPLY
DEMO CALLING NINE ONE ONE
DEMOLY TO STOKE RACIAL TENSIONS
IS NOT DEMO WRONG. BUT IT ALSO
DEMOCTS INTERFERES WITH THE
DEMOATCHERS ABILITY TO SEAL
DEMOS THAT ARE MERITORIOUS. IT
DEMOS OFFICERS AWAY FROM DOING
DEMOAL POLICE WORK. WE'RE SAD
DEMOE CURRENTLY IN OUR COUNTRY
IN OUR DEMOUNITIES AND IT'S OUR
DEMO THAT THIS BILL WILL DIS
DEMONTIVIZE THE CALLS INITIATED
DEMOUSE I HATE DISCRIMINATION.
ALL THE DEMO KIND MAINTAINING
THE DEMOGRITY OF THE NINE ONE
ONE DEMOEM FOR THOSE THAT NED
IT DEMO EMERGENCY NINE ONE ONE
DEMOEM SHOULD BE PROTECTED.
DEMO THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
DEMO OUTLOOK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL DEMOT ANY OTHER
DEMOESSES ON THE LINE IN
DEMOORT. NAME AND- FILIATION
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
WE DO DEMO LINE SIX TWENTY FOUR
DEMO SIX TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS DEMO. BUT BUT I'M SURE
DEMOERS CURSING OF THE
DEMOFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
IN DEMOORT THANK YOU. AND ONCE
DEMON IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
DEMOORT OF AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
DEMO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
DEMO AT THIS TIME NINE SIX OH
TWO DEMO LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
DEMO SIX HUNDRED AND TWO YOUR
DEMO IS OPEN. WE HAVE NO
DEMOHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
DEMOK YOU WE HAD NO LEAD
DEMOSITION SO LET'S JUST SEE IF
DEMOE'S ANY CALLERS WHO WOULD
DEMOSE THIS. PUBLIC COMMENT
DEMO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU DEMO TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB DEMONTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
YOU MAY DEMOS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT DEMO TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
DEMO TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB DEMONTEEN SEVENTY FIVE YOU
MAY DEMOS ONE AND ZERO. WE HAVE
NO DEMOENT THANK YOU. OKAY AND
NOT DEMO NOTE THAT I DID NOT
DEMO FOR PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
DEMOUSE I'M LOOKING AT THE ROOM
AND DEMOEST SEE ON THE SCREEN
THE DEMOR ROOM AND THERE'S BEEN
NO DEMOERENCE THERE'S THOUGH
DEMOVIDUALS HERE OR I WOULD
DEMO CALLED SO JUST WANT TO
DEMO SURE THAT WAS. STATED ON
THE DEMORD IS THERE A MOTION.
DEMOT WE HAVE A MOTION. YOU
DEMOMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
DEMOE. EXPECTED ASKED RELIABLE
AND DEMOTHY VOLUNTEERS GO THIS
DEMOKLY THANK YOU AS- I THINK
DEMO IMPORTANT BILL AND A BLOOD
WAS DEMOGHT FORWARD AND- GLAD
WE DEMO'T HAVE TO HAVE
DEMOETING ONCE IN THE SAME
DEMOECT MATTER SOME GOOD FOLKS
DEMO TOGETHER AND- I SEE NO
DEMOR HANDS RAISED SO. WITH
DEMO WE WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL.
AB DEMONTEEN SEVENTY FIVE TO
DEMO TO APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER
HI IN OUR AYE DEMOLACH. ALL
DEMOT MOORLACH AYE BRADFORD AYE
DEMOFORD AYE JACKSON. JACKSON
HI DEMOSON AYE MITCHELL. BY MID
DEMO MORALE. MOREAU ABSENT.
DEMO FEDERAL CENTER MALL IN AB
SO DEMONTY FIVE JONES SAWYER.
DEMOELL VOTING ON. THE MORALE I
AND DEMOER. SENATOR WIENER AYE
THE DEMOS OUT SEVEN ZERO RIGHT-
DEMOLAR THE BILLS OUT SEVEN
DEMO THANK YOU AND WE'LL SEE A
DEMOLE LATER- THANK YOU SPIRIT
DEMOERS. SO WE WILL TAKE A HALF
DEMO. BREAK NOW AND- WE'LL COME
DEMO AT ONE THIRTY ONE. THANK
YOU DEMO
DEMOY HERE TO OF VOTE
WE CAN DEMOAINLY KEEP GOING
DEMOUSE WE HAVE A LOT TO DO SO
WE ARE DEMOG TO KEEP GOING THIS
IS THE DEMOIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
AND WE ARE NOW DEMOG TO GO TO
OUR DEMO- ITEM WHICH I ACTUALLY
SEE YOU DEMOED A- OUR KEANDRE.
DEMOALLY WAS MURDERER SU CHI'S
DEMO WAS NEXT. AND. TWENTY
DEMOE SIXTY TWO. OR SHE MAY
DEMO TO GO NEXT BUT- I HAVE
DEMO AT THE WITNESSES CALL IN
ON A DEMO AND I HAVE TO FOLLOW
IN DEMOR AND SENATOR- WIENER
DEMORE SUPPOSED TO PRESENT MR
DEMOR SU CHI'S BILL CORRECT.
DEMO PLEASE FOR SENATE. I WOULD
DEMOALLY IF WE WEREN'T IN THIS
DEMO OF STRANGE THING WHERE WE
DEMO TO HAVE WITNESSES IT IS A
I DEMOD GO OUT ORDER. BUT NOT
DEMOY. GO FOR CENTER WIENER.
AND I DO NOT IN ANY WAY DEMO TO
DEMORFERE WITH ANY LEGITIMATE
DEMO OF DELIBERATIONS BUT I
DEMO TO GO AS EXPEDITIOUSLY AS
WE CAN GO DEMOD THANK YOU THANK
YOU DEMOM CHAIR- I'M TODAY I'M
DEMOENTING AB- TWENTY THREE
DEMOY TWO ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOER MEMBER MERITS ARMORED
DEMO MURATSUCHI. THIS LICENSE.
DEMO ENFORCE COMPLIANCE
DEMOUNTABILITY FOR FIREARM
DEMOSACTIONS BY AUTHORIZING THE
DEMORTMENT OF JUSTICE TO FIND
DEMOSPONSIBLE GUN DEALERS AS
DEMOSED TO ONLY HAVING THE
DEMOITY TO CONFISCATE GUNS. HI
DEMO BILL WILL INCENTIVIZE
DEMOLIANCE WITH STATE LAW BY
DEMOWING DOJ TO FIND DEALERS.
FOR DEMOATIONS. TO ME AS AN
DEMORNATIVE TO THE ALL OR
DEMOING LICENSE REVOCATION
DEMOEEDINGS PROVIDED UNDER.
DEMOE LAW. I'M CURRENTLY
DEMORAL LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
DEMOTED RESOURCES- TO OVERSEE
THE DEMO THAN TWENTY THREE
DEMORED SINCE GUN DEALERS IN
OUR DEMOE. CALIFORNIA'S
DEMORTMENT JUSTICE ONLY CURRENT
DEMOON IS TO REVOKE IT OUT OF
DEMOLIANCE LICENSE THROUGH A
DEMOTHY PROCEDURE THIS- HIGH
DEMOES. APPROACH AFFECTS
DEMOONSIBLE DEALERS WHO FEAR
DEMO WILL LOSE THEIR LICENSE.
DEMOD ON POLITICALLY MINOR
DEMORS I AM UP IN THIS
DEMORTMENT JUSTICE NEEDS AN
DEMORNATIVE INTO THAT. AEROBIC
IN THE FOR THE DEMO- THE
DEMOFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
DEMOICE IS AND TRONG SUPPORT OF
DEMO BILL- AND THEY HAVE
DEMOESSED THE NEED FOR THIS
DEMOTIONAL. ENFORCEMENT. LATER
IN HIS DEMOTY TWENTY TO IN
DEMOR TO GIVE MORE TIME TO A
DEMO REGULAR FOR THE BILL AND
WE DEMO TO TAKE THIS. TO MAKE
DEMO WE ARE KEEPING OUR STREETS
DEMO. I REQUEST FOR AN AYE
DEMO. WITH ME VIRTUALLY TODAY
R. DEMOA RICE- FROM BROUGHTY
DEMOED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE.
AND I DEMOES FROM THE
DEMORTMENT OF JUSTICE. I JUST.
DEMOESSES GO AHEAD. THREE
DEMOTES TOTAL. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY DEMO IS ERIC RICE AND I AM
DEMOKING ON BEHALF OF BRADY AND
DEMOONAL GUN VIOLENCE
DEMOENTION ORGANIZATION I'M THE
DEMORAM MANAGER FOR THE
DEMOATING CRIME DEFINITION EVAN
DEMOAND A CITY WITH NO BRICK
AND DEMOAR STORES WITHIN CITY
DEMOTS YEAH CONTINUES TO BE
DEMOLY IMPACTED BY EVERYDAY GUN
DEMOENCE I HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
DEMOING AS A MEMBER OF THE
DEMOAND VIOLENCE PREVENTION
DEMOITION WHICH IS THE
DEMOECTIVE. OF COMMUNITY BASED
DEMONIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUAL ON
THE FOR DEMOESSED BY WHERE THE
DEMO IS NEVER ENDING AB TWENTY
DEMOE FIFTEEN HERE HAVE THE
DEMONTIAL TO SLOW THE STEADY
DEMOAM OF CRIME GUNS INTO
DEMOES LIKE OAKLAND AFTER LAW
DEMORCEMENT ANOTHER TOOL TO
DEMORE COMPLIANCE WITH CURRENT
GUN DEMO WITHOUT BEING OVERLY
DEMOTIVE MOST IMPORTANTLY AND
DEMOMIZES THE POSITIVE IMPACT
AND DEMOUNITY BASED VIOLENCE
DEMOENTION PROGRAMS BY LIMITING
DEMOSS TO ILLEGALLY OBTAIN
DEMO REASON I URGE YOU TO PASS
AB. DEMOTY THREE SIXTY TWO
DEMOK YOU. GREAT IS THERE NOW
DEMO WITNESS ON THE LINE. RIGHT
DEMOS GO TO THE MANAGER AND IT
IS DEMOALLY. GO AHEAD PLEASE GO
DEMOD. MY APOLOGIES BASS
DEMOERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMORTMENT OF DEFENSE AND ON
DEMOLF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
DEMOER BECERRA WOULD LIKE TO
DEMOK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC
DEMOK YOU FOR OFFERING THE BELL
DEMORE NEAR FOR PREVENTING
DEMOT. AGAIN HAS THE PERCENT.
DEMOONSENSE MEASURE TO GIVE THE
DEMORTMENT CORRECTIVE ACTION
DEMOECT CORRECT INCORRECT
DEMOON SHORT OF ACTUALLY
DEMOKING. FIREARMS LICENSE. ONE
OF THE DEMOGS THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO DEMOT OUT OF THAT THIS LAW
IS NOT THE DEMOT OF ITS KIND
DEMONOIS DEPARTMENT THE CLEVE
HAS DEMONSING INVOLVED
DEMOSTIGATIVE AUTHORITY OVER
DEMOARMS DEALERS IN THEIR
DEMOE. IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THE DEMOARMS DEALER LICENSE
DEMOIFICATION ACT OF THE PUBLIC
DEMOTY. SLOWED OUTLINED HER
DEMOIREMENTS BAYERN DEALERS
DEMO FOLLOW IN CONSEQUENCES
DEMO THE REQUIREMENTS IN THE
DEMOE. VERIFY ANYTHING YOU BACK
I'M DEMO ACT. AND WHEREAS THERE
MAY BE A DEMOEMEANOR EIGHT.
DEMONY THE FEDERAL PENALTY
DEMOCIATED CREDIT UP TO TEN
DEMOSAND DOLLARS AS DETERMINED
BY THE DEMORTMENT IN THE
DEMOLTY MUST BE PAID WITHIN
DEMOTY DAYS. AND VASTLY
DEMOERENT THAN WHAT IS BEING
DEMOIDERED BY NFL. AND WE ARE
DEMOING A TWO YEAR IN. IN ORDER
TO DEMO INTO CONSIDERATION THE
DEMOSSARY REGULATORY PROCESS TO
DEMOTE PUBLIC COMMENT. AND TO
DEMO A REGULATORY SCHEME THAT
DEMOS SENSE THAT WILL ENCOURAGE
DEMORS DEALER TO COMPLY WITH
THE DEMO THANK YOU KINDLY MAKE
OUT DEMO SUPPORT THANK YOU. ALL
DEMOT. I NEED. SKEWS ME
DEMORATOR YOU CAN KEY UP THOSE
DEMO WHO ARE CALLING IN
DEMOORT. AND THOSE CALLING IN
DEMO YOUR NAME AND SUPPORT. AND
DEMOES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN DEMOORT OF AB TWO THREE SIX
TWO DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
TO GET DEMO THE QUEUE AND IF
YOU ARE DEMOG A SPEAKER PHONE
YOU MAY DEMO TO PICK UP THE
DEMOSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
DEMOERS. AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN
DEMOORT OF AB TWO THREE SIX TWO
DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO
GET DEMO THE QUEUE. I WILL GO
TO DEMO NUMBER SIX EIGHT.
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. HIGHLINE SIX
TO DEMOT WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN
FOR DEMO PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE
DEMOURE. OKAY NO RESPONSE. IF I
DEMONE ELSE WISHES TO QUEUE UP
IN DEMOORT OF AB TWO THREE SIX
TWO DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN IF
DEMO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD. I
DEMO NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
DEMO TIME. ALL RIGHT- LET'S SEE
IF WE DEMO ANY COMMENTS FROM-
MY DEMOEAGUES. OR QUESTIONS
DEMO- MOTION GO AHEAD CENTER
DEMO MARKETS JUST HAD ONE
DEMOTION MADAM CHAIR AND HORSE
DEMO WAS A IS MEETING. IT WAS
DEMO THE WORD OF THE FINE
DEMONUES GO VISIT TO STIR THE
DEMONUE SOURCE FOR THE S. A. G.
OR DEMO IT GO TO THE GENERAL
DEMO. OF THE- SITE I THINK IT'S
A DEMOIAL CAMP OF PERHAPS THE
DEMOESENTATIVE FROM DOJ COULD
DEMOER THAT QUESTION. DO WE
DEMOL HAVE- IS OURS ON THE LINE
DO YOU DEMO TO ANSWER WHERE THE
DEMONUE GOES. I'M NOT SURE
DEMOS ON. MEDICARE OKAY GO
DEMOD. WITHOUT EXPLICIT
DEMOCULATION IN THE BILL UP FOR
THE DEMOS WOULD GO I WOULD
DEMOME GENERAL FUND BUT I'M NOT
DEMORELY SURE AND- THERE COULD
BE AN DEMOCULATION AS TO WHERE
IT DEMOD GO TO ONE OF THE
DEMOIAL FUNDS. THAT SUPPORT
DEMORTMENT THEY'RE REQUIRING
DEMOH INCLUDES THAT DEALERS
DEMO ON FIRE SAFETY ENFORCEMENT
DEMO THEIR NUMBER OF POSSIBLY
BUT IT DEMOD BE DEPOSITED TO.
THE WE DEMO A CLARIFICATION.
DEMO LET ME CHECK WITH THE-
DEMOITTEE STAFF IS THEIR
DEMOGNATION IN THIS BILL IS TO
IT DEMO OFTEN OUR FIREARMS FEES
GO TO THE DEMORCEMENT OF THAT
AND GO TO DEMO SPECIAL ACCOUNT
YOU DEMO- COMMITTEE STAFF CAN
DEMO IT SOMETIMES FEELS LIKE
DEMO COULD BE. YOUR LIFE AS A
DEMONUE SOURCE AND CAN GET
DEMOR GRASS OF AS OPPOSED TO
DEMOLY GOING AFTER THE BAD
DEMORS. BUT CLERICAL ERRORS BE
DEMOECT TO A THOUSAND DOLLAR
DEMO. IT WOULD BE I MEAN IT
DEMOS GENERAL'S ALWAYS HAS
DEMORETION TO INVESTIGATE- AND
DEMORMINE WHETHER SOMETHING IS
A DEMOATION OF THE LAW- AND TO
YOU DEMO AND I THINK IT WOULD
BE DEMOS UNLIKELY TO ME THAT
DEMOE WAS A MINOR CLERICAL OR
DEMOGRAPHICAL ERROR- THAT WAS
NOT DEMONTIONAL THAT NOT SEEM
DEMO SOMETHING THAT THEY WOULD
GO DEMOR BUT YOU KNOW IN TERMS
OF DEMO A QUORUM COURT ERROR ON
THE DEMO IT COULD BE. IT COULD
BE DEMOIFICANT ARE NOT
DEMOIFICANT BOB IT DOES GIVE
DEMO LIKE PROSECUTORIAL
DEMORETION AS WITH ALL
DEMORCEMENT AGENCIES UNDER
DEMOT NOW THE ONLY- OPTION THEY
DEMO IS TO REVOKE A LICENSE SO
DEMO EITHER ALL OR NOTHING-
DEMO AT LEAST GIVES THEM AN
DEMORNATIVE TO SIX SOMETHING
DEMO IS NOT EFFECTIVELY.
DEMOING OFF THE BUSINESS. THANK
YOU DEMOER THANK YOU CHAIR
DEMOERN SO I DID CLARIFY IT
DEMO NOT SPECIFY SO AT THE
DEMONT IT WOULD GO TO GENERAL
DEMO BUT CERTAINLY- APPROACH SO.
IT DEMOFY THAT WERE APPROPRIATE
TO DO SO DEMOE I JUST WANNA
DEMO SURE WE DON'T REFUSE
DEMOTHING. THANK YOU CERTAINLY
ALL DEMOT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR DEMOENTSALL RIGHT THEN- IS
A DEMOTE BY SENATOR WIENER YOU
CAN DEMOE ON BEHALF OF MISTER
DEMOE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCY
DEMO THAT WOULD TAKE A MOTION.
I DEMOT KNOW SORRY- SKEWS ME
DEMOER JACKSON GO AHEAD. JUST
DEMOFLY I WANT TO SUGGEST THAT
DEMO GOING TO A SPECIAL BOND
FOR DEMORCEMENT BY THE ATTORNEY
DEMORAL A THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE
PER DEMOON ISN'T GOING TO MAKE
THE AG DEMOLY INGRESS.
DEMOFULLY WHAT IT WILL DO WELL
DEMOENISH OF THE FUNDS AND
DEMOABLY AREN'T NECESSARILY%
DEMOUATE ENOUGH AND I THINK THE
DEMOT IS WELL MADE. THAT WHEN
THE DEMOCES EITHER- I TERMINATE
THE DEMOTMENT- OR IGNORE THEM
THE DEMONSE WHEN YOU HAVE PUT A
DEMOLE GROUND IN THEIR OF THE
DEMO I THINK THAT BENEFITS
DEMOYBODY. SO I JUST LIKE TO-
DEMOESTS THIS IS A WIN WIN FOR
DEMO SIDES AND THAT. ARE AT THE
DEMOOPRIATE TIME I KNOW THAT
DEMOTOR WIENER CAN'T SPEAK ON
DEMOLF OF THE AUTHOR PER SE BUT
I'D DEMO TO SUGGEST THAT THIS
BE DEMOGNATED TO GO INTO THE
DEMO. FOR ENFORCEMENT OF THESE
DEMOS OF LAWS. RIGHT SO WE'LL
DEMO THAT AS A SUGGESTION WE
DEMO NOT TAKE THAT AS AN
DEMODMENT HERE- AND BUT SIR.
DEMO CAN BE COMMUNICATED TO THE
DEMOOR AND THE AUTHOR CAN
DEMOOUSLY. IF SO WILLING
DEMOTIATE. THAT IN THE APPROACH
DEMOITTEE. ALL RIGHT. THE RIVER
TO THE DEMOOR AND I
DEMOECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OH I'M
DEMOY DID I NOT HEAR FROM THE
DEMOSITION MY APOLOGIES I
DEMOGHT I ASKED I ASKED FOR THE
DEMOSITION BUT I DID ASK I
DEMOD. YOU DID. OKAY. GO AHEAD
IS IT THE DEMO OPPOSITION WHO
IS ON OR IS IT DEMO OPPOSITION
DEMOVE CALLED IN. IT IS
DEMORWOMAN THANK YOU VERY MY
DEMO IS MY THE MAN WITH
DEMOONAL SPORTS. AND I'M HERE
TO DEMOIFY AGAINST THIS BILL.
DEMORE NOT LISTED AS THE LEAD
DEMOSITION I DON'T BELIEVE.
DEMOO I'M SO SORRY IN OTHER
DEMOS YEAH ARE YOU WATER A WEEK
FOR DEMOIFICATION GO AHEAD JUST
GO DEMOD. GO AHEAD OKAY CENTER
MY DEMO IS MICHAEL FINLEY AGAIN
DEMO THE NATIONAL SHOOTING
DEMOTS FOUNDATION WE ARE
DEMONST THE BELL. THERE ARE
DEMOTIONS AS THEY WERE JUST
DEMOED AS TO WITH WHICH FNDS
DEMO BE USED FOR AND WHERE THE
DEMOS WILL GO AND WE'RE OUR
DEMOILERS ARE VERY CONCERNED.
DEMOT THE POTENTIAL OF USE FOR
DEMO A COUPLE OF THE- COUPLE
DEMOIMONYFOCUSED ON THIS
DEMONG COMMUNITIES SAFER. I
DEMOD IMPLORE YOU NOT TO- DAHLE
DEMO THAT TRAP WHEN WE ARE
DEMOING AT SURVEYS THAT ARE
DEMOUCTED BY THE US DEPARTMENT
OF DEMOICE. BY AND LARGE THE
DEMORITY OF FIREARMS USED IN
DEMOES OR STOLEN OR BOARD
DEMOINED A WAY THAT IS ALREADY
DEMOGAL UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
DEMO NOT PRECLUDE CRIMINALS
DEMO GETTING AT. BUT THERE ARE
BIG DEMOTIONS SURROUNDING THIS
DEMO. AND. WHAT WHAT SORT OF
DEMOONS WILL BURST. ONE EXAMPLE
THE DEMOING LABEL THAT ALL MAIN
DEMO'LL RETAILER OR TO CLICK ON.
HAS DEMO CHANGED THREE IN THE
DEMO IT IT A ON THE PREVIOUS.
DEMONERATE OF THE WARNING LABEL
DEMOUCTS ARE. AND THE DOJ THAT
DEMO COULD FIND REACH. I ONLY
HAD DEMOE MINUTES I'VE USED A
DEMOTE TO HAPPEN I'LL DEFERRED
AT DAN DEMO WITH GENERATORS THE
DEMONDS ARE EXCELLENT GO HEAD
DEMO RIGHT GO AHEAD DAN REED.
YES DEMOM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE DEMOITTEE FOR THE RECORD
THE AND DEMO WITH NATIONAL
DEMOE ASSOCIATION. ALSO IF
DEMORE FOR GUN OWNERS A
DEMOFORNIAN OPPOSITION TODAY-
AS DEMO YOU'RE WELL AWARE
DEMOFORNIA LAWS REGARDING.
DEMOARMS DEALERS AS WELL AS
DEMORAL LAW IS CAN BE VERY
DEMOLICATED. AND AT DIFFERENT
DEMOS GENERATE HAS BEEN
DEMOORTIVE OF THE MORE
DEMOEMENTAL APPROACH HOWEVER WE
DO DEMOCT TO THIS BILL INVOICE
DEMOSITION TODAY. BECAUSE WE'RE
DEMOERNED WITH THE AMBIGUITY OF
DEMO BILL THE BROADNESS- YOU
FOR DEMOY THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE DEMO UP REGULATIONS AND WHAT
DEMOE REGULATIONS MAY LOOK
DEMO. COULD DO THAT. I THINK WE
DEMOGE HOW THIS BILL
DEMOEMENTED WHERE CLIENTS ARE
TO BE DEMO X. AND I THAT THAT'S-
DEMO WE SHOULD PUT RIVERS.
DEMOE ABOUT DOLLAR ELECTRICALLY
DA DEMOARS. IS NOT SMALL
DEMOTOES A LOT OF THESE MOM AND
POP DEMONESSES. AND THAT COULD
DEMOD PUT SOMEONE UNDER
DEMOCIALLY IF YOU HADI JUST
DEMOIONED BUT CLERICAL ERROR
AND DEMO AMOUNT OF FINE COULD
BE DEMOED ON NON. IF THIS WAS A
DEMOISTENT CLERICAL ERROR COULD
DEMO MEAN- EACH ONE OF THOSE
DEMOL CLERICAL ERRORS THAT
DEMOONE FAILED TO GET REAL
DEMOIFICATION FROM THE
DEMORCING AGENCY ON. COULD BE A
DEMOTED TEN TWENTY THIRTY
DEMOSAND DOLLARS SO WE HAVE
DEMOERNS ABOUT WE ALSO CONCERNS
DEMO WHERE THE MONEY IS GOING
HOW DEMOT MOTIVATE. OVERLY
DEMOESSIVE ENFORCEMENT- WHEN
DEMOOUT WARNING OPPOSITION
DEMOK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
DEMOS SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
DEMOESSES. WHO ARE CALLING IN
DEMOSITION. OKAY HEARING NONE
WE DEMO GO TO. WE'VE ALREADY-
DEMO HERE WITH CLOSE TO YOUR
DEMOT WE HAVE TO DO THE ROLL
DEMO POLITIES. AGAIN WE'RE
DEMOON- I THOUGHT THERE WAS A
DEMOON MY WRONG OKAY THERE WAS
NOT A DEMOON. I MOVED THANK YOU
IT DEMO GET THROWN OFF WE CLOSE
IT AND DEMO HAVE TO GET OUT SO.
MS DEMOHELL HAS MOVED AND THE
DEMOON IS TO PASS TO APPROACH
DEMO OF THE FINANCIAL. LAW
DEMOER BRADFORD. BRADFORD MOVE-
I DEMOGHT YOU DID OKAY I THINK
DEMO'RE THE MOST WOULD GO.
DEMOTOR BRADFORD I WAS MOVED.
DEMOE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
DEMOPS. YOU WITH LET YOUR ROLE
DEMO. AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO
DO DEMO APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER
BY IN OUR AYE DEMOOCK MORE LIKE
NO DEMOFORD BRADFORD AYE
DEMOSON. JACKSON HI JACKSON I
DEMOHELL MITCHELL I'D MITCHELL
AYE DEMOLE. MORRELL KNELT
DEMOND- WINNER WINNER HI BILLS
OUT DEMO TWO RIGHT THAT BILLS
OUT DEMO TWO WILL NOW GO TO A
DEMO ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR
DEMOTY THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OUR DEMOTS GO AHEAD THANK YOU
DEMOM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
DEMOTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE IS A
DEMOLE BILL THAT REQUIRES
DEMOTY SHERIFF'S STATEWIDE TO
DEMOILE COMPILE AND SUBMIT DATA
ON DEMONDER RECIDIVISM PROGRAMS
DEMOIDED INMATES IN COUNTY
DEMOS AND THE SUCCESS RATES IN
DEMOE. RECIDIVISM PROGRAMS THIS
DEMO IS MERELY A MEASURE THAT
DEMOS US GOOD INFORMATION AS WE
DEMO THE ECONOMIC CRISIS WERE
IN TO DEMO BETTER DECISIONS-ABOUT WHERE ARE. DOLLARS SHOULD
GO SO DEMO WE ARE SUPPORTING
DEMODIVISM PROGRAMS THAT WORK
AND DEMORING THAT THE DOLLARS
TO GO TO THE DEMOTIES ARE BEING
DEMOT RESPONSIBLY. WITH THAT I
DEMO TURN IT OVER TO THE
DEMOESSES ON THE LINE IN
DEMOORT WE HAVE LESLIE HOUSTON
DEMO THE SOLANO COUNTY PUBLIC
DEMONDER'S OFFICE AND DAN
DEMOAS AUTO FROM THE LOS
DEMOLES DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
DEMOCE. RIGHT LEAD WITNESSES GO
DEMOD THREE MINUTES TOTAL. I
DEMOK DAM GOING FIRST OKAY GO
DEMOD. ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
DEMOTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
DEMOCE THE PUBLIC SAFETY
DEMOIGNMENT ACTIVE TWENTY
DEMOEN WAS DESIGNED TO BOTH
DEMOCE OUR PER PART AND REDUCE
OUR DEMODIVISM RATE TODAY ALL
DEMOTIES ARE. EXPERIMENTING
DEMO DIFFERENT RECIDIVISM
DEMORAMS IN OUR COUNTY JAILS
DEMOTIES NEED RELIABLE AND
DEMOASED INFORMATION TO JUDGE
THE DEMOCTIVENESS OF THEIR
DEMORAMS. WITHOUT THIS
DEMORMATION WE CANNOT DETERMINE
DEMOHER THEY'RE PROGRAMS NEED
TO BE DEMODED OR ELIMINATED IN
A DEMOERENT PROGRAM TRIED. AB
DEMOTY FORTY THREE WILL GIVE
DEMOTIES THE ABILITY TO
DEMOUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
DEMOR PROGRAMS COMPARED TO
DEMOE IN OTHER COUNTIES WITH
DEMO INFORMATION MORE.
DEMOLABLE COUNTIES CAN FIGURE
OUT DEMOH PROGRAMS ARE MOST
DEMOCTIVE AT REDUCING
DEMODIVISM FOR THESE REASONS
THE LOS DEMOLES COUNTY DISTRICT
DEMORNEY'S OFFICE IN STRONG
DEMOORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
DEMOTY THREE. AND LESLIE GO
DEMOD. OKAY I'M WHAT WE CALL
THE DEMOTON I'M ACTUALLY
DEMOKING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION ON
THE DEMORED SOLANO COUNTY
DEMOIC DEFENDER- MOST OF WHAT I
WAS DEMOA SAY IS ALREADY BEEN
FED SO LET ME DEMOT HERE WE
DEMOT MONEY SPENT TO REDUCE
DEMODIVISM BUT NO DATA ON
DEMOESS RATES. EVERY COUNTY IS
DEMOG IN A DIFFERENT DIRECTION
AND WE DEMOLY DON'T KNOW WHAT
DEMOS WELL WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DEMO CAN BE REDUCED BY
DEMOBILITATION THAT ADDRESSES
THE DEMOS OF INDIVIDUALS IN THE
DEMOINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM LOCAL
DEMOIFFS ARE IN PART
DEMOONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
DEMOICES AND OPPORTUNITIES.
DEMO ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS
DEMOING AT THE SUCCESS OF
DEMOICULAR PROGRAMS AND
DEMOICES WELL THE STATE AND
DEMOL TO YOUR MAKERS WITH NOT
DEMO THEM THE KNOWLEDGE
DEMOSSARY. TO APPROACH.
DEMOCATE OUR LIMITED RESOURCES
TO THE DEMORAM'S ANSWER. THAT
DEMO ENCOURAGE REHABILITATION.
AND DEMOCE RECIDIVISM. BEFORE
DEMOIGNMENT I WOULD RECOMMEND
MY DEMONTS AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
THE DEMO YOU PROGRAMS OF THE
DEMO EXISTED IN THE JAILS IN
THE DEMOS THAT IT WOULD HELP MY
DEMONT BUT NONE OF US KNEW IF
THE DEMORAMS WORK. WE ASK YOU
TO DEMO I ON AB TWENTY FOUR
DEMOTY THREE BECAUSE MY
DEMOIRED SHARE OF STATEWIDE TO
DEMOILE THE DATA THE PUBLIC CAN
DEMOSION MAKERS WILL LEARN WHAT
DEMOS TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
DEMOR. WHAT DID PERSONS. GET
DEMOGRATE INTO THEIR
DEMOUNITIES. AND YOU. MASON
DEMO L. SCARCE RESOURCES YOU.
DEMOK YOU BUT IF THERE'S ANY
DEMOR WITNESSES CALLING IN
DEMOORT. MODERATOR. THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE IN DEMOORT OF AB TWO
DEMO EIGHT THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE DEMO ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
DEMOAD WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
SIX DEMORED SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
DEMOD SIX SIX TWO. DISABILITY
DEMOTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
WE DEMO A LINEUP EIGHTY THREE
DEMOSE GO AHEAD LINE EACH THREE.
DEMOCCORD OUR MOM HAPPENED THE
DEMO BECAUSE THE PUBLIC
DEMONDER'S OFFICE DIDN'T
DEMOORT ALSO VOICING COURT ON
DEMOLF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
DEMOTY AND JUSTICE AND WE THE
DEMOLE SAN DIEGO. LADIES AND
DEMOLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
ARE IN DEMOORT OF AB TWENTY
DEMO EIGHTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE DEMO ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE
DEMO IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
DEMOINUE. I THEN WE WILL TO THE
DEMO OPPOSITION WHICH I'VE
DEMOED AS COREY SELLS A LOAN
DEMO THE STATE SHERIFFS. THANK
YOU DEMOM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DEMO CELLS WILL ON BEHALF OF
THE DEMOFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
DEMOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
DEMOSITION TO AB TWO FOUR EIGHT
DEMOE. SHERIFFS ACROSS THE
DEMOE PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
DEMOBILITATIVE PROGRAMMING TO
DEMO INMATES WITH THE DESIRE TO
DEMONCE FORMERLY INCARCERATED
DEMOONS RE ENTRY INTO SOCIETY
AND DEMOCE THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
DEMOLE RE OFFEND. UNFORTUNATELY
DEMO BILL IMPOSES VAGUE AND
DEMOENSOME DATA COLLECTION
DEMOIREMENTS WITHOUT ANY
DEMOANTEE OF FUNDING TO COVER
THE DEMOS COSTS. AB TWO FOUR
DEMOT THREE REQUIRE SHERIFF'S
TO DEMORT QUOTE DATA ON EACH OF
THE DEMO RECIDIVISM PROGRAMS
DEMO PROVIDE INMATES IN THEIR
DEMOTY JAIL FACILITIES UNQUOTE.
THE DEMOE OF WHAT IS BEING
DEMOHT BY LANGUAGE IS UNCLEAR
DEMOVER AND IS LIKELY TO YIELD
DEMOERATE RESPONSES FROM THE
DEMOD. OPTIONALLY DEFINITION OF
DEMOORISM COULD BE INTO. AS
DEMO. COUNTY JAILS TO ASCERTAIN
DEMO COURTS OTHER JAILS OR
DEMOE PRISONS. POTENTIALLY
DEMOUDING SUCH ENTITIES AND
DEMOR STATES. ON INFORMATION AS
TO DEMOEQUENT CONVICTIONS.
DEMOIRING SUCH WOULD BE VERY
DEMONSIVE AND DIFFICULT TO
DEMORTAKE. A PROBLEM
DEMOERBATED BY THE FACT THAT
THE DEMO PROVIDES NO FUNDING
FOR ITS DEMOIREMENTS. AGAIN
DEMOES SINCE YOU SAY SEAT OF
DEMOMOND PROVIDING PROGRAMMING
AND DEMOCING RECIDIVISM. BUT
DUE TO THE DEMO'S AMBIGUOUS
DEMOUAGE AND LACK OF FUNDING WE
DEMO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
DEMO THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET'S
SEE IF DEMOE'S ANY OTHER
DEMOERS IN OPPOSITION MODERATOR.
AND DEMOES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
ARE IN DEMOSITION OF AB TWO
DEMO EIGHT THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE DEMO ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEY PAD DEMON THAT IS ONE THEN
DEMO. THE LINE NUMBER. SIX
DEMORED SIXTY NINE NINE SIX SIX
DEMO. MEMBERS ALL ON BEHALF OF
LOS DEMOLES COUNTY SHERIFF ALEX
DEMOANUEVA IN OPPOSITION. AND
IT IT DEMONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB. TWO DEMO EIGHT THREE
DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO.
I DEMO NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
DEMOSE CONTINUE EXCELLENT WILL
DEMOG IT TO A THE COMMITTEE
DEMOTOR JACKSON GO AHEAD. THANK
DEMO AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
DEMO BILL THIS IS ALMOST A-
DEMOTING THAT WE HAVE TO DO
DEMO BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
DEMOT TRYING TO REDUCE
DEMODIVISM AND WE ARE KEEPING
ANY DEMORDS TO SEE WHETHER OR
NOT DEMO'S WORKING. SO I
DEMOECIATE THIS A FIRST STEP- I
DEMO WONDER IF I MAY INQUIRE OF
THE DEMOORS TO THE CHAIR. IS
DEMOE A SIMILAR REQUIREMENT FOR
OUR CD SHE ARE FOR DEMOE OF OUR
OF DEMO WHO ARE IN CARS TO IN
DEMOE PRISON TO KEEP TRACK OF
DEMOR RECIDIVISM RATES AS WELL.
WE DEMO TRACK OF RECIDIVISM
DEMOS BUT WE DON'T NECESSARILY.
YES WE DO DEMO TRACK OF
DEMODIVISM RATES FOR THE STATE
DEMOONS YES. NO I WONDER IS
DEMO PROGRAM SOMEWHAT MIRRORED
TO DEMO IN TERMS OF WHAT IT IS
DEMO'S EXPECTED OF THE
DEMOIFF'S AS FAR AS-
DEMOTIFYING IN COMPILING THAT
DEMO. ON THEIR ANTI RECIDIVISM
DEMORAMS IN THE SUCCESS RATE TO
DEMOE PROGRAMS. MADAM CHAIR FOR
ME YES I AM DEMOK YOU CENTERS
IN OUR FOR THE DEMOT FEATHER
DEMONER. EJECTED FOR THE
DEMOTION- YES SO THROUGH THE
DEMONISTRATION WERE ABLE TO
DEMOECT STATE DATA BUT AS YOU
DEMO SINCE REALIGNMENT MORE
DEMOE PROGRAMS ARE HAPPENING AT
THE DEMOTY LEVEL AND WE HAVE
NOT DEMO ABLE TO GET ANY DATA
O HOW DEMO IS HAPPENING AT THE
DEMOE LEVEL THAT WE TRY TO
DEMOGE WITH THE SHERIFF'S GIVEN
DEMOR OPPOSITION. THAT HAS NOT
DEMO SUCCESSFUL YEAH WE WERE
DEMO TO PULL THE DEFINITION OF
DEMODIVISM FROM ELSEWHERE IN
THE DEMO SO IT SHOULD BE
DEMOISTENT. SO BUT MY QUESTION
IF I MAY IS- IS THE DEMORAM
DEMO IS BEING SET UP BY THIS
DEMOSLATION. IT DOESN'T MIRROR.
THE DEMORAM OR I SHOULD SAY THE
DEMOIREMENTS THAT ARE SET FORTH
FOR CDC ARE TO DEMOIDE THAT
DEMORMATION FOR THEIR- OF
DEMOONERS IN OUR STATE PRISONS.
SO DEMOGER CORRECT ME IF I'M
DEMOG BUT BECAUSE CDCR IS A
DEMOE AGENCY WE WORK WITH THAT-
DEMONISTRATION TO GET THAT DATA
SO IT DEMON'T HAVE TO BE A
DEMOIREMENT HOWEVER WE DON'T
DEMO THE SAME ABILITY TO REACH
DEMO THE COUNTIES WHICH IS WHY
DEMO LEGISLATION IS REQUIRED SO
DEMO SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT. THANK
DEMO THIRD THE MIKE OFF CORRECT
ALL DEMOT. THERE ARE NO OTHER
DEMOS UP. YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU DEMOK YOU SO MUCH FOR
DEMOING THE BILL TODAY AND THAT
DEMO PASSED UP THE ASSEMBLY
DEMO FLOOR WITH BIPARTISAN
DEMOORT AND NO NO THAT'S I
DEMOECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
DEMOR MOTION BUILT. SINCE THE
DEMOE IN THE WILDERNESS CHACKO
DEMOER JACKSON MOVES WILL ITS
DEMOGY JACKSON MOVE A GENERAL
DEMOREST IN A ALL RIGHTS RIVER
DEMOON AND THAT MOTION WOULD BE
DO DEMOED TO APPROACH ROLL CALL
DEMOSE. AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
DEMOE DO PASSED TO
DEMOOPRIATIONS SKINNER BY IN
OUR AYE DEMOLACH. MOORLACH AYE
DEMOFORD. BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
DEMOSON ALL RIGHT JACKSON AYE
DEMOHELL THE JULY THE FILL AYE
DEMOLE. VOTING BROWN NOT VOTING
DEMOER. WHEN OUR ONLINE SIX
DEMO FOR YOUR BILLS OUT SIX
DEMO THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO-
THE DEMO TWELVE WAS ON
DEMOENSUS LET'S ALREADY PASSED
DEMO NOW GO TO ITEM THIRTEEN
DEMOMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER AB
DEMOTY EIGHT NINETY ONE GO
DEMOD. PROTEINS YOU-
DEMOOPRIATELY WAITING THANK YOU
DEMON AND WE DO CLEAN UP
DEMOEEN SPEAKERS YES WE DO
DEMOOPRIATE CAN YOU GO AHEAD
DEMO AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
DEMOERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
DEMOENT AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
ONE A DEMORICT THAT WILL
DEMOIDE PEACE OFFICER STATUS TO
DEMOUM OFFICERS IN EXPOSITION
DEMO LAST YEAR THE
DEMONISTRATION SIGNED A
DEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
DEMO BARGAINING UNITS SEVEN OF
THE DEMOFORNIA STATE LAW
DEMORCEMENT ASSOCIATION TO
DEMOIDE PEACE OFFICER STATUS TO
THE DEMOUM OFFICERS. MUSEUM
DEMOCERS IN EXPOSITION PARK
DEMOIDE SAFETY AND SECURITY IT
DEMOERLY THIRTY TO FIFTY
DEMOSAND ATTENDEES AT THE
DEMONCE CENTER AND WHERE WHERE
DEMOCE THE SENATE OFFICE AND L.
A. DEMOTY SUPERVISORS OFFICE
ARE ARE DEMOTED. PALESTINIAN
THE DEMOFORNIA AFTER AMERICAN
DEMOUM. OF NATURAL MUSEUM L. A.
U. DEMOENTARY SCHOOL LAFC
DEMOER STADIUM EXPOSITION PARK
DEMOLF THE FUTURE TO LUCAS
DEMOUM AND EVENTUALLY THE WORLD
CUP IN DEMOTY TWENTY SIX AND
THE DEMOER OLYMPICS IN TWENTY
DEMOTY EIGHT WILL BE HELD. A
DEMORED SIXTY ACRES ONE POINT
DEMON MILLION PEOPLE VISIT
DEMOY YEAR. THIS BILL
DEMOGNIZES THE OUTSTANDING
DEMO. THE MUSEUM OFFICERS
DEMOLY AFTER AMERICAN LATINO
DEMO DONE KEEPING THE PUBLIC
DEMO BY SIMPLY CODIFYING DMO
YOU DEMOED INTO. INTO BY THE
DEMOE THIS BILL IS SPECIFIC TO
DEMOUM OPTICS VISION PART AND
IS DEMOISTENT WITH OTHER BILLS
THE DEMOITTEE HAS PASSED WITH
DEMO ME TODAY TO TESTIFY OVER
THE DEMOE IS LEVINE ON BEHALF
DEMOFORNIA STATE. OFFERED A
DEMOIATION MEMBERS ARE ASK
DEMOE I MR LEVINE. MADAM CHAIR
DEMOERS SHE WILL BE IN ABOUT
THE CSL THE A DEMOE PARTY UNIT.
DEMO MY COMMENTS ARE LARGELY
DEMOISTENT WITH THE MISTER
DEMOS SAWYER- AS YOU STATED IN
DEMOTY NINETEEN A BARGAINING
DEMO IN THE MINISTRATION-
DEMORED INTO THE MEMORY OF
DEMO. BRAND BUT STANDING IN
DEMOED TO CONVERT TO THIRTY
DEMOE MUSEUM SECURITY OFFICER
DEMOTIONS CURRENTLY STATIONED
DEMO THERE TO EXPOSITION PARK
TO DEMOY SWORN PEACE OFFICERS
DEMOTIONS THESE OFFICERS WILL
DEMO TO UNDERGO BASIC POST
DEMONING AS A PART OF- THE
DEMOUTORY CHANGE THE ANGLE IS
NOT A DEMO TIME COMING WITH
DEMONG CHANGE APPROACH FILE A
TO DEMOHER TRAIN PROFESSIONAL
DEMO THIS UNIT- THE SOME
DEMOION VOTED IT PASSED BY THIS
DEMOSLATURE TWENTY TWENTY IT
WAS A ONE DEMOTEEN- EIGHTY
DEMOTY. ONE IS LESS THE STAFF
CAN DEMOLY CUT. WITH THAT WE
DEMO THREE I BOOK THANK. THANK
YOU ARE DEMOE ANY OTHER
DEMOESSES CALLING IN SUPPORT ON
DEMO FIND OTHERS NO OTHER MAIN
DEMOE ANY. CALLING SUPPORT.
DEMORATOR AB LADIES AND
DEMOLEMEN IF YOU WERE IN
DEMOORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
DEMOTY ONE YOU CAN PRESS ONE
DEMO ZERO ON THE PHONE KEY PAD
AT DEMO TIME AGAIN ONE THEN
DEMO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO DEMOT NINE ONE. BE JUST
A DEMONT THANK YOU. IT'LL BE
DEMO ONE MORE MOMENT. THANK YOU
ARE WE DEMO LINE NUMBER SIX
DEMON EIGHT. IT'LL BE JUST ONE
DEMO MOMENT THANK YOU LINE SIX
DEMON EIGHT WE HAVE THE LINE
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
DEMO IS MARIA IDEAS I AM A
DEMOER OF POOR EXCUSE YOU SEE
DEMO OUR MEDIA BUT I'M NOT
DEMONO ALAMEDA. AND I'M IN
DEMOR OF. WHAT IS THAT WE'RE
DEMOG RIGHT NOW EIGHTY. AB ONE
DEMO FIVE ZERO- WE'RE NOT ON
DEMO BILL SO AND- I THINK OUR
DEMOY- ON JONES SAWYER AB
DEMOTY EIGHT NINETY ONE. OKAY
AB DEMOTY EIGHT NINETY ONE
DEMOK YOU. MODERATOR WE COULD
YOU DEMOUNCED THAT THESE ARE
DEMO CALLS IN SUPPORT OF AB
DEMOTY EIGHT NINETY ONE LET TO
SEE IF DEMOE'S ANY. LADIES AND
DEMOLEMEN AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
DEMOORT OF AB TWO EIGHT NINE
ONE DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT DEMO TIME. EVERYONE IN THE
DEMOE PLEASE CONTINUE THIRDS
THE I DEMOT BELIEVE NO WE HAVE
NO. DEMOAL LEAD OPPOSITION
DEMOS SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
DEMOING IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
DEMO. IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB DEMOT NINE ONE PLEASE
DEMOS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
DEMOE KEYPAD. AGAIN THE IN
DEMOSITION OF AB TWO EIGHT NINE
ONE DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON THE DEMOPHONE KEY PAD. I
DEMO NO ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
DEMOINUE EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT SO
ON. DEMOMBLY MEMBER ID IN
DEMORAL- WOOD- IF THIS WERE A
SET OF DEMORITY GUARDS FOR
DEMOPLE I'M NOT SURE IF I WOULD
BE IN DEMOORT OF GIVING THEM
DEMON OFFICER STATUS BUT THESE
ARE DEMOIC EMPLOYEE. WHO WE
DEMOUGH THE FORGETTING
DEMOEMENT WAS CLARIFIED THAT
DEMO IS IN FACT THE RULE AND SO
AND DEMON THAT IT IS
DEMOOPRIATE TO HAVE THEM
DEMOSIFIED. IN A WAY THAT
DEMOWS THEM TO BE A SINCE THEY
DEMO THAT EXACT ROLE IN OR NOT.
I DEMOK IT MADE MY POINT- SO I
DEMO BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL.
AND DEMOS JUST SEE IF THERE'S
ANY YES DEMOER BRADFORD.
DEMOURE I'M JUST CURIOUS. IT'S
THE DEMOD OF THESE OFFICERS
DEMO APPLE'S CERTIFICATION SO
DEMO MEANS THEY HAVE TO ATTEND
DEMOEMY. THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
DEMOND A CAT AND- FREEDOM
DEMOICULATING MORE. TRAINING ON
DEMOCE OFFICERS AND WHAT'S
DEMOTION OF THE TIME AND
DEMOEMIES WILL BE SIMILAR O
DEMOR SWORN POLICE OFFICERS WHO
DEMOE. TIMES I DON'T KNOW BUT I
DEMOD FIND IT OUT FOR YOU
DEMOER AND UPON GRADUATING WILL
DEMO AB. CHAIN LEVINE MAY KNOW
DEMO AND WILL THEY ACQUIRE
DEMOT THIRTY POINT ONE STATUS.
DEMO PLEASE OPTIONAL REASON I'M
DEMO I'M OF HIS BILL ENOUGH
DEMOS AGO I DID AB ONE TO WAIT
FOR LAX DEMOCE OFFICERS WHO.
FOR SO DEMO FOUGHT FOR A FULL
DEMOCE STATUS AND- HAPPY THIRTY
DEMOT ONE SO I'M JUST CURIOUS.
DEMOUS WILL A HALF COULD SOME
DEMOATIONS OF EIGHT THIRTY AND
I DEMOD SAY THEY WOULD THEY
DEMOD NOT HAVE IT COMPLETE
DEMOUSE THIS IS. WOULD NOT BE
DEMO TO. IN ORDER ARMED UNLESS.
THE DEMOE DIRECTOR PART
DEMOORIZE. SO IT'S MY
DEMORSTAND THERE GET. ALISON
DEMOE TO BE ABLE TO GET.
DEMONING A LARGE. SO THEY CAN
DEMO UP TO A CERTAIN STATUS.
CAN DEMO ME FROM. CORRECT WRONG.
DEMO'T ONE POINT WE HAVE. ARMED
DEMOCERS AT THE PARK I THOUGHT
IT ONE DEMOTY DID HAVE SHUFFLED
DEMOUS. NOW SENATE MITCHELL
DEMO AN ORIGINAL BE MORE
DEMOLIAR WITH THAT THANK YOU I
DEMOK YOU'RE I REMEMBER THAT
DEMO SENATOR BRADFORD AND IT
WAS A- DEMOGORY OF LAW
DEMORCEMENT THAT ACTUALLY HAD
DEMOONSIBILITY OF THE STATE
DEMO HERE TO. THAT ONE AWAY
DEMO TIME HOW HIGHLY PATROL GOT
THE DEMORACT FIVE I SEEM TO
DEMOLL JUST LIKE YOU THAT THEY
DEMO ARMED. YEAH BECAUSE I KNOW
DEMO WE WERE DOING L. A. ACTION
WE DEMORENCE THE FACT THAT AT
ONE DEMOT WE THOUGHT THOSE GUYS
DEMOLD MINIMUM OPERATED HAD HAD
DEMO FULL STATUS SO. I'M IN
DEMOORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BUT DEMOER ORLOK. MADAM CHAIR
DEMOUSE OF SOME OF THE SAME
DEMOONS AND BECAUSE OF THE-
DEMONTIAL MOVE IN AND
DEMOREMENT BENEFITS- I'M
DEMOERNED ABOUT THE BILL AND
DEMO BE. PROPOSED OKAY. ANY
DEMOR QUESTIONS NO ONE ALL
DEMOT SO. APOLOGIES IF I DID
NOT DEMOCE IF THERE WAS ARGUE
DEMOON WAS THERE ALREADY IN
DEMOON. AND CENTER RITUAL MADE
DEMO MOTION AND THE. OKAY AND
THE DEMO BUSINESS THE MOTION IS
TO DEMOOR PROBES REGGIE I'M
DEMOY SIMILAR NUMBERS RELEASED
DEMO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
DEMO VOTE. ALL RIGHT A ROLL
DEMO AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE
DO DEMOED TO APPROPRIATIONS
DEMONER BY INTER ADAM MARBACH
DEMOLACH NO BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE DEMOSON. JACKSON ALL RIGHT
DEMOS IN HIGH MITCHELL.
DEMOHELL III MORALE. MORALE NO
DEMOND NARROW WINNER. NOW
DEMOER NO. THAT'S FORTY THREE.
THE DEMO IT PASSES THE VOTE IS
A DEMO VOTERS FORD SKIS ME THE
DEMO RECEIVED FORTY THREE THE
DEMOS OUT AND- WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO DEMOK YOU COMMITTEE MUCH
DEMO NOW MOVE TO- SKEWS ME ITEM
DEMOTEEN. AND THAT IS ASSEMBLY
DEMOER WEBER SPILL. THE TEA OF
DEMOEVE SOMEONE ELSE'S. NO SHE
DEMOENTING FIVE OH SORRY OKAY
GO DEMOD WAS IN WRITTEN IN MY
DEMOS GO AHEAD OF A- AND WIENER
DEMO BE PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
DEMOMBLY MEMBER WEBER AB THIRTY
DEMON. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
DEMO IF I HAVE THE PLEASURE
DEMOY PRESENTING AB THIRTY
DEMONTY AS A CO AUTHOR AND ON
DEMOLF OF DOCTOR WEBER. SB
DEMOTY SEVEN THE WILL REDUCE
DEMOWFUL DISCRIMINATION IN THE
DEMOCISE OF PEREMPTORY
DEMOLENGES- IN THE JURY
DEMOCTION PROCESS HI THIS IS AN
DEMORTANT- CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DEMORM BILL. THE CALL. AND THE
U. S. DEMOEME COURT'S FIVE BAR
DEMO DISCRIMINATION THE WHEELER
THE DEMO AND DECISIONS BEING
THE DEMOARY- DECISIONS IN THIS
DEMO. COURTS AND LEGAL SCHOLARS.
DEMO DEBATED WHETHER THE
DEMOENT LEGAL STANDARD IS
DEMOCTIVE AT STOPPING
DEMORIMINATION IN PEREMPTORY
DEMOLENGES. HI THIS BILL WOULD
DEMOOVE COURTS THE PROCESS THE
DEMOTS USE FOR ASSESSING
DEMOHER PRIMARY CHALLENGE
DEMORIMINATES AND THE STOPS
DEMONATION IN JURY SELECTION.
AB DEMOTY SEVENTY MIX
DEMOAMENTAL ANSWER EXISTING LAW
DEMO OF THE CREATED BY THE
DEMOTS- AND IT SETS THE PROCESS
FOR A DEMOE TO DETERMINE
DEMOHER FROM THREE CHALLENGE IS
THE OF DEMOAL OR OTHER
DEMORIMINATION. ON BILL ALLOWS
DEMOES TO OBJECT ON THEIR OWN
DEMOON TO PRINTER CHALLENGES.
IT DEMOTS THE BURDEN OF PROOF
DEMO THE PERSON- FROM THE
DEMOON EXERCISING THE PRINTER
DEMOLENGE- TO THE- EXITING FROM
THE DEMOON. CONTESTING THE
DEMOARY SEARCH ALLEN TO THE
DEMOON EXERCISING A PEREMPTORY
DEMOLENGE THEY WILL HAVE TO
DEMOIFY AND PROVE. THAT THEIR-
DEMOTER WAS NOT DISCRIMINATORY.
THE DEMO CHANGES THE STANDARD
DEMO SUBJECTIVE INTENT. TO
DEMOCTIVE ACTION RECOGNIZING
DEMO WHATEVER SOMEONE
DEMOECTIVE INTENT IF THEY ARE
IN DEMOCT PERMITTING. IT IS A
DEMOLEM I REGARD THE WATERS.
DEMOECTIVE INTENT WAS. I AM IN
MY. DEMO MILLION THE AND
DEMOEAD OF PROVING THE EXIST OF
AND THE TO DEMOEAD SHOW A
DEMOTANTIAL LIKELIHOOD THAT
DEMOCTIVELY REASONABLE PERSON
DEMOD VIEW RACE AS A FACTOR IN
THE USE OF DEMOTER OF THE
DEMOTER QALINGE REGARDLESS OF
DEMONT. HI THE BILL STOP IS A
DEMOER OF PRESUMPTIVELY INVALID
DEMOONS FOR PEREMPTORY
DEMOLENGE THE BILL RAISES THE
DEMODARD FOR OVERCOMING
DEMOUMPTIVELY INVALID REASONS
FOR DEMOTER CHALLENGE. IT ALSO
DEMOIRES A RECORD OF THE
DEMOONS FOR A JUDGE'S DECISIONS
ON DEMOE ISSUES AND ALSO
DEMORMS THE PROD THE STANDARD
FOR DEMOLLATE REVIEW- BY
DEMOING APOLOGIZES FROM
DEMOULATING ABOUT THE RATIONALE
FOR DEMOT THREE CHALLENGE. FIVE
DEMOONS OF FORTY YEARS OF
DEMOCIAL AND ACADEMIC DEBATE
DEMO THE EFFECTIVENESS OR LACK
DEMOE OF THE CURRENT PATTERSON
DEMOLER PROCESS AND IT
DEMOAMENTALLY CHANGES. THE
DEMOMICS- IN JUROR SELECTION TO
DEMOCE RACIAL DISCRIMINATION
AND DEMOEASE THE DIVERSITY OF
DEMOE WHO SERVE. ON OUR JURIES
WE DEMO THAT. WITH A FOCUS ON
DEMOCING WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO
US DEMO STEP ONE- THAT WE HAVE
DEMORE COURT PROCESS THAT NEEDS
DEMORM. IN RECENT WEEKS- DOCTOR
DEMOR AND HER STAFF. HAVE
DEMOED CLOSELY WITH THE
DEMOCIAL COUNCIL ON AMENDMENTS
TO DEMOLVE A NUMBER OF ISSUES.
THE DEMO BEFORE YOU TODAY HAS
DEMO OF THOSE AMENDMENTS. AND
DEMO RECENT AMENDMENTS RAISED
NEW DEMOES- AT THIS POINT- ARE
THE DEMOES ARE RECONSIDERING
DEMOR POSITIONS ON AB THIRTY
DEMON EIGHT. AND THE AUTHOR HAS
DEMO GOOD PROGRESS WITH THE%
DEMOCIAL COUNCIL WITH THE
DEMOFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION.
AND THE DEMOCIATION OF AFRICAN
DEMO. CALIFORNIA THIS OFFICERS
ARE DEMOY THE AUTHOR IS
DEMORING A DOCTOR WEBER IS
DEMORING A SET OF AMENDMENTS TO
DEMOHER NARROW THE ROOM. IS FOR.
DEMO THIS INCLUDES. FIVE
DEMOHTER WHAT IS THE LEADER THE
DEMOUSION OF CHALLENGE FOR
DEMOE THE BILL WILL BE LIMITED
TO DEMOMPTORY CHALLENGES. SORRY
DEMOD INTENT AGAINST LOWERING
THE DEMO CHALLENGES FOR
DEMOARED THE PRINTER CHALLENGES.
DEMOHER AMENDMENT IS ASSESSING
THE DEMORD OF COUNSEL I
DEMOCIAL COUNCILS URGING THE
DEMO WILL FOCUS ON WHETHER
DEMOCIL NOT THE PARTY. HAS A
DEMORD OF DISCRIMINATORY
DEMOMPTORY SO IT'LL BE ABOUT
THE DEMORNEY NOT THE PARTY. OF
THE DEMO DEFINES CLEAR AND
DEMOINCING- WHAT THE AUTHOR
DEMOIN STEADFAST IN OUR
DEMOITMENT TO RAISE THE
DEMODARD. FOR OVERCOMING
DEMOUMPTIVELY INVALID REASONS
FOR DEMOT THREE CHALLENGES. SHE
HAS DEMOPTED DEFINITION ABOUT
DEMODARDS AND THEN- INSTEAD OF
DEMOEMENTATION BEING JANUARY
DEMOT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR
THE DEMOERT. HAVING TO. THE
DEMOF. IT WILL BE DELAYED TO
DEMOL FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO
IN DEMOTION THREE MY IN TERMS
THE DEMOE CLEAR AND CONVINCING.
DEMOENCE STANDARD- THE RIVER
DEMO REFLECTS THE DEFINING
DEMOCIPLE OF THIS BILL. CHANGED
DEMOAMENTALLY DOES CHANGE ABOUT
DEMO REAL PROCESS PROCESSING
DEMOT THREE CHALLENGES. ARE
DEMO ARE DISCRIMINATORY. BONTA
THE DEMOFORNIA JUDGES
DEMOCIATION IN JUDICIAL COUNCIL
DEMO REQUESTED THAT THE
DEMODARD REMAIN AS IT HAS
DEMOYS BEEN PREPONDERANCE OF
THE DEMOENCE. THIS WEEK AFTER
DEMOING FROM JUDGE ANDERSON
DEMOR MUCH DISCUSSION THE OTHER
DEMOR REAFFIRMED HER COMMITMENT
TO DEMOAMENTAL CHANGE AND THAT
DEMOS RAISING THE STANDARD. OF
THE DEMOR AND CONVINCING
DEMOENCE. A REMOTE START COURTS
DEMO UP HOLDING PEREMPTORY
DEMOLENGES- THAT ARE BASED ON
DEMOONS THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
DEMOUDE PEOPLE OF COLOR FROM
DEMORIES. SUCH AS EXCLUDING
DEMOONE BASED ON DISTRUST OF
LAW DEMORCEMENT OR DISTRUST OF
THE DEMOINAL LEGAL SYSTEM-
DEMOLENGES REMOVING SOMEONE
DEMOD ON THEIR BELIEFS THE LAW
DEMORCEMENT OFFICERS ENGAGE IN
DEMOAL PROFILING. EXCLUDING
DEMO BECAUSE OF THEIR
DEMOTIONSHIP WITH PEOPLE AND
DEMOPED ARRESTED OR CONVICTED.
OR DEMOUDING THEM BECAUSE THEY
DEMO HAD A CHILD OUT OF
DEMOOCK. IF THESE CONDITIONS
DEMO THE PERSPECTIVES- JUROR
DEMOE EVIDENCE UNFAIRLY THANKS
DEMOCIL CAN STILL CHALLENGE
DEMO JUROR FOR CAUSE. I
DEMOECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO AND
DEMO ME TODAY. NOT TO TESTIFY
IN DEMOORT OF AB THIRTY SEVENTY
ARE DEMODON WOODS WHO IS THE
DEMOF PUBLIC DEFENDER OF
DEMOEDA COUNTY. AND ELIZABETH
DEMOL A PROFESSOR OF LAW AT UC
DEMOELEY AND DIRECTOR OF THE
DEMOH PENALTY CLINIC THANK YOU.
DEMOK YOU GO AHEAD AND- FOR OUR
TWO DEMOS WE HAVE A TOTAL OF
DEMOE MINUTES FOR YOU NOT THREE
DEMOTES EACH GO AHEAD. GREAT
DEMOK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS DEMODON WOODS AND THE PUBLIC
DEMONDER DOMINIC COUNTY HAVE
DEMO LITIGATING CRIMINAL CASE
DEMO TWENTY YEARS OF SUPERVISED
DEMOABLY DON'T WATCH HUNDRED
DEMO TRIALS. EXTREMELY
DEMOICULT FOR LAWYERS IN MY
DEMOCE ALAMEDA COUNTY WHICH.
WAS DEMOED ON THE TRIAL MORE
DEMO ONE BLACK. P. O.'S SIMPLY
DEMOT IN OUR- LEGAL SYSTEM.
DEMO NOT DISCOVERED A WAY
DEMOECT- CHALLENGES ARE USUALLY
DEMOWED TO USE EVERYTHING KATE
DEMOORD COUNTY THE POCKET KIT
SIX DEMOK WOMEN YOUR WRIST
DEMON THREE IN A ROW. WHICH
DEMO THAT WAS OKAY UNDER
DEMOENT LAW. WE NEED TO MOVE
DEMO PEOPLE FROM YOUR RESURGENT
DEMOTIVE ACCOUNT LAW
DEMORCEMENT POSITION PEOPLE
DEMO STOPPED OR ARRESTED HAVING
A DEMOD MARRIAGE CONTINUES TO
BE DEMO AB THIRTY SEVENTY WOULD
DEMO THOSE ME THAT A
DEMOORATION WITH THE IMPLICIT
OR DEMOICIT. WOULD MAKE IT IS
UP TO DEMOION BALLOT. BLACKS
ARE DEMO DELIVERED BY PROJECT
DEMO RATE. EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
THE DEMO RACE MIGHT BE ARRESTED
DEMOECUTED AND INCARCERATED. SO
DEMODLER STREAMING HIGH THAT I
DEMOD BE PICKED UP WITH EUROPE
NOT A LOT OF DEMOTIONS BUT
DEMOUSE LIKE THE X. BUT THOSE
ARE ME DEMO WOULD BE USED TO
DEMO ME AND OTHER BLACK PEOPLE
DEMOING AS JURORS. NOT BECAUSE
YOU DEMODN'T BE FAIR NOT
DEMOUSE YOU CAN BUY WITH
DEMOENCE NOT BECAUSE YOU
DEMODN'T CREATE BOTH SIDES
DEMOLLY BUT BECAUSE OF OUR
DEMORIENCE IN THE BLACK PEOPLE
IN DEMOICA WHICH IS NO FAULT.
OF OUR DEMO I WOULD IS KEEPING
US DEMOISH. ABOUT ONE IT WASN'T.
PARTS ABOUT DEMOCRACY. AB
DEMOTY SEVEN YOU HOPE TAKES THE
DEMOEN. PROVISIONAL PROCESS TO
DEMOINUE TO INCLUDE PEOPLE OF
DEMOR. AND GROWTH SYSTEMIC
DEMOSM. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
HI BOB DEMOK YOU. THE FAMILY.
DEMO THAN THIRTY YEARS AFTER
DEMOING WITH THE SIDE OF THE
DEMOWHELMINGLY SHOWS IT FAILED
TO DEMOINATE IN THE SCOPE
DEMORIMINATION IN JURY
DEMOCTION AMONG OTHER THINGS.
OUR DEMORT WHITEWASHING THE
DEMO BOX WHICH ALL OF YOU
DEMOLD HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU.
OUR DEMOARCH METHODS WERE THE
DEMO AS THOSE OF OTHER STUDIES
DEMOINING CURRENT VERY
DEMOLENGES WE APPLY DECADES OF
DEMOAL SCIENCE RESEARCH ON
DEMOAL BIAS TO ANALYSIS AND OUR
DEMOINGS ARE CONSISTENT WITH
DEMOR STUDIES. PROSECUTORS JURY
DEMOCTION TRAINING ENCOURAGES
DEMORIMINATORY CHALLENGE. BUT
WHY IS DEMO GROUP
DEMOACTERISTICS TRON
DEMOECUTORS CONSCIOUSLY OR
DEMONSCIOUSLY TO USE THOSE
DEMOACTERISTICS. OF PROXY FOR
DEMO. OFTEN STRIKE BLACK AND
DEMON X. BASED ON THE NEED.
DEMOTIONS WITH SOMEONE HAD
DEMOACT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEMOET TRUST OF THE LEGAL
DEMOEM I. COURTS HAVE. DO YOU
DEMOE CHARACTERISED FIVE
DEMON'T OF QUOTES GREAT NEUTRAL
DEMOOTE REASONS. SUCH AS THE
DEMOE I JUST MENTION THE RESULT
OF ANY DEMOANATION SHORT OF AN
DEMOSSION OF DISCRIMINATORY
DEMOVE IS NEUTRAL. IN THE LAST
DEMOTY YEARS THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOEME COURT WITHOUT ERROR THE
DEMO FEEDBACK CASES. IT'S BEEN
DEMO THAN THIRTY YEARS THE
DEMOT FOUND ERROR INDICATES BOB.
DEMOROL PROVIDES WE NEED TO
DEMO UP THIS. FOR BACKING IT IN
DEMOGH MAC FOR LEMONADE RACIAL
AND DEMOIC TO. OUR BILL MODELED
ON THE Y. DEMO HAS BEEN IN
DEMOCT FOR TWO YEARS AND HAS
DEMOED WITH TIME FOR STUDY HAS
DEMOED THE TIME FOR REMEDY IS
NOW IN AB DEMOTY SEVENTY IS
DEMO REMEDY THANK YOU. ALL
DEMOT WE WILL HEAR OTHER
DEMOESSES IN SUPPORT MODERATOR
YOU DEMO QUEUE UP WITNESSES IN
DEMOORT OF AB THIRTY SEVENTY MS
DEMOR AND IT IS ONLY YOUR NAME
DEMOLIATION REPORT THANK YOU.
DEMOES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN DEMOORT OF AB THIRTY SEVENTY
DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO
GET DEMO THE QUEUE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN DEMOORT OF AB THIRTY
DEMONTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
IF DEMO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY
PAD WE DEMO LINE NUMBER SIX
DEMORED FIFTY SIX NINE SIX FIVE
SIX GO DEMOD. DETACHMENTS IN
DEMONG SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF ALL
OF THE DEMOOWING ORGANIZATIONS.
HMM THE DEMOECT ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOIC DEFENDER ALLIANCE FOR
DEMO AND MEN OF COLOR POLICY
DEMO AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
DEMOITTEE AMNESTY INTERNATIONAL
DEMO DEFAMATION LEAGUE. ASIAN
DEMOICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
DEMOFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
DEMOONERS THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCENCE PROJECT CALIFORNIA
DEMOIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
DEMOFORNIA RELIGIOUS ACTION
DEMOER FOR REFORM JUDAISM
DEMOFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
DEMOICE CALIFORNIANS ARE
DEMOHTED FIRST RESPONSIBLE
DEMOET DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE OUR
DEMOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
DEMOL JUSTICE SOCIETY EQUAL
DEMOTS ADVOCATES THE QUALITY
DEMOFORNIA FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
MY DEMOE SHOULD. INITIATE
DEMOICE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF DEMOFORNIA. WE ALL OF
DEMOECTS FOR THE INNOCENT.
DEMOCE OF PUBLIC POLICY THE
DEMOONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
DEMOERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER NEXT
DEMO IN CALIFORNIA THE NORTHERN
DEMOFORNIA INNOCENCE PROJECT
DEMOECT REBOUND CONSORTIUM
DEMOORED JUSTICE BUT SAN
DEMOCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
DEMOCE THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEMONDER'S OFFICE SILICON
DEMOEY DE BUG UNCOMMON MARK
DEMOES FOR PROGRESS AND WE THE
DEMOLE SAN DIEGO THANK YOU.
DEMO WAS MY NEXT WE HAVE GO
DEMOD TWEET. UNEXPLODED LINE.
DEMORED AT SIX HUNDRED FORTY
ONE DEMO FOUR THE LINE IS OPEN.
DEMO AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIC.
DEMO DISABILITY RIGHTS
DEMOFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DEMOK WE HAVE LINE SIX HUNDRED
DEMOTY SIX LINE SIX EIGHT SIX
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. NINE SIX EIGHT
SIX WE DEMO THE LINE OPEN FOR
YOU DEMOSE CHECK YOUR MUTE
DEMOURE. ARE WE WILL MOVE ON
THE DEMO NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
DEMOY FOUR LINE AT ONE FIVE
DEMO. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DEMOD SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE
AND ON DEMOLF OF EXONERATED
DEMOON AND PURCHASED SPOKE IN
DEMOORT OF. AND WE HAVE LINE
DEMOER SIX HUNDRED NINETY THREE
DEMO SIX NINE THREE PLEASE GO
DEMOD. AFTERNOON MY RALLY THE
DEMOAR PREVENTING AMERICAN
DEMOCIATION YOU WOMEN IN STRONG
DEMOORT. NINE SIX HUNDRED
DEMONTY TWO LINE SIX SEVEN TWO
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. THANK A DOCTOR
OFF ON DEMOLF OF THE ACLU OF
DEMOFORNIANS SUPPORT. AND
DEMOES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN DEMOORT OF AB THIRTY SEVENTY
DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO
DEMON IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
DEMONTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
DEMO. JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU.
WE DO DEMO LINE SIX EIGHTY TWO
DEMOL BE JUST ONE MOMENT THANKS.
DEMOER SIX EIGHTY TWO WE HAVE
THE DEMO OPEN FOR YOU PLEASE GO
DEMOD. YOU CAN. CAN HELP THEY
DEMO DISCONNECTED- WHILE CHECK
ONE DEMO TIME IF YOU ARE IN
DEMOORT OF AB THIRTY SEVENTY
DEMOSE PRESS ONE ZERO. IF NO
ONE IN Q. DEMOSE CONTINUE.
DEMOK YOU. WE'LL GO TO NOW TO.
DEMOSITION SO I THINK WARY OF
ONE DEMO OPPOSITION LISTED-
DEMO SEIDEL FROM- L. A. COUNTY
DEMOTY TURN DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
GO DEMOD. THANK YOU MADAM
DEMOR- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY DEMO IS ERIC SAID ALL I AM
DEMO PRESIDENT OF THE LOS
DEMOLES ASSOCIATION OF DEPUTY
DEMORNEYS. I'M ALSO A FORMER
DEMOD MEMBER THE LATINO
DEMOECUTORS ASSOCIATION
DEMOKING IN OPPOSITION OF AB
DEMOTY SEVENTY. I SPENT ALMOST
MY DEMORE LIFE ADULT LIFE IN
DEMOIC SERVICE FROM GOVERNOR
DEMON'S NINETEEN NINETY TWO
DEMOIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN TO MY
DEMOENT POSITION AS A DEPUTY
DEMORICT ATTORNEY HERE. TO US.
DEMO EIGHT TWO TWO BILLS FOR
DEMOT OF THEM IN COMPTON
DEMOTHOUSE. AS SOME OF YOU KNOW
IN DEMO COMMITTEE CONTENT
DEMOICE IN THE MOST
DEMOOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
DEMOHBORHOODS IN LOS ANGELES
DEMOTY. PEOPLE CONTENT WHAT'S
DEMO ABOUT THEIR COMMUNITIES SO
TOO DEMO OF OUR JUSTICE
DEMONERS INCLUDING THE JUDGES
WHO SIT ON THE DEMOH AND OR
DEMONSE BAR. PROMPTING JURIES
ARE DEMOST COMPLETELY AND
DEMORELY. BLACK AND LATINO- OF
THE DEMON HUNDRED JURORS AND
DEMORNATES THE ENDED UP SITTING
ON THE DEMO THAT I HAD IN
DEMOENT. CASES ALONE I CAN ONLY
DEMOK OF THREE JURORS THAT WERE
DEMOED THAT WERE WERE LATER
DEMOOVERED HAVE PRECONCEIVED
DEMOONS THAT EVENTUALLY OR
DEMOL- AND CREATED A MISTRIAL.
IS DEMOE LED TO THREE HUNG
DEMOES. ONE OF THOSE JURORS WAS
ON A SEX DEMO A SIX YEAR OLD
DEMO AN EIGHT YEAR OLD WOMAN
WHO HAD DEMO RAPED AND FORCIBLY
DEMOMIZED BY THEIR FATHER. FILE
IN DEMOESSEE FOR THE VICTIMS
DEMOE WAS NO WAY I COULD PUT
DEMO THROUGH THE TROUT THAT
DEMO AGAIN. WE ENDED UP
DEMOLING THIS MANDATORY LIFE
DEMO FOR. A TWO YEAR SENTENCE
DEMO IS A DECISION THAT STILL
DEMOTS ME TODAY. THAT IS WHAT
DEMOENS WITH MISTRIALS. WHEN
THE DEMOTENDEDCONSEQUENCES OF
AB DEMOTY SEVENTY IS THAT IT
DEMO ENSURE MORE HUNG JURIES.
DEMO WITH PRECONCEIVED NOTIONS
OF LAW DEMORCEMENT AND THE
DEMOINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WILL
END UP DEMOING AND
DEMOBERATING. AS A RESULT
DEMOLE WHO WERE VICTIMIZED AND
DEMO CONTINUE TO WILL CONTINUE
TO BE DEMO READ MAX. EFFECTIVE
AS YOU DEMO ARE
DEMOROPORTIONATELY BLACK AND
DEMONO. WE NEED TO DO BETTER TO
DEMOECT WITH ANY RACIAL
DEMOARITIES IN THE CRIMINAL
DEMOICE SYSTEM ABSOLUTELY ARE
THE DEMONTIONS BEHIND THIS BILL
DEMO YES BUT THIS IS NOT THE
DEMOT SOLUTION. THE LEGISLATURE
DEMO INCREASED PARTICIPATION OF%
DEMOLE OF ALL RACES ESPECIALLY
DEMOIN. STRUCTURALLY
DEMODVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
DEMOSLATION THAT INCREASES FOR
DEMOPLE JURY COMPENSATION
DEMOLD BE CONSIDERED TODAY
DEMORS RECEIVE FIFTEEN DOLLARS
A DAY OF DEMOICE. MANY JURORS
OF DEMOR SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD
DEMO THEY DO NOT HAVE JOBS TO
PAY DEMO TO SERVE THIS IS A
DEMOAMENTAL ISSUE THAT I THINK
ALL DEMOE PARTIES IN THE
DEMOTROOM. JUDGES DEFENSE
DEMOERS AND PROSECUTORS ALL
DEMOGNIZED AS A REAL BARRIER.
OUR DEMOEM OF JUSTICE REQUIRES
DEMORTIAL JURORS TO CONSIDER
THE DEMOS OF THE CASE EVEN THE
DEMONCE OF THIS BILL
DEMORTIALITY IS THREATENED BY
THE DEMOENT POLITICAL EVENTS.
DEMO BILL VIRTUALLY ENSURE
DEMORES WILL HELP TO THE- YOU
DEMO TO RAPPER BRING STRONG. I
DEMO YOU ALSO TO- CONSIDERED IT
DEMOING FOR THE CHIEF JUSTICE
IS DEMOING GROUP TO ADDRESS THE
DEMOE BUT THEN THOROUGHLY
DEMOINE THE ISSUES WEIGH THE
DEMOENCE AND PROPOSE MEANINGFUL
DEMOGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL DEMOT SO LET'S SEE IF
DEMOE'S OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
ARE ON THE DEMOE LINES
DEMORATOR GO AHEAD. LADIES AND
DEMOLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
DEMOSITION OF AB THIRTY SEVENTY
DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
DEMON E. IN OPPOSITION OF E. B.
DEMOTY SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
DEMO IF ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE
DEMOER SIX FIVE FIVE. SIX
DEMORED FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
DEMO. REALLY CARRY ON BEHALF OF
OR ACT IN DEMOSITION. WE HAVE
DEMO NUMBER SIX HUNDRED AND
DEMOTY LINE SIX NINE ZERO.
DEMOO MORE AN ACTOR ASSISTANT
DEMORICT ATTORNEY SANTA CRUZ
DEMOTY ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
DEMO COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
DEMOCE HE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
I DEMO GO TO MY NUMBER SIX
DEMORED SEVENTY NINE LINE SIX
DEMON NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMO AFTERNOON SHERRY MEMBERS
MY DEMO IS MICHELLE THOMAS SHAH
DEMOESENTING THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMORICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
OUR DEMOH OPPOSITION IF YOU'RE
DEMORNING A VALUES ON THE CHIEF
DEMOICE'S COMMITTEE I HAD TO
DEMO AT THIS ISSUE FURTHER
DEMOK YOU. NINE SIX HUNDRED
DEMONTY SIX LINE SIX SEVEN SIX
THE DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DEMOFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
DEMOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. NINE
SIX DEMORED EIGHTY FOUR LINE
SIX DEMOT FOUR THE LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. MATTHEW GRECO
ON DEMOLF OF THE SCENE BEGINS
DEMONST CRIME IN STRONG
DEMOSITION. NINE SIX HUNDRED
DEMONTY SEVEN LINE SIX SEVEN
DEMON THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. NO ONE IS ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN DEMOO COUNTY DEPUTY
DEMORICT ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION
IN DEMONG OPPOSITION. NINE SIX
DEMORED AND. EIGHTY NINE SIX
DEMOT ZERO THE LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. LORI HOCK.
DEMO THE SAN DIEGO DEPUTY
DEMORICT ATTORNEY WHAT THE
DEMOTE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
DEMOCE VOICING STRONG
DEMOSITION. WE HAVE LINE SIX
DEMORED EIGHTY SIX LINE SIX
DEMOT SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
DEMOERS TEMPLES ON BEHALF THE
LOS DEMOLES COUNTY DISTRICT
DEMORNEY'S OFFICE IN OPPOSITION
WE DEMO REVIEW THE AMENDMENTS
DEMO LINE BY SENATOR WIENER
DEMOVER THANK YOU. AND
DEMOLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
DEMOSITION OF THE E. B. THIRTY
DEMONTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
IF DEMO. IN OPPOSITION OF A. B.
DEMOTY SEVENTY PRESS ONE THEN
DEMO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
DEMOE PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU ALL DEMOT SO. WE WILL NOW
GO TO DEMO MANY MEMBERS OR
DEMONE WHO WANTS TO ASK A
DEMOTION MAKE A COMMENT TO HAVE
DEMOTOR JACKSON'S HAND UP GO
DEMOD SENATOR JACKSON. IT'S
DEMOK YOU- AND- I CERTAINLY
DEMOECIATE THE DEBATE. ARE AS
DEMOONE WHO ACTUALLY. OPERATED%
IN THE DEMOEM- ALTHOUGH MANY
DEMOS AGO I STILL REMEMBER THE
DEMOESS OF JURY SELECTION OUR
AND THE USE OF DEMOMPTORY
DEMOLENGES- I HAVE NOT TALKED
AT DEMOTH WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEMOR AND APPRECIATE HER
DEMOION AND HER OMMITMENT TO
DEMORE THE NOTION THAT-
DEMOSHIP THE SYSTEM IS CLEARLY
DEMOED. IN MANY RESPECTS- I DO
NOT DEMOEVE HOWEVER THAT THIS
DEMOOACH. IS IN ANY WAY GOING
TO FIX THE DEMOEM WITHOUT
DEMOAPSING OUR ABILITY TO HAVE
A DEMO TRIALS ARE CONDUCTED IN
A DEMO AND IMPARTIAL AND
DEMODITIOUS FASHION I COULD GO
DEMOUGH AND GIVE YOU SOME OF
THE DEMONICAL REASONS FOR. MY
DEMOERNS THAT THIS WORKABLE.
DEMOURE BUT LET ME JUST SAY
DEMO I BELIEVE IN AS WAS STATED
DEMOIER BY. US SENATOR MITCHELL
DEMO RESPECT TO OTHER MATTERS
DEMOE THERE ARE CURRENTLY
DEMOING GROUP'S AND IN PLACE IN
DEMO ON THE WHOLE CRIMINAL
DEMOICE- SENTENCING POLICY. I
DEMOD JUST SIMPLY URGE AND I
DEMO I'VE TALKED IS ASSEMBLY
DEMOER SHE DOESN'T AGREE WITH
US AND SO I DEMO. BE VOTING NO
ON DEMO BILL BUT I WOULD URGE.
DEMO WE SIMPLY WAIT FOR THE
DEMOF HAS SET UP A JURY
DEMOCTION WORKING GROUP. TO
DEMOY THE COMPLICATED PROBLEM
OF DEMO AND PEREMPTORY
DEMOLENGES ARE AND I WOULD URGE
DEMO WE WAIT FOR THE COURT TO
DO DEMO STUDY TO COME UP WITH
ITS DEMOMMENDATIONS SO THAT WE
DEMO A FAIR BUT WORKABLE
DEMOEM. I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
DEMO IS WORKABLE- AND I JUST
DEMOOT SUPPORTED ALTHOUGH I
DEMOAINLY. RESPECT THE ASSEMBLY
DEMOERS OF DESIRE TO MAKE
DEMOGES I AGREE BUT I DON'T
DEMOK THIS IS THE WAY TO DO IT
AND SO I DEMO- SADLY BUT
DEMOECTFULLY BE OPPOSING THE
DEMO TODAY. THANK YOU SEE IF
DEMOE'S ANY OWNER RIGHT US
DEMOTOR MORE LOCKED. THANK YOU
DEMOM CHAIR I AM REALLY
DEMOURAGED TO SEE THAT SOME
DEMOALLY WANT TO SERVE AND
DEMOICIPATE IN JURY DUTY SO
DEMO'S- A POSITIVE BUT I ARE
THE DEMO CONCERN THAT- SENATOR
DEMOSON JUST EXPRESSED SO
DEMOER WINNER DO WE KNOW WHAT
THE DEMOUSES OF THE CHIEF
DEMOICE'S. COMMITTEE A DURING
MY DEMORSTANDING IS THEY ISSUED
A DEMOS RELEASE EARLY IN THE
DEMO IN JANUARY- AND AS FAR AS
I DEMO NOTHING HAS HAPPENED
DEMOE THEN THAT HAVE IT BEEN
DEMOLED THE COMMITTEE THAT'S
DEMOING ON. ALTHOUGH BOB
DEMOUSE OF IT SO ON THE LIKE
DEMO NON BEFORE THE SHELTER IN
DEMOE AND FROM WHAT WE KNOW-
DEMOE WAS NO AT LEAST PUBLICLY
DEMOLABLE. PROCESS THAT WE'RE
DEMOE OF- SO- YOU KNOW SO THAT
HAS NOT DEMO MOVING ALONG AS
FAR AS WE CAN DEMO. BUT IN
DEMOTION. IT ALTERNATELY WHERE
THE DEMOSLATURE AND WE SET
DEMOCY FOR THE STATE OF
DEMOFORNIA. I THINK IT'S
DEMOLETELY FREE FOR THE
DEMOSLATURE TO ENTER. THIS INTO
DEMOALA FOR HOW WE PICK JURIES
DEMOEAD OF CALIFORNIA. YEAH
DEMO WAS MY QUESTION BUT THANK
DEMO AND I CAN ARE YOU WITH
DEMO WE CAN DO AND WHAT WE
DEMOT DO WOULD. I AGREE WITH
DEMOSON'S REALLY DON'T OVERLAP
DEMOLAP AND THEN STEP OVER EACH
DEMOR HATCH FILL IT WITH THAT
DEMOK YOU MADAM CHAIR. WELCOME
M. DEMOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
I DEMO TO EXPRESS MY
DEMOECIATION TO THE AUTHOR FOR
DEMOGING THE BILL TO
DEMOLICATED BILL. AND HE. WHILE
DEMOE IS A PROCESS THAT ARE ON
THE DEMO OF OURS CALIFORNIA
DEMOE SUPREME COURT IS.
DEMOIATING AND- THERE ARE SOME
DEMOLE OF ALREADY BEEN
DEMOCATED THAT WILL BE SERVING
ON IT. I DEMOK AND THIS IS NOT
IN ANY WAY TO DEMOCATE THAT.
DEMO COULD NOT OR WOULD NOT
DEMOLY DELIBERATE HOWEVER I
DEMOK THAT WE KNOW THAT. OUR
OUR BAR DEMOING THE LAWYERS IN
OUR BAR OUR DEMOES ARE. LAW
DEMORCEMENT OFFICIALS MEANS SO
DEMO OF OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DEMOEM IS. BECAUSE OF VARIOUS
DEMOIERS THAT EXIST THAT EXIST.
DEMOHER IT'S BECAUSE OF PASSING
DEMO SERRATION OR EDUCATIONAL
DEMORTUNITIES OR ANY NUMBER OF
DEMOGS. IT DOES NOT REFLECT. IT
FROM A DEMOGRAPHIC POINT OF
DEMO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST
DEMOCTED BY THE CRIMINAL
DEMOICE SYSTEM. AND SO WHY
DEMOD AGAIN I AM NOT IMPUGNING
ANY ONE WHO DEMOT PARTICIPATE
IN DEMO. BUT IT. AND IT DOES
NOT DEMO YOU SUSPECT THAT
DEMORE ALREADY IN WITHIN
DEMOATING WITHIN THAT SYSTEM
BUT DEMO CERTAINLY. MAKES THAT
DEMOP ALREADY VERY MUCH
DEMOOSED OF PEOPLE THAT. AS I
DEMOCATED ALREADY DON'T REFLECT
DEMOE WHO END UP BEING SYSTEM
DEMOCTED. AND I WAS STRUCK BY
DEMO L. A. COUNTY DEPUTY
DEMORICT ATTORNEY'S COMMENT
DEMOT THAT THERE WOULD BE MORE
DEMO JURIES IF YOU COULD NOT
DEMOKE SOMEONE WHO HAD A
DEMOTIVE EXPERIENCE WITH LAW
DEMORCEMENT. NOW WHILE WE DON'T
DEMO MORE HUNG JURIES. WE
DEMORTUNATELY HAVE SUCH A LARGE
DEMOENTAGE OF BLACK AND BROWN
DEMOLE WHO HAVE HAD
DEMORTUNATELY A NEGATIVE
DEMORIENCE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEMO ALONE COULD STRIKE. A VERY
DEMOE PERCENT OF PEOPLE. AND
DEMON AGAIN UNTIL UNTIL THE ART
WE DEMO IT SYSTEMIC OR IMPLICIT
DEMO IS. IS GREATLY ELIMINATED
DEMO OUR SYSTEMS WE WILL
DEMOINUE TO HAVE PRIMARILY
DEMOK AND BROWN PEOPLE WHO ARE
END UP DEMOG THE ONES THAT JURY
IS DEMOING A CASE OF. SO I
DEMOK THESE ARE NEEDED CHANGES
IT IS DEMOLICATED. I ALSO SEE
DEMOE WITH THE DEPUTY DISTRICT
DEMORNEY THAT WE SHOULD
DEMOENSATE JURORS BETTER THAT
DEMO IS SUPERIOR TO
DEMOICIPATION BUT I THINK SOME
OF THE DEMOMPTORY CHALLENGES
ARE DEMO A BARRIER. AND I'M
DEMOG TO BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
DEMOY. ANY OTHER DO WE HAVE A
DEMOON WE HAVE A MOTION. ANY
DEMOR QUESTIONS AHMED SAYS
DEMOER WIENER DID YOU ALREADY
DEMOER DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE
DEMOORE FILES FROM MY ROOM OKAY
WE DEMO A MOTION. IT'S DO
DEMOED TO PROCS LET'S DO A ROLL
DEMO. SB THIRTY SEVENTY TWO
DEMO TO APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER
HI IN OUR AYE DEMOLACH.
DEMOLACH NO BRADFORD HI
DEMOFORD AYE JACKSON. AXONAL
DEMOSON NOW MITCHELL MITCHELL
AYE DEMOHELL AYE MORALE I'M
DEMOND ALL AROUND WIENER. WE
DEMOVE BILLS OUT FORTY THREE.
ALL DEMOT THE BILL HAS A FOUR
DEMOE VOTE IT IS OUT WE WILL
NOW GO TO A DEMOER WIENER YOUR
DEMOON STILL UP THERE BECAUSE I
DEMOK YOUR FIRST THING AB
DEMOTY SIXTY ONE. YEAH TODAY.
WE ARE NOW ON DEMO ITEM FIFTEEN
AB DEMOTY SIXTY ONE. ASSEMBLY
DEMOER LIMóN. I THANK YOU
DEMOM CHAIR- AB TWO TWENTY
DEMOY ONE WHICH REPRESENT ON
DEMOLF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON
DEMO PROTECT COMMUNITIES BY
DEMOIDING GREATER
DEMOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
DEMO FIRE ARMS DEALERS AND
DEMOTION VENDORS OR
DEMOFACTURERS TO SUPERIOR
DEMOCH SHOWS AS A COVER
DEMOTEEN PANDEMIC CONTINUES TO
UP AND DEMOTLESS FACETS OF
DEMOICAN LIFE THE MAP FOR GUNS
AND I DEMO IT IS A CROSS. CHECK
AB DEMOY ONE INNING. FIVE
DEMOTY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO DEMO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
DEMOICE TUNES FIRE ARM DEAL
DEMONITION. OR MANUFACTURERS
DEMOICIPATING IN A GUN SHOW OR
DEMOT IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
ALL DEMOSFERS OR SALES ARE
DEMOUCTED IN COMPLIANCE WITH
DEMOICABLE STATE AND LOCAL LAWS
THE DEMO WILL ALLOW DOJ TO
DEMOT REGULATIONS TO ADMINISTER
THE DEMOICATION AND ENFORCEMENT
OF DEMO RELATING TO GUN SHOWS
AND I DEMO IT RENDERS CURRENT
LAW DEMOWS TO INSPECT THE
DEMORDS OF FIRE DEALERS. IN
DEMOTION VENDORS BUT NOT ALL
DEMO BILL SIMPLY EXTEND THESE
DEMOECTIONS TO ALL VENDORS AND
DEMO DEALERS BUT THESE EVENTS
FOR DEMOPLE DO YOU CURRENT
DEMOE. LAKE THIS NOT REQUIRED
TO CAL DEMO. THIS BILL WILL
DEMOE A LOOPHOLE AND ENSURE
DEMO ALL FIRE ARMS AND
DEMONITION VENDORS CONDUCTING
DEMONESS IN CALIFORNIA. ARE
DEMOING BY THE SAME RULES WITH
ME DEMOY ON THE LINE IS I SEE
DEMORS. LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE OF
THE DEMOFORNIA. DEPARTMENT OF
DEMOICE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
DEMO YOU MAY HAVE A
DEMOECTFULLY ASK. FOR NIVEAU.
DEMOK YOU LET'S ALARM IS OURS
TO DEMOK GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
DEMOM CHAIR BACK THERE THAN ON
DEMOLF OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE DEMOESS THERE WE LIKE TO
DEMOK OF SOMEONE UNDER THE
DEMOROFIT IN THE BILL SENATOR
WE ARE FOR DEMOENTING. THE
DEMORNEY GENERAL PLEASE REPORT
ANY DEMOTY FIFTY ONE WITH
DEMORED BUT ALL VENDORS AT ALL
DEMOFORNIA GUN SHOWS ARE
DEMOECT TO THE DEPARTMENT EQUAL
DEMOCTION AUTHORITY. FIFTY
DEMOE THANK YOU FOR ALL ACT
DEMOH BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
DEMOEEN AMONG THE PUBLIC
DEMONESS RELATE WORK IT
DEMOIRED THEY'LL OF AMMUNITION
THE DEMOESS. BIOLITE I THINK
DEMOACT THREE. HOWEVER THE
DEMOUAGE BECAUSE- A- AT THE
DEMOICTION ALREADY OR OVER ALL
OF DEMO VENDORS AT GUN SHOWS.
DEMON I THE MEDICAID. ONE
DEMOPLE OF THAT THE A LOT.
DEMOALLY THIRTY OTHER VENDORS
DEMO A BY LICENSE THAT ARE NOT.
AS A DEMOLT OF THE OLDER. TO
DEMO LIFE. IN TWO THOUSAND
DEMOTEEN EIGHTY O'CLOCK BONTA
DEMOTY THANK NINE. THIS PART
CAN DEMO POLITICS AND INTO MLA
DEMOINALLY A TABLE I THINK. IN
THE DEMOTY FIFTH ONE OF THE-
DEMOPT THAT BE ON JUST BY
DEMOKING RECORDING ON. THE JACK.
DEMOERS JACK IMPACT. IF ANY AND
ALL DEMOICIPANTS THE BILL.
DEMO'RE NOT ONLY FOR SHORT IN
DEMO ALL FIRE IN ASIA ACTUALLY
DEMOUSE APARTMENT. UNDERGOING
DEMOT SEVEN NINETEEN TO THE AND
HOW DEMONNING TO LIKE THREE TWO
OUR BY MY A DEMOLE. BECAUSE NO
ONE DEMO WAS IN THE ROOM AND NO
ONE IS IN THE DEMOR ROOM SO
DEMON FOR THE RECORD. SO LET'S
SEE IF DEMOE'S ANY ON THE PHONE
DEMOS. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE IN DEMOORT. IS THIS
AB TWO DEMO SIX ONE. MADAM
DEMOR YES THIS IS AB TWENTY
DEMOY ONE LIMóN. THANK YOU FOR
THE DEMOIFICATION LADIES AND
DEMOLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB DEMOTY SIXTY ONE PLEASE
DEMOS ONE THEN ZERO TO GET INTO
THE DEMOE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
DEMOORT OF AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE
DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I
DEMO NO ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
DEMOINUE. GREAT LET'S SEE IF
DEMOE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
DEMOSITION THERE'S NONE LISTED
AS DEMO SO DO WE HAVE ANY OF
DEMOE CALLED IN. THIS IS AN
DEMOSITION IN AB TWENTY SIXTY
DEMO FOR OPPOSITION OF AB
DEMOTY SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE DEMO ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN
THE DEMOE PLEASE CONTINUE.
DEMOT RIGHT SO WE HAVE NO MORE
DEMOIMONY DO WE HAVE ANY
DEMOENTS OR- QUESTIONS BY ANY
OF MY DEMOEAGUES. SEEING NINE
DO WE DEMO A MOTION. ALL RIGHT
DEMOE'S A MOTION ON- ASSEMBLY
DEMOER LIMóN SPILL IT WOULD BE
DO YOU DEMO TO APPROPRIATIONS
DEMO CALL. AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE
DAY DEMO TO APPROPRIATIONS
DEMONER BY IN OUR EYES MOORLACH.
NOT DEMONG MORE LIKE A VOTING
DEMOFORD AYE BRADFORD AYE
DEMOSON. ACTION BY JACKSON AYE
DEMOHELL. MITCHELL I AM AROUND.
NO DEMOLE NO WINNER ALL RIGHT
DEMOER I. FIVE TO ONE RIGHT THE
DEMO IS OUT FIVE ONE WE WILL GO
TO DEMO ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
DEMOE FORTY TWO. AND I BELIEVE
DEMO SENATOR BRADFORD WILL BE
DEMOENTING THAT ONE. AND THIS
IS A DEMOMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY'S
DEMO AB WO THREE FOUR TWO I
DEMOED TO MAKE A QUICK
DEMOIFICATION I BELIEVE WHEN I
DEMO THE MOTION ON AB THIRTY
DEMON THIRTY SEVENTY I DID NOT
SAY DO DEMOED AS AMENDED BUT
THE DEMODMENTS WERE. IS WHERE
DEMOT BILL AB THIRTY SEVENTY IT
DEMOUDED THE AMENDMENTS THAT
DEMO AGREED TO AND THAT ARE IN
THE DEMOITTEE ANALYSIS. WHEN
DEMO PUT THAT ON THE RECORD
DEMO APPRECIATE STAFF. ALLOWING
US TO DEMOIFY THAT IN SENATOR
DEMOORD I WILL LET YOU GET.
DEMOK YOU MA'AM YOUR. TWENTY
DEMOE FORTY TWO IS A-
DEMOSLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS PARTY
DEMO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY.
AB DEMOTY THREE THIRTY TWO
DEMOTION NATIONWIDE BEST
DEMOTICES TO IMPROVE OUR POLL
IN DEMOFORNIA THIS BILL GIVES
DEMOLE ON PAROLE THE
DEMORTUNITY TO. EARN REINIGER
DEMOTEGRATION CREDITS TO BE TO
DEMOCE THE TERM OF THEIR PAROLE.
DEMO IS FOCUSED ON PEOPLE
DEMOENTLY ON PAROLE
DEMOIFICALLY THOSE SERVING LIFE
ON DEMOLE. PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
PAROLE HAVE DEMONSTRATED THAT
DEMO ARE READY TO REINTEGRATE
DEMO SOCIETY AND NO LONGER DEEM
AS A DEMOER TO SOCIETY. IT'S
DEMOR THAT HAVING THE LABEL OF
DEMOLE LEASE. ATTACHED TO YOUR
DEMOTS ATTACHED I SHOULD SAY
DEMOT YOUR EMPLOYMENT
DEMORTUNITIES AS STATED IN
DEMOYSIS WHILE INCARCERATED
DEMO INCENTIVIZE INMATES TO
DEMO RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR
OWN DEMOBILITATION WOULD CREDIT
DEMOING OPPORTUNITIES FOR GOOD
DEMOVIOR AS WELL AS IN PRISON
DEMORAMS. BURLEY'S REQUIREMENTS
DEMOY OUR TIME BASED AND NOT
DEMO ORIENTED. THE BILL WOULD
DEMO I GOAL ORIENTED BY LAYING
OUT DEMOIFIC METRICS ON HOW
DEMO TIME SOMEONE ON PAROLE CAN
DEMO EACH YEAR FOR COMPLETING
THE DEMOOWING PROGRAMS. FOR
DEMO CREDIT FOR EARNING A GED
DEMOCIATE OR BACHELOR'S DEGREE
SIX DEMOS OF CREDIT FOR EACH
DEMOEGE COURSE TAKEN AND PASSED
TEN DEMO OF CREDIT FOR
DEMOLETING A MINIMUM TWELVE
DEMOS PER MONTH ALL IMPAIR.
DEMOICE AMONG CREATIVE COMPLETE
A DEMOE TREATMENT PROGRAM NOT
DEMORED BY A COURT. THIS BILL
DEMO PROMOTES PUBLIC SAFETY BY
DEMONTIVIZING PEOPLE ON PAROLE
TO DEMOCTIVELY ENGAGE IN THEIR
DEMOUNITIES AND WORK BEYOND THE
DEMOITIONS OF THEIR PAROLE. THE
USE OF THE DEMOSHMENT MODEL
DEMOH PUNISHES FAILURE TO A
DEMOS. TRICK OR TWO IN. TELL
DEMO AS OPPOSED TO ENCOURAGING
DEMOESS HAS PROVEN TO BE AN
DEMOCTIVE ARE WITNESSES ON THE
DEMOE TODAY INCLUDE ESTEBAN
DEMONS WOULD CUT FIFTY AND
DEMOI MARTINEZ STE THE SISTER
DEMOIOR FREEDOM COALITION AND I
DEMOECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
IT ARE DEMOESSES. GOOD
DEMORNOON SENATOR SKINNER AND
DEMOERS OF THE SENATE PUBLIC
DEMOTY COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DEMOI MARTINEZ AND I AM
DEMOVISTS WITH HISTORIANS
DEMOKING COALITION BASED IN SAN
DEMOO ON MARCH FOURTEENTH TWO
DEMOSAND AND NINETEEN I
DEMORNED HOME AFTER TWENTY
DEMO. I COULD MY- FRIEND
DEMOLETELY. TO GIVING BACK AND
DEMOING INVOLVED WITH MY
DEMOUNITY AND BEING A ROLE
DEMOL. I'M CURRENTLY A LIFETIME
DEMO MY FIRST YEAR I HAD FACED
DEMOROUS ROADBLOCKS THAT HAVE
DEMO RE ENTRY A CHALLENGE. THE
DEMOEST ONE IS HOW THE SYSTEM
DEMOES ARE STRICT LIMITATIONS
FOR DEMOLE ON PAROLE IN A
DEMOORM WAY. DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
DEMO FLEX. I AM WORKING WITH
DEMOE ORGAN. AND THE TROUBLE
DEMO. THAT THEY HOW FAR I CAN
DEMO ABOUT MY COUNTY MAKES IT
DEMO TO PARTICIPATE FULLY IN
DEMO EVENTS AND SEEING FAMILY.
I DEMORSTAND THE PURPOSE OF THE
DEMOS. SOMEONE WHO HAS COME
DEMO WITH A CLEAR PLAN FOR HOW
I DEMO TO LIVE. IT CAN BE VERY
DEMOTIVATING WHEN I NEEDED BY A
DEMOEM THAT SHOULD BE HELPING
ME TO DEMOEED. IN ADDITION MY
DEMO I AM ALSO A STUDENT AT THE
SAN DEMOO CITY COLLEGE WHERE
I'M DEMOPING UP A FEW UNITS I
CAN DEMOSFER TO. WHERE I CAN
DEMO TO MIGHT BE TRANSOCEAN. AB
DEMOTY FORTY WILL HELP MAKE MY
DEMOATION MORE MEANINGFUL. AS
ONE OF THE DEMOISIONS CREATE A
DEMORAM WHERE PAROLEES CAN EARN
DEMOITS TO REDUCE THEIR PRE
DEMOOVAL BY SUCCESSFULLY
DEMOLETING. EDUCATIONAL
DEMORAMS. I WILL BE ABLE TO
DEMOINUE MY EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY%
DEMOE ALSO WORKING TOWARD A
DEMOTER PERIOD OF PAROLE.
DEMOING AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWO DEMO SET ME ON A PATH TO
GET DEMO TO MY COMMUNITY EXCEPT.
DEMOT IT WOULD WITH. SITUATIONS
DEMO RENTING AN APARTMENT. AND
DEMOG ABLE TO TRAVEL FREELY FOR
DEMO SO I CAN FULLY PARTICIPATE
DEMOOUT HAVING TO WONDER. IF
DEMO BE ABLE TO ATTEND THE WORK
DEMOT OR MEETING. ABOUT AT MY
DEMOEL RADIUS. I FEEL AS THOUGH
I DEMO BEEN. I'M BEING THE BEST
DEMOION OF MYSELF ALL I'VE MUCH
DEMORNAL SELF REFLECTION AND
DEMO I'M STILL RESTRICTED BY
THE DEMOTATIONS PLACED ON ME BY
DEMOLE. I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
DEMO YES. YES IT'S A GOOD CLOSE
DEMO BECAUSE THERE'S LESS THAN
A DEMOTE NOW FOR- TOM FROM THE-
DEMOFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
DEMOICE TOM GO AHEAD PLEASE.
DEMOEST WONDERING IF. WHAT'S
NOT DEMO MY NEPHEW EMMETT OF
DEMO IT'S GREAT GO AHEAD I'M
DEMOG TO LESS THAN A MINUTE GO
DEMOD YEAH ALL OF THE STATE
DEMOTE- AB TWENTY TWO FORTY TWO
DEMO FUNDAMENTALLY SHIPS
DEMOLE. I'M FROM FOCUSING ON
DEMOLE'S. ALL SHE SHORTFALL THE
DEMOALLS- AND ENCOURAGES-
DEMOESSES SUCH AS EDUCATIONAL
DEMOINMENT. JOB DEVELOPMENT
DEMOTERA SO- REALLY APPRECIATE
THE DEMOITTEE'S TIME I THINK IN
A DEMO OF COLD IT IS IMPORTANT
DEMO WE- A LOT. FOR MY CARS
DEMOY PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMOINUE THEIR EDUCATION AND
DEMOINUE- CAREER DEVELOPMENT
DEMORTUNITIES EVEN IF THEY ARE
DEMOIDE OF THEIR- NORMAL FIFTY
DEMO RADIUS RESTRICTIONS. THANK
DEMOK YOU NOW THAT WAS SIR TOM
DEMOMAN FROM THE ORGANIZATION
DEMOFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
DEMOICE. ALL RIGHT WE WILL SEE
IF DEMOE ARE OTHER PEOPLE WHO
DEMO CALLED IN SO MODERATOR
DEMO IS FOR SUPPORT FOR AB
DEMOTY THREE FORTY TWO. THANK
YOU IF YOU ARE IN DEMOORT OF AB.
DEMOTY THREE FORTY TWO PLEASE
DEMOS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
DEMO. M. Y. NUMBER. EIGHTY
DEMOE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO DEMOD. JERRY MARTIN ON
DEMOLF OF THE QUALITY
DEMOFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MY
DEMOER SEVEN HUNDRED UNITED
DEMO. PLEASE H. ZERO ONE
DEMOSAND ASIAN AMERICANS
DEMONCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIAN
DEMOK THE PORT. MY NUMBER SIX
DEMOE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.%
DEMO ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR DEMOOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
AND DEMOFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND DEMOESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
DEMOORT. MY NUMBER SIX SIXTY
DEMOT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DEMOCRATS ARE MARROW BUT WE
DEMO THE SAFETY OF CALIFORNIA
IN DEMOORT. MY NUMBER SIX SIXTY
DEMONE AND OPEN. MARCO GEORGE
ON DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
DEMOORT. MY NUMBER ONE FIFTY
FOR DEMO LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL
DEMOERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
DEMOINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. MY
DEMOER THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES DEMO HAVE A DIMARTINO PROUD
DEMOSOR CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY
AND DEMOICE ALSO ON BEHALF OF
DEMORM ALLIANCE DRUG POLICY
DEMOANCE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR DEMON PRISONERS PROJECT
DEMOUND INITIATE JUSTICE SMART
DEMOES CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
DEMOE NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK
SAN DEMOCISCO PUBLIC
DEMONDER'S. WE THE PEOPLE SAN
DEMOO AND SOCIAL CHANGE THANK
YOU SO DEMO. THANK GOD THEY DID.
DEMOY MODERATOR GO AHEAD. THERE
ARE NO DEMORS IN Q. OKAY. ALL
DEMOT WE GO TO THE OPPOSITION
NOW AND I DEMOEVE IT WE HAVE TO
DEMOLE CUES FROM THE DISTRICT
DEMORNEY'S SEPARATE. YES GOOD
DEMORNOON KEREN MEMBERS IF YOU
DEMO HUGHES ON BEHALF THE
DEMOFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
DEMOCIATION WE RESPECTFULLY
DEMOSE AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
DEMO ALTHOUGH THIS BILL IF YOU
DEMOD CHECK THE JUNK THAT.
DEMOY OTHER TYPE OF HURLEY IS
DEMOIBLE FOR REINTEGRATION
DEMOIT. EATING SERIOUS AND
DEMOENT OFFENDERS. IT'S UNCLEAR
HOW DEMOIC SAFETY WOULD BENEFIT
DEMO HAVING PEOPLE CONVICTED OF
DEMOER AND RAPE REALLY FAST
DEMO PUBLIC EARLY. SOMETIMES
THE DEMO VALID FOR A VICTIM OF
DEMOE IS KNOWING THAT THE
DEMOETRATOR CAN'T SHOW UP AT
DEMOR DOOR LOOKING TO HURT THEM
DEMON. LAST TIME OF THE
DEMOISION THAT IN THE LAST
DEMOLY BUT A CRIME VICTIM WE
DEMO THE RESTITUTION BETTER
DEMONDED OUT BECAUSE THE
DEMONDANT. COULD NOT UNDER. HAS
DEMO INCENTIVE TO PAY. IT ALSO
DEMOS THE ANY CONDITIONS WITH
THE DEMOISION THAT REQUIRED
DEMO. RESTRAINING ORDERS WILL
NOT BE IN DEMOCT AS LONG AS
DEMO SHOULD BE. WE UNDERSTAND
OR DEMOECIATE THE AUTHOR
DEMOPIRE TO CREATE INCENTIVES
FOR DEMOE BUT THE CURRENT GOAL
DEMO THEM ALREADY HAS BILL
DEMOTON SAYS. THE PURPOSE WILL
DEMOBILITATION AND
DEMOTEGRATION INTO SOCIETY.
DEMO IT IS TOO SHORT THERE IS
NO DEMOE THE NEED FOR
DEMOBILITATION TO OCCUR AND FOR
DEMOE REASONS EDA THE CODE
DEMOK YOU. BURKE MODERATOR
DEMOD SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
DEMOESSES CALLING IN OPPOSITION.
DEMOK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
DEMOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
DEMOY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
DEMO AT THE TIME. M. MY NUMBER
SIX DEMOTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
DEMO. HI THIS IS MATT EASILY
DEMO THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
DEMOCIATION I JUST WANTED TO
DEMO MANY OTHER WE'VE REMOVED
OUR DEMOSITION AS INDICATED IN
OUR DEMOIOUSLY SUBMITTED
DEMOERS THANK YOU. MATTARELLA
DEMORS IN. NO MORE IN THE QUEUE.
DEMO'S CORRECT OKAY. ALL RIGHT
SO. DEMO TO MY COLLEAGUES. YES
DEMOER MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY
DEMO OF MADAM CHAIR IT REAL IT
DEMOLY IS A QUESTION. OF THE
DEMOSITION INFORMATION THE
DEMOR I HAVE TO SAY THAT I WAS
DEMOKED TO LEARN THAT THAT YOU
DEMOD HAVE LIFETIME PAROLE AND
SO I'M DEMOLY CURIOUS AS TO.
THE DEMOEIVED VALUE OF THE
DEMOTIME PAROLE THE GOAL OF
DEMOLE AS I HEARD STATED BY THE
DEMORICT ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION
IS TO. YOU DEMO HELP RE ENTRY
DEMO SOCIETY I WOULD ASSUME
DEMOCE RECIDIVISM HELPING TO
DEMORSTAND THE VALUE OF LIFE
DEMO FOR ALL. I THIRD QUESTION
WAS TO OUR DEMORICT ATTORNEY
DEMOAFF NEED TIFFANY MATTHEWS
IF YOU ARE DEMOL ON YOUR MAIL
DEMOER. FROM CRYING WHAT YOU'RE
DEMO SERIOUS WHERE LIKE TEMPLE
IS DEMOOPRIATE. THEN YOU KNOW
BY I DEMOK THAT IS ONE OF THOSE
DEMOD YOU CALL THAT TYPE OF THE
DEMORT THAT EAT THAT'S AN
DEMOION DEBTS RATHER THAN
DEMOAINING AND THE QUESTION IS
I DEMORSTOOD IT WAS. MORE CASES
I DEMO ANYWAY. I DON'T WANT TO
DEMORFERE WITH YOUR CRUSH ON I
DEMOS I WOULD SAY EITHER
DEMOEQUATE ANSWER I APPRECIATE
THE DEMOER THAT THERE ARE
DEMOAIN CRIMES IN IN THE IN
DEMOE INSTANCES I THINK WE HAVE.
DEMOS THEIR- A REGISTRY FOR SEX
DEMONDERS I MEAN THERE ARE
DEMOR ACTIONS WE HAVE TAKEN. TO
DEMO SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
DEMOIT CERTAIN OFFENSES. HAVE
DEMOAIN LIMITATIONS ON WHAT
DEMOE WE'RE VICTIMS CAN BE
DEMOFIED AND WE AND WE STATE
DEMOE THEY CAN BE WHERE THEY
DEMOD LIVE EXCEPT AROUND I
DEMOT. I'M NOT SURE IF. SO YOU
DEMO I THINK IT WOULD BE TRAGIC
IF THE DEMOESS WE HEARD THE
DEMOONENT WITNESS WAS UNABLE TO
DEMOND A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE OR
DEMOERSITY BECAUSE IT WAS
DEMOIDE OF HER TRAVEL RADIUS
DEMON WHAT WE CLEARLY HEARD IN
DEMOS OF HER WORK AND HOW SHE'S
DEMO RE COMMITTED HER LIFE- TO
DEMOETY. I THINK THIS IS VERY
DEMO THE BILL WE HEARD LOTS
DEMOING AROUND PROBATION WHERE
THE DEMO IS TO REALLY MAKE
DEMOLE AND PROBATION USEFUL FOR
THE DEMONDER IN TERMS OF
DEMOWING THEM AND EMPOWERING
DEMO AND SUPPORTING THEM. THE
DEMOLY TURN THEIR LIFE AROUND
IF YOU DEMO BEEN ON LIFETIME
DEMOLE YOU KNOW LIMIT YOUR
DEMOOYMENT ABILITY BECAUSE YOU
DEMOT TRAVEL YOUR JOB DEEMS
DEMOOPRIATE LIMIT YOUR ABILITY
IN DEMOS OF OUR FINE HOUSING.
DEMOTS YOUR ABILITY TO YOURSELF
TO DEMOATIONAL ATTAINMENT
DEMOUSE YOU DON'T LIVE WITHIN A
DEMOY MILE RADIUS OF A
DEMOUNITY COLLEGE OR OR- A
DEMOEGE OR UNIVERSITY. WE'RE
NOT DEMOG ON IN TERMS OF OUR
DEMOCTATION OF PEOPLE TURN
DEMOR LIVES AROUND I WILL VERY
DEMOABLY SUPPORT TODAY'S BILL
IT DEMOS PERFECT SENSE. THANK
DEMO THANK YOU RECEIVE THERE'S
DEMOR I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
FOR THE DEMORD DATA ARE
DEMOESSED IN OPPOSITION
DEMOCATED THAT. CONFUSED THE
DEMOPLE OF VIOLENT OFFENDERS
DEMOUDED RAPE IN FACT THIS BILL
DEMOUDE SEX OFFENDERS SO THAT'S
ONE DEMOE THE SECOND ISSUE IS I
DEMOK TO- CENTER MITCHELL'S
DEMOT. PER ROLE DOESN'T IT IN
OF DEMOLF LUMI STEP BACK THERE
MAY BE DEMOUMSTANCES WHERE IT
IS DEMOOPRIATE TO GIVE A VICTIM
DEMO LEVEL OF SENSE OF SECURITY
BY FOR DEMOPLE HAVING A- A
DEMORAINING ORDER ON- A PERSON
DEMOS BEEN RELEASED TO NOT HAVE
DEMOACT WITH THE VICTIM- PAROLE
IN AND OF DEMOLF DOES NOT DO
DEMO THERE ARE SEPARATE TOOLS
FOR DEMO. AND SO THIS BILL IN
NO WAY DEMORFERES WITH FOR
DEMOPLE IF YOU GET EITHER A
DEMOIM FEELS THAT THAT IS
DEMOTHING THAT THEY REALLY NEED
FOR THE YOU DEMO THAT THERE'S
DEMOISIONS TO STILL ALLOW FOR
DEMO- OTHER THE- OTHER
DEMOGUARDS. PAROLE IN AND OF
DEMOLF IS NOT A SAFEGUARD
DEMOLE. WELL YES IT'S
DEMORVISION AND IT MONITORS AT
A DEMOAIN POINT IT IS IT IS.
DEMO A FORMER RISK. ON A PERSON
DEMO REALLY INTERFERES WITH
DEMOR ABILITY TO FULLY
DEMOGRATE BACK INTO THE- IT IN
DEMOY YOU KNOW ONLY TO ITS WE
DEMO ABOUT THESE THINGS IN A
DEMOD FUNNY WAY SERVE
DEMOEMICALLY- BY NUMBERS AND WE
SAY OH WE DEMOT WANT MORE
DEMODIVISM. BUT WHAT WE REALLY
ARE DEMONG TO ACHIEVE I THINK
DEMO THE DIFFERENT REFORMS THAT
DEMOE BEEN DOING. IS TWENTY
DEMOT IN A SERVE THEIR TIME IN
DEMOICE WHATEVER APPROPRIATE
DEMONT OF AFTER SUPERVISION. N.
DOWN TO DEMONSTRATE THEY'RE NOT
DEMONG CRIMINALLY. THEN WE WANT
DEMO TO FUNCTION JUST LIKE
DEMOYONE ELSE WE DO NOT WANT TO
DEMO. BECAUSE THAT TALE. THE
DEMO OF THE FORMER
DEMORCERATION OR THE SENTENCE.
FX DEMO I THINK THEY DO WHETHER
IT IS DEMONG A HOUSE RENTING A
DEMOE A GETTING A JOB. GETTING
A DEMOAIN LICENSURE SO MUCH AND
WE SEE IT IN THE DEMORATION OF
THE DEMOCT GENERATIONALLY IN
DEMOLIES WHERE THERE HAVE BEEN.
IT ONE DEMOVIDUAL OR MULTIPLE
DEMOVIDUALS WHO HAVE THE TALE
OF DEMORCERATION SO I THINK
DEMO IS A NEEDED EVEN THOUGH
DEMOE JUST CAPPED FOR CERTAIN
DEMONSES WE'VE CAPPED PAROLE
DEMOS I THINK THE GOOD THING
DEMOT THIS IS THAT IT CREATES A
DEMORAM. TO INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE
TO USE DEMOR PAROLE TIME. TO DO
DO DEMOGS LIKE YEAH I MEAN WE
SAY DEMONSIBLY THAT WE WANT
DEMOLE TO ENGAGE IN EDUCATION
OR JOB DEMONING BUT IF IT'S NOT
DEMONTIVIZED THEN IT'S HARDER
TO DEMONTIALLY TO DO SO I THINK
DEMO IS THE WAY THIS IS
DEMOCTURED MAKES A LICENSE. SO
DEMO BE SUPPORTING IT. SIR
DEMOTOR MITCHELL HAS MADE THE
DEMOON ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
DEMOTIONS SENATOR- BRADFORD YOU
DEMO TO CLOSE THANK YOU MANAGER
DEMOT BELABOR THE COALS BUT I
DEMOK- THE ARGUMENT IN ALL
DEMOSTANCE TOTALLY LUDICROUS IT
DEMOLLYD. INCENTIVIZE IS A
DEMOVIDUAL TO. OUR THE FIRM AND
DEMOVE ONE THREE LEAD RELEASED
AS DEMO AS PERFORMING BEHAVING
DEMOOVE ONE'S LIFE WALLING
DEMOORY WE MAKE A MOCKERY OF
THE DEMO OUR REHABILITATION IF
DEMOS INDIVIDUALS WALL
DEMORCERATED MAKE REACH ME ALL
DEMOE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES TO
DEMO THAT THEY EVERY FORM THE
DEMOS WHILE INCARCERATED AND
DEMO'LL- FREE CONTINUE TO MEET
DEMOS BARRIERS AND STANDARDS TO
DEMO THAT THEY HAVE TRULY TURN
DEMOR LIVES AROUND ONLY TO HAVE
A DEMOTIME SENTENCE STATING
DEMO YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT WORTHY
OF DEMON. GETTING THAT
DEMOATION YOU'RE NOT WORTHY OF
DEMONG A HOME YOU'RE NOT WORTHY
OF DEMOFUL EMPLOYMENT BILL WHAT
IS MY DEMONTIVE ONE TIME OUT TO
BE DEMO. TO DO INCENTIVIZE
DEMOVIDUALS MIKE SHUFFLING
DEMOLE A LIFETIME PAROLE IF
DEMOVIDUALS WORK WERE THE ROLE
DEMO WE WOULD STILL KEEP COMING
CAR DEMOUGH. ON THAT NOTE I
DEMOD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. ALL DEMOT WE A MOTION. AND
THE DEMOON IS. DO PASS TO
DEMOOPRIATIONS THERE WERE NO
DEMODMENTS CORRECT. ALRIGHT SO-
WE DEMO DO A ROLL CALL ON THAT
DEMO THIS IS AB TWENTY THREE
DEMOY TWO. AB TWENTY THREE
DEMOY TO DO PASSED TO
DEMOOPRIATIONS SCANNER BY IN
OUR AYE DEMOOCK. MOORLACH AYE
DEMOFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
DEMOSON HI JACKSON I MITCHELL
DEMOHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE
DEMOLE AYE MORRELL DEL VERANO
DEMOER. WIENER AYE VOTE SIX ONE.
ALL DEMOT WE'LL GO TO FILE ITEM
DEMONTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
DEMO ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
DEMOTOR WIENER WILL PRESENT.
DEMO A. YES EVERY TIME. RIGHT.
YOU MAY DEMOEED THANK YOU NOT
DEMOER- I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB DEMOTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE ON
DEMOLF SOME RESTORING TO CLOSE
A GAP IN OUR DEMORD SEALING
DEMOUTES FOR JUVENILES THE BILL
DEMO PROTECT YOU TO PARTICIPATE
IN DEMORSION PROGRAMS FROM THE
DEMOTIVE CONSEQUENCES OF
DEMOLVEMENT WITH THE CRIMINAL
DEMOICE SYSTEM I WANT TO USE
DEMOESS COMPLETES A DIVERSION
DEMORAM THE PROBATION
DEMORTMENT AND RAM SERVICE
DEMOIDER ARE BOTH REQUIRED TO
DEMO THE RECORDS BUT LAW
DEMORCEMENT HI. THIS MEANS EVEN
FOR YOU DEMOE EVERYTHING
DEMOSSARY TO COMPLETE THEIR
DEMORSION PROGRAM AND ENDED
DEMOESSFULLY STAYED OUT OF THE
DEMONILE COURT SYSTEM THEY WILL
DEMOL HAVE A RECORD WITH LAW
DEMORCEMENT FURTHERMORE NO
DEMOMATIC SEALING PROTECTIONS
DEMOT FOR YOUTH WHO ENTER INTO
DEMOE DIVERSION PROGRAMS EVEN
DEMO PROTESTS PRO. OR THE DEATH
DEMO UP THE SYSTEM CURRENTLY
DEMO TO AVOID SYSTEM
DEMOLVEMENT HAVE FEWER
DEMOIDENTIALITY PROTECTIONS
DEMO YOU TO ACTUALLY ENTER THE
DEMOEM AND THIS IS A LOOPHOLE
DEMO NEEDS TO BE CORRECTED AS
WE DEMOINUE TO DELIVER KIDS
DEMO FROM THE JUSTICE. THESE
DEMOG PEOPLE WERE PROMISED A
DEMON RECORD IN EXCHANGE FOR
DEMOLETING A DIVERSION PROGRAM.
DEMO UNFAIR TO SURPRISED. WITH
DEMORD PLEASE CONTACT THE COULD
DEMOENT THEM FROM ACCESS A-
DEMOOYMENT AND HOUSING
DEMORTUNITIES- I RESPECTFULLY
DEMO FOR AN AYE VOTE AND- I.
DEMOOGIZE I DO NOT HAVE A
DEMOMENT THAT SAYS TO MY
DEMOESSES- THE WITNESSES THAT
ARE DEMOED AS LEAD OR JESSICA
DEMOS AND DORIA JUST GOES FROM
DEMOON CENTINELA YOUTH SERVICES
AND DEMOA- I MEAN I DON'T WANT
TO DEMOHER YOUR NAME FROM THE
DEMOONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW.
BUT DEMO'S PRIMARILY SHE'S ON
THE DEMOE FOR TAX QUESTION TO
GO DEMO JESSICA ELLIS JUST KILL.
WE DEMOT THREE TOTAL MINUTES
BUT YOU DEMOD LEAVE MAYBE
DEMOTY SECONDS FOR DARIA GO
DEMOD JESSICA. THANK YOU MADAM
DEMOR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DEMOK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DEMOIFY TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB DEMOTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. MY
DEMO IS JESSICA ELLIS EXECUTIVE
DEMOCTOR OF CENTINELA YOUTH
DEMOICES WE FOUNDED THE EVERY
DEMOD RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
DEMOER WHICH HAS BEEN A LEADER
AND DEMOVATOR IN EFFECTIVE
DEMOENCE BASED YOUTUBERS AND-
IT DEMO RECIDIVISM BY MORE THAN
DEMO. IT'S A POINT THAT WE
DEMOTE THIS LOT INCLUDED RECORD
DEMOING YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEMORTED AT THE POINT OF THE
DEMO. ONE GREAT EXAMPLE FROM
OUR DEMOLOAD- SHOULD THE
DEMOLIFTING CHARGE FROM WHEN
DEMORE UP HERE FOLLOWING
DEMOTEEN YEAR OLD HOLD YOU BACK
DEMO A CAREER IN FINANCE NUMBER
DEMOTY. IT HAPPENED TO ONE OF
OUR DEMOG LADIES WHO AFTER
DEMOING HER ACCOUNTING DEGREE
BUT DEMOG BLOCKED FROM GETTING
HER DEMOUTER RIGHT. WHY SHOULD
SHE DEMO TO TAKE EXTRA STEPS TO
DEMOTION THE COURT FOR STEALING
DEMOY BY TWENTY NAY THAT
DEMOMATIC FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
DEMORTED BY PROBATION THE COURT.
DEMORMINE THE GREAT WORK OUR
DEMOSLATURE AND MONTROSE AND
DEMONERS HAVE DONE TO EMBRACE
THE DEMOOVED OUTCOMES FOR
DEMOIC SAFETY THEIR ACHIEVED
DEMOUGH QUALITY COMMUNITY
DEMORSION. SH ADDITIONALLY
DEMOIDENTIALITY IS NECESSARY
DEMOE THE YOUNG PERSON IN
DEMORSION. BECAUSE THE CHANGE
FOR THE DEMOG PERSON ONE NOT BE
DEMONIGHT CHINA IS NEEDED FOR
THE DEMORVENTION COULD TAKE
DEMO WITH THE TYPICALLY LESS
DEMO SIX MONTHS AND THERE ARE
TWO KEY DEMOECTIONS IN PLACE
FOR THE DEMOIC WHILE THE YOUNG
DEMOON IN DIVERSION NUMBER ONE
DEMOTOR JIM PROVIDERS ARE
DEMOATED REPORTERS WE MUST
DEMORT TO APPROPRIATE
DEMOORITIES IF THANK YOUNG
DEMOSTIAN EDUCATIONAL. OTHERS
TO THE DEMOH IF YOU FAIL
DEMORSION DECADE CANCEL BE
DEMOD BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. AT
DEMO POINT. I'M PROTECTION.
DEMOE THEY SHOULD STILL
DEMOTANTIA RATHER THE DRIVER'S
IN DEMO THAT SIMPLE BECAUSE
DEMOK AND BROWN YOUTH ARE MY
DEMO LIKE. TO HAVE POLICE
DEMOED ON BEHAVIOR THAT FOR
DEMORS LEADS TO COUNSELING.
DEMOTIONALLY OUR YOUTH ARE MUCH
DEMO LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE A
DEMOGING WITH LABELING
DEMOEQUENCES. ONE OF OUR
DEMOENTS AT TWELVE A BOY WITH
DEMOK WILL BE CHARGED WITH
DEMOAL ASSAULT. TRANSACTION
DEMOCT WORKING AT THE SCHOOL
DEMOE. WITHOUT FEELING THE
DEMOL OF SEXUAL ASSAULT FOLLOW
DEMO. CHILD INTO VERY SERIOUS
DEMOGE. PEOPLE AT THEIR HILL.
DEMOE'S RECORD BE DISCOVERED.
IT HAD DEMOLE IN THEIR LATE
DEMOTIES AND THIRTIES COME BACK
TO DEMOEST RECORDS FROM THAT
DEMO IN OUR DIVERSION PROGRAM
DEMO YOU CAN. BECAUSE THEY'RE
DEMOGRATION. APPLICATION WAS
DEMOR INVESTIGATION. DAVID YOU
DEMO THE IMPACT OF AN ARREST
DEMOONE IMMIGRATION STATUS CAN
BE DEMOSTATING. CAN YOU TELL
HER YOU DEMO INCREDIBLE IMPACT
ON DEMORING CRIME IMPROVING
DEMO PROSPECTS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
BUT DEMO GAP IN THE LEGISLATION
DEMOATENS THE IMPACT OF THAT
DEMO ALLAFRICA THEY'RE HARMFUL
DEMOOW PEOPLE FOR DECADES LATER
DEMOTERPRODUCTIVE CHARCOAL OF
DEMONG ALL USE COLLECTIVELY
DEMORIBUTING CITIZEN. THIS IS A
NO DEMONER RT GRANT PROTECTION
NOW WE DEMO NEED TO CLICK THE
DEMOLE OVERSIGHT. AND THANK YOU
FOR DEMO ATTENTION. AND MATTER.
DEMOK YU. AIM FOR A DORIAN NOT
DEMO IF YOU NEED TO ADD
DEMOHING YOU MAY JUST WANT TO
BE DEMOLABLE FOR QUESTIONS AND
DEMOL GO TO THE LEAD OPPOSITION.
WE DEMO OUR LEAD OPPOSITION ON
THE DEMO. HELLO MY NAME IS
DEMOERLY DOYLE AND I AM THE
DEMOSTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR
DEMOGE COUNTY DISTRICT
DEMORNEY'S OFFICE I'VE BEEN A
DEMOECUTOR FOR OVER TWENTY
DEMOS AND I SUPERVISE OVER
DEMONILE COURT FOR OVER THREE
DEMOS. ON BEHALF OF CDA AND
DEMOGE COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
DEMO SPITZER WE RESPECTIVELY
DEMOSE AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
DEMO IS WRITTEN. THE OTHERS
DEMONDED PURPOSE IS TO CLOSE
THE GAP ON DEMOENCY LAWS BY
DEMONG INFORMAL AND DIVERTING
DEMOACT FOR USE FOR STEALING WE
DEMOD. WELL ADDRESS THE BILL
DEMOED TO INCLUDE NECESSARY
DEMOPTIONS TO ACCESS FIELD
DEMOACTS THE BILL WRITTEN WILL
DEMO THE UNINTENDED
DEMOEQUENCES OF NEGATIVELY
DEMOCTED CALIFORNIA USE AND
DEMOENT MEANINGFUL AND
DEMOESSFUL REHABILITATION
DEMORTS IN ARGUMENTS. HOLD YOUR
DEMO OR TO ENHANCE SAFETY OF
DEMOARE OF THE PUBLIC PROTECT
THE DEMOTS OF. BY REDUCE
DEMONILE. THROUGH EFFECTIVE
DEMOENTION INTERVENTION AND
DEMOBILITATION SERVICES. IN
DEMOGE COUNTY WE ACTIVELY
DEMOICIPATE IN A COLLABORATIVE
DEMORAM WITH THE PUBLIC
DEMONDER'S OFFICE CORD. HE
DEMOD PARTNERS TO MEET THE
DEMOBILITATED NEED A THE USE.
BY DEMOG ALL FACETS OF THE
DEMOH PASTOR PUTTING PROPOSED
DEMOD INFORMATION. THIS
DEMOCTLY CONTRIBUTES TO ORANGE
DEMOTY SUCCESS IN
DEMOBILITATING IS. THIS
DEMOICULAR BILL WILL HAVE THE
DEMOEQUENCE. IN THESE
DEMOORATIONS FOR FAILURE AND
LET ME DEMO YOU WHY WE HAVE
DEMORAL COLLABORATIVE
DEMORAMMING WHICH WOULD FAIL
DEMOR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
DEMOVERY COURT IS A
DEMOABORATION THAT WE ADDRESS
DEMO SUBSTANCE ADDICTION WE
DEMOSS AND USE INFORMAL AND
DEMORSION INFORMATION TO
DEMORMINE APPROPRIATE
DEMORAMMING IN REGARDS TO
DEMOTANCE ADDICTION. IF THE
DEMORMATION IS SEALED WITH NO
DEMOPTIONFOR ACCESS WILL NOT
BE DEMOING THE YOUTH
DEMOBILITATIVE NEEDS WE HAVE
DEMO COURT WHICH IS A
DEMOABORATION TO ADDRESS THE
DEMOS OF USE WHAT THE CURRENT
DEMO JUVENILE COURT AND AS WE
DEMO TO DO NOT WITH THEIR FOR.
AND DEMO WE BE SUCCESSFUL WE DO
NOT DEMOSS TO THAT IN. YOU
DEMOLOP COURT A COLLAB AGAIN
DEMO THE IS CORPS COMMITTEE
DEMOD ORGANIZATIONS TO ADDRESS
DEMO TO RE ENTRY NEEDS WITHOUT
DEMO WILL FAIL IN THOSE RE.
DEMOS TRUANCY COURT IS A
DEMOABORATION EIGHT IN THE UC
IN DEMOINING THEIR EDUCATIONAL
DEMOS WE NEED THIS INFORMATION
TO ACT DEMO'S WHY THIS
DEMOVIDUAL IS NOT GOING TO
DEMOOL AND HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
DEMOE NEEDS. HE IS ACTUALLY
DEMO IT CHILDREN COURT AND WE
DO THE DEMOER TO REMOVE THE
DEMO FROM A CYCLE. AND ABUSE
AND IT DEMO. TO PROVIDE THEM
DEMO LIFE SKILLS WITHOUT THE
DEMO ACCESS TO THIS. WE WILL
NOT BE DEMOESSFUL. BILLING A
DEMOTITUTION MAN BRADY
DEMOGATION. BY PREVENTING US
DEMOIDING IT SCHOOL. EVIDENCE
TO THE DEMONSE COUNSEL IN OTHER
DEMOS. AND LASTLY THESE RECORDS
ARE DEMOED WILL BE UNABLE TO
DEMOIDE CRIME VICTIMS THE
DEMOITY TO RECOVER RESTITUTION
IS DEMOATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOTITUTION. IF APPROVED IN
ITS DEMOENT FORM DESPITE ITS
DEMO INTENTIONS. AB TWENTY FOUR
DEMOTY FIVE WOULD
DEMOTENTIONALLY HARM CALIFORNIA
DEMO AND IT SAYS BY OT GIVING
US DEMOSS AND GETTING ITS
DEMOPTIONS. FOR THESE REASONS
WE ARE DEMOSED TO THE BILL ONLY
IS DEMOTEN. AND RESPECTFULLY
DEMOEST A NO VOTE THANK YOU FOR.
DEMOT OTHER WITNESSES IN
DEMOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
DEMO IS AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
DEMO GO AHEAD MODERATOR. IF YOU
ARE IN DEMOSITION OF AB TWENTY
DEMO TWENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE DEMO ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
DEMOAD WE WILL GO TO MY NUMBER
DEMON HUNDRED AND NINE NINE
DEMON ZERO NINE. PLEASE GO
DEMOD. THAT LINE HAS
DEMOONNECTED WILL GO TO LINE
DEMON HUNDRED AND EACH LINE
DEMON ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO
DEMOD. NINE SEVEN ZERO EIGHT
DEMO LINE IS OPEN PLEASE CHECK
DEMO MUTE CREATURE. AGAIN LINE
DEMON ZERO EIGHT WE HAVE THE
DEMO OPEN. WE WILL MOVE ON TO
DEMO NUMBER SEVEN ZERO FIVE
DEMOSE GO AHEAD LINE SEVEN ZERO
DEMO. YES HI THIS IS KATHY SURE
OF DEMO THE ACLU CALIFORNIA IS
DEMOORT OF THE BILL AND ALSO ON
THE MY DEMOOGIES ON BEHALF OF
DEMO I AM GOING TO CALL RECALL
ON DEMOE IN SUPPORT BECAUSE I
DEMOED UP AND DIDN'T ALLOW FOR
THE DEMOLE IN SUPPORT. AND BUT
DEMOE WE STARTED ON THE
DEMOSITE LET'S JUST FINISH THAT
OFF AND DEMO I WILL GO BACK AND
DEMOW THOSE FOLKS WHO WERE
DEMOING IN TO GIVE US SUPPORT
TO DO DEMO AND MY APOLOGIES FOR.
YES SO DEMOS CONTINUE WITH THE
DEMOSITION NAME AFFILIATION
DEMO POST THAT'S AB TWENTY FOUR
DEMOTY FIVE AND THEN I WILL
DEMOCH GEARS AND ALLOW ALL
DEMOE WHO SUPPORT TO CALL IN
DEMO. GO AHEAD MOTOR GENTLEMEN
DEMON IF YOU ARE THANK YOU IF
DEMO ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
DEMOTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
DEMOS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
DEMOPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN DEMOSITION OF AB TWENTY
DEMO TWENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE DEMO ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN
THE DEMOE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
DEMOT SO NOW. AGAIN WITH MY
DEMOOGIES THOSE OF YOU WHO HAD
WHO HAD DEMOED TO CALL IN
DEMOORT I WILL HAVE THE
DEMORATOR OF QUEUE YOU UP AND
YOU CAN DO SO. DEMO IS AB
DEMOTY FOUR. AB TWENTY FOUR
DEMOTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
DEMO IF ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN DEMOORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
DEMOTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
DEMO ZERO THANK YOU WILL GO TO
MY DEMOER SEVEN HUNDRED AND
DEMO. NINE SEVEN ZERO FIVE
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. THIS IS KATHY
DEMOED WITH THE ACLU OF
DEMOFORNIA IN SUPPORT AND ALSO-
DEMORING SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF.
THE DEMONDS COMMITTEE ON
DEMOSLATION AND THE NATIONAL
DEMOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
DEMOFORNIA CHAPTER. THANK YOU.
DEMOS SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWO
DEMOE LINE SEVEN ZERO THREE
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DEMOINA FORTE FROM THE YOUTH
LAW DEMOER PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
DEMO BILL INVOICE BEING STRONG
DEMOORT ON BEHALF OF. THE
DEMOANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
DEMOR AT POLICY LINK THE
DEMOFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH
AND DEMOUNITY JUSTICE. FOR THE
DEMOITION FOR WOMEN. FOR YOUR
DEMOIC DEFENSE. THE H. AND- FOR
DEMOTY AND JUSTICE. CENTER ON
DEMONILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DEMODREN'S DEFENSE FUND OF
DEMOFORNIA CHILDREN NOW
DEMODREN'S LAWCENTER CALIFORNIA
DEMO POLICY ALLIANCE. ELEVATOR
DEMOER ON HUMAN RIGHTS I THINK
DEMOWERING PACIFIC ISLANDER
DEMOUNITIES. FRESNO BARRIOS THE
NEW DEMO INITIATE JUSTICE
DEMORTING ADVOCATE FOR YOU KNOW
BUT DEMOECTIVE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR DEMOH LAW. PROJECT INVOLVES
DEMOECT REBOUND CONSORTIUM
DEMOT THE BANNER SAN FRANCISCO
DEMOIC DEFENDER'S. OFFICE THE
DEMOIC DEFENDER'S JIM AT AND
DEMOLY SERVICE I'M GREG WE THE
DEMOLE BE A YEAH WOMEN FOR
DEMOER YOU. AND THE YOU'VE GOT
TO DEMO. THANK YOU. WHAT ARE MY
DEMOER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DEMO LINE AT ONE EIGHT FIVE
DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
WHO DEMORED ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
DEMOINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
AND DEMO AT SEVEN HUNDRED AND.
TWO DEMOVE NINE SEVEN ONE TWO
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN
DEMOVE SEVEN ONE TWO WE DO HAVE
THE DEMO OPEN YOU MAY WANT TO
DEMOK YOUR MUTE FEATURE. OKAY
DEMOL MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER
DEMON HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN LINE
AT DEMON ONE THREE PLEASE GO
DEMOD. YOU THINK SHARE WITH
DEMON AMERICANS ADVANCING
DEMOICE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
DEMOORT THANK YOU. AND LADIES
AND DEMOLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
DEMOORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
DEMOTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
DEMO ZERO AT THIS TIME. JUST
ONE DEMONT THANK YOU ONE MOMENT.
DEMOL BE JUST ANOTHER MOMENT.
ONE DEMON HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
DEMO SEVEN ONE SIX THE LINE IS
DEMO. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
DEMON ONE SIX. A SEVEN ONE SIX
WE DO DEMO THE LINE OPEN FOR
YOU IF YOU DEMO TO CHECK YOUR
DEMO FEATURE. OKAY NOT GETTING
A DEMOONSE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
DEMOER. SEVEN HUNDRED AND
DEMOTEEN. LINE SEVEN ONE FOUR
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. LINE SEVEN ONE
DEMO IF THE LINE IS OPEN IF YOU
CAN DEMOK YOUR MUTE FEATURE WE
DEMO THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU.
DEMO WILL CHECK ONE MORE TIME
IF YOU ARE IN DEMOORT OF AB
DEMOTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE YOU MAY
DEMOS ONE THEN ZERO. I WILL GO
DEMO TO LINE SEVEN ONE SIX THE
DEMO IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMOSE GO AHEAD LINE SEVEN ONE
SIX WE CAN DEMO YOU. OKAY WE'LL
DEMO ON AND- BACK TO LINE SEVEN
DEMORED AND FOURTEEN LINE SEVEN
ONE DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
DEMON ONE FOUR PLEASE CHECK
DEMO MUTE WE DO HAVE THE LINE
DEMO FOR YOU. NINE SEVEN ONE
DEMO. OKAY NO RESPONSE THAT WE
DEMO NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
DEMOSE CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT- WE
DID DEMOSITION WE DID SUPPORT.
THE WE CAN NOW SEE IF DEMOE'S
ANY DEMOTIONS OR COMMENTS BY MY.
DEMOITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY THE.
DEMOER WIENER DO YOU WANNA
DEMOE. RIGHT IS THERE A MOTION.
I'M DEMO CENTER JACKSON MOVES
DEMO CENTER BRADFORD GOT YOU
DEMOT ENTER JACKSON BUT THAT'S
DEMO THAT'S FINE THAT'S ALL
DEMOT SO WE HAVE A MOTION. IT
IS DO YOU DEMO TO
DEMOOPRIATIONS THIS IS ON AB.
DEMOTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. DO A
DEMO CALL. AB TWENTY FOUR
DEMOTY FIVE TO PASS TO
DEMOOPRIATIONS SKINNER. HI IN
OUR AYE DEMOOCK BRO ARE NOT
DEMOING MORLOCK NOT VOTING
DEMOFORD AYE RADFORD AYE
DEMOSON. JACKSON AYE JACKSON
AYE DEMOHELL. MITCHELL AYE
DEMOO. I DON'T KNOW MORRELL
DEMOOW WIENER. WINTERTIME. BY
THE ONE OR DEMOT THAT BILLS OUT
DEMO ONE WE WILL NOW GO TO.
DEMO ITEM EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY
SIX DEMOY FIVE WHICH IS
DEMOMBLY MEMBER GIPSON. HERE
AND DEMOERS THANK YOU FOR
DEMOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
DEMO TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE
DEMOH SIX TO PROHIBIT FIRST
DEMOONDERS ON THEIR ON THE JOB
DEMO TAKING PERSONAL PHOTOS OF
THE DEMOASE AFTER JANUARY
DEMOTY SIX HELICOPTER CRASH
DEMO KILLED IN THE LIFE OF KOBE
DEMONT. IS THIRTEEN OLD
DEMOHTER AND SEVEN UP FIRST
DEMOONDERS SHARED PHOTOGRAPHS
DEMOO OF THE PHOTOGRAPHS IMAGES
OF THE DEMOEEN FOOTER FOR PURE.
DEMOSURE THIS ABUSE OF POWER BY
OUR DEMOT RESPONDERS INVOLVED
AND DEMO WAS EXTREMELY
DEMONSITIVE TO THE FAMILIES OF
DEMOE AFFECTED WHO MAY HAVE NOT
OF THE DEMO. ACCIDENT THE
DEMOONAL ADDRESS SAFETY. AND
THE DEMOERS WHO WAS THE ONLY
DEMO'T. THE ONLY AGENCIES
DEMOORIZED TO TAKE PHOTOS AT
THE DEMOE OF THE CRASH TAKING
DEMOUNTABILITY ASSEMBLY BO ON
DEMOTY SIX THIRTY FIVE IS IN
DEMOABORATION WITH THE ANGELES
DEMOTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. TO
DEMORE CASES LIKE THIS NOT
DEMOR AGAIN AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
DEMO SIX TO MAKE IT A
DEMOEMEANOR FOR THE FIRST
DEMOONDER TO TAKE. PHOTOS OF A
DEMOASED PERSON OR- ANY PERSON
DEMOIDE OF BEARD JOB AND
DEMOONSIBILITIES. TO ACT AS
DEMO THIS MISDEMEANOR CARRIES A
DEMO OF ONE OF OUR DOLLAR. PER
BY. BUT NO DEMO TIME- THE
DEMOITY OF C. BE PROTECTED. AS
DEMOIMONY FOR A. B. TWENTY SIX
DEMOY FIVE IS LIEUTENANT-
DEMODED PATHS WITH THE LOS
DEMOLES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEMORTMENT OFFICES ALEX BEING
DEMOE OF A THE SHARES. ALL
DEMOT- MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DEMOK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY GO
DEMOD. LIEUTENANT BRANDON UP ON
DEMOLF OF US YOUR PALATE YOU
DEMO WHATEVER THE PROBLEM
DEMOSOR OF AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
DEMO. AT PEACE OFFICERS WERE
DEMOCTED BY THOSE WITH SERVICE
DEMO PROFESSIONALISM IN ALL OF
OUR DAY TO DAY DEMOTICE WITH
THE DEMOIC WE SIR. THE
DEMOESSIONALISM IS MOST
DEMORTANT WHEN WE ARE TRUSTED
DEMO THE PERSON'S MOST PRIVATE
DEMORMATION DURING TIMES OF
DEMOEDY. WE ARE TRUSTED THE
DEMORS GREATLY WHEN HANDLING
DEMORMATION THAT ISNOT MEANT
FOR DEMOIC VIEW YOUR
DEMOEMINATION. WE'RE A POWER TO
DEMORE SECURE SCENES OF GREAT
DEMOSTATION INCLUDING DEATH.
AND DEMOE GIVEN THE AUTHORITY
TO DEMOT THE PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THE DEMOES. IN THE BLOCK TO
DEMOATE THIS TRUST. BY TAKING
DEMOOS FOR NO LAWFUL PURPOSE
THE DEMOOR BY ELATION OF PUBLIC
DEMOT. AND CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
DEMOIDE A REMEDY FOR THIS
DEMOVIOR. THIS BEHAVIOR CANNOT
BE DEMOROLLED BY HAVING A-
DEMOCY IN PLACE MOST AGENCIES
OF NOT ALL DEMOADY HAVE A
DEMOCY IN PLACE THAT ADDRESSES
DEMO. UNFORTUNATELY THE THREAT
OF A DEMOCY VIOLATIONS
DEMOATIONS NOT STRONG ENOUGH TO
DEMOR THIS FROM HAPPENING AGAIN.
IF DEMOTED I HIGHLY DOUBT AND
DEMO THIS LAW WILL BE. WILL BE
DEMO VERY OFTEN. NOT VERY OFTEN
DEMO THE VAST MAJORITY OF LAW
DEMORCEMENT OFFICERS WOULD NOT
DEMOGE IN THIS ACTIVITY IN THE
DEMOT PLACE. HOWEVER THERE WILL
BE DEMO MOMENT WHEN THE
DEMOTATION MIGHT JUST BE TOO
DEMOWHELMING FOR THE OFFICE
DEMO. THAT'S A CRIME MIGHT
DEMOR A MOMENT OF PAUSE. AND
DEMO'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DEMOMPLISH WITH THIS BILL. WE
DEMO WORKED WITH THE OPPOSITION
IT DEMO SEVERAL OF THEIR
DEMOMMENDED AMENDMENTS
DEMOUDING THE FALL. WE LOWERED
THE DEMO FROM FIVE THOUSAND ONE
DEMOAR. WE REMOVED THE JAIL
DEMOHT JAIL TIME IS FOR THE
DEMOTE. AND WE ALSO
DEMORPORATED LANGUAGE TO
DEMOIRE AGENCIES NOTIFIED
DEMOOYEES OF THEM THE CHANGE IN
DEMO WITH THAT THANK YOU AND I
DEMOECTFULLY ASK YOUR BIBLE.
ALL DEMOT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY DEMOR FIVE PEOPLE CALLING
IN DEMOORT. ON THIS BILL WHICH
IS AB DEMOTY SIX FIFTY FIVE.
DEMOES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN DEMOORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
DEMOY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
DEMO ZERO TO GET INTO THE QUEUE
DEMON IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB DEMOTY SIX FIFTY FIVE.
DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
DEMOENT PLEASE. MY NUMBER SEVEN
DEMORED AND EIGHTEEN THAT IS
DEMO. SEVEN ONE EIGHT THE LINE
IS DEMO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU AT DEMO IS ANNA KELLY LET
ME TO DEMOTY DISTRICT
DEMORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT OF
THE DEMO THANK YOU. AND IF YOU
ARE IN DEMOORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
DEMOY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
DEMO ZERO. NO ONE IS IN THE
DEMOE PLEASE CONTINUE. BARBECUE
IS A DEMOE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
DEMOED AND THERE'S NO ONE WHO
DEMO IN THIS ROOM OR THE OTHER
DEMO SO WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S
DEMONE ON THE PHONE LINE WAS
DEMOOSED TO THIS BILL. IF YOU
DEMO IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
SIX DEMOY FIVE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE DEMO ZERO AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN DEMOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIX
DEMOY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
DEMO ZERO. THERE IS NO ONE
DEMOING UP PLEASE CONTINUE.
DEMOT ON MEMBERS SENATOR
DEMOLACH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
A- DEMOK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEMOON- THE BRYANT FAMILY YOUR
DEMOTITUENTS AND- BEEN AT THEIR
A OR K. DEMOER INNER FORMER
DEMO BUT- I'D TO I'D LIKE TO
DEMO THE BILL. THANK YOU. LET'S
SEE IF DEMOE'S ANY OTHER
DEMOENTS HERE. QUESTIONS RIGHT
WE DEMO A MOTION ON THE BILL-
DEMOMBLY MEMBER GIPSON YOU MAY
DEMOE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
DEMOR AND MEMBERS AND THANKS
FOR THE DEMONG THIS BILL I
DEMOECTFULLY ASK THAT I WILL BE
DEMO OF THE BRYAN FAMILY AND
DEMORS. RIGHT THE MOTION IS- DO
DEMOED TO APPROPRIATIONS- WE
DEMO A WE HAVE THE MOTION ON
THE DEMOR. WE CAN DO A ROLL
DEMO. AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE
TO DEMO TO APPROPRIATIONS
DEMONER. BY DINNERTIME MORLOCK.
DEMOLACH AYE BRADFORD HI
DEMOORD I'D JACKSON. ACTION BY
DEMODENT FIVE MITCHELL WITH A
LOT OF DEMOHELL I AM MORALE.
DEMOELL I WROTE I WIENER WIENER
I DEMO NOT SEVEN ZERO BY THE
DEMO PASSED SEVEN ZERO THANKS A
DEMOMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU VERY
DEMO RUBIO BEFORE WE GO TO THE
DEMOITEM WE- AS YOU NOTICE ON
WE HAD IT- IF DEMO PERMITS
DEMOOUSLY THE WHOLE LIST BUT
WE- DEMO THAT IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO DEMOINUE THE HEARING BECAUSE
IT IS US DEMORE FOR. AND BUT I
DEMO ANNOUNCE THAT AB FIFTEEN
OH SIX DEMOH WE HAD MOVED IN ME
DEMORDS THE END WE WILL HEAR ON
DEMOESDAY RATHER THAN TODAY AND
DEMO'S WHERE THE BECAUSE THERE
ARE DEMOL SOME DISCUSSIONS-
DEMO DOCTOR THIS THIS- THE
DEMOERENT AGENCIES THAT ARE
DEMOCTED AND SUCH SO- IT GIVING
IT A DEMOLE MORE TIME IS A GOOD
DEMO AND ELLIPSIS GET HOME A
DEMOLE EARLIER TO SO- WILL GO
TO DEMO OUR LAST BILL. ON
DEMOY'S HEARING WHICH IS. FILE
DEMO NUMBER NINETEEN AB TWENTY
DEMO FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
DEMOER KALRA. MADAM CHAIR
DEMOERS AVAILABLE ON A FIRST
DEMO. I THANK THE CHAIR FOR A
DEMO THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION
OF DEMO MEASURE IS A POLICY
DEMOISSION UNDERSTAND
DEMOATHIZE WITH THE CHALLENGES
DEMOE ALL FACED IN WORKING AS
DEMO BILLS AS PA. TO HELP
DEMORESS OUR COLLECTIVE EFFORT
TO DEMOOVE THE LIVES OF ALL
DEMOFORNIANS AND IS NOT AN EASY
DEMOESS TO APPRECIATE XMI
DEMOITUDE TO THE CHAIR AND HER
DEMOF FOR THE COLLEGIAL
DEMOOACH AND THE RESPECTIVE
DEMON ME AND ALL THOSE INVOLVED
DEMO THIS BILL FOR. US THANK
YOU AND DEMO THE MEASURE AND
DEMOERS OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMOENT AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
TWO DEMORE YOU TODAY I
DEMOECIATE ALL OF YOU. AS MANY
OF US DEMO EXPERIENCE THESE
DEMO SEVERAL MONTHS WE ARE AT A
DEMOSROADS OF SORTS. A WAS
DEMOD DETERMINE WHETHER WE AS A
DEMOUNITY. AS A STATEWIDE
DEMOUNITY CAN MAKE SIGNIFICANT
DEMODES TOWARDS ADDRESSING AND
DEMOING. O'CONNELL JUSTICE
DEMOEM OF INGRAINED
DEMOITUTIONALIZED RACISM. AB
DEMOTY FIVE FORTY TWO WOULD
DEMOBLISH THE RACIAL JUSTICE
DEMO A LONG OVERDUE MEASURE
DEMO WOULD MAKE IT LEAR THAT
DEMOING OR OBTAINING A CRIMINAL
DEMOICTION. OR IMPOSING A
DEMOENCE BASED UPON RACE
DEMOICITY OR NATIONAL ORIGIN IS
DEMOIBITED. AS CLEARLY LAID OUT
IN THE DEMOYSIS. THE RACIAL
DEMOICE ACT SEEKS TO OVERTURN
THE DEMOEDENT SET IN NINETEEN
DEMOTY SEVEN BY THE US SUPREME
DEMOT IN THE KLASKY B. CAMP
DEMORWISE KNOWN AS THE MCCLUSKY
DEMONG.IN HIS RULING WRITING
FOR THE DEMO FOR MAJORITY
DEMOICE POWELL WROTE THAT
DEMOISTICAL EVIDENCE WAS
DEMOFFICIENT TO SHOW A
DEMOTITUTIONAL VIOLATION.
DEMOIRING INSTEAD THAT OFFENDED
DEMO EXCEPTIONALLY
DEMOPTIONALLY CLEAR PROOF OF
DEMORIMINATION. UNDER THE FACTS
OF HIS DEMOER ON CASE. RIDING
FOR THE DEMORITY. JUST AS
DEMOER CLEARLY SUMMARIZED THE
DEMOONALE FOR THE MAJORITY'S
DEMOION ALTHOUGH RACIAL
DEMORIMINATION IS PERVASIVE IN
OUR DEMOICE SYSTEM THE COURT
WAS DEMOID OF HAVING TO
DEMOGNIZE THE HARM RACISM AND
DEMORIMINATION HAVE AND OTHER
DEMOS OF CRIMINAL CASES HENCE
THE DEMOT WAS AFRAID OF TOO
DEMO JUSTICE. AS A RESULT THIS
DEMOL STANDARD NEARLY HAS BEEN
DEMOLY A SYMBOL TO MEET. THE
DEMOIRES INDIVIDUALS TO SUBMIT
DEMOR OWN PREJUDICES AND
DEMOLEDGE OF THE PREJUDICIAL
DEMOVIOR WAS PURPOSEFUL AND
DEMONTIONAL. THUS MAKING
DEMORESS OF RACISM ACCEPTABLE
AND DEMOISSIBLE IN OUR CRIMINAL
DEMOICE SYSTEM. THIS IS A
DEMOOUND EXAMPLE ABOUT RACISM
DEMOMES INSTITUTIONALIZED. HOW
IT DEMOMES EMBEDDED IN OUR LAWS
AND DEMOTICES BELOW THE SURFACE
DEMOS AND OPERATIVA COME SECOND
DEMOGHT FOR SOME. ET
DEMOAORDINARILY. DETRIMENTAL TO
DEMORS. HOWEVER THE BEAUTY OF
DEMO RULING IS THAT THE
DEMOUSKY MAJORITY OBSERVED THAT
DEMOE LEGISLATURES CONCERNED
DEMOT RACIAL BIAS IN THE
DEMOINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM COULD
ACT TO DEMOESS IT. SO HERE WE
ARE WE ARE DEMONG IT CLEAR THAT
DEMOSM AND BIAS ARE PERVASIVE
AND DEMOPRESENT IN OUR CRIMINAL
DEMOICE SYSTEM IT'S TIME FOR
DEMOFORNIA TO PROHIBIT THE USE
OF DEMO AND IT HAPPENED AROUND
AT THE DEMO AS A FACTOR IN OUR
DEMOE'S CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DEMOEM. THIS IS A SIMPLE YET
DEMOOUND ON STEP TOWARDS EQUITY
IN OUR DEMOINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
ONE DEMO IS LONG OVERDUE AND
DEMO TIME TO ESTABLISH. THANK
DEMO WE WILL START THEN WITH
DEMO OF A LEAD TIME. WITNESSES
IN DEMOORT AND WE HAVE TO
DEMOESSES AND SUPPORT BRANDON
DEMOS FROM THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOF PUBLIC DEFENDER AND AMBER
DEMO HOWARD FROM CALIFORNIA'S
DEMOED FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
AND DEMON I WILL REMIND OUR
DEMO WITNESSES YOU HAVE THREE
DEMOTES TOTAL. NOT EACH GO
DEMOD. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
SEE DEMODAN WHICH PUBLIC ENEMY
DEMON AGAIN- I'VE BEEN A PUBLIC
DEMOG TO TWENTY TWO YEARS I'M
THE DEMOT BLACK CHIEF PUBLIC
DEMOSIT AND HISTORY ABOUT THE
DEMOTY AND CURRENTLY THE ONLY
DEMOF BLACK PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
THE DEMOE AND I'M TIRED OF
DEMONG THAT. THAT STATEMENT
DEMOT THERE SPEAKS VOLUMES I
DEMO THIS RESIDENT EVERYTHING
THE DEMOL OF THE CRIMINAL
DEMOICE SYSTEM I'M HERE LEGAL
DEMOER MARCOS TOLD BY JUDGE
DEMO BLACK AND LATINO PEOPLE
DEMO VIOLENT AND MORE CRIMINAL
IN THE DEMOK MEANS MORE LAW
DEMOING DURING THE JIM CROW
DEMO JUST LAST WEEK DURING A
DEMOL APOSTAS CRIED BLACKLINE
DEMOAL STALKING THEIR PREY
DEMOD YOU NOT WERE TO MINE
DEMOATED IN CRIME FROM
DEMOTICAL FAMILIES ALMOST
DEMOTICAL AND PROBATION
DEMOMMENDED ONE BE SENT TO A
DEMOP HOME AND OTHER TO STAY AT
DEMO WAS APPARENT IN THE ONLY.
DEMOERENCE WITH THE CONGRESS
DEMO PERSPIRATION FROM THE
DEMOT IN THE NATION. WHEN WE
SAY DEMOGH. WHAT MAKES A SCHOOL
DEMOT IT DOESN'T PART OF
DEMOECUTORS ALONE IT BY THE LAW
DEMORCEMENT JUDGES AND DEFENSE.
IT DEMO YOU CANNOT BE RACIST
AND A DEMOURE SOME JUSTICE.
DEMOLLY WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
DEMORTY CAMP MENTIONED CASES.
THE DEMOY COULD NOT CONNECT
DEMO AND THEY FOUND THAT IN
DEMO CASE PROSECUTORS SOUGHT
THE DEMOH PENALTY 70% OF CASES
DEMO BLACKS. DEPENDS WHERE AND
IT DEMOMES A WHITE ONLY
DEMOTEEN SANITATION AMONG WHITE
THE CAN DEMOACT THAT COMES. IN
DEMO CASE THE SUPREME COURT
DEMO THAT SUCH A CAMPUS PARTY
DEMOENTION. OUR OF A CRIMINAL
DEMOICE SYSTEM. IS NOT NAY. IT
DEMO TAKES PEOPLE WITH THE
DEMOAGE AND WILL TO CONFRONT.
AB TWO DEMO FOUR TO PROVIDE
DEMO MEGHAN TO TAKE THAT.
DEMOECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AMBER
DEMO. YEAH THANK YOU MADAM
DEMOR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
I DEMO EVER THIRTY FOUR YEAR
OLD DEMOERLY INCARCERATED BLACK
DEMON LIVING IN SOUTHERN
DEMOFORNIA I AM EXECUTIVE
DEMOCTOR- FOR STATEWIDE
DEMOITION OF OVER SEVENTY
DEMONIZATIONS WHO HAVE BEEN
DEMOING IN ADVOCATING FOR MUCH
DEMOED CHANGES TO OUR PUBLIC
DEMOTY MODEL THAT WILL WORK TO
THE DEMO MANICHAEAN A RADICALLY
DEMONTEGRATED THEM AT A TIME
DEMOE THEY BIRTH MINUTE ALL
DEMO THE STATE ALL OVER THE
DEMOON ARE CALLING FOR THE
DEMOERENT OF BLACK LIVES IN THE
DEMOECTION OF BLACK LIVES STATE
DEMOENCE. WE CAN BE A GOOD FOR
THE DEMO THAN THAT LIVE IN
DEMOT PROVIDE YOU LONG RACISM
HAS DEMO WIDELY RECOGNIZED OF
THE DEMOASIVE STRUCTURAL PART
DEMOT POLITICAL SYSTEM
DEMOETUATING THE DEVASTATION OF
DEMOK FAMILIES ACROSS
DEMOUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
DEMOFORNIANS THIS BILL AND THE
DEMOCT. DEPEND BUT- BEFORE YOU
TO DEMORONT THE- RACISM. IN THE
DEMOINAL LEGAL TO FOR. WRITING
THE RAW OF DEMO THIS IS THE
DEMONT TO PASS THE RACIAL THE
ACT A DEMORFUL LEADER AMERICA
DEMOORY ONE THAT. GET IN GOOD
DEMOBLE NEXT. TO AND HELP RID
THE DEMO OF AMERICA. I THINK
DEMOE. THE KIND OF TROUBLE JOHN
DEMO THE TOP ABOUT WE ENCOURAGE
AYE DEMO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND DEMOS SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
DEMOERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
DEMORATOR GO AHEAD THIS IS AB
DEMOTY FIVE FORTY TWO IN
DEMOORT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE IN DEMOORT OF AB
DEMOTY FIVE FORTY TWO PLEASE
DEMOS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN DEMOORT OF AB TWENTY
DEMO FORTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE DEMO ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE
DEMON HUNDRED AND. SEVENTEEN
DEMO SEVEN ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO
DEMOD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
DEMO HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
DEMOTS CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
DEMOORT. WE HAVE LINE SEVEN
DEMORED AND TWENTY ONE NINE
DEMON TWO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEMO AFTERNOON PATHOLOGY DOCTOR
ON DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOLTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
DEMOK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SIX DEMORED AND NINETY EIGHT
DEMO SIX NINE EIGHT PLEASE GO
DEMOD. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DEMO MARYLAND RALSTON. AND I'M
IN DEMONG SUPPORT. OF THE
DEMOAL JUSTICE ACT ALONG WITH
THE DEMOOWING GROUPS. A NEW
DEMO AARON FOR DICTION
DEMOTMENT AND HEALING ALAMEDA
DEMOTY PUBLIC DEFENDER AMNESTY
DEMORNATIONAL CALIFORNIA
DEMOGRANT POLICY CENTER
DEMOFORNIA INNOCENCE PROJECT
DEMOFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
DEMOCIATION CALIFORNIANS FOR
DEMOTY AND JACKSON. DRUG POLICY
DEMOANCE CHANCE PROJECT BRANCH
DEMOITTEE ON LEGISLATION
DEMOGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER
I DEMO TO SEE A DOCTOR JEFF LA
DEMONO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
DEMOFORNIA PLAY- LOWER PROJECT
FOR THE DEMOCENT. THE RENT
DEMOCE OF PUBLIC POLICY
DEMOONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
DEMOERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
DEMOONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
DEMOHERN CALIFORNIA INNOCENCE
DEMOECT POLICY LAKE ALLIANCE OF
DEMO AND MEN OF COLOR PROJECT
DEMOUND CONSORTIUM. RESTORED
DEMO. THE PHONE ALLIANCE MARC
DEMO THE SOUTH. AND WE THE
DEMOLE BANDY. THANK YOU
DEMORATOR GO AHEAD. WE HAVE MY
DEMOER SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DEMO LINE SEVEN TO FOUR PLEASE
GO DEMOD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
DEMO MAKAN OFFERING STRONG
DEMOORT ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOOWING CO SPONSORS OF AB
DEMOTY FIVE READY TO. THE
DEMOICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
DEMOITTEE. ASIAN AMERICANS
DEMONCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
DEMOITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS.
DEMOFORNIANS UNITED FOR A
DEMOONSIBLE BUDGET ELLA BAKER
DEMOER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS LEGAL
DEMON VOTERS CALIFORNIA NEXT
GEN DEMOFORNIA NEW D. W. ASKED
ME DEMOL THIRTY NINE THIRTY
DEMOK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
DEMO NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
DEMONTY TWO POINT ONE SEVEN TWO
DEMOSE GO AHEAD. SENATE BRAMBLE
DEMOING ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND DEMONG SUPPORT. WE GO TO
DEMO ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
DEMO AT ONE FIVE FOUR PLEASE GO
DEMOD. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN DEMOORT. WE HAVE LINE SIX
DEMORED AND SEVENTY TWO LINE
SIX DEMON TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY GOD DEMOOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE DEMO OF CALIFORNIA AND
DEMONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
DEMOES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN DEMOORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
DEMOY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
DEMO AT THIS TIME. NO ONE IN
THE DEMOE PLEASE CONTINUE.
DEMOK YOU. ITSELF WE WILL GO TO
OUR DEMOSITION. AND MY
DEMORSTANDING IS LEAD
DEMOSITION WILL BE YOU'RE A
DEMOESENTED BY DHF ROSEN. DO WE
DEMO HIM ON THE LINE. JEFFREY
IS ON THE DEMO APPEARING ON
DEMOLF MR OCEAN OKAY GO AHEAD.
DEMO PERSONAL MEMBERS OF THE
DEMOITTEE JUST RUINED APPEARING
NOT DEMO ON BEHALF OF JEFF ROSE
WHO BY DEMO BUT AS WELL AND ON
DEMOLF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMORICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
SB DEMOTY FIVE FORTY TO CREATE
AN DEMOACTICAL. UNFAIR.
DEMOCESSARY AND COST MEANS. OF
DEMOHING A GOAL. FERVENTLY BY
DEMO OF PROVIDING EQUAL JUSTICE
FOR ALL DEMORDLESS OF RACE
DEMOICITY OR NATIONAL ORIGIN.
DEMORE GOING ON WE WANNA MAKE
DEMO YOU'RE FULLY AWARE THAT
DEMOE WE OPPOSED THE BILL I
DEMOGRE WITH MANY OF THE
DEMOMPTIONS THAT HAVE GENERATED
THE DEMO THIS WILL NOT STOP US
DEMO WORKING TO IMPROVE IT AND
DEMOEN ITS DAMAGING IMPACT IF
DEMON THE CHANCE TO DO SO. OUR
DEMOEMENTS ARE GONNA BE
DEMOLUSORY DUE TO TIME
DEMOTRAINTS BUT WE ARE HAPPY TO
SIT DEMO AND EXPLAIN THE
DEMOONING BEHIND EVERYTHING YOU
DEMO THE BILL IMPRACTICAL
DEMOUSE IT WILL RESULT IN
DEMOSSIVE. LITIGATION DUE TO
DEMOGUOUS AND CAN. LANGUAGE ANY
DEMOONABLE OBSERVER IS GOING TO
DEMOTE UNPRECEDENTED LEGAL
DEMOES MANY OF WHICH SHOULD BE
DEMOLVED BEFORE THIS BILL IS
DEMOED ON. THE BILL IS UNFAIR
AND DEMOST BECAUSE IT WOULD
DEMOIRE THE REVERSAL OF THE
DEMO NO MATTER HOW DEVASTATING
THE DEMOE WITHOUT ANY SHOWING
DEMO THE DEFENDANT SUFFERED ANY
DEMOUDICE AS A RESULT OF THE
DEMO THAT THE BUYERS HAD ANY
DEMOCT WHATSOEVER ON THE
DEMOOME OF THE TRIAL FOR THE
DEMONDANT WITH DEPRIVED OF A
DEMO TRIAL. A STANDARD THAT
DEMO NOT REQUIRE SHOWING THAT
THE DEMOGED VICE IMPACTED THE
DEMOICT IS ILLOGICAL AND CAN
DEMOUCE HORRIFIC RESULTS. FOR
DEMOPLE UNDER THIS BILL IF
DEMOE WAS A MASS SHOOTING IN A
LAW DEMORCEMENT OFFICER
DEMOLVED IN THE- WHO NEARLY
DEMO. AN UNDISPUTED VIDEO. AT
WHO DEMOIFIED TO UNDER.
DEMOLUSION WAS BIASED AGAINST
TO DEMOND. IT WOULD HAVE TO BE
A DEMOEW. REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
DEMOY PEOPLE OBSERVED THE
DEMONDANT DOING THE SHOOTING
THE DEMO WAS REVEALED TO THE
DEMO THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEMOCER DID NOT EVEN TESTIFY
AND PLL THE DEMOLE MURDERED
DEMONG TO THE SAME GROUP AS A
DEMONDANT. THE BILL IS
DEMOCESSARY BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
DEMOECTION COMPONENT OF THE DUE
DEMOESS CLAUSE OF THE FIFTH
DEMODMENT ALREADY PRECLUDES
DEMONG THE DECISION TO PUT.
DEMO A BIBLE STANDARD SUCH AS
RAY DEMO. OTHER ABA TRAFFIC.
OUR OF THE DEMOTEENTH MEMBERS
OF THE DEMORAL CONSTITUTION AND
DEMOCLE ONE SECTION SEVEN FROM
THE DEMOIONARY OF THE
DEMOFORNIA CONSTITUTION. AND
DEMOLY THE BILL COMES WITH
DEMOBITANT COST. THIS BILL
DEMOIRES THE PROSECUTION TO
DEMOLOSE ALL RELEVANT EVIDENCE
TO THE DEMOON WITHOUT ANY
DEMOONARY SHOWING A PLAUSIBLE
DEMOIFICATION FOR THE DISCOVERY.
DEMO DOES THIS MEAN IN REAL
DEMO BUT FOR THE DEFENDANTS
DEMOGED WITH ASSAULT WITH A
DEMOLY WEAPON GREAT BODILY
DEMORY. AND SEEK RELEVANT
DEMOOVERY BEARING ON WHETHER
DEMOERS OF DEFENDANTS
DEMOIZABLE CLASS. WOULD
DEMOROPORTIONATELY CHARGED WITH
DEMO SERIOUS BUT SIMILAR CRIMES
DEMO SIMPLE ASSAULT OR BATTERY
IN DEMOARISON TO OTHER GROUPS.
DEMOR ANY OBJECTIVELY REGIONAL
DEMOOACH THIS COMPARISON WOULD
DEMOIRE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE
DEMOUMSTANCES UNDERLINE THE
DEMOES REPORTEDLY BASED ON THE
DEMO OR SIMILAR CONDUCT AND
DEMOVANT CHARACTERISTICS OF THE
DEMONDANTS CHARGED WITH THOSE
DEMOES. SUCH AS A CRIMINAL
DEMOORY. OTHERWISE THE
DEMOARISONS ARE MEANINGLESS.
DEMO IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
DEMOE IN YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN.
A DEMOLE DISCOVERY. OF THIS
DEMORE WOULD INVOLVE A THREE
DEMOD AND ALL THE CABIN PROVIDE
ONE DEMOSANDFOUR HUNDRED AND
DEMOY SIX DIFFERENT FILES. SUCH
DEMO COULD BE IDENTIFIED
DEMOTED REVIEWED AND REDACTED
TO DEMOLY WITH THE STATE
DEMOTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENT. IN
DEMOS TOTAL TIME THAT WOULD BE
A PRO DEMOING APPROXIMATELY
DEMOT MONTHS TO HANDLE THE
DEMOOVERY CLASS A COURSE OF A
DEMORED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DEMOARS IN A CLARA COUNTY JUST
TO GO TO THE DEMOS FOR A SINGLE
DEMO. EVEN IF RELEVANT. LIMITED
AND IT IS NOT DEMOORY CARE
DEMOOP. I WOULD BE CLOSE TO ONE
DEMO MILLION DOLLARS OF COST TO
DEMOCTIVELY RESPOND TO A SINGLE
DEMOON PLEASE DO NOT PASS THIS
DEMO IN ITS CURRENT FORM. THANK
DEMO LET US SEE IF THERE'S
DEMOR CALLERS IN OPPOSITION TO
DEMO BILL. MODERATOR LADIES AND
DEMOLEMEN IF YOU WERE IN
DEMOSITION OF AB TWO FIVE FOUR
TWO DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
DEMON IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB DEMO FOUR TWO PLEASE
DEMOS ONE THEN ZERO WE HAVE
DEMO SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DEMON PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
DEMON TWO SEVEN. WE'RE GOING TO
DEMO ON TO MY NUMBER SIX
DEMORED AND. SEVENTY SIX THAT
IS DEMO SIX SEVEN SIX. YOUR IS
DEMO. BENNINGER MEMBERS CORY
DEMOS ARE LOW ON THE OF THE
DEMOFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
DEMOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
DEMOSITION. WE GO TO MY NUMBER
DEMON HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
DEMO AT SEVEN TWO SIX PLEASE GO
DEMOD. GOOD AFTERNOON LAUREN
DEMOR SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
DEMORICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND
DEMOECTFUL OPPOSITION. LADIES
AND DEMOLEMEN AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN DEMOSITION OF AB TWO FIVE
DEMO TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
IF DEMO. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
DEMOSE CONTINUE. THANK YOU.
DEMOE DONE OPPOSITION WE'VE
DEMO SUPPORT LET'S SEE IF WE
DEMO SOME COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
DEMO START. SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEMOA THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A- IT
IS DEMO A VERY COMPLICATED
DEMOPTIVELY SIMPLE YET HIGHLY
DEMOLICATED BILL. AND IF I
DEMOK ABOUT MUCH OF THE BILLS
DEMO WE HAVE HEARD TODAY CANTOR
DEMO WEEK. IN MANY CASES AND
NOT ALL AND BUT DEMORE SORT OF
A I DEMOK IT'S A- READ THROUGH
DEMO YEAR'S BILLS THAT HAVE
DEMO FOR COMMITTEE. IN THAT
DEMOE THERE HAVE BEEN. MANY
DEMORTS TO DATE THIS IS NOT
DEMO IT'S NEVER HAPPENED. I
DEMOK THIS LAST FEW MONTHS IN
DEMOICULAR. THERE ARE MANY OF
US. DEMO SPEAK FOR MYSELF THERE
DEMO HAVE RECOGNIZED THAT WHILE
WE. DEMOE WE HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED
THE DEMOAL BIAS THAT EXISTS IN
OUR DEMOERENT SYSTEMS AND WE
DEMO DONE VARIOUS REFORMS TO
DEMOESS IT. I THINK THERE'S
DEMO THERE'S BUT IT'S MORE OF A
DEMO AN INFLECTION POINT OR A
DEMOECTION POINT OF A MUCH
DEMOER MAGNITUDE THAT IT HAS
DEMO IN A WHILE. EIGHT THERE
DEMO SOME IT. BUT BEING ONE BUT
DEMOR THINGS AND I THINK THE
DEMOEMIC JUST PEOPLE. BUT WHEN
WE DEMO ALL SHOT IN. AND
DEMOHING- THE MEDIA PERHAPS
DEMO SOCIAL MEDIA ARE THAT.
DEMO A VERY SERIOUS REFLECTION
DEMOT AND. OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD
DEMO TO SEE. THAT TRAINING IN
DEMONG TO RECOGNIZE IMPLICIT
DEMO. THAT THAT I THINK WE
DEMOD HOPE THAT THAT COULD.
DEMOECT FOR EXAMPLE I THINK WE
DEMO HAVE DATA THAT SHOWS THAT
IT IS DEMOFUL. BUT NOT ENOUGH.
AND DEMOE THERE MAY BE SOME
DEMOSTANCE TO MOVING IN SUCH A
DEMOCTION AS YOUR BILL HAS IS
DEMORIBING. I THINK WHAT'S
DEMORTANT FOR US TO NOTE IS
DEMO. R. AND I DON'T HAVE THE
DEMOGRAPHICS FOR JUDGES BUT I
DEMOED UP THE STUDY NOW THAT
DEMOE NUMBERS WILL BE OFF A
DEMOLE. BUT THERE'S A TWENTY
DEMOEEN STUDY THAT SHOWS THAT
DEMOGST CALIFORNIA'S
DEMOECUTORS NO THESE ARE ALL
ALL THE DA DEMOCES IT WAS FIFTY
DEMOE OUT OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
DEMOTIES. ONLY 9% OF OUR
DEMOECUTORS AT THAT POINT WHERE
DEMONO. 70% WERE WHITE. THERE
WAS A DEMOER PERCENT OF BLACK
DEMOECUTORS THEN THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF CALIFORNIA BUT
DEMOENTAGE OF WHO'S PROSECUTED
DEMOER OTHER WORDS THAT. AND
THE DEMOR- SAMEER TWENTY
DEMOEEN AND HOPEFULLY IT'S
DEMOER CHANGED 80% OF ALL
DEMOERS 80% OF ALL PEOPLE WITH
DEMO BARCHART. RIGHT IN
DEMOFORNIA. SO GIVEN MATCH AND
IT DEMO TAKE WELL WE'RE
DEMOAINLY DOING A LOT SO THAT
WE CAN TO DEMOGE THAT. IT WILL
BE A DEMO TIME. BEFORE THAT
DEMOE ARE GRAPHICS CHANGE AND
SO DEMO WE'RE FACED WITH THAT I
DEMOK. PUTTING INTO STAFF
DEMOGES AS YOU ARE DESCRIBING.
ARE DEMOABLY NOT ONLY NECESSARY
DEMO AND- I DO APPRECIATE THAT
IT IS. DEMOLICATED I'M AND THIS
IS AN ODD DEMO IN THAT- THIS IS
A DEMOCATED. WELL CERTAINLY
DEMO HAVING HEARING I DON'T
DEMO THAT WERE PER SE
DEMOCATING IT. BUT YOUR BILLS
AND I CAN DEMO THE SAME LEVEL
OF DEMOING SAID IT MIGHT HAVE
DEMORWISE. BUT I STILL THINK
DEMO PROBABLY VERY IMPORTANT TO
DEMO NOT PROPERLY I DON'T MEAN
TO DEMOING LIMITATION ON THAT
IS DEMORTANT TO MOVE NOW. AND
DEMO I'M HOPEFUL RIGHT NOW AS
WE DEMO ACTED ON A LOT OF
DEMOGS IN THE LAST TWO
DEMOINGS. WHAT I'M HOPEFUL IS
DEMO. OUR WILLINGNESS TO ACT
ON. A DEMO NUMBER OF THEM. DOES
NOT DEMOARDIZE ANY OF THEM.
DEMOUSE SOMETIMES THERE'S A
DEMOGUE THAT OCCURS WITH US
DEMO OF OUR MEMBERS ARE. SO I
DEMOLY DO NOT I REALLY HOPE
DEMO. ARE ACTING IN THIS TIME
DEMOE IT IS A IT IS A STRONG
DEMOMENT A REFLECTIVE MOMENT
DEMOE IS. THERE SO MANY MANY
DEMOGS THAT THAT I THINK OF
DEMOUSE THIS IS NOT JUST THE
DEMOESTS SANDY. D. A. IN.
DEMOGE FLOYD INCIDENT BUT EVEN
THE DEMOH OF OUR OUR
DEMORESSMAN LUIS. IN THE
DEMOUSSIONS THAT- AND THEN HIS
DEMOLY'S READING OF THE LETTER
DEMO HE WROTE THAT HE WANTED
DEMOYONE TO DID HE WANTED ALL
OF US TO DEMO. UPON HIS DEATH
SO I DEMOK IT'S JUST ONE OF
DEMOE UNIQUE TYPE OF MOMENTS
AND I DEMO HOPE THAT OUR IN OUR
DEMONG IN RESPONSE TO IT THAT
DEMOE NOT DOING SUCH THAT WE
DEMODE ANYTHING. AND THAT IN
DEMO IT HAS THE IMPACT THAT I
DEMOK- MANY OF OUR THE VOTES IN
OUR DEMOONS IN THE LAST COUPLE
DEMO OF ARE TRYING TO MAKE. SO.
DEMO I WILL STOP THERE I AM
DEMOORTING THE BILL TODAY. LET
ME SEE IF ANY DEMOHER MY
DEMOEAGUESWITH EITHER ONE ASK
A DEMOTION OR- AS ANYTHING. ALL
DEMOT WE HAVE A MOTION. DO NOT
DEMO. MY HAND I'M SORRY I KEPT
DEMOING AT THIS THE GOOD I
DEMO'T SEE THAT BLUE DOT TILL
NOW OF DEMOSE SENATOR JACKSON
DEMOCE YOUR REMOTE TO PUT YOUR
DEMO US SO PLEASE YOU HAVE TO
DEMOE I AM VERY HERE AND I AM
DEMO ANGUISHED- BECAUSE I SURE
THE DEMORATIONAL GOALS OF THIS
DEMOURE- I SHARE AND HAVE
DEMOED AND HAVE A GREAT.
DEMOECT FOR THE OFFER THIS
DEMO- I APPRECIATE SURE IS
DEMOION FOR JUSTICE AND I THINK
DEMO'S WHAT WE'RE ASKING ABOUT
IS DEMO GOING TO GET US TO
DEMOICE- AND WE HAVE TO GET IT
DEMOT BECAUSE IF WE DO NOT HAVE
A DEMOEM OF JUSTICE THAT WORKS
FOR DEMOYONE. THEN WE HAVE
FAILED AS A DEMOCRACY AND WE
DEMO FAILED IN OUR FUNDAMENTAL
DEMOCIPLES OF A PROVIDING A
DEMOETY WITH LIBERTY AND
DEMOICE FOR ALL AND- I AM. VERY
DEMOERNED THAT WE ARE. IN OUR
DEMORTS TO GET THERE A PLACE
DEMOE WE'VE NOT BEEN I MEAN
DEMOE'S NO QUESTION THAT THIS
DEMOEM HAS BEEN RIGGED AGAINST
DEMOLE OF COLOR. I WOULD SUBMIT
OUR DEMOETY HAS BEEN ALSO
DEMOED AGAINST. WOMEN AGAINST
HER DEMOQ COMMUNITY AND WE'RE
DEMOING AND MAKING PROGRESS IN
DEMO AREA AS WELL. BUT THE
DEMOTION FOR ME IS DOES THIS
DEMO GET US TO WHERE WE WANT BE
AND I AM NOT DEMOINCED THAT
DEMOONE WHO HAS PRACTICED IN
DEMO AREA THAT THE- ELEMENTS
DEMO. ARE AND THERE ARE MANY OF
DEMO OUT WILL. GET US TO THAT
DEMOT THE THERE CERTAINLY HOPE
DEMO THEY WILL BUT AS I HAD
DEMOIONED IN THE EARLIER BILL
BY DEMO MY A GOOD FRIEND DIDN'T
IN DEMOONE I ADMIRE
DEMOENDOUSLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEMOR. THE AYE I AM NOT
DEMOINCED THAT THE THAT THE
DEMOTICALITIES THAT THE- THAT
THE DEMOESS. IS GOING TO DO
DEMO AND YOU KNOW I KNOW THERE
ARE DEMO OUT THERE WHO OPPOSES
DEMO THEY OPPOSE IT BECAUSE
DEMO DON'T BELIEVE IN. THEY
DEMOT BELIEVE IN IN JUSTICE FOR
ALL OR DEMO SAY THEY DO BUT
DEMO DON'T BELIEVE THERE IS
DEMO THEY DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S
DEMORIMINATION- I DO BELIEVE
DEMO IN A AND I AND THE
DEMOISTICS ARE CLEAR. BUT THIS
IS A DEMOESS THAT- IN ORDER TO
DEMOEVE JUSTICE WE HAVE TO DO
IT IN A WAY DEMOE WE CAN GET AS
DEMOE TO THAT GOAL AS IS
DEMONLY POSSIBLE GIVEN THE
DEMOLTIES IN THE- IMPERFECTIONS
OF THE DEMON CONDITION. AND SO
I DEMO THAT THIS ISSUE THAT
DEMO BILL ALSO DEALS WITH THE
DEMOMPTORY CHALLENGE ISSUE
DEMOH I HAVE ASKED THAT WE
DEMOYED- TAKING UP UNTIL THE-
DEMOF JUSTICE WORK. DOES THEIR
DEMO AND I WOULD NOTE FOR YOU
BY THE WAY DEMO THE
DEMOWHELMING MAJORITY OF THE
DEMOLE ON THAT WORK GROUP ARE
DEMOLE OF COLOR.SO I KNOW THAT
THE DEMOT. IS COMMITTED TO A
DEMOER SYSTEM A FAIRER SYSTEM
OF DEMOICE AND- I KNOW THAT WE
DEMO TO MOVE IN THAT. DIRECTION
WE DEMO TO TAKE THIS
DEMORTUNITY BECAUSE I KNOW THE
DEMOR AND I CERTAINLY HAVE COME
DEMO AN ERA WHERE WE- THOUGHT
DEMOL RIGHTS WAS GOING TO
DEMOEN WITH THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT IN THE DEMOIES AND
DEMOENING TO THE ELOQUENCE OF
DEMOIN LUTHER KING AND- ARE
DEMOING UPON US TO BE ARE
DEMOER IN OUR HIGHEST SELVES
DEMO TO. MAKE SURE THAT THE ART
DEMOS TOWARDS JUSTICE- AND I
DEMOK THAT THERE I THINK THAT'S
DEMO WE WERE AT THAT TIME- TO
TRY DEMO AGAIN BUT WITH GREATER
DEMOLVE PERHAPS AND WITH
DEMOTER SUCCESS. I DON'T. I I'M
DEMO NOT THERE THAT THIS BILL
DEMO US THERE AND- I WANT TO BE
DEMOR MIGHT I'M GOING TO STAY
OFF THE DEMO TODAY I WILL IF
THE DEMO. TO MOVE I WILL. TO
DEMOEW IT I WOULD. I WOULD LIKE
DEMO WE LOOK AT THIS AND ASK
DEMOELVES IS THIS TRULY GOING
TO GET US DEMOE WE NEED TO GO
OR IS DEMO REALLY JUST A
DEMOEMENT THAT SAYS. THE SYSTEM
HAS DEMOED US WE'RE ESSENTIALLY
DEMOG. TO BLOW IT UP OR WE'RE
DEMOG TO. BASICALLY START ALL
DEMO AGAIN- I THINK THAT THERE
ARE WAY DEMO WE ACHIEVE OUR
DEMOS. WITHOUT CREATING SOME OF
THE DEMOOUS PROBLEMS THAT I SEE
IN DEMO BILL AND SO I
DEMOECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMOE MY- POSITION HERE BECAUSE
I DO. DEMOEVE IN THE GOAL I
DEMO DON'T THINK AT THIS MOMENT
I DEMOT FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT
DEMO IS THE WAY TO GET. THANK
DEMOTOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
DEMO MUCH MADAM CHAIR- I
DEMOECIATE- THE PHYSICS YOU
DEMOE IT WAS A- ONCE AGAIN
DEMOR REMINDER OF- FRANKLY MY
DEMOITY. ON I APPRECIATE THE
DEMOR BUT FOR BRINGING THIS
DEMOURE FORWARD YOU KNOW I
DEMOT KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE
DEMORY OF TINKERING AROUND THE
DEMOS. OF JUSTICE. AND I AM
DEMO VERY CLEAR THAT NOT ONE
DEMO. WILL BRING A SENSE OF
DEMOLVE OR SOLUTION TWO
DEMOK THAT- THE WORLD IS IN A
DEMOE TODAY WHERE WE HAVE BEEN
IN THE DEMO WHERE THERE IS A
DEMOSED ENERGY AND ATTENTION.
AND DEMO CREATED AN OPPORTUNITY
DEMO PROBABLY MORE DIRECT MORE
DEMOK DIALOGUE IN PUBLIC
DEMOOURSE. PUBLIC DISCOURSE
DEMOND RACE. RACISM BIAS
DEMOICIT AND EXPLICIT SO THE
DEMOON THAT A SINGLE BILL WILL
GET US DEMOHER ALONG I THINK
DEMO NOT A REALISTIC ONE NOR DO
I DEMOK IT'S REALISTIC TO THINK
DEMO MINOR ADJUSTMENTS THIS
DEMOON AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID OF
WE DEMOLDN'T THROW THE WHOLE
DEMOEMATIC I'M NOT CONVINCED
DEMO WE COULD ACTUALLY ACHIEVE
DEMOICE WITHOUT DOING NOT TO BE
DEMOECTLY FRANK- I'M GOING TO
DEMOORT THE BILL. BECAUSE IF
NOT DEMO THEN WHAT. I
DEMOECIATE. THE. PUTTING
DEMOARD THAT BRINGS- PROPONENTS
AND DEMONENTS TOGETHER TO HAVE
A- DEMOLY AND YET ALSO LAKE
DEMOERSATION. TO WATCH THE NEWS
DEMO WEEK AND SEE A YOUNG
DEMOCAN AMERICAN MAN TELL A
DEMOE THAT HE WISHES TO BE
DEMOECUTED AS A WHITE MAN. WAS
DEMOFULLY IRONIC IN TELLING.
DEMO THAT HE KNEW THAT JUSTICE
IS NOT DEMOD. AND WOULD MAKE
DEMO AND THE SOMEWHAT PERCEIVED
AS DEMORD STATEMENT IN AN
DEMORT. TWO HALF FROM HIS
DEMOPECTIVE EIGHT JEFF IN FAIR
DEMORIENCE BEFORE THE COURT WAS.
DEMOIC SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE DEMOURE TODAY AND
DEMOECIATE THIS BEING ONE OF
DEMOIPLE EFFORTS- THAT WE'LL
ALL DEMO TO- LOOK AT ANY VALUE
DEMOING TURNED UPSIDE DOWN AND
ALL DEMOND TO FIGURE OUT IF WE
CAN DEMO IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR
DEMOECTIVE JEFF SOCIETY ON WHEN
DEMO APPROPRIATE I'LL BE MORE
DEMO HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
DEMOICE WIENER I THANK YOU I
DEMOORT THIS BILL AND I THANK
THE DEMOOR FOR OFFER BRING YOUR
DEMOARD- YOU KNOW I REALLY WANT
TO DEMOCIATE MYSELF WITH CENTER
DEMOHELL'S REPORT REMARKS ON
OUR DEMOINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
NOT DEMO FLAWED THIS ISN'T THIS
DEMOT SIMPLY A SYSTEM THAT HAS
DEMO PROBLEMS AND YOU CAN GO
AND YOU DEMO WHAT YOU'RE GOING
TO FIX DEMO CAR AND YOU FIX A
FEW DEMOGS AND THEN IT RUNS
DEMOECTLY THIS SYSTEM OUR
DEMOINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
DEMORTUNATELY. IS ROTTEN TO THE
DEMO AND I DON'T SAY THAT
DEMOTLY AND THERE PLENTY OF
DEMO PEOPLE AND YOU KNOW WHO
ARE DEMONG TO MAKE THE SYSTEM
DEMO WELL THIS ISN'T ABOUT
DEMONIZING EVERYONE IS INVOLVED
IN DEMOT JUSTICE SYSTEM THERE
ARE DEMOLE WHO ARE WORKING
DEMOLY HARD. TO TRY TO RUN AND
DEMOATE AN EQUITABLE SYSTEM.
BUT THE DEMOEM ITSELF IS SO.
DEMO IT IS BROUGH. IT IS SO. SO
DEMOLY. FLAWED ARE GOING BACK.
DEMOREDS OF YEARS. AND SO WE
DEMO TO TRY A RADICALLY
DEMOERENT APPROACHES AND YES
DEMO MEANSTHAT WE DON'T NEED
DEMOTY SOME ODD PRISONS AND WE
DEMO TO BE CLOSE ENOUGH NOT
DEMO ONE OR TWO LITTLE WHOLE
DEMOH OF PRISONS. HI WE HAVE TO
GET OUT OF MY BED DEMOYTHING
DEMOS TO RESULT IN CARCERI
DEMORCERATION LONGER SENTENCES
DEMOHOW. ARE GOING TO FIX
DEMOETIES PROBLEMS. WE NEED TO-
DEMOOWLEDGE THE DEEP DEEP
DEMOSM AND OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DEMOEM IT'S NOT JUST. THERE ARE
DEMO PEOPLE WHO ARE BAD ACTORS
AND IF YOU GET RID OF DEMOEM
DEMO BE RACIST ANYMORE. THE
DEMOEM WAS SET UP. TO BE RACIST
AND SO WE DEMO TO TRY RADICALLY
DEMOERENT APPROACHES TO HOW WE
DEMO OUR COMMUNITY SAFE AND HOW
WE DEMO OUR COMMUNITY SAFE AND
DEMO THE DOESN'T CRIMINALIZE
DEMORE POPULATIONS IN TERROR
DEMOUNITIES APART- AND THAT'S
DEMO THIS IS ABOUT. AND THIS
DEMO IS IN THAT VEIN OF NOT
DEMO TINKERING AROUND THE EDGES
BUT DEMOTING TO GO TO THE VERY
DEMOT OF THE PROBLEM- AND
DEMO'S WHY SUPPORTER. WE HAVE A
DEMOON I'M GONNA LET YOU CLOSE
DEMOMBLY MEMBER BUT I MIGHT.
DEMO CLOSE TO GENERATIONAL
DEMOEAGUES A SPOKE A BIT
DEMOIER WANTED TO JUST ADD. A
DEMOLE TOO- MY REFLECTION ON
DEMOE THINGS. I. I THINK THAT
OUR DEMOINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
DEMOLY JUST IT IS DOING. IT IS
DEMOG WHAT IT WAS INTENDED AND
SO I DEMO A HARDER TIME. NOT
DEMOER TERMINAL NEEDS. THE.
GIVEN THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF.
DEMOS IN PROSCAR WHO ARE
DEMOECUTORS EVEN AS BRENDAN
DEMOSTOCK TOUR EVEN THE PUBLIC
DEMONDERS WHO ARE JUDGES AND
THEN THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF WHO IS
DEMOECUTED. THAT'S WHY WE NEED
DEMO AN EXPLICIT BILLS THIS.
DEMOL THOSE ALL THOSE THINGS
DEMOGE AND THEY WILL TAKE
DEMOER WILL NEED WE HAVE TO
DEMO THIS KIND OF. REALLY A
DEMOTIC CHANGE AND IT'S THAT
ONE I DEMO DO WHAT IT'S
DEMONDED I DON'T MEAN THAT
DEMONE IN IT IS A WRONG OR BAD
DEMOGH THERE MAY BE SOME IT IS
DEMO THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT JUST
THE DEMOORY OF HOW MANY OF OUR
DEMO WERE ESTABLISHED HOW MUCH
OF OUR DEMOL CODE WAS
DEMOBLISHED HOW EVEN OUR AS
DEMOE TALKED ABOUT AND I THINK
DEMOTOR BRADFORD MILLER HAS
DEMONDED US HOW EVEN OUR POLICE
DEMORTMENTS WERE ESTABLISHED.
DEMO IT'S WE CANNOT DO THAT THE
DEMO EXIST THAT'S REAL. BUT WE
DEMO AND THIS BILL DOES PUT IN
A DEMO. THAT MUST BE VIEWED TO
DEMO THOSE CORRECTIONS WE CAN'T
GO DEMO AND CHANGE HISTORY BUT
WE CAN PUT IN A DEMO THAT CAN
DEMON TO MAKE THE CORRECTIONS
AND DEMO'S ARGUE THIS BILL. SO
YOU MAY DEMOE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEMOK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
DEMO IT TO THEM COMMENTS FROM
ALL MY- DEMOTE COLLEAGUES HERE-
AND YOU DEMO. IT WE THERE'S A
LOT DEMOG ON CERTAINLY IN IN
DEMOINAL JUSTICE AND CERTAINLY
A AND DEMOENESS OF MY I THINK
DEMOICULARLY AS IT APPLIES AND-
THE DEMOS SECTION WITH RACIAL
DEMOICE AND RACISM- I WILL KNOW
DEMO I INTRODUCED THIS BILL
DEMORE. THE TORTURE AND MURDER.
OF DEMOGE FLOYD- BECAUSE THIS
IS NOT DEMOTHING THAT EXISTED.
DEMOR HIS MURDER AS WE ALL KNOW
DEMO EXISTED FOR A VERY LONG
DEMO AND WE DO HAVE TO DO A LOT
OF DEMOGS. IN DEALING WITH THE
DEMOTOMS OF OUR BASIS- COME A
DEMO SYSTEM- THAT APPLIES TO A
LOT OF. THE DEMOCTS OF IT SO
DEMOD YOU PLEASE OSTRACON
DEMOITY READ BOOKS ON THE
DEMOITY XIN. MONEY FOR SOCIAL
DEMOICES CLOSING PRISONS WE
AVE TO GET TO THE DEMO OF WHY
WE ARE DEMOE WE ARE. AT THIS
DEMONT- THE- IS THE DA'S
DEMOESENTATIVE SAYS THAT THIS
IS DEMOACTICAL INJUSTICES
DEMOACTICAL. AND YOU KNOW THERE
ARE A DEMOER OF AMENDMENTS AND
WE ARE DEMOING ON AND I DO GET
DEMOIT ALTHOUGH THE DA'S UP
DEMOCATE THEY OPPOSE THEY ARE
DEMOING DOWN WITH US TRYING
DEMOR BEST TO WORK WITH US TO
DEMO IT BETTER AND MORE
DEMOTICAL SO TO SPEAK AND WE'RE
AND DEMO ALONG WITH THE
DEMOSORS I'M LISTENING- WE DO
DEMOW NUMEROUS REMEDIES FOR
DEMOES WE DO REQUIRE A PRIME
DEMOSIA SHOWING UP BY THE
DEMONSE- WHEN AN EMOTION EITHER
DEMONG TRIAL OR FALLING
DEMOICTION IS PUT FORWARD. BUT
THE YOU DEMO THE REALITY IS
DEMO WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE WHERE
WE ARE AND IF THE DEMO. OF
DEMOESENTED THE SAME THAT WE
DEMO EQUAL PROTECTION CLAUSE.
DEMO PROHIBITS PROSECUTION
DEMOD ON RACE WE HAVE A U. S.
IN DEMOFORNIA CONSTITUTIONAL WE
DEMO THOSE ALL ALONG. THEY DONE
SO DEMO'RE SAYING THE STATUS
QUO IS DEMOING THE WRONG END-
DEMOE'S NO OTHER WAY TO PUT
DEMO AND THIS SYSTEM. IT HAS WE
DEMOT AFTER THE SYSTEM THIS
DEMO DOESN'T BLOW IT UP. OUR
DEMOENT SYSTEM HAS GONE OUT
DEMOUNITIES OF COLOR FOR
DEMORATIONS. GENERATIONS OF
DEMOK MEN AND WOMEN LATINO MEN
AND DEMON THAT ENCOURAGE OUT OF
DEMOR COMMUNITIES CHILDREN
DEMOOUT PARENTS COMMUNITIES
DEMOOUT LEADERS. IT'S OUR
DEMOENT SYSTEM DOES BONE UP OUR
DEMOUNITIES AND OUR
DEMOHBORHOODS. WE DO HAVE TO
GET IT DEMOT. BUT FOR DECADES
DEMOE BEEN GETTING IT WRONG.
AND SO I'M FAR DEMO PERFECT AND
DEMO LEGISLATION IS SOMETHING
DEMO OBVIOUSLY- YOU KNOW IS ONE
DEMOE GONNA GET YOU TO WORK ON.
BUT WE DEMOT STAND STILL WE
DEMOT IGNORE- WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN OUR DEMOINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I DEMOED AS A DEPUTY GENERAL
DEMOEN YEARS. AND WAS PEOPLE OF
DEMOR WHO IT WAS BROWN AND
DEMOK FACES THAT CAME BEFORE ME
AS MY DEMONTS THAT I CARE
DEMOLY ABOUT. THAT CLEARLY WERE
DEMOING THE BRUNT OF THE SYSTEM
AND DEMO WASN'T AN ACCIDENT IT
WAS BY DEMOGN. AND I THINK ONCE
WE DEMOGNIZE THAT THE WAY THE
DEMOICE SYSTEM IS. IS NOT A
DEMOE. BUT IT'S BY DESIGN BUT
DEMOE THAT STOOD HERE BEFORE US.
NOW DEMO WE'RE STANDING HERE
NOW DEMOL BE A SHAME IF WE
DEMOT DO ALL WE CAN. TO FIX THE
DEMOEM. AND SO LET'S CREATE A
NEW DEMOGN THE DESIGN THAT
DEMOALLY DOES APPLE JUSTICE UP
DEMOS THE VALUES OF THE
DEMOTITUTION FOR ALL.
DEMOFORNIANS FOR EVERYONE. THAT
IS DEMONG IN OUR COMMUNITIES
DEMO I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
DEMO A LONG WAY TO DOING THAT-
DEMOUSE A LOT OF THESE BIASES
AND DEMOUDICES AND THERE'S BEEN
AN DEMOICIT BIAS TRAINING I'M
AT. DEMO THOSE ARE ALL GOOD
DEMOGS BUT THEY DON'T SOLVE THE
DEMO OF THE PROBLEM BECAUSE
DEMO YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF IT
YOU DEMOT SEE IT WHEN YOU'RE IN
DEMO SYSTEM WHETHER AND DESPITE
TO SO DEMO FOLKS THAT ARE IN
THE DEMOEM WORKING IN THE
DEMOEM. BUT LET ME PULL BACK
AND DEMO IT'S SO BLATANTLY
DEMOOUS THAT. WE ARE USING THIS
DEMOINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AS A
DEMOON TOWARDS OUR COMMUNITY
AND DEMOICULARLY BLACK AND
DEMONO COMMUNITY AND- HI. I
DEMOT BEAR ANOTHER DAY AND I
DEMO THAT THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
DEMO CAN EITHER BUT THAT I
DEMOECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BOUGHT.
ALL DEMOT SO THE MOTION. IS
DEMOE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WE CAN A DEMO CALL. AB TWENTY
DEMO FORTY TO DO PASSED TO
DEMOOPRIATIONS SKINNER HI IN
OUR AYE DEMOLACH MORE LOCHNER
DEMOFORD HI BRADFORD AYE
DEMOSON. ACTION NOT VOTING
DEMOS AND NOT VOTING MITCHELL.
DEMOHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE
DEMOLE. RIGHT NOW ROUND NOW WE
I DEMOER AYE. BUT FOR TWO BILLS
ON THE DEMO IS OUT TO VOTE WAS
DEMOY TWO. RIGHT I THINK WE
DEMO ONE BILL THAT HAS TO HAVE
DEMO OUT ON SLITS OPEN THE
DEMOS ON. THAT BILL WAS A. B.
DEMON SIXTY SEVEN GRAYSON. AB
DEMON SIX SEVEN GRAYSON LET'S
DEMO THE ABSENT MEMBERS SKINNER
HI DEMONER I WINNER. WINNER
DEMO THE BILLS OUT SIX TO ONE
DEMOT IS THAT COVERS ALL OF OUR
GET DEMOT SO. I APPRECIATE
DEMOYONE'S TIME. AND A- WE ARE
NOW DEMOURNED FOR PUBLIC
DEMOTY- HEARING AND WE WILL SEE
DEMO OTHER AGAIN AT- ON
DEMOESDAY. THANK YOU.